thank you hey guys welcome back to the
cloud computing week by simply learn on
the day one we learn the fundamentals of
cloud computing through an end-to-end
Fill cost hope you had a comfortable
understanding of the basics don't worry
if you have missed on the first day the
video is available on our official
channel on the day 2 we will be taking
the things to the next level today we
will be learning a complete cloud
computing framework all together yes you
heard me right today we will be learning
AWS cloud computing framework one of the
most powerful and in-demand Frameworks
for cloud computing but before we begin
let me tell you guys that we have daily
updates on multiple Technologies if you
are a tech geek in a continuous hunt for
latest technological Trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and hit that Bell icon
to never miss an update from Simply
learn so without any further Ado let's
get started
meet Rob he runs an online shopping
portal the portal started with a modest
number of users but has recently been
seeing a surge in the number of visitors
on Black Friday and other holidays the
portal saw so many visitors that the
servers were unable to handle the
traffic and crashed is there a way to
improve performance without having to
invest in a new server wondered rob a
way to upscale or downscale capacity
depending on the number of users
visiting the website at any given point
well there is Amazon web services one of
the leaders in the cloud computing
Market before we see how AWS can solve
Rob's problem let's have a look at how
AWS reached the position it is at now
AWS was first introduced in 2002 as a
means to provide tools and services to
developers to incorporate features of
amazon.com to their website in 2006 its
first Cloud Services offering was
introduced in 2016 AWS surpassed its 10
billion Revenue Target
and now AWS offers more than 100 cloud
services that span a wide range of
domains thanks to this the AWS cloud
service platform is now used by more
than 45 of the global market now let's
talk about what is AWS AWS or Amazon web
service is a secure cloud computing
platform that provides computing power
database networking content storage and
much more
the platform also works with a PSU go
pricing model which means you only pay
for how much of the service is offered
by AWS you use
some of the other advantages of AWS are
security AWS provides a secure and
durable platform that offers end-to-end
privacy and security
experience you can benefit from the
infrastructure management practices born
from Amazon's years of experience
flexible it allows users to select the
OS language database and other services
easy to use users can host applications
quickly and securely scalable depending
on user requirements applications can be
scaled up or down AWS provides a wide
range of services across various domains
what if Rob wanted to create an
application for his online portal AWS
provides compute services that can
support the app development process from
start to finish from developing
deploying running to scaling the
application up or down based on the
requirements the popular Services
include ec2 AWS Lambda Amazon light cell
and elastic Beanstalk for storing
website data Rob could use AWS storage
services that would enable him to store
access govern and analyze data to ensure
that costs are reduced agility is
improved an innovation accelerated
popular services within this domain
include Amazon S3 EBS S3 Glacier and
elastic file storage
Rob can also store the user data in a
database with aw Services which he can
then optimize and manage popular
services in this domain include Amazon
RDS dynamodb and redshift if Rob's
businesses took off and he wanted to
separate his Cloud infrastructure or
scale up his work requests and much more
he would be able to do so with the
networking Services provided by AWS some
of the popular networking Services
include Amazon VPC Amazon Route 53 and
elastic load balancing other domains
that AWS provide services in are
analytics blockchain containers machine
learning internet of things and so on
and there you go that's AWS for you in a
nutshell now before we're done let's
have a look at a quiz which of these
services are incorrectly matched one
two
three
four
we'll be pinning the question in the
comment section comment below with your
answer and stand a chance to win an
Amazon voucher several companies around
the world have found great success with
AWS companies like Netflix twitch
LinkedIn Facebook and BBC have taken
advantage of the services offered by AWS
to improve their business efficiency and
thanks to their widespread usage AWS
professionals are in high demand they're
highly paid and earn up to more than one
hundred and twenty seven thousand
dollars per annum once you're AWS
certified you could be one of them too
hello everyone let me introduce myself
as Sam a multi-platform cloud architect
and trainer and I'm so glad and I'm
equally excited to talk and walk you
through the session about what AWS is
and talk to you about some services and
offerings and about how companies get
benefited by migrating their
applications and infra into AWS so
what's AWS let's talk about that now
before that let's talk about how life
was without any cloud provider and in
this case how life was without AWS so
let's walk back and picture how things
were back in 2000 which is not so long
ago but a lot of changes a lot of
changes for better had happened since
that time now back in 2000 a request for
a new server is not an happy thing at
all because a lot of money a lot of
validations a lot of planning are
involved in getting a server online or
up and running and even after we finally
got the server it's not all said and
done a lot of optimization that needs to
be done on that server to make it worth
it and get a good return on investment
from that server and even after we have
optimized for a good return on
investment the work is still not done
there will often be a frequent increase
and decrease in the capacity and you
know even news about our website getting
popular and getting more hits It's still
an Bittersweet experience because now I
need to add more servers to the
environment which means that it's going
to cost me even more but thanks to the
present day Cloud technology if the same
situation were to happen today my new
server it's almost ready and it's ready
instantaneously and with the Swift tools
and technologies that Amazon is
providing uh in provisioning my server
instantaneously and adding any type of
workload on top of it and making my
storage and server secure you know
creating a durable storage where data
that I stored in the cloud never gets
lost with all that features Amazon has
got our back so let's talk about what is
AWS there are a lot of definitions for
it but I'm going to put together a
simple and a precise definition as much
as possible now let me iron that out
Cloud still runs on and Hardware all
right and there are certain features in
that infrastructure in that cloud
infrastructure that makes cloud cloud or
that makes AWS a cloud provider now we
get all the services all the
Technologies all the features and all
the benefits that we get in our local
data center like you know security and
compute capacity and databases and in
fact you know we get even more cool
features like content caching in various
global locations around the planet but
again out of all the features the best
part is that I get or we get everything
on a pay as we go model the less I use
the less I pay and the more I use the
less I pay per unit very attractive
isn't it right and that's not all the
applications that we provision in AWS
are very reliable because they run on a
reliable infrastructure and it's very
scalable because it runs on an on-demand
infrastructure and it's very flexible
because of the designs and because of
the design options available for me in
the cloud let's start talk about how all
this happened AWS was launched in 2002
after the Amazon we know as the online
retail store wanted to sell their
remaining or unused infrastructure as a
service or as an offering for customers
to buy and use it from them you know
sell infrastructure as a service the
idea sort of clicked and AWS launched
their first product first product in
2006 that's like four years after the
idea launch and in 2012 they held a big
sized customer even to gather inputs and
concerns from customers and they were
very dedicated in making those requests
happen and that habit is still being
followed it's still being followed as
reinvent by AWS and at 2015 Amazon
announced its Revenue to be 4.6 billion
and in 2015 through 2016 AWS launched
products and services that help migrate
customer services into AWS well their
web products even before but this is
when a lot of focus was given on and
developing migrating services and in the
same year that's in 2016 Amazon's
revenue was 10 billion and not but not
the least as we speak Amazon has more
than 100 products and services available
for customers and get benefited from all
right let's talk about the services that
are available in Amazon let's start with
this product called S3 now S3 is a great
tool for internet backup and it's it's
the cheapest storage option in the
object storage category and not only
that the data that we put in S3 is
retrievable from the internet S3 is
really cool and we have other products
like migration and data collection and
data transfer products and here we can
not only collect data seamlessly but
also in a real-time way monitor the data
or analyze the data that's being
received that they're cool products like
AWS data transfers available that helps
achieve that and then we have products
like ec2 elastic compute Cloud that's an
resizable computer where we can anytime
anytime after the size of the computer
based on the need or based on the
forecast then we have SIMPLE
notification Services systems and tools
available in Amazon to update us with
notifications through email or through
SMS now anything anything can be sent
through email or through SMS if we use
that service it could be alarms or it
could be service notifications if you
want stuff like that and then we have
some security tools like KMS key
management system which uses AES 256-bit
encryption to encrypt our data at rest
then we have Lambda as service for which
we pay only for the time in seconds
seconds it takes to execute our code and
we're not paying for for the
infrastructure here it's just the
seconds that the program is going to
take to execute the code for the short
program will be paying in a milliseconds
if it's a bit bigger program we'll be
probably paying in 60 seconds or 120
seconds but that's a lot cheap lot
simple and lots cost effective as
against paying for service on an hourly
basis which a lot of other services are
well that's cheap but using Lambda is a
lot cheaper than that and then we have
services like Route 53 at DNS service in
the cloud and now I do not have to
maintain and DNS account somewhere else
and my cloud environment with AWS I can
get both in the same place all right let
me talk to you about how AWS makes life
easier or how companies got benefited by
using AWS as their ID provider for their
applications or for the infrastructure
now Unilever is a company and they had a
problem right and they had a problem and
they picked AWS as a solution to their
problem all right now this company was
sort of spread across 190 countries and
they were relying on a lot of digital
marketing for promoting their products
and their existing environment their
legacy local environment proved not to
support their changing I.T demands and
uh they could not standardize their old
environment now they chose to move part
of their applications to AWS because
they were not getting what they wanted
in their local environment and since
then you know rollouts were easy
provisioning your applications became
easy and even provisioning
infrastructure became easy and they were
able to do all that in push button
scaling and needless to talk about
backups that are safe and backups that
can be securely accessed from the cloud
as needed now that company is growing
along with AWS because of their Swift
speed in rolling out deployments and
being able to access secure backups from
various places and generate reports and
in fact useful reports out of it that
helps their business now on the same
lines let me also talk to you about
Kellogg's and how they got benefited by
using Amazon now Kellogg's had a
different problem it's one of its kind
now their business model was very
dependent on an infra that will help to
analyze data really fast right because
they were running promotions based on
the analyzed data that they get so
they're being able to respond to the
analyzed data as soon as possible was
critical or vital in their environment
and luckily sap running on Hana
environment is what they needed and you
know they picked that service in the
cloud and that sort of solved the
problem now the company does not have to
deal with maintaining their legacy infra
and maintaining their heavy compute
capacity and maintaining their a
database locally all that is now moved
to the cloud or they are using Cloud as
their it service provider and and now
they have have a greater and Powerful it
environment that very much complements
their business let me start the session
with this scenario let's imagine how
life would have been without Spotify for
those who are hearing about Spotify for
the first time a Spotify is an online
music service offering and it offers
instant access to over 16 million
licensed songs Spotify now uses AWS
Cloud to store the data and share it
with their customers but prior to AWS
they had some issues imagine using
spotify before AWS let's talk about that
back then users were often getting
errors because Spotify could not keep up
with the increased demand for storage
every new day and that led to users
getting upset and users canceling the
subscription the problem Spotify was
facing at that time was their users were
present globally and were accessing it
from everywhere and they had different
latency in their applications and
Spotify had a demanding situation where
they need to frequently catalog of the
songs released yesterday today and in
the future and this was changing every
new day and the songs coming in rate was
about 20 000 a day and back then they
could not keep up with this requirement
and needless to say they were badly
looking for a way to solve this problem
and that's when they got introduced to
AWS and it was a perfect fit and match
for their problem AWS offered a
dynamically increasing storage and
that's what they needed AWS also offered
tools and techniques like storage life
cycle management and trusted advisor to
properly utilize the resource so we
always get the best out of the resource
used AWS addressed their concerns about
easily being able to scale yes you can
scale the AWS environment very easily
how easily one might ask it's just a few
button clicks an AWS sold spotify's
problem let's talk about how it can help
you with your organization's problem
let's talk about what is AWS first and
then let's into how AWS became so
successful and the different types of
services that AWS provides and what's
the future of cloud and AWS in specific
let's talk about that and finally we'll
talk about a use case where you will see
how easy it is to create a web
application with AWS all right let's
talk about what is AWS AWS or Amazon web
services is a secure cloud service
platform it is also pay as you go type
billing model where there is no upfront
or Capital costs we'll talk about how
soon the service will be available well
the service will be available in a
matter of seconds with AWS you can also
do identity and access management that
is authenticating and authorizing a user
or a program on the Fly and almost all
the services are available on demand and
most of them are available
instantaneously and as we speak Amazon
offers 100 plus services and this list
is growing every new week now that would
make you wonder how AWS became so
successful of course it's their
customers let's talk about the list of
well-known companies that has their ID
environment in AWS Adobe Adobe uses AWS
to provide multi-terabyte operating
environments for its customers by
integrating its system with AWS Cloud
Adobe can focus on deploying and
operating its own software instead of
trying to you know deploy and manage the
infrastructure Airbnb is another company
it's an Community Marketplace that
allows property owners and travelers to
connect each other for the purpose of
renting unique vacation spaces around
the world and the Airbnb Community users
activities are conducted on the website
and through iPhones and Android
applications Airbnb has a huge
infrastructure in AWS and they're almost
using all the services in AWS and are
getting benefited from it another
example would be Autodesk Autodesk
develops software for engineering
designing and entertainment Industries
using services like Amazon ideas or
rational database service and Amazon S3
or Amazon simple storage servers
Autodesk can focus on deploying or
developing its machine learning tools
instead of spending that time on
managing the infrastructure AOL or
American online uses AWS and using AWS
they have been able to close data
centers and decommission about 14 000
in-house and co-located servers and move
Mission critical workload to the cloud
and extend its Global reach and save
millions of dollars on energy resources
bitdefender is an internet security
software firm and their portfolio of
softwares include antivirus and
anti-spyware products bitdefender uses
ec2 and they are currently running few
hundred instances that handle about 5
terabytes of data and they also use
elastic load balancer to load balance
the connection coming in to those
instances across availability zones and
they provide seamless Global delivery of
service is because of that the BMW group
it uses AWS for its new connected Car
application that collects sensor data
from BMW 7 Series cars to give drivers
dynamically updated map information
Canon's office Imaging products division
benefits from faster deployment times
lower cost and Global reads by using AWS
to deliver cloud-based services such as
mobile print the office Imaging products
division uses AWS such as Amazon S3 and
Amazon Route 53 Amazon cloudfront and
Amazon IM for their testing development
and Production Services Comcast it's the
world's largest cable company and the
leading provider of internet service in
the United States Comcast uses AWS in a
hybrid environment out of all the other
Cloud providers Comcast chores AWS for
its flexibility and scalable hybrid
infrastructure Docker is a company
that's helping redefine the way
developers build ship and run
application this company focuses on
making use of containers for this
purpose and in AWS the service called
the Amazon ec2 container service is
helping them achieve it the esa or
European Space Agency although much of
esa's work is done by satellites some of
the programs data storage and Computing
infrastructure is built on Amazon web
services Esa chose AWS because of its
economical pay as ego system as well as
its quick startup time the Guardian
newspaper uses AWS and it uses a wide
range of AWS services including Amazon
Kinesis Amazon redshift that power and
analytic dashboard which editors used to
see how stories are trending in real
time Financial Times FD is one of the
world's largest leading business news
organization and they used Amazon
redshift to perform their analysis A
Funny Thing Happened Amazon Redshirt
performs so quickly that some analysis
thought it was malfunctioning they were
used to running queries overnight and
they found that the results were indeed
correct just as much faster by using
Amazon redshift ft is supporting the
same business functions with costs that
are 80 percentage lower than what was
before general electric GE is at the
moment as we speak migrating more than
9000 workloads including 300 desperate
Erp systems to AWS while reducing its
data center footprint from 34 to 4 over
the next three years similarly Howard
Medical School HTC IMDb McDonald's NASA
Kellogg's and lot more are using the
services Amazon provides and are getting
benefited from it and this huge success
and customer portfolio is just the tip
of the iceberg and if we think why so
many adapt AWS and if we let AWS answer
that question this is what AWS would say
people are adapting AWS because of the
security and durability of the data and
end-to-end privacy and encryption of the
data and Storage experience we can also
rely on AWS way of doing things by using
the AWS tools and techniques and
suggested best practices built upon the
years of experience it has gained
flexibility there is a greater
flexibility in AWS that allows us to
select the OS language and database easy
to use swiftness in deploying we can
host our applications quickly in AWS be
it a new application or migrating an
existing application into AWS
scalability the application can be
easily scaled up or scaled down
depending on the user requirement cost
saving we only pay for the compute power
storage and other resources you use and
that too without any long-term
commitments now let's talk about the
different types of services that AWS
provides the services that we talk about
fall in any of the following categories
you see like you know compute storage
database Security customer engagement
desktop and streaming machine learning
developers tools stuff like that and if
you do not see the service that you are
looking for it's probably is because AWS
is creating it as we speak now let's
look at some of them that are very
commonly used within compute Services we
have Amazon ec2 Amazon elastic Beanstalk
Amazon light sale and Amazon Lambda
Amazon ec2 provides compute capacity in
the cloud now this capacity is secure
and it is resizable based on the user's
requirement now look at this the
requirement for the web traffic keeps
changing and behind the scenes in the
cloud ec2 can expand its environment to
three instances and during no load it
can shrink its environment to just one
resource elastic Beanstalk it helps us
to scale and deploy web applications and
it's made with a number of programming
languages elastic Beanstalk is also an
easy to use service for deploying and
scaling web applications and services
deployed a bit in java.net PHP node.js
python Ruby Docker and lot other
familiar services such as Apache
passenger and IIs we can simply upload
our code an elastic Beanstalk
automatically handles the deployment
from capacity provisioning to load
balancing to Auto scaling to application
Health monitoring and Amazon light sale
is a virtual private server which is
easy to launch and easy to manage Amazon
light cell is the easiest way to get
started with AWS for developers who just
need a virtual private server light sail
includes everything you need to launch
your project quickly on a virtual
machine like SSD based storage a virtual
machine tools for data transfer DNS
management and a static IP and that too
for a very low and predictable price AWS
Lambda has taken Cloud Computing
Services to a whole new level it allows
us to pay only for the compute time no
need for provisioning and managing
servers an AWS Lambda is a compute
service that lets us run code without
provisioning or managing service Lambda
executes your code only when needed and
scales automatically from few requests
per day to thousands per second you pay
only for the compute time you consume
there is no charge when your core is not
running let's look at some storage
services that Amazon provides like
Amazon S3 Amazon Glacier Amazon abs and
Amazon elastic file system Amazon S3 is
an object storage that can store and
retrieve data from anywhere websites
mobile apps iot sensors and so on can
easily use Amazon S3 to store and
retrieve data it's an object storage
built to store and to drive any amount
of data from anywhere with its features
like flexibility in managing data and
the durability it provides and the
security that it provides Amazon simple
storage service or S3 is a storage for
the internet and Glacier Glacier is a
cloud storage service that's used for
archiving data and long-term backups and
this Glacier is an secure durable and
extremely low cost cloud storage service
for data archiving and long-term backups
Amazon EVS Amazon elastic blog store
provides Block store volumes for the
instances of ec2 and this elastic Block
store is highly available and a reliable
storage volume that can be attached to
any running instance that is in the same
availability Zone ABS volumes that are
attached to the ec2 instances are
exposed as storage volumes that persist
and independently from the lifetime of
the instance an Amazon elastic file
system or EFS provides an elastic file
storage which can be used with AWS cloud
service and resources that are on
premises and Amazon elastic file system
it's an simple it's scalable it's an
elastic file storage for use with Amazon
cloud services and for on-premises
resources it's easy to use and offers a
simple interface that allows you to
create and configure file systems
quickly and easily Amazon file system is
built to elastically scale on-demand
without disturbing the application
growing and shrinking automatically as
you add and remove files so your
application have the storage they need
and when they need it now let's talk
about databases the two major database
flavors are Amazon RDS and Amazon
redshift Amazon RDS it really eases the
process involved in setting up operating
and scaling a rational database in the
cloud Amazon RDS provides cost efficient
and resizable capacity while automating
time consuming administrative tasks such
as Hardware provisioning database setup
patching and backups it sort of frees us
from managing the hardware and sort of
helps us to focus on the application
it's also cost effective and resizable
and it's also optimized for memory
performance and input and output
operations not only that it also
automates most of the services like
taking backups you know monitoring stuff
like that it automates most of those
Services Amazon redshift Amazon redshift
is a data warehousing service that
enables users to analyze the data using
SQL and other business intelligent tools
Amazon redshift is an fast and fully
managed data warehouse that makes it
simple and cost effective analyze all
your data using standard SQL and your
existing business intelligent tools it
also allows you to run complex analytic
queries against petabyte of structured
data using sophisticated query
optimizations and most of the results
they generally come back in seconds all
right let's quickly talk about some more
services that AWS offers there are a lot
more services that AWS provides but are
we going to look at some more services
that are widely used AWS application
Discovery Services help Enterprise
customers plan migration projects by
gathering information about their
on-premises data centers in a planning a
data center migration can involve
thousands of workloads they are often
deeply interdependent server utilization
data and dependency mapping are
important early first step in migration
process and this AWS application
Discovery service collects and presents
configuration usage and behavior data
from your servers to help you better
understand your workloads Route 53 it's
a network and content delivery service
it's an highly available and scalable
Cloud domain name system or DNS service
and Amazon Route 53 is fully compliant
with IPv6 as well elastic load balancing
it's also a network and content delivery
service elastic load balancing
automatically distributes incoming
application traffic across multiple
targets such as Amazon ec2 instance
containers and ipu addresses it can
handle the varying load of your
application traffic in a single
available zones and also across
availability zones AWS Auto scaling it
monitors your application and
automatically adjusts the capacity to
maintain steady and predictable
performance at a lowest possible cost
using AWS Auto scaling it's easy to set
up application scaling for multiple
resources across multiple services in
minutes Auto scaling can be applied to
web services and also for DB Services
AWS identity and access management it
enables you to manage access to AWS
services and resources securely using IM
you can create and manage AWS users and
groups and use permissions to allow and
deny their access to AWS resources and
moreover it's a free service now let's
talk about the future of AWS well let me
tell you something cloud is here to stay
here's what in store for AWS in the
future as years pass by we're gonna have
a variety of cloud applications born
like iot artificial intelligence
business intelligence serverless
Computing and so on cloud will also
expand into other markets like
healthcare banking space automated cars
and so on as I was mentioning some time
back lot or greater Focus will be given
to artificial intelligence and
eventually because of the flexibility
and advantage that cloud provides we're
going to see a lot of companies moving
into the cloud all right let's now talk
about how easy it is to deploy an web
application in the cloud so the scenario
here is that our users like a product
and we need to have a mechanism to
receive input from them about their
likes and dislikes and you know give
them the appropriate product as per
their need all right though the setup
and the environment it sort of looks
complicated we don't have to worry
because AWS has tools and Technologies
which can help us to achieve it now
we're going to use services like Route
53 services like Cloud watch ec2 S3 and
lot more and all these put together are
going to give an application that's
fully functionable and an application
that's going to receive the information
like using the services like Route 53
cloudwatch ec2 and S3 we're going to
create an application and that's going
to meet our need so back to our original
requirement all I want is to deploy a
web application for a product that keeps
our users updated about the happenings
and the newcomings in the market and to
fulfill this requirement here is all the
services we would need ec2 here is used
for provisioning the computational power
needed for this application and ec2 has
a vast variety of family and types that
we can pick from for the types of
workloads and also for the intents of
the workloads we're also going to use S3
for storage and S3 provides any
additional storage requirement for the
resources or any additional storage
requirement for the web applications and
we are also going to use cloudwatch for
monitoring the environment and
cloudwatch monitors the application and
the environment and it provides trigger
for scaling in and scaling out the
infrastructure and we're also going to
use Route 53 for DNS and Route 53 helps
us to register the domain name for our
web application and with all the tools
and Technologies together all of them
put together we're going to make an
application a perfect application that
caters our need all right so I'm going
to use elastic Beanstalk for this
project and the name of the application
is going to be as you see GSG sign up
and the environment name is GSG signup
environment one let me also pick a name
let me see if this name is available yes
that's available that's the domain name
so let me pick that and the application
that I have is going to run on node.js
so let me pick that platform and launch
now as you see elastic Beanstalk this is
going launch an instance it's going to
launch the monitoring setup or the
monitoring environment it's going to
create a load balancer as well and it's
going to take care of all the security
features needed for this application
foreign
look at that I was able to go to that
URL which is what we gave and it's now
having an default page shown up meaning
all the dependencies for the software is
installed and it's just waiting for me
to upload the code or in specific the
page required so let's do that
let me upload the code I already have
the code saved here
so that's my code
and that's going to take some time all
right it has done its thing and now if I
go to the same URL look at that I'm
being thrown an advertisement page all
right so if I sign up with my name email
and stuff like that you know it's going
to receive the information and it's
going to send an email to the owner
saying that somebody had subscribed to
your service that's the default feature
of this app look at that email to the
owner saying that somebody had
subscribed to your app and this is their
email address stuff like that not only
that it's also going to create an entry
in the database and dynamodb is the
service that this application uses to
store data there's my dynamodb and if I
go to tables all right and go to items
I'm going to see that a user with name
Samuel and email address so and so has
said ok or has shown interest in the
preview of my site or product so this is
where this is how I collect those
information right and some more things
about the infrastructure itself is it is
running behind load balancer look at
that it had created a load balancer it
had also created an auto scaling group
now that's the feature of elastic load
balancer that we have chosen it has
created an auto scaling group and now
let's put this URL you see this it's
it's not a fancy URL all right it's an
Amazon given URL a dynamic URL so let's
put this URL behind our DNS let's do
that
so go to Services go to Route 53
go to hosted Zone and there we can find
the DNS name right so that's a DNS name
all right
all right let's create an entry
and map that URL to our load balancer
right
and create now technically if I go to
this URL it should take me to that
application all right look at that I
went to my custom URL and now that's
pointed to my application previously my
application was having a random URL and
now it's having a custom URL choose from
over 300 in-demand skills and get access
to 1 000 Plus hours of video content for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more let me help you understand
about AWS ec2 a compute servers in the
cloud through this video somewhere far
in the country a scientist has a lab far
in the woods and at one day he stumbled
on a calculation that he had trouble
solving and he was very certain that his
computer can handle it and he asked his
computer to do the math or the
calculation for him and the computer
thought about it for a while then took
couple of hours in trying to process the
data and eventually at one point it gave
up and died due to low memory and this
old scientist is now clueless about how
he was going to finish the task and
complete his invention and let the whole
world know about it and that's when he
was introduced to this new friend AWS as
you see on the screen AWS was very handy
in replacing his old machines and it was
able to give him the service that he
wanted at that moment AWS has been
around for a while helping people with
their computer needs and now this new
scientist friend ener is welcomed by the
new and trendy ID technology AWS and
sure enough his new AWS friend welcomed
and walked him through the new way of
computing and this new Happy faced AWS
friend talked to this scientist about
AWS ec2 in specific and walked him
through about all the new Innovations in
ID and in Cloud that he had been missing
all these days so his new friend AWS
started the conversation about
explaining how there is no need for any
hardware units no managing Hardware or
provisioning in AWS and secondly it
explained increasing and decreasing the
capacity as per the demand is just a
click away and the best part here is
that there is no upfront commitment and
we only pay for what we have used just
like we pay electricity and water bills
and all this comes with complete control
from our side other words the whole key
for this infrastructure is with us and
as if this was not enough all this comes
with Enterprise grade security that's
beyond imagination and on-premises and
if this tool does not excite you then
this definitely would you can work from
anywhere in the world now this really
made the scientist to get excited
especially when he thought about working
from home working from home there is
nothing like it isn't it now this person
the scientist is not tied up to a
particular environment he can work from
home work on the Fly work from anywhere
still the data and everything else in
his ID environment is secure and safe
now let's move to the next level of
discussion let's talk about what is ec2
and some of the use cases of ec2 and
this use case we're going to talk about
are this architecture we're going to
talk about it notifies a group of users
about a new letter and the components
are resources this architecture would
need be first ec2 instance then SNS a
simple notification service and coupling
ec2 and S3 service together that's all
it would require to get an architecture
that notifies a group of users about a
new newsletter and now I think it would
be a good time to talk about what ec2 is
AWS offers plenty of services offered
under different domains like you know
compute storage database migration
Network management tools Media Services
security business productivity
application integration machine learning
game development and lot more coming up
out of which ec2 falls under the compute
capacity so what is ec2 ec2 is a web
service which aims to make life easier
for Developers for providing secure and
resizable compute capacity in the cloud
with ec2 it is very easy to scale up or
scale down our infrastructure based on
the demand and not only that this ec2
service can be integrated well with
almost all the services in Amazon and
out of all this the best part could be
we only pay for what we use all right
let's talk about this use case a use
case here is that a successful business
owner has a bunch of users and a
successful product that's running and
now he has developed few more products
that he thinks will be very successful
that he thinks his customers are going
to like now how can he advertise his
product to his new and prospective
customers or the solution for this
question can be addressed by AWS in AWS
we can use services like simple
notification service SNS and ec2 for
compute and S3 for storage we can in a
way integrate them all and achieve this
business use case and that sort of got
this business owner very chewed up and
now he wants to use the service and he
wants to get benefited from the service
he wants to advertise or he wants to
notify his users every time the company
creates a newsletter alright so let's
talk about what it would take to get
this environment up and running or what
it would take to connect the environment
and put the applications on top of it
firstly we would require an AWS account
and then for compute capacity we would
require an ec2 instance and here's how
we go about doing it the first thing is
to create an Ami which is Amazon Mission
image that's really the softwares and
the application packages we would need
to run our application and the second is
to choose the hardware in here it's the
instance type depending on the workload
we would be choosing the hardware and
depending on the intents of the workload
we will be choosing the size of the
hardware and finally we would configure
the instances in a how many instance do
I want you know which subnet do I want
them in and what's going to be the in a
stop or terminate a behavior of the
instance and do I want to update any
patches when the instance starts running
all those speeds of information go in
here when we configure the instance and
then the first three steps is really
about the OS volume and the Basic
Hardware now it's time to add additional
storage to the ec2 instance that would
be step four here we add additional
storage to the ec2 instance and then
tags we use tags or we would configure
tags to easily identify an ec2 instance
at a later point you know we give it
some meaningful names so we can identify
like you know which team it belongs to
which billing department it belongs to
what's the purpose behind launching this
instance stuff like that in an
environment where we run 700 to 800 or
even more instances identifying an
instance and trying to understand you
know who owns the resource for what
purpose we created it could be an
full-time work so tagging comes to a
rescue at that time after tagging as
step 6 we would configure the firewall
which is also called Security Group for
the ec2 instant and this is where we
would allow or deny connection from
external world to this particular ec2
instance well it works both ways from
outside and from inside out this
firewall blocks the connection based on
port number and IP address and finally
as step 7 we review all the
configurations that you have done and we
make sure that the configurations is
what we wanted and finally click on
submit that's going to launch an ec2
instance alright this was just an
overview of how to create an ec2
instance now let's talk about each and
every step in detail so to begin with
let's talk about how to create an Ami
well the Ami is just a template a
template that's used to create a new
instance or an a new computer or a new
VM or a new machine based on the user
requirement the things that go into an
Ami are the software the operating
system the additional applications that
get installed in it stuff like that the
Ami will also contain software
information you know information about
operating system information about
access permission information about
volumes they all compact in the Ami
again the Ami is of two types one is
predefined Amis are called Amazon
provided Amis the other one would be
custom Amis the Amis that we create and
if you're looking at a particular Ami
that you don't want to create but still
want to get it from Amazon there is a
place or a portal called Ami Marketplace
there we get like thousands of Amis in
there available for us to shop and use
them on a pay as you go business model
and use them as pay as you go billing so
there you can search Ami that you're
looking for most probably you'll be able
to get it there now let's talk about
choosing the instance type the instance
type is basically the hardware
specification that's required for a
machine that we're trying to build and
the instant types is categorized into
five main families they are to begin
with it's compute optimized now compute
optimize gives us lots of compute power
a lot of processing power so if my
application is going to require a lot of
processing power I should be picking
compute optimized instance and the
second one is memory optimized now this
is very good for application that
require in memory caching you know there
are some applications that perform comes
well with cash or through cash or the
application would create a lot of data
that it wants to keep in cash for
re-reading or for processing you know
for lengthy processing stuff like that
for those type of application this
memory optimized instance that comes
within memory cache is a very good use
case and the third one is the instant
that comes with the GPU otherwise called
GPU optimized GPU stands for graphical
process unit and this is very good for
application that deals with gaming this
is very good for application that's
going to require large graphical
requirements and storage optimized is
the fourth option just like the name
says this is a very good use case for
storage servers and the fifth family
type is general purpose just like the
name says it's for general purpose if
you're not particular about the family
then you generally would end up picking
the general purpose because here the
services are sort of equally balanced
you know you'll find about balance
between the virtual CPU and the memory
and the storage and the network
performance it's sort of balanced all
the components all the features that
needs to go in a computer are sort of
balanced in general purpose now these
instant types are fixed and they cannot
be altered because it's Hardware based
we buy Hardware we do not have much
control on the hardware that's being
used well we have options but we do not
have control on the hardware and these
instant types are divided into five main
families they are computer optimized
memory optimized GPU enabled storage
optimized and general purpose then as
third thing we have to configure the
instance now here is where I have lot of
options about purchasing you know what
type of purchasing do I want to do do I
want to go for a spot instance do I want
to go for a reserved instance do I want
to go for an on-demand instance these
are different billing options available
and that's available under configure
instance now only that here's where I'm
going to put the ec2 instance do I want
and public IP address assigned to it do
I want an IAM role attached to it IM
role is authentication what kind of
authentication am I going to provide and
the shutout Behavior the Sharon
behaviors include do I want to stop the
instance when the user shuts down the
machine from the desktop or do I want to
Simply terminate this instance when the
user shuts down the instance from the
desktop so those things go in here just
like the name says configure instance
lot of instance configuration options
comes in here that's the third step and
not only that under the advanced details
or Advanced tab under configure instance
I can bootstrap the instance with some
scripts now bootstrap is nothing but the
scripts that you want to be run in the
instance before it actually comes online
let's say you're provisioning the
instance for somebody else you know
instead of you launching the instance
and then logging in and running some
commands and then handing it over to the
other person you can create bootstrap
shell scripts and you know paste it in a
console option available under configure
instance and Amazon is going to take
those commands run it on the instance
before it hands over to the user that
initially requested for that instance
now it could be a different user or just
you it sort of automates you know
software installation procedures in the
instance that we will be launching and
not only that there are multiple payment
options available under configure
instance the user can pick an instance
under normal price and that instance
would apply normal rates applied to it
and there are also options like reserved
instance where the user can pay for an
instance upfront before a year or before
months you know for a span of year or a
span of months and that way they can pay
less per hour for using that instance
not only that you can also go for spot
instance like B waiting for those
instances whoever bids more they get the
instance for that particular time well
these instances are a lot cheaper than
on-demand instances and through bidding
and buying you can keep the instance as
long as your bid price doesn't exceed
the price that Amazon is proposing and
as the fourth step we will have to add
storage to the instance that we are
about to launch and here we have bunch
of storage options I can go for a
permanent storage which is free or I can
go for an external elastic block storage
also called EBS which is paid and it's a
permanent storage or else I can
integrate my ec2 instance with S3 for
its storage needs and the best part
about storage is a free subscription
users they get to use 30 gigabit of SSD
storage or magnetic storage for the
whole year in this page where we are
ready to add storage we will have to to
mention or provide the size in gigabit
and the volume type is it going to be an
provisioned volume is it going to be an
general purpose volume is it going to be
a magnetic volume stuff like that there
are volume types and we also need to
give inputs about where the disk will be
mounted and whether this volume needs to
be encrypted or not so all these options
are all these inputs are received from
us under the adding storage section and
then the fifth option would be adding
tags like we discussed sometime back
tags are very helpful to identify a
machine in an environment where we have
700 or 1000 VMS running and security
groups are the actual firewall that sits
in front of ec2 instance and it protects
that ec2 instance from unintended
inbound and outbound traffic now here is
where I can fine tune the access to my
ec2 instance based on port numbers and
based on IP address from which it can be
accessed and finally we get to review
the whole changes or the whole
configurations that we have made to find
out whether they are intact with the
requirement and then click on submit
that's going to launch an ec2 instance
but hold on we're not done yet when
we're about to launch or before the
Amazon console actually launches the ec2
instance it's going to give us an option
to create a keypad remember I said it's
key pair you know key pair is two things
one is public and private the private
key is downloaded by the user and is
kept with the user and the public key is
used by Amazon to confirm the identity
of the user so just go ahead and
download the private key and keep it for
yourself and this private key gets
downloaded as an dot pem file it's a
format of the file and it gets
downloaded as dot pimp file and our next
step is to access the ec2 instance and
because the instance that we have
launched in this example let's assume
it's Linux and instance and that's going
to require a tool called putty to be
able to access it and this putty tool is
really needed when we are trying to
access a Linux instance from Windows
instance most of the time Windows
instance will have putty installed in
them but in some rare cases they do not
come with putty in those cases we can go
ahead and download putty and putty
generator and we can start using it to
access the Linux instance now you might
ask well I understand putty what's putty
generator now the file that we have
downloaded is in dot Pam format but
unfortunately putty does not accept dot
pem format as input you know it has to
be converted into a different format
called PPK and put it gen is a tool that
helps us to convert the dot pem file
into PPK file so the quick way to do it
is download generator open it up click
on conversion and insert the dot pem key
that we have downloaded and save the
private key and this when we save the
private key it gets saved as a DOT PPK
type private key and when that's done
the next very step is to open putty and
try to log in and the way to log in is
to open putty put that IP address here
and then click on auth you know this is
where we would input the file that we
have created so click on off and then
click on browse and find the dot PPK
file that we have converted and stored
browse it and upload it and then click
on open now that's going to open up a
login screen for us and the Amis comes
with a default username depending on the
Ami that we have picked the username
might differ in our case we have picked
an Ami for which the username is ec2
hyphen user and this is the default by
the way let's put the username ec2
hyphen user and hit enter and that's
going to open up the Linux instance
using CLI there are a few other things
that we can do with the terminal that
will explain it a little later alright
so we have successfully launched an ec2
instance and yeah give yourself a pat on
your back launching an instance was just
one part of the solution so let's
actually talk about how we can notify
our customers SNS or simple notification
service is a service or a product in
Amazon that helps us to notify customers
through email so navigate to SNS in your
account and create a topic and we're
going to use this topic for public
notification so let's make it public and
then add subscribers to it now these
subscribers these subscribers are the
people who you want to be notified about
the newsletter so we already have the
email database in there add them to the
subscribers list and then they will
start getting new newsletters as and
when we post them to the topic and as
Next Step create a bucket in S3 where I
can store content and in that bucket
create an event that triggers a
notification to simple notification
service so this is how it will be set up
and notification will be sent to our
subscribers anytime we put something in
our S3 bucket so S3 bucket is going to
create an event for the notification and
the notification is going to make sure
that it's delivered to your end Customer
because they're already subscribed to
the topic as subscribers and finally
let's connect the S3 with ec2 so the
bucket and the AWS instance are in sync
so we put some content in the S3 bucket
our email system notifies our customers
and the customers can go online to a
website that's hosted in ec2 and because
S3 and ec2 are in sync the items that we
put in S3 will also show up in Easy too
see how this is all connected and it's
working together and once this is all
connected our subscribers will regularly
be informed anytime we put new content
in the S3 bucket and the same content
will be made available in ec2 instance
through the website let me welcome you
to this new video learning where we're
going to learn about Lambda one day at
office in a growing company there was
this question going on between two IT
personnel it was about the new role that
his colleague Jessica has taken Benjamin
the guy standing here wants to know
about it and Jessica's job is new
different and dynamic and interesting
too she scale and manage servers and
operating systems and apply security
patches onto them and monitor all of
these at the same time to ensure the
best quality for application is given to
the users and Benjamin was awestruck
with the amount of work Jessica is doing
and with the time it would take to
complete all of them but Jessica being a
very Dynamic person very suitable for
the job said it was easy for her to
handle all of it and even more but that
easiness on the job did not last longer
as the Environ grew more and more it
being a startup company Jessica was
getting drained and was not really happy
about all her job as she used to be
Jessica's manual way of scaling and
environment did not last long and she
was also finding out that she missed to
scale down some of the resources and
it's costing her a lot she needs to pay
for the service that she was not at all
using she sort of felt that she was at
the end of the road and there was no way
out from this manual task she was very
desperate and that's when Benjamin
suggested something and that brought
back the peace and joy Jessica initially
had Benjamin suggested about a service
called Lambda that can ease the work
that Jessica is doing at the moment and
Lambda as happy as it looks like it's a
solution that solves the manual
repetitive work and lot more and Lambda
introduced itself as the problem solver
and started to explain the the following
things the very same thing that we're
gonna learn about in this series so in
this section we're going to learn about
the features of AWS Lambda and we're
going to talk about what Lambda is and
then we're going to talk about where
Lambda is being used in the it or in the
cloud environment as we speak and then
we're going to talk about how Lambda
works and some use cases of Lambda and
we're going to be particularly
discussing about the use case about
automatically backing up the data that's
put in the cloud storage let's talk
about Lambda in detail Lambda
automatically runs our code without
requiring us to provision or manage
servers just write the code and upload
it to Lambda and Lambda will take care
of it that means that we don't require
any server to run or to manage and all
you need to do is write the code and
upload it to Lambda and Lambda will take
care of it which also means that we can
stop worrying about provisioning and
managing service the only thing Lambda
expects from you is a code that's
working AWS Lambda also automatically
scales our application by running code
in response to each trigger our code
runs in parallel and processes each
triggers individually scaling precisely
with the size of the workload scaling
here is done automatically based on the
size of the workload Lambda can scale
the application running the code in
response to each and every trigger that
it receives billing in Lambda is meter
on the seconds we only pay for the
amount of time that our code is running
which means that we're not charged for
any of the servers the only payment
required is for the amount of time the
code is computed with AWS Lambda we are
charged for every 100 milliseconds we
are actually charged for 100
milliseconds our code executes and the
number of times our code is triggered
and we don't pay anything when the code
is not running let's talk about what is
AWS Lambda now Lambda is one of the
service that falls under the company
compute section or the compute domain of
services that AWS provides along with
ec2 EBS elastic load balancer Lambda is
also a service that comes under the
bigger umbrella of compute services in
AWS and Lambda allows us to execute code
or any type of application with AWS
Lambda we can run code for virtually any
type of application or backend Services
all we need to do is supply our code in
one of the languages that AWS Lambda
supports as we speak the languages that
are supported by AWS Lambda are node.js
Java c-sharp go and Python and Lambda
can be used to run code in response to
certain events from other services and
based on the event it can run functions
and those functions can be of node.js
java c-sharp Etc now let's talk about
where is Lambda used there are huge
number of use cases for Lambda and there
are many ways AWS Lambda is used
specifically in the business world let's
talk about some of them one use case is
AWS Lambda is used to process images
when it is uploaded in an S3 bucket
let's say the object gets uploaded in an
S3 bucket in a format that we don't
expect it to be which means the file
needs to be formatted so it gets
uploaded in a raw format and AWS Lambda
is triggered anytime a new object is
added to the bucket and the images are
processed and converted into thumbnails
based on the devices the other end
device that could be reading the data it
could be and PC it could be an apple
machine it could be an Android phone it
could be an Apple phone it could be a
tablet What Not So based on the devices
different formats Lambda can get
triggered and convert video or convert
the picture into the different format
that it requires another use case for
Lambda is to analyze the social media
data let's say let's say we're
collecting the hash trending data and
the data is received and it's added into
the Kinesis stream to feed into the
Amazon environment and Lambda action get
triggered and it receives the data and
then the data is stored into the
database which can be used by businesses
for later analysis and some of the
companies that have gotten tremendous
benefit using Lambda or Thompson routers
benchlings nordstorm Coca-Cola robot are
some of the companies to name at the
moment that have received tremendous
amount of benefit by using Lambda let's
look at how Lambda Works in other words
let's look at how the complicated
function behind the scenes work in a
simple and in a seamless way so here
clients send data now clients send data
to Lambda and clients could be anyone
who's sending requests to AWS Lambda it
could be an application or other Amazon
web services that send adding data to
the Lambda and Lambda receives the
request and depending on the size of the
data or depending on the amount or
volume of the data it runs on the
defined number of containers if it is a
single request or if it is less request
it runs on a single container so the
requests are given to the container to
handle and the container which contains
the code the user has provided to
satisfy the query would run and if
you're sort of new to Containers then
let me pause here for a while and
explain to you what container is now
container image is a lightweight
Standalone executable package of a piece
of software that includes everything
needs to run it like the codes the
runtimes the system tools the system
libraries and any of the settings needed
and it is at the moment available both
on Linux and windows based application
and containerized software will always
run the same regardless of the
environment it's running on and
containers isolate software from its
surrounding for example there could be
difference between a development and
staging environment so that's sort of
isolated and this helps in reducing the
conflict between the teams running
different software on the same
infrastructure all right now that we
know containers needed to understand
Lambda so if there are few requests it
sends to a single container but as and
when the request grows it actually
creates multiple containers shares the
multiple requests to the different
containers there and depending on the
volume depending on the size depending
on the number of sessions the more
number of containers are provisioned so
to handle those requests and when the
requests reduce the number of containers
reduce as well and that helps in Saving
costs we're not running any resources
and paying for it when we're not using
them and in fact we're not at all paying
for the resources we'll only charge for
the amount of time a function is running
inside these containers now consider a
situation where you have to set up a
temporary storage and as a system to
backup the data as soon as the data is
uploaded which is a near real-time
backup now a near real-time manual
backups are nearly impossible and
they're not that efficient too and near
real-time manual backups that's what the
business demands but that's not near
real-time backup that too a manual one
that's not at all efficient even if we
come up with a solution of manually
backing up close to near real Time
That's not going to be efficient looking
at the amount of data that will be put
in and looking at the random times the
data will be put into the source bucket
and there is no way we can do a manual
backup and they keep it as real as
possible but if that's still your
requirement we can use AWS Lambda and
set things up so AWS Lambda manually
handles the backup in other words for an
impossible or a difficult situation like
that aw slander comes for the rescue and
this is what we do create a 2s3 bucket
one would be the source bucket where the
data will be uploaded and the other one
is and destination bucket where the data
will be backed up from the source bucket
and for these buckets to talk to
themselves it's going to require an IM
role and then for the automatic copy
it's going to require an Lambda function
to copy the files from The Source bucket
to the destination bucket and what
triggers the Lambda function the Lambda
function is triggered every time there's
a change in the metadata for the
Buckhead and this data is then uploaded
into the destination bucket and after
setting all this up we can literally
test it by putting a data in the source
bucket that's going to automatically
replicate or that's going to
automatically copy the data from The
Source bucket to the destination bucket
all right let's see how we can replicate
data between two bucket well we have a
feature to cross region replicate in S3
that's a feature that comes along with
S3 what if you want to replicate between
two different buckets in two different
accounts in those cases we can use
Lambda to replicate the data between the
buckets so you put one data or you put
data in the source bucket and that data
gets replicated to the destination
bucket and let's see how that's done the
procedure here would be to have two
buckets to begin with and then create an
IM role that lets you access to pull
data from The Source bucket and put data
on the destination bucket and then
create Lambda files or Lambda event or
triggers to actually look for event in
the source bucket and anytime a new data
gets added Lambda gets triggered copies
the data from The Source bucket and
moves the data to the destination bucket
and it uses the IM role and policy for
the needed permissions and in just a
couple of clicks we we have set up a
temporary backup system that can run
seamlessly without any manual
intervention and that can be as near
real time as possible alright that's the
concept and let's see how it is done
real time through the slab so to begin
with we need two buckets so I have here
a source bucket and a destination bucket
and the source bucket as of now do not
have any data in it so as the
destination bucket all right so that's
one down the second would be to create
an IM role right so let me create an IM
role and the role is going to have this
policy in it a policy that's allowing
get object on the source bucket and a
policy that's allowing put object on the
destination bucket and here I'm going to
use or I'm going to paste my source and
destination buckets Arn all right go to
Services go to S3
Source bucket
all right click on the source bucket and
copy the bucket Arn
so that would be the source bucket Arn
right on on the destination bucket copy
the destination bucket Arn
and this is going to be my destination
bucket Arn so with this I'm going to
create a policy
all right
go to IM
and create a policy
now I I have already created a policy
with the same information all right
destination bucket Arn and a policy is
available with the name S3 bucket copy
Lambda attach the policy to the role
all right go to rules create a role
Lambda is the service that's going to
use it in here attach the policy that we
have created
right give it a name
and then create a role now I have a role
created as well
all right copy Lambda and that's having
the policy that we have created sometime
back now create a Lambda function let's
go to Lambda
create a function give it a name like S3
bucket copy all right choose a role that
we want to use
all right that's the rule that we want
to use copy one two
create a function
all right
and then here we're going to use node.js
code right I have a sample code
this can be used as template in here
replace the source bucket with the name
of the source bucket and the destination
bucket with the name of the destination
bucket this is a node.js code that gets
run when an event get triggers now
what's an event anytime there is a new
object placed in the S3 bucket it
creates an event and the evil triggers
Lambda and Lambda checks this Source S3
bucket picks the data puts it in the
destination bucket all right paste it
here
paste it here and click on save all
right now before you click on Save just
ensure that you have the appropriate
rules defined that's all you got to do
click on save all right now I I already
have created
a Lambda function
all right
which is the same thing same code and
the rule is attached to it
now it's running it's active now let's
put this to test go to S3
pick the source bucket
put some data in it
all right and in theory those data
should be present in the destination
bucket as well
there you go it's all done by Lambda I'm
going to be touring you with different
S3 features and technical details in
this section so what are we going to
learn we're going to learn about what is
cloud storage in general and then the
types of storage available in general in
the cloud and how things were before
anybody adopted using S3 that's
something are we going to learn and then
we're going to immediately dive into
what is S3 and then the benefits of
using S3 over other storage and then
we're gonna do a couple of labs or
console walkthroughs about what is
object and how to add an object what is
bucket how to create a bucket stuff like
that and then we're going to talk about
how Amazon S3 generally works now it
comes with a lot of features it comes
with a lot of Promise um how does this
all work how does Amazon able to keep up
with the promise we're going to talk
about that and then we will talk about
some features add-on features that comes
along with the Amazon S3 so what is
cloud storage in general cloud storage
is a service that provides web services
where we can store our data and not only
that that data can be easily accessed
and the data can be easily backed up
everything over the internet in chart if
you could store your data if you could
access the data if you could backup your
data everything you do through the
internet then that's a good definition
for cloud storage and additional
definitions are in cloud storage we only
pay for what we use you know no
commitment no pre-proitioning is you
know pay as you go type subscription and
the best part is we pay on a monthly
basis you know we don't rent a hardware
for the year or we don't give commitment
for the whole year it's pay as you go
and pay on a monthly basis and these
Cloud storages are very reliable meaning
once you put the data in it it's never
going to get lost and these cloud
storage edges are scalable assuming I
have a requirement to store 100 times of
what my actual data size is and I want
it now it's available in the cloud and
these storages are secure as well
because we're talking about data data
virginity they need to be secure and
Amazon provides tools and Technologies
through which we can secure our data and
these are generally not found in the
on-premises storage system so let's talk
about the different types of storage in
general so S3 is cloud storage in AWS
and then we have elastic Block store now
elastic Block store is actually the SSD
hard drives that gets attached to our
ec2 instance you know it's like the C
drive it's like the D drive it's like
the e Drive that gets attached to our
instances now EFS is elastic file system
the underlying technology is kind of the
same but it differs from EBS in a way
that EBS can be accessed only by the
system that's attached to it meaning the
e volumes and the D volumes we spoke
about they can be accessed only if there
is an instance connected to it but these
EFS are actually shared file systems
elastic file system all right they are
shared systems they can be accessed by
multiple systems they can be accessed
from inside the Amazon environment it
can be accessed from on-premises
equipment as well the glacier is
actually the archiving solution in the
cloud if you want to dump a data and try
to keep them in the low cost as possible
then Glacier is the product we should be
using and then we have storage Gateway
if I want to safely move my data from my
local environment to the cloud
environment and also want to keep a copy
of the data locally so users locally can
access them and in a cloud users or
Internet users can access the data from
the cloud if that's your requirement
then storage Gateway is the one we would
be choosing and then we have snowball
snowball is really an data Import and
Export a system but it is actually an
Hardware that gets shipped to our
premises where we can copy a data into
it and then I ship it back to Amazon and
Amazon would copy the data into whatever
destination we give them in our account
and if the data is really huge then I
can call for a snowmobile which is
actually a data center on a truck where
Amazon would send me a truck loaded with
the data center as you see that has
compute capacity lots and lots of
storage capacity and electricity AC and
a lot more so they get compared near our
data center and cables run into our data
center we can copy data into it send it
back to Amazon and they would copy it to
our account in whatever storage that we
advise them so if the data is really
really huge then I would be calling
snowmobiles snowmobile is not available
in all the regions all right let's take
this example how things were where
before S3 was introduced you know two
professionals are having a conversation
and one of them is finding it very
difficult to sort of manage all the data
in the organization well if the data is
small it can be easily managed but as
company grow and we are living in an era
where data is everything we want data to
backup every idea we want data to backup
every proof of concept that we provide
so data is everything so in this era
it's all about collecting data analyzing
them and saving you know not losing logs
you know saving them analyzing stuff
like that so coming back to our
discussion here one person finds it very
difficult to store and manage all the
data that they have so some of the datas
that this person is having problem
storing is datas that application used
to running and then datas that gets sent
to the customers and data us that the
websites require the data that are
because of the email backups and a lot
more are the storages that an Enterprise
can have and this person is having
problem backing up all those data and
even if we think of increasing the local
storage capacity that's going to cost
the fortune and few things that make it
sometimes impossible to increase the
storage capacity in-house is you know we
will have to go and pay heavy to buy
hardware and software to run these
storages and we need to hire a team of
experts for maintaining them the
hardware and the software and anytime if
there is a dynamic increase in the
storage capacity the on-premises or
in-house Hardwares won't be able to
scale and data security data security is
very costly when it comes to building
our own storage environment in-house and
adding data security on top of it so the
other guy in the conversation was sort
of quietly listening everything the
manager was saying and then he slowly
introduced him to S3 because he knew
that all the problem that this manager
was worried about can be solved to S3 in
other words all the scalability all the
data security all the not being able to
provision hardware and software
components are all available with S3 so
that actually brings us to the
discussion about what S3 is S3 is simple
storage service it actually provides an
object storage service let me talk to
you about object and block storage
object storage is where you can store
things in the drive all right you can't
install anything in it and this object
storage can be accessed directly from
the internet whereas block storage is
something that needs to be attached to
an instance and we can't directly access
it but we can install software in it so
that's a high level difference between
object storage and block storage and S3
is an object storage what does that mean
we can store data from the internet we
can retrieve from the internet but we
can't install anything in S3 all right
so so S3 is an object based storage and
it's it's really built for storing and
recovering or retriving any amount of
data or information from anywhere in the
internet few other things you need to
know about S3 is that the Z3 is
accessible through the web interface the
storage one type of accessing or one way
of accessing S3 is by dragging dropping
content into it and another way of
retrieving data from S3 is go to a
browser click on download that's going
to let you download any content and the
data can be five terabytes in size now
we're talking about one file you know
you can have hundreds or thousands of
files like that one file can be as big
as 5 terabytes in size and S3 is
basically designed for developers where
they can push logs into S3 or retrieve
logs anytime they want inside of storing
locally in the server they can use S3 as
code repositories you know where they
can save the code and have the
applications read the code from there
and lot more if they want to safely
share the code with another person with
a lot of encryption and security added
on top of it that's possible as well so
there are a few things about S3 and on
top of all this S3 provides 11 9
durability and four nine availability
meaning durability is if I store the
data will it get lost Amazon is like no
it's not going to get lost you're gonna
have the data because we provide 11 9
durability for the data and availability
is if you want the data now will you be
able to show it Amazon is like yes we
will be able to show it we have 99.99
availability and when you request the
data we will be able to show the data to
you all right so let's talk about the
benefits of S3 S3 is durable as we saw
it provides 11 9 durability S3 is low
cost out of all the storage options in
Amazon S3 is the cheapest ns3 is very
scalable like we were saying there
there's no required to pre-provision a
storage capacity you know if you need
more go ahead and use more if you need
even more go ahead and use even more and
once you're done some data needs to be
removed just remove the data so that
particular month you will be paying less
so it's very scalable in nature and it's
very available as well S3 isn't regional
service you know it's not based on one
availability zone so one availability is
on going down within Amazon the whole
availability going down it's not going
to affect your ability to access S3
storage and S3 is secure a lot of
security features like bucket policy a
lot of security features like encryption
and then MFA authentication are possible
with S3 that actually adds a very good
security layer on top of the data that
we have stored in S3 and not only that
this S3 is very flexible in terms of
cost flexible in terms of where I want
to store the data in terms of cost there
are a lot of pricing tiers within S3 S3
itself is a cheap service now within
that we have a lot of price and tiers
depending on the durability so I can
always choose to put data on a different
storage tier or storage option in S3
we're going to talk about it as you
stick along and in terms of flexibility
in region I can always choose any of the
region available in the console or in
the S3 console to put my data to there
is no restrictions on where I can or
cannot put the data in the cloud as long
as there are regions available for me to
move the data to and data transferring
with S3 is very simple all I have to do
is browse to the bucket upload the data
and the data gets uploaded and we can
also upload data using CLI commands are
very similar to Linux commands are very
similar to what we would use in the Run
command prompt in Windows and what we
would use in the Run command prompt uh
in the Powershell all right let's talk
about a basic building block of S3 which
is bucket and objects now what's a
bucket what's an object object is the
actual data and bucket is the folder
where the objects get stored let me give
you a new definition for object so
object is the actual data plus some
information that reference the data like
is it an JPEG file the name of the file
and at what time it was added to so
they're called metadata right so object
is actually data plus metadata and
bucket is actually a container that
receives the data and safely stores in
it and when we add a data in a bucket
Amazon S3 creates an unique version ID
and allocates it to the object so we can
easily identify it at a later Point let
me show you a quick lab on S3
foreign
console if you're wondering how I
reached here go to Services Under
storage and S3 is right here
and let's create a bucket called simply
learn
now the bucket names will have to be
unique
so I really doubt if simply learn will
be available let's let's check it anyway
all right it doesn't seem to be
available so
um
let me pick another name or let's call
it simply learn that
samuel.com
and I'm gonna put this in
Mumbai or I can choose Oregon
let me choose Oregon
yes let me choose Oregon
and let me create a bucket
sure enough a bucket got created let me
upload an object into the bucket
and you know these objects can be as big
as
five terabytes we talked about it right
all right let me upload an object
all right so that's my object so you get
the relation right here's a bucket
right here's my bucket and within that
is my object now object is the actual
file plus what type of file it is and
then
and then the size of the file the date
in which it got added and the storage
class it is in at the moment
so if I have to access it
I can simply access it through the
internet
so let's talk about how does this S3
bucket work anyway all right so how does
it work a user creates a bucket they
will specify the region in which the
bucket should be deployed we had an
option we could have chosen to deploy in
all the regions Amazon provides S3
service you know beat not Virginia beat
Mumbai B Tokyo beat Sydney uh beat uh
Oregon and we chose Oregon to be the
destination region where we want to
create bucket and save our data there
and when we upload data into the bucket
we can specify three types of storage
classes in our case we pick the default
which was a S3 standard as we saw on the
object data it was on S3 standard so
that's the basic thing later once the
object gets added we can always add a
bucket policies you know policies Define
who access it and who should not access
it what can they access are we going to
allow users only to read or to read
write as well stuff like that so that's
bucket policy we're defining the life
cycle or the lifespan of the data in the
S3 bucket now over the time do you want
the data to automatically move to a
different storage tier and at any point
do you want to sort of expire the data
you know get the data flushed out of
your account automatically you know
those things can be configured in
lifecycle policies and Version Control
is creating multiple versions if you're
going to use S3 for a code repository
creating multiple versions let's say if
you want to roll back to whatever you
had before a month how are you going to
do it if you kept updating the file and
never took a version of it so Version
Control helps us to keep different
versions and it helps us to roll back to
the older version anytime that is a need
so let's talk about the different
storage classes in S3 the different
storage classes in S3 begins with S3
standard now this is the default and
it's very suitable for use case is where
you need less or low latency for example
if you want to access the data of a
student's attendance you would retrieve
them very quickly as much as possible so
that's a good use case to store data in
S3 let's understand the different
storage classes in Amazon S3 now let's
take a school for example and the the
different data is present in a school
and the features of those data the
validity of the data all right so let's
take this example and there are
different storage options in S3 let's
take S3 standard for example and what
would be the actual candidate data that
can be stored in S3 standard let's talk
about that so S3 standard in general is
suitable for use cases where the latency
should be very low and in here the good
example are the good candidate file that
can be stored in S3 is a data that needs
to be frequently accessed and that needs
to be retrieved quickly something like
students attendance report or students
attendance sheet which we access daily
and then it needs to be retrieved
immediately as and when we need it the
other type of storage tier in S3 is
infrequent access or in frequent data
access just like the name says the use
case for that is less frequently
accessed data I mean the candidate data
that should go in infrequent access data
is a student's academic record you know
which we don't need to access on a daily
basis but if there is a requirement we
might want to go and look at it then
that's going to be quick so it's not a
data that we would access on a daily
basis but it's data that needs to show
up on your screen real quick and the
third option is Amazon Glacier now
Glacier is really an archival solution
in the cloud so for archives high
performance is not a requirement so
let's talk about some candidate data
that can go into archives something like
students admission fee and it's not
critical also now anytime if you want to
look at the data you can always wait to
retrieve the data so in other words you
know put it in the archive and the
driving from the archival takes time so
a student's old record are a good
candidate to be put in the archives the
other options are one zone IA storage
class where the data is infrequently
accessed and the data is stored in a
single availability zone for example you
know by default Amazon stores data in
multiple availability zones and there is
a charge for that now it's not an option
but the charge includes storing data in
multiple availability zones but if your
data requirement is you want to keep the
charges in a low even further you can
choose a one's own IA storage class
where it stores data in one availability
Zone and the candidate data that can go
in a one zone in frequent access is
students report card and the other
option with Amazon S3 is standard
reduced redundancy storage it is
suitable for cases where the data is not
critical and the data can be reproduced
quickly for example you know take a copy
of the library book take a copy of the
PDF library book for example now we
would have a source PDF and we would
make copies of it and then we make it
available for the readers to read the
other option in S3 is reduced redundancy
storage here the use case is data that's
not critical and a data can be
reproduced quickly for example a books
in the library are not that critical and
we always have a copy of the book we're
talking about PDF so if the customer
facing or the student facing book gets
deleted I can always copy the same PDF
put it in the destination folder and
make it available for the users to read
that would be a very good use case for
reduced redundancy storage all right
let's summarize everything that we
learned about different storage options
in S3 so S3 standard it's for frequently
accessed data it's the default storage
if you don't mention anything the data
gets stored in S3 standard it can be
used for cloud applications you know
content distribution gaming applications
big data analytic Dynamic websites they
are a very good use case for S3 standard
frequently accessed data the other one
on the contrary is S3 standard
infrequently accessed data just like the
name says the use case is this is good
for data that will be less frequently
accessed and and then the use case are
it's good for backups it's good for
disaster recovery and it's good for
lifelong storage of data Glacier on the
other hand is very suitable for
archiving data which is in frequent only
accessed and the Vault lock feature is
the security feature of the glacier that
also provides a long-term data storage
in the cloud this is the lowest storage
tier within S3 the other options are one
zone in frequent access storage class
just like the name says it's
infrequently accessed and it is stored
in just one availability Zone and use
cases are any data that doesn't require
any high level of security can be stored
here in one zone the fifth storage tier
is reduced redundancy storage this is
good for data that's frequently accessed
it's good for data that is non-critical
and that can be reproduced if it gets
lost and reduce redundancy storage or
RRS is an highly available solution
designed for sharing or storing data
that can be reproduced quickly all right
let's compare and contrast couple of
other features that are available in S3
for example durability availability SSL
support burst bike latency and life
cycle management so in standard the
durability is 11 9 durability it's the
same for standard standard IA one zone
IA Glacier except for reduced redundancy
the durability is 11 9 and availability
of all the storage classes is all the
same except for one zone IA where the
availability zone is 99.5 percentage all
of these products support SSL connection
and the first byte latency of these
products are most of them provide access
with millisecond latency except for
Glacier it provides retrieval time of
couple of minutes to a maximum of hours
and all of them can be used for a life
cycle management you know moving data
from one storage tier to another storage
share that's possible with a all of
these storage options all right now that
we've understood the different types of
storage options available on S3 let's
talk about some of the features that are
available on S3 lifecycle management now
lifecycle management is a service that
helps us to define a set of rules that
can be applied to an object or to the
bucket itself lifecycle is actually
moving the data from one storage tier to
another storage tier and finally
expiring it and and completing the life
cycle of the object with lifecycle
management we can manage and store our
objects in a very cost effective way it
has two features basically transition
actions and expiration actions let's
talk about transition actions with
transition action we can choose to move
the objects or move the data from one
storage class to another storage class
with lifecycle management we can
configure S3 to move our data from one
storage class to another storage class
at a defined time interval or at a
defined schedule let's talk about
transition actions in more detail let's
say we have our data in S3 at the moment
and we haven't used the data for quite
some time and it's that's how it's going
to be for the rest of the time so that
data is a very good candidate to move to
the infrequent axis because S3 standard
is a bit costlier and has three
infrequent access is a bit cheaper than
S3 standards so the kind of usage sort
of fits very well for moving that data
into infrequent access so using
lifecycle transition or lifecycle
management I can move the data to S3
infrequent access after 30 days and
let's say that the data stayed in
infrequent access for 30 more days and
then now I realized that nobody is
looking into the data so I can find an
appropriate storage here for that
particular data again and I can move it
to that particular storage which is
Glacier so in this case after 30 days or
in a total of 60 days from the time the
data got created the data can be moved
to Glacier and what is this really help
us with the life cycle management help
us to automatically migrate our data
from one storage cost to another storage
cost and by that it really helps us to
save the storage cost lifecycle
management can also help us with object
expiration meaning deleting the object
or flushing it out after a certain
amount of time let's say that our
complex requirement requires that we
keep the data for seven years and we
have like thousands and thousands of
data like that it would be humanly
impossible to check all those or keep
track of all the dates and you know when
they need to be deleted stuff like that
but with lifecycle management it is very
much possible I can simply create a data
and set up lifecycle management for the
data to expire after seven years and
exactly after seven years the data is
going to expire meaning it's going to be
deleted automatically from the account
all right let me show you a lab on
lifecycle management and let me explain
to you how it's actually done so I'm
into the bucket that we have created and
here's our data into the bucket assume
we have thousands and thousands of data
in the bucket and that requires to be
put in a different storage tier over
time and that requires to be expired
after seven years let's say so the way I
would create a life cycle management is
go to management from inside the bucket
and click on life cycle and then add and
lifecycle rule just give it a name name
like expire so all the objects that's
present in this bucket meaning the
current version of it set a transition
for it so the transition is at the
moment they are in S3 so here I would
like to put them in infrequent access
after 30 days and then after it's been
an infrequent access for 30 days I would
like to move it to Glacier all right
plus 30 days so how do you read it so
for the first 30 days it's going to be
in Glacier so how do we actually read it
after I put the data in S3 the data is
going to get moved to standard IA and
then it's going to stay in standard IA
and after 60 days from the data creation
it's going to get moved to Glacier so on
the 31st day it's going to move to
standard IE on the 61st day it's going
to move to Glacier let's say if I want
to sort of delete the data if I want the
data to get deleted automatically after
seven years you know being in a glacier
how do I go about doing it let me open
up a quick calculator
365 into 7 that's
2555 days right after that the data is
gonna get deleted pretty much I have
created a life cycle so after on the
31st day it's going to get moved to
infrequent access and on the 61st day
Glacier and after seven years is over
any data that I put in the bucket it's
going to get deleted all right let's
talk about bucket policies bucket
policies are some permission files that
we can attach to an a bucket that allows
or denies access to the bucket based on
what's mentioned in the policy so bucket
policy is really an IM policy where you
can allow and deny permission to an S3
resource with bucket policy we can also
Define security rules that apply to more
than one file in a bucket now in this
case you know we can create an user or
let's say there's already a user called
simply learn or we can allow or deny
that user connection to the SD 3 bucket
or connecting to the S3 bucket using
bucket policy and bucket policies are
written in Json script and let's see how
that's done all right there are tools
available for us to help us create
bucket policies what you're looking at
is a tool available online that helps us
to create a bucket policy so let's use
this tool to create a bucket policy I'm
going to create a deny statement I'm
going to deny all actions to the S3
bucket and what is the Arn to which we
want to attach the Arn of the resources
actually the name of the bucket but it
really expects us to give that key in a
different format so the Arn is available
right here copy bucket Arn so this is
actually going to deny everybody now we
wanted to deny a user just one user now
look at that now we have a policy that
has been created that's denying access
to the bucket and it's denying a user
called simply learn pretty much done so
I can use the policy and go over to
bucket policies so once I save it only
the user calls simply learn won't have
access to the bucket and the rest of
them will have access to it so once I
save it it gets added and only the user
simply learn will not have access to the
bucket because we're denying them
purposefully the other features of S3
include data protection we can protect
our data in S3 with the now one of which
is bucket policy I can also use
encryptions to protect my data I can
also use IM policy to protect my data so
Amazon S3 provides a durable storage not
only that it also gives us unprotected
and scalable infrastructure needed for
any of our object storage requirements
so here the data is protected by two
means one is data encryption and the
other one is data versioning data
encryption is encrypting the data so
others won't get access or even if they
get access to the file they won't be
able to access the data without the
encryption key and versioning is making
multiple copies of the data so let's
talk about them in detail what's data
encryption now data encryption refers to
protecting the the data while it is
being transmitted and protecting the
data while it is at rest now data
encryption can happen in two ways one is
client encryption encryption at rest and
server side encryption encryption that's
in motion client-side encryption refers
to when client sends the data they
encrypt the data and send it across to
Amazon and server side encryption is
when the data is being transferred they
get encrypted and stay encrypted
throughout the transfer versioning is
another security feature let I mean it
helps us so our unintentional edits are
not actually corrupting the data for
example let's say you edited the data
and now you realize that the data is
incorrect and you want it all back now
how do you roll back without versioning
it's not possible in other words only
with versioning it's possible so
versioning it can be utilized to
preserve recovery and restore any early
versions of every object that we stored
in our Amazon S3 bucket unintentional
erases or overrides of the object can be
easily regained if we have versioning
enabled and it's possible only if we
have one file with the same name and
anytime we update the file it keeps the
file name but creates a different
version ID take this bucket and data for
example in a photo.pmg is a file that
was initially stored it attached a
version ID to it and then we edited it
let's say we added some Watermark we you
know added some graphic to it and that's
now the new version of it when we store
it we store it with the same file name
it accepts the same file name but
creates a new version ID and attaches it
anytime we want to roll back we can
always go to the console look at the old
versions pick the version ID and roll
back to the old version ID all right
let's take this example now I'm in a
bucket that we've been using for a while
and let me upload an object now before
we actually upload an object this bucket
needs to be versioning enabled so let me
watch enable this Bucket from this point
onwards this bucket is going to accept
versioning so let me upload an object
photo.jpg let me upload it all right it
successfully got uploaded good enough
it's uploaded now let me upload another
object with the same file name now look
at that it was uploaded at 7 40 35 am
let me upload another object with the
same file name that I have it stored
right here that got up to uploaded but
with the same name
all right so that's the other photo now
what if if I want to switch back the way
I would switch back is simply switch
back to the older version Look at that
this is the latest version and this is
the old version that I have I can simply
switch back to the old version that was
created at such and such time and I can
open it
that's going to open the old file so in
short it creates different version of
the data that I create as long as it's
with the same name and at any point I
can go and roll back to the original
data this is a very good use case if you
want to use S3 for storing our codes
let's talk about other feature like
cross region replication now cross
region the application is an very cool
feature if you want to automatically
keep a copy of the data in a totally
different region for you know data
durability for any additional data
durability or if you want to serve data
to your customers who live in another
country or who are accessing your data
from another country if you want to
serve the data with low latency cross
region replication is a very cool
feature that you can use and get
benefited from and let's see how that's
done so before we actually do a lab on
Cross region replication let's put
together a proper definition for it
cross region application is a feature
that provides automatic copying of every
object uploaded to our bucket or your
bucket Source bucket and it
automatically copies the data to the
destination bucket which is in a
different AWS region as you see here in
the picture I put data only in region
one it's going to copy the data to
region 2. and for us to use cross region
replication versioning must be turned on
so it creates versions and copies the
versions as well if tomorrow the
original region goes down let's say the
other region will be active and it has
the complete data that was present in
the original region or at any point if
we want to Simply you know cut the
region replication and use the other
bucket as in Standalone bucket it can be
used as well because it already has all
the data that was present in the master
or all the data that was present in the
original replication bucket let's see
how that's done so there are two things
needed one is versioning and another one
is role when we transfer data from a one
bucket to another bucket we need proper
permissions to do so and these roles
they give us proper permissions to
transfer data from one bucket to another
bucket let's see how that's done right
so here's my bucket a bucket in US organ
let's create another bucket
and
Mumbai
call it dot Mumbai
.com
and put it in
put it in Mumbai
or create that bucket in Mumbai there
you go we have one in Oregon we have one
in Mumbai we're planning to replicate or
create application between these two
right create application between these
two buckets so go to the first bucket go
to management and start a replication
add a rule so all content in this bucket
is going to get replicated this is my
source bucket it's quite simple select
the destination bucket now my
destination bucket is going to be simply
learn.samual.mumbai.com all right it
says well you have versioning enabled in
your Source bucket but not on your
destination bucket do you want to enable
it now without which we won't be able to
proceed further so let's go ahead and
enable versioning through the console
that shows up and then like I said it's
going to require permission to put data
onto the other bucket now I can create
different roles these are different
roles that are used for different other
services I can also choose to create a
role that specifically gives permission
only to move the data from one bucket to
another bucket three months it's done so
if I go over to my source bucket and if
I add some data to it let's say
index.html assuming I'm adding some
files to it in theory they should move
to the other region automatically there
you go I'm in the Mumbai region and the
data is they got moved to the other
region automatically let's talk about
the other feature called transfer
acceleration now it's a very handy and a
helpful tool or a service to use if we
are transferring data which is very long
distance from us meaning from the client
to the SD bucket let's say from my local
machine which is in India if I transfer
the data over to Oregon let's say so
long distance if it is going to go
through the internet it's going to go
through high latency connections and my
transfer might get delayed if it is an 1
gigabit file it's okay but if we're
talking about anything that's uh you
know five terabyte size now if you're
talking about anything that's a five
terabyte in size then uh it's not going
to be a pleasant experience so in those
cases I can use transfer accelerator uh
with which in a secure way but in a fast
way or a fastest way transfers my data
from the laptop or from client to the S3
bucket and it makes use of a service
called cloudfront to transfer or to
enable the data acceleration so the way
it would do it is instead of copying the
data directly to the location instead of
copying the data directly to the
destination bucket it copies the data
locally into a cloudfront location which
is available very local to whatever
place we are in and from there it copies
the data directly to an S3 bucket not
going through the internet it helps
eliminate a lot of latency that could
get added when transferring the data so
let's see how that's done
right here I'm in the S3 bucket and
under properties I can find transfer
accelerator and if I enable transfer
accelerator so I'm in another bucket let
me go to properties and let me go to
transfer accelerator and enable transfer
accelerator so now if I put data into
this bucket they're gonna get copied to
the local cloudfront location and from
there they're gonna get copied to the S3
Bucket from the cloud front now if we
need to compare you know how the speed
is going to be compared to directly
putting the data to the internet and
using cloudfront there is a tool
available that actually runs for a while
and then comes with a report that tells
me how much will be the improved speed
if I use transfer accelerator and it
shows for all the regions available in
Amazon so from the source to the
destination if you want to put uh you
know what's the normal and what's the
accelerated speed when you transfer the
data those results we will get it in the
screen so at the moment this tool is
going through its testing like uploading
some file through the internet and
uploading some file using cloudfront and
it has come up with the calculation that
if I'm uploading file to San Francisco
compared to uploading through the
internet and through cloudfront it's 13
times faster so similar way it's going
to calculate for all the regions
available and it's going to give me a
result welcome to this new learning
series called I am a service in AWS for
security here in this section we're
going to talk about what is Security in
AWS and then we're going to slowly or
gradually move on to the other topics
like types of security available in AWS
out of all the services y IM is the most
preferred one and then we're going to
talk about what is IM in general how it
works the building blocks or components
in IM and the features it the the
attractive features that provides that
makes IAM stand out from the rest of the
services available we're going to talk
about that and then we're going to end
today's session with a demo about how
IAM gets well interacted with other
services in Amazon and help create a
secure environment in the cloud let's
talk about AWS security Now Cloud
security is the highest priority in AWS
and when we host our environment in the
cloud we can be rest assured that we are
hosting our environment in a data center
or in a network architecture that's
really built to meet the requirement of
the most security sensitive organization
and this high level of security is
available to us on a pay as you go type
meaning there is really no upfront cost
at that we need to pay and the cost for
using the service is a lot lot cheaper
than what it is in an on-premises
environment so AWS Cloud provides a
secure your virtual platform where we
can deploy our application now compared
to the on-premises with AWS the security
level is very high and the cost involved
in using or attaching that type of
security to our application is very low
compared to on-premises there's really
no upfront cost and the cost is very
lower whatever cost that we pay is very
lower than what it would be in
on-premises and all this contributes to
the secure environment we can get
through IM in AWS Cloud there are really
many types of security services
available in AWS to name a few or to
name the familiar ones IM stands first
followed by a key management system KMS
and then we have Cognito that's another
service and web access firewall Waf is
another security service in AWS now
let's start our discussion by talking
about IM and that's what this whole
series is about now I am or identity and
access management it really enables us
to manage access to AWS services and AWS
resources in a very secure manner with
IM we can create groups we can actually
allow those users or groups to access
some servers or we can sort of deny them
to access the service whichever we want
that's all possible through identity and
access management and this feature comes
with no additional charge now let's talk
about how things were before AWS before
AWS or before I am in general it was not
that safe in a corporate to share the
password over the phone or through the
email that was the practice that was
existed at that time now we all can
remember the days when we need to switch
to a different account or we had just
one admin password commonly stored in a
location or one person would reset it
and maintain it and anytime or we need
to log in we call the person ask for the
admin password word over the phone and
then we try logging in now that was not
secure at all back then you know
somebody could walk by and sort of
eavesdrop and get the password now they
walk away with the password with them so
they're all possible when we share the
password over the phone and through the
internet or email now with AWS a lot of
options are available that I'm not
sharing password over the unsecured
medium now a slack is a third-party
product available with AWS it's not an
AWS product but slack is a third-party
application that's hosted on AWS and
it's really a communication tool that
helps people to share a documents so now
we're not sharing the password over the
phone rather through the applications
and the no eavesdrop person can really
catch the password and you know try it
in their system to access our
environment that's not possible so you
see the difference now back then sharing
password was only through phone and
email and you would write it on a paper
and you give it to somebody but now
technology is providing Provisions
enough for us to share the password in a
secure way we're still talking about I
am I am is an web servers for securely
controlling access to the AWS resource
now it really helps us to authenticate
our sort of limit access to a certain
set of users accessing the AWS account
or certain set of users accessing a
certain set of resources in AWS account
now you see this picture we have an IM
administrator who's trying to allocate
permissions to different group of people
so we have group one on the top and
group two in the middle and group 3
towards the end the administrator using
im or IAM empowers the administrator
allow access to certain group to certain
resources that's what IAM is all about
now let's talk about the building blocks
or let's talk about the elements that
make and complete I am so the elements
are category into six different elements
we have the principle in IM the
authentication the request the actual
request coming in the authorization
allowing denying access actions what are
the scope of actions can be taken and on
what resource is it easy to visit RDS is
it S3 bucket so what resource these
actions are applied to so they are the
basic elements of an IM workflow let's
talk about principle for example an
action on AWS resource can only be
performed by a principal an individual
user they can be a principal a role in
AWS IM it can be a principle as well in
other words a principle is an entity
that can take an action on an AWS
resource you know a principle can be an
user a principle can be a role a
principle can be an application that's
trying to access the AWS environment
secondly authentication now
authentication is a process of
confirming the I identity of the
principle trying to access the AWS
environment now how do we get
authenticated or how does a user get
authenticated by providing credentials
or the required keys to validate that
this is what he or she is as per what's
in the record so all principle must be
authenticated and we get authenticated
using the username and password to log
into the console if it is CLI or we get
authenticated using the axis key and the
secret access key the other component
that makes up IM is request when a
principal tries to use the AWS
Management console what the principle is
doing or what the user is doing is
sending a request to the AWS environment
and the request will have the principal
actually wants to perform is it an put
request or is it a get request or is it
a delete request stuff like that and
it's also going to carry information
about on which resource the action needs
to be done is it done easy to one is it
on S3 bucket simplylearn.com stuff like
that so it has a specific action that it
wants to perform and the resource on
which it wants to perform and also some
information about from where the request
is originating from is it within an AWS
environment or is it with another cloud
service provider or is it with
on-premises stuff like that so these
information will be present in the
request authorization now this IAM uses
information from the request context to
check for matching policies and it
determines it takes a decision whether
to allow or to deny the request now here
it has a logic by default all the
resources are denied and the IM
authorizes your request only if every
part of the request is allowed by a
matching policy so there is an
evaluation logic and that says by
default all requests are denied and if
there is an explicit allow then it
overrides the default deny and if you
are explicitly denying a service then
all all the allow statements gets
overridden and all the other statements
gets over return and this explicit deny
stands by default only the AWS account
root user has access to all the
resources in that account so if you're
not signed in as a root user then we
must be specifically granted permission
through a policy in other words we need
to be authorized through the policy now
let's talk about action now after
authenticating and authorizing the
request AWS approves the action that we
are about to take Now using action we
can view the content we can create a
Content or create a bucket or create an
ec2 instance I can edit content or even
I can delete a resource that's all based
on the action that I'm allowed to do now
that was about actions now where is the
action performed the action is performed
on the resources a set of actions can be
performed on a resource and anything
that's not mentioned in the action or
any anything that's not tagged with the
action and the resource they don't get
to complete for example let's say if you
attempt to delete an IM role and you
also request to access the ec2 instance
for that role then the request gets
denied now let's talk about some of the
other components of Im so the other
components are IM are the basic building
block is in user and then many users
together they form a group and then
policies are the engines that allows or
denies a connection based on policy one
gets to access or gets no access to a
resource and then rows roles are another
component roles are temporary
credentials I would say that can get
assumed to an instance as and when
needed right let's talk about this
component called user in an IM with IM
we can securely manage access to AWS
services and we can create an IM user
anytime there is a new employee joining
our car operate so it's a one-to-one
mapping you know one user or one
employee get a username directly
attached to them and a username or a
user is an account specific thing you
know it's very local to that AWS account
that we are using so for in detail and
IM user is an entity that we create in
an AWS environment to represent a person
or a service that interacts with AWS
environment and this user is going to
have some credentials attached to them
and by default they do not have a
password and they do not have any access
key or secret access key attached to
them in fact literally no credentials of
any kind now we must create a user and
we must create the type of credential
that gets attached to the user do they
want to access CLI So based on that we
would be adding credentials to them a
user by default is not authorized to
perform any action in AWS and the
advantage of having one to one user is
that we can assign permissions
individually to that user for example we
might want to assign administrative
permissions to few users who can
administer our AWS environment and users
are entity within an AWS account users
don't have to pay separately you know
they start using the servers and that
get bills under the account they are
attached to so separate users doesn't
mean that separate payment for those
users they are just users in our account
and you know the whole account gets to
pay for the resources that they
provision again the IM user does not
always represent a person an IM user is
really just an identity with Associated
credential and permissions attached to
it it could be an actual person who is a
user and it could be an application also
a who's a user next we'll talk about
groups talking about groups or
understanding group is very easy a
collection of user forms an IM group and
we can use IIM group to specify
permission for multiple users so that
any permission that's applied to the
group is also applied to the users who
are an ad to that group now there are a
few things you might want to know about
group a group can have many users and a
user they can belong to many groups but
groups can't be nested meaning group can
only have users you know a group cannot
have a group inside a group that's not
possible and there's nothing called a
default group that sort of automatically
includes all users in the AWS account if
you want to have a group then we will
have to create a group now let's take
this diagram for example now this is a
diagram of a small company now the
company owner creates an admin group for
users to create and manage other users
as the company expands every day and the
admin group creates a developer group
and a test group each of these group
consists of users users who are people
users who are application that interact
with AWS environment so the different
types of users we have are Jim is a user
Brad is an user and Dev app one is a
user and and so on so each users have an
individual set of security credentials
so like I said it's one to one and the
uh 10 users that we see on screen are
shared between or they belong to
multiple groups in the account and
managing group is quite easy we set
permission to the group and that
permission gets applied to all the users
automatically in the group and after we
applied the policy if I add another user
to the group the new user will
automatically inherit all the policies
all the permissions that's already
mentioned in that group so
administrative button is sort of taken
away administrative button about user a
privilege or user permission management
is sort of taken out with IM all right
the next thing we would want to discuss
is policy a policy sets permission and
controls the access to AWS resource and
the policies these permissions and
controls are stored in Json format a
policy is a very clear document it
defines who has access to a resource and
what are all the actions they can
perform so in other words policies and
entity in AWS that when a policy gets
attached to an identity or a resource
you know it really defines the
permission what they can and cannot do
and AWS it evaluates these policies when
a principal such as a user makes an
request and the permission statement and
the policy it really defines whether the
usage is allowed to access a service or
is he denied to access a service all
right let's take this example now we
have a task the task is to give Paul who
is a developer access to Amazon S3
environment and what you're looking at
is a snippet of what a policy would look
like so these are some questions we will
have to answer or these are some
questions the policy tries to answer and
once it found an answer then it becomes
a complete policy so who wants access to
the service it's Paul who wants access
to the service and what action do Paul
want now Paul wants to download or Paul
wants to upload objects in S3 in Json
language it's otherwise called Paul
wants to get information Paul wants to
put information otherwise Paul wants to
get object Paul wants to put object in
S3 and which resource does he want now
in this case every bucket the star
symbol represents all buckets in S3 so
which results its all bucket in S3 so we
can start reading already from the data
present here so who wants access Paul
wants access what action does he want he
wants to get he wants to put and what's
the resource that he's trying to access
or you want to give him access it's all
the bucket in AWS and when does he want
these are additional statement that goes
in a policy so since when does he want
that access he wants access till March
2nd 2019. so all this who all this
action all this resource you know till
the time all this gets allowed so this
is the statement that really defines now
does this all refer to an allow
statement or does this all refer to a
deny statement if we had deny here it's
the direct opposite of what we discussed
but we have allow that means Paul is
allowed to get and put access in an S3
bucket and all the buckets in S3 till
March 2nd 2019 he's allowed to access
the resources so if we put together put
all the information that we have
gathered or all the answers that we have
so far if we put together in Json format
this is how it's gonna look like so the
effect is allow or deny here it's
allowing and the principle is any now
who can access it it's any an action
it's any bucket in S3 any action in s
actually put get request and the
resource is any bucket in S3 so that's
how a basic policy would look like or
that's how a basic policy is formed by
answering those basic questions so let's
talk about the types of policies so we
have two broad categories manage policy
and inline policy the manage policy it's
the default policy that we attach to
multiple entries be users beat groups
and beat roles in our AWS account on the
other hand inline policy are the
policies that we create and manage them
and these policies are emboded directly
into a single user group or a role so if
I need to brief it a little bit more
then a managed policies are Standalone
identity based policies that we can
attach to multiple users groups and
roles in our AWS account we can use two
types of managed policies in other words
manage policies they themselves have two
categories one is AWS managed policies
which is created and managed by AWS and
the other one is customer managed
policies just like the name says it's
managed by the customer now we can
create and edit an IM policy in visual
editor or simply create a Json policy
document directly and upload it in the
console and start using them so that's
manage policy on the other hand inline
policies are policies that we create and
manage and that are embedded directly
into a single user group or role let's
talk about this next component called
role now this role is very similar to
everything that we discussed so far it's
a set of permission that defines what
actions are allowed and denied by an
entity in an AWS console the role is
very similar to end user I said very
similar I didn't say it's the same as
the user but I said it's very similar to
the user and the difference is that user
is hard-coded user permissions are
hard-coded but the role permissions are
accessed by any entity in a beta user or
a beat and AWS service and moreover the
role permissions are temporary on the
other hand user permissions are
permanent and the role permissions are
temporary
so in detail a role is very similar to a
user in that it's an AWS entity with
permission policies that determines what
the identity can and cannot do in AWS
now instead of it being uniquely
associated with one person a role is
intended to be assumable by anyone who
needs it roles generally do not have a
long term credential you know password
or access Keys associated with it you
know it does not have long-term
credentials it only has temporary
credentials created dynamically and
provided to the user as in when the user
assumes a role and wants to access any
service roles can be assumed by users
roles can be assumed by applications
roles can be assumed by services that
normally we don't have access to AWS
resources for example you might want to
Grant a user in your AWS account access
to your resource that they do not
normally have or Grant users in one area
previous account access to resource in
another AWS account now this is
something that we don't have by default
and this is something we may not need
all the time or you might want to allow
a mobile app to use AWS resource but you
do not want to save the key or save the
credential or save the passwords in the
mobile app or sometimes you might want
to give access to resources who already
have identities defined outside of AWS
like a user who's already and Google or
Facebook authenticator if you want to
give them some service or if you want to
let them to access some of the resources
in your account we can use roles for
that purpose or you also might want to
Grant access to your account to a third
party a consultant or an auditor so they
can for some time get some temporary
access to audit our AWS resources
remember they're not permanent users
just template users they want some
temporary access to our environmental
the audit is over so for those cases is
roles are a very good use case so let's
take this example let's see where roll
sits and let's see how roles give
permission to other services so here is
a scenario where where an easy to
instance wants access to an S3 bucket by
default though both of them were created
by the same username are the same admin
they do not have access by default so by
default they don't have access and I
also do not want to give permanent
access in a one-on-one hard-coded
permanent access instead I would like to
create and share access so that's
possible through rule so coming back to
the discussion uh the scenario here is
that an ac2 instance wants to access
data in an S3 bucket so the first thing
is to create a role or a permission we
saw how that's done right using policies
roles use policies policy is the actual
working engine for any permission
related actions right so create a role
with an appropriate policy that gives
access to S3's bucket and then launch an
ec2 instance with the role attached to
it we said rules are assumed by any
entity right it would be user it could
be an application it could be a service
it could be another resource in AWS
account so here it's another resource in
AWS account right so we create a role
and we attach it to an ec2 instance so
now the ec2 instance can assume the role
now the same role can be attached to
another ec2 instance the same role can
be attached to another user the same
role can be attached to another database
service we get the idea right roles can
be assumed by anyone so when the ec2
instance wants to communicate with S3 it
contacts the role and then the role
gives this ec2 instance some temporary
username and password that expires after
one hour let's say so it's a temporary
username and password now with that
temporary username and password the ec2
instance can access the uh S3 bucket and
access the file with the credential that
it already has and that credential is a
temporary one and other credential will
expire after one hour or how much of a
Time the admin sets it to be and then
the next time when is when an ec2
instance wants to contact S3 it will
have to contact the rule and the role
will propose a new access key and secret
access key in other words a new
credential with that new credential the
second time the ec2 instance will be
able to contact the S3 bucket and get
the information so the password is not a
permanent or a one-time or a hard-coded
password it keeps rotating it's a token
it's a secure token that an ec2 instance
or any application that uses the role
gets to access the resources on the
other end so let's talk about the
features of IM the main feature of IM is
that I can create separate username and
password for individual users or closes
and I can delegate access no those days
where we had just one username and
password for admin and we need to call
the other person to get the username and
password over the phone if it gets
compromised you know the whole account
gets compromised stuff like that those
issues are gone I can create separate
username and password for all thousand
users in my account no more username and
password sharing I can manage access to
all those thousand accounts in a very
simple and an easy way so IM provides
share access for all the Thousand users
in my account it provides share access
to the AWS environment and the
permissions that can be given through IM
are very granular now we saw how
restrictions can be put on get request
you know we can allow a user to download
information and not update an
information so that's possible through
the IM policies that we looked at some
time back and with the use of roles you
know we're authenticating an ec2
instance answer of the application
running on top of it so if there are
like 10 or 20 up applications running on
top of an ec2 instance instead of
creating a separate username and
password for all those 20 instances I
can create a role and assign that role
to the ec2 instance and all the
applications running on the ec2 instance
get a secure access to the other
resources use the role credential that's
provided to that ec2 instance now
besides username and password IM also
supports multi-factor authentication
where we provide a credential the
username and password plus and OTP from
our phone or an randomly generated
number that gets displayed in our phone
before Amazon console or before Amazon
CLI would authenticate and lets us
access some of the service in the
account so it's called multi-factor
authentication it's username and
password plus something else from what
you have I am also provides identity
Federation if a user is already
authenticated with the corporate ad or
Facebook or Google you know IM can be
made to trust that authentication method
and then allow access based on that
authentication now without Federation
what would happen is the users will have
to remember two passwords you know one
for on-premises and one for cloud
anytime they work on on premises they'll
have to use one set of password and
anytime they switch to the cloud which
is going to be very frequent in uh every
day so anytime they switch to the cloud
they will have to again type in the
cloud username and password now with
identity Federation we can sort of
Federate or we can connect both the
authentication systems both on-premises
and Im so users can just use one
username and password for both
on-premises and Cloud environments and
all that we saw so far it's free to use
there is no additional charge for IM
security there is no additional charge
for creating additional users groups or
policies it's a free service comes along
with any account IMS and PCI DSS
compliant product now IM comes with
password policy where we can reset the
password remotely or rotate the
passwords remotely and we can set rules
like how a user should pick an password
it should not be the one that was used
in the past any of the past three times
stuff like that so you get the idea
right how the features of IM help us to
build and a secure authentication and
authorization system in or for our AWS
account all right it's time to do a
quick lab let's let's put all the
knowledge that we have earned so far
together and apply it and try a lab and
solve the problem so here is a problem
statement we need to create an S3 bucket
for a company where users can read or
write the data only if they are
multi-factor authenticated so there
could be like 20 users in an account but
a user is allowed to to read or write a
data in an S3 Market only if the user is
multi-factor authenticated now this is a
very good use case if we have a
sensitive data in an S3 bucket and you
only want privileged or MFA
authenticated users to do changes to
those buckets and for those privileged
users you would enable multi-factor
authentication so let's see how that's
done before that let me talk to you a
bit more about multi-factor
authentication a multi-factor
authentication is that additional level
of security process it's provided by AWS
here the user's identity is confirmed
only after the user proposes or the user
passes two level of verification now one
being the username and password and
another being an OTP that gets generated
in this case it's the mobile phone it
could also be an RSA token key that
generates the one-time password that's
possible as well but in this case it's
the mobile phone now that's going to be
very similar to how we login to our
Gmail account sometimes when we log into
a Gmail account and I mean if you have
the proper setting enabled it's going to
send an 110 password to mobile phone and
only after we put that information it's
going to let us log in let's see how all
this is done in an AWS account so the
first thing is to log in to the AWS
account create a user and attach the
user to the virtual MFA device now we're
going to use Google Authenticator here
and we're going to attach the user to
Google Authenticator and make the user
use the Google Authenticator one-time
password every time he logs in to the
account now this is an addition to the
username and password that he or she
already has right so the first thing is
to log into the account connect or sync
the virtual Appliance with the AWS
username and password now when we sync
there will be an one-time password that
gets shown in the phone type in the
password in the AWS console and then the
phone and the username comes to sync and
from that point onwards the user anytime
they log in they will have to propose
their username and password which is the
first step of security and then once
they typed in the username and password
type in the MFA code that gets generated
on the phone that would be the second
step of security or the last step of
security once that is done the account
is going to let them log in and access
the AWS resources all right so in order
to test IM MFA S3 together this is what
we're gonna do so we're gonna create a
bucket and we're gonna have two users
and we're gonna allow or deny access to
the S3 bucket to those two users based
on whether they are MFA authenticated or
not and on purpose we're going to assign
MFA to one user and no MFA to the other
user like you might have guessed by now
the user with MFA will have access to
the bucket and the user with no MFA
attached will not have access to the
bank both of them are going to have full
S3 services but MFA like I said is one
layer above the other permissions MFA
stands at all time so irrespective of
whether the underlying policy says but
they have full access to the S3 bucket
they are not going to because MFA stands
on top of it let's see how that's done
to begin with firstly we need a bucket
so let's create a bucket
so I'm in my AWS console so let me go to
S3
and in here create a bucket call that
bucket as simply learn MFA bucket and
let me put it in North Virginia and
create
all right so that's done
now I'm going to put a separate folder
in here
I'm going to create another folder in
here and the name of the folder is tax
documents now this is where I'm planning
to keep my tax files
and I only want my privileged users to
be able to upload and download
information from the tax document so on
the bucket side it's partially done or
on the S3 side it's partially done so
let's go back to IAM and here we're
going to create two users one a junior
employee and another one and a senior
employee the senior employee is the one
who's going to have MFA access and more
access to the S3 bucket and the junior
employee is the one who's not going to
have access to that particular bucket so
let's get started let's create an user
under iam
click on users and let's create a user
called as user
Junior
right so he's a junior user
and for the password
set a password
the user does not need to create a new
password at sign in because it's a test
environment and the user who creates the
username and the user are the same
person so let's keep it simple username
password Management console access
and this user is going to have full S3
bucket access all right this is really
the policy
we should be familiar with this Json
document by now it says effect is
allowed and what action any action in S3
and what resource anybody who's attached
to it review
and create a user
so this user is having S3 full access
now let's create another user call them
as senior employee
all right attach
a policy to the user
you know from the surface level both of
them have the same permissions both of
them have S3 full access
all right so both of them have S3 full
access as we see
there's one thing different we're going
to do to this senior employee now we're
going to attach MFA to this employee so
the way we would do it is under the
summary section of that particular user
click on security credential and see
here is a place we can attach an MFA to
this user so let's attach MFA to this
user for MFA I can use both virtual MFA
or Hardware MFA this being in lab
environment we're going to use Virtual
MFA now that is an application there are
a lot of applications available but
there is one application that I'm using
at the moment called Google
Authenticator
so once we have installed the
application and once it is running
so I can go to Virtual MFA device and
once it is running I can scan the code
using the Google Authenticator in my
mobile phone once you turn on the
application and once you do scan the
barcode that is showing right here now
that's going to give us codes that we
can use and we will have to put in those
codes here twice we'll have to wait for
some time and it will generate a second
set of key that we can put so my first
set of key is four zero two three five
one right I'll have to wait for some
time and then it would throw me a second
set of key it's like validating twice
right here so let me put in my second
set of key
so this user is now MFA authenticated
user so anytime this user logs in it's
going to ask for MFA anytime this user
proposes something it's going to attach
the MFA key along with it all right so
we're done with IM what have you done
with IM we have created two users both
of them have s34 access but one of them
have MFA access and the other one does
not have MFA access and based on whether
the user is having MFA or not you know
we're identifying privileged users by
this MFA right so based on whether the
user has MFA or not are we going to
allow deny access in the S3 bucket
so we already have a bucket we already
have a folder and this is a very
privileged folder path here I would like
to restrict access based on whether the
user is having MFA or not
so let me create a bucket policy here
now here's a policy that I have written
the policy says that you know under tax
document folder give access only if the
user is MFA authenticated right if the
user is not MFA authenticated simply
deny the access to that user so as you
might guess right now the user 1 will
not have access or the junior employee
you will not have access because it's a
privilege and you know Junior employee
might tend to delete them unknowingly
and only privileged users get access to
the tax document because it's
confidential because it's privileged
because if it gets deleted we won't be
able to get it back for those reasons
right so apply the bucket policy
now try logging in as
the different users and see how the
permissions are applied on both the
users all right so let's make a note of
the IM URL
and then the two usernames and password
let's login
so let me log in as the privileged user
sure enough I'm being asked for an MFA
code let me put my MFA code
so let's directly navigate to the S3
bucket
right here's my privileged path let me
try uploading some content
claim forms
sure enough I'm able to upload content
into it will I be able to delete
yes I'm able to delete as well now let's
see what's the situation for the other
user
so let's log in as the other user
navigate to the SC bucket
if you noticed when logging in it did
not ask for an MFA code because the user
is not set up for MFA
so navigate to the folder which we want
to test
now try adding some files
as you see it's failing to add content
to this bucket it shows error because
the bucket policy is requiring MFA and
this user is not MFA and we did that in
IEM or under iam
but still as you see you know they will
be able to view the content in the
bucket they can do all that we have
specifically restricted access to upload
and download content from the bucket and
that's exactly this user is now denied
with welcome to this new video Lesson
where we're going to learn about plot
formation in this section we're going to
learn about why we need a solution
called cloud formation or why we need a
product called cloud formation and we're
going to talk in detail about what is
cloud formation and then how cloud
formation works and the concepts
involved in cloud formation like I know
templates and stacks there are some
Concepts involved in cloud formation
we're going to talk about that and how
do we maintain access control over cloud
formation we're going to talk about that
as well in this video and then we're
going to go through a demo or a lab
where we create an lamp stack
environment from a template through
cloud formation and then we're going to
talk about some use cases one of which
include being able to create it and
redeployable template using cloud
formation that's a very good use case
we're going to talk about that in this
video so let's talk about why cloud
formation so when the number of products
and services grow more and managing them
and maintaining them becomes an tedious
work and cloud formation is sort of
eases that environment now cloud
formation is really an infrastructure as
the code and it sort of solves all the
problem that we discussed sometime back
and with cloud formation we can actually
create a perfect clone of the server
configuration at any point in time and
we can also manage the configuration
changes and configuration changes with
cloud formation we can manage the
configuration changes across the
environment and not only that we can
easily embed in the ad hoc changes to
our existing environment so one might
ask why use cloud formation let's look
at the current problem that we have
creating and managing multiple aw
results in the portal is a big task
especially when you need to replace some
Services it becomes an bigger task now
cloud formation eases that word let me
explain it in detail now at the moment
without the cloud formation or
environments that don't use cloud
formation have this problem that is lot
of time is being spent on building the
infrastructure and less focus and less
time at the moment is being given on
developing that application that runs on
that environment that's because majority
of the time is consumed by building the
environment and if we need to redeploy
the same environment again and again the
same happens in a cycle again in a new
environment we start from the scratch
build environment and then put
application on top of it now that can be
avoided using cloud formation now
without cloud formation still is a
problem because the the resource or the
bandwidth that is needed for the
application development is not provided
because that's taken by developing the
infrastructure and to solve that problem
we we can use cloud formation now that
leads to a discussion about what is
cloud formation so let's talk about or
let's try understanding what cloud
formation is cloud formation is a
service that provides users a simple way
to create and manage collection of AWS
Resources by provisioning and updating
them in a very orderly and in a
predictable way if I need to expand the
explanation of cloud formation cloud
formation is a service that really helps
us to model and set up our Amazon web
services or resources so we can spend
less time on managing the resources and
show more focus on the application that
runs on top of it we can simply create a
template for an ec2 instance or for an
RDS instance and upload it in the cloud
formation portal and cloud formation
will provision and configure those
resources based on the template that we
Define we really don't have to sort out
the complexities in dependency between
those applications once again template
is vetted and validated cloud formation
takes the responsibility of handling the
dependencies between the application in
an orderly and a predictable way it
creates those services and makes it
available for us once the template is
fully run so in short the cloud
formation it allows us to create and
model our infrastructure and
applications without we having to
perform the manual action for example
the well-known company called Expedia is
able to easily manage and run its entire
front and back-end resources they run on
AWS in cloudfront what does that mean
they are spending less time on managing
infrastructure and More Time On The Core
Business and application that runs on
top of it and we're still talking about
what plot formation is with cloud
formation it enables us to manage our
complete infrastructure or AWS resource
in a text file now we're going to see
that in a moment you know it's either a
Json or an yaml file and that file is
called as the template to begin with the
resources the template provision is
called the stack all right so the
abstract of the code is called the
template and the resource that it
Provisions is called the stack and this
stack can be I mean it's going to run
resources obviously and those resources
can be updated as well it's not like
once you create a stack it's done if you
need a change you need to go create
another resource that's not needed this
stack is an updatable stack let's say if
I'm including two more servers if I'm
sort of extending my environment it's
branching out to another application now
I'm including another functionality in
my environment all those can be emboded
in the update and can be updated so like
I said the stack is an updatable one now
let's talk about what the template can
do or some features and functionality of
the template Now using a template we can
almost include all the application and
resources that a user might require
let's say you know after the easier to
instances provision running an
application on top of it and you want to
templatize that and include that in the
template that's possible as well and
these templates are portable ones
meaning I can use the template in one
region and I can use the same template
in another region and that's going to
build a very similar environment in
another region I can also share that
with the customer and when they run it
it's going to run an environment from
the portable template in their account
in their environment of course all the
security is taken care I'm just saying
that if we need to build a resource if
you need to build an architecture if you
need to build an environment which looks
very similar to the other environment
that is possible and and these templates
are usable by the use of some sections
in the template like the parameter
section the mapping section the
condition section within the template is
what makes the templates reusable and we
will talk about parameters mapping and
conditions down the line we're still
talking about AWS how AWS cloud
formation works and we're going to talk
about how a template becomes an
infrastructure right so to begin with
one requires a template and the template
would be in Json or yml format so one
would develop a template based on the
requirement based on number of ec2
instances based on whether they want a
load balancer based on whether they want
and a Windows Server based on whether
they want an database server in that
environment and then based on the
applications that will be running on top
of it that can be templatized in the
code itself so one creates a code and
then the code is saved locally or they
can be put in an S3 Bucket from which
the cloud formation will call the
template and provision the resource
right so we use cloud formation to
create a stack or create the resource
defined in the template and
cloudformation analyzes the template
first validates template and then it
identifies the dependencies between them
and then it starts from provisioning the
resource one after the other for example
if you need five servers in a new VPC
obviously it's going to create the VPC
first and servers second and stack all
right let's understand the two major
components in cloud formation by now you
might have guessed it the two major
components are the template and the
stack together the aid or they
complement cloud formation and that's
how the resource of provision that's how
the results are managed and that eases
the job of the administrator who's
managing the environment so let's talk
about template first a template in cloud
formation is an text file or a formatted
text file in Json or yaml language and
that the code or the template or the
text file that actually describes how
your infrastructure looks like or will
look like one's provision and for us to
create the template or for us to you
know modify an existing template we can
use a tool available called cloud
formation designer from the console or
any text editing tool that's available
but I would recommend the cloud
formation designer though that has a
rich Graphics in it and these templates
are built off or they consist of nine
main objects the first of which is the
format version and this really
identifies the capabilities of the
template based on the version number and
then the second object in a template
would be description and this helps us
to include any arbitrary comments about
the template for what reason are we
building this template what's the
purpose of it stuff like that and then
we have the object called metadata in a
template and that includes a details
about the template details of the
resources in the template and then we
have the optional parameters section
this really helps us to customize our
template now parameters enable us to
input custom values to our template each
time we create or update and stack and
the mapping object it helps us to match
a key to a corresponding set of named
values for example if you want to set a
value based on a region then we get to
create a mapping that uses region name
as the key and then the value that we
want to specify for each specific
regions and then we have conditions
object this is again an optional object
with this we can include statements that
Define when a resource is created or
when a property is defined for example
we can compare whether a value is equal
to another value and based on the result
of that condition we can conditionally
create additional resources and then the
object called transform it's it's an
optional object as well and this
transforms section specifies one or more
transforms that we can use in our cloud
formation template for example uh AWS
cloud formation transforms helps
simplify template authoring by
condensing the expression of the AWS
infrastructure as a code or the cloud
formation template and it enables reuse
of template components for example we
can condense multiple line resources
declaring it into a single line in our
template now we will talk about all
these examples in the upcoming slides
and then we have the required section
called resource that declares the AWS
resource that you want to include in the
stack for example if you want to include
an ec2 instance if you want to include
an S3 bucket we would be using the
resource object in our stack and then we
have object called output this output
object it's an optional object in the
template and it helps us to sort of
declare the outputs that we can import
into other Stacks or we can actually
show it on the cloud formation console
for example if you want the output of
the or the name of the S3 bucket that
got created in response to a cloud
formation template now we can have that
outputted into an output section in the
cloud formation console itself so it's
sort of easy for us to identify the
resources that the template provisioned
so with all of those objects put
together this is how a full-blown cloud
formation template with all the objects
included is going to look like now this
includes optional and mandatory object
let's talk about those objects in detail
in the upcoming section all right let's
now discuss each and every object of
this template structure and let's begin
our discussion with the format version
The Format version it really defines the
capabilities of the template the latest
version format version as of now is the
one that was updated on 2010. now the
value of the template format version it
has to be an string and if we really
don't specify the format version cloud
formation automatically assumes the
latest version talking about description
descriptions are really any comments
that help ourselves that we want to
embed in the template itself that can be
a description and this description in a
template it has to be an string the
length of the string can be between 0 to
124 bytes in length the metadatars are
really used in the template to provide
any additional information using the
Json and yaml objects and metadata holds
some implementation details of a
specific resource and parameters are
really a way to customize the template
each time we create or update our stack
these parameters are the ones that helps
us to give some custom value to the
template during runtime in the example
shown below the parameter named instance
type parameter it lets us to specify the
ec2 instance type for the stacks to use
when creating or updating the stack by
default as we see it's picking T2 micro
and this is the value that will get
picked if we don't provision another
value to it and mapping mapping really
enables us to map a key to a
corresponding named value that we
specify in a conditional parameter and
also we can retrieve the map or to try
the values in the map using the function
find in map in strict function let's
take this example let's say based on a
region if you want to set values in a
template we can create a mapping that
uses a key and holds the value that you
want to specify for each region and the
object conditions can be used when we
want to reuse the templates by creating
resources in a totally different context
for example in a template during stack
creation all the conditions that we
mentioned in the template are evaluated
and any resources that are associated
and that come up to be true are created
and any condition that fails are in
valid are kind of ignored automatically
and the check moves forward to the next
condition and conditional is an optional
object and it includes statement that
Define when a resource is created or
when a property is actually defined for
example you can create whether for
example you can compare whether a value
is equal to another value and based on
the result of that condition we can
conditionally create resources if you
have multiple conditions then they are
generally separated with commas
sometimes conditions are very helpful
when we want to create templates in a
condition and when put together the
syntax is going to look like the one
that you see on the screen now the
optional object called transform it
specifies one or more transforms that
the cloud formation uses to process our
template now these transform sections
are built on a simple declarative
language of AWS cloud formation with a
powerful macro system that helps us us
to reuse the templates or the template
components and they really help us to
condense or simplify our codes by
enabling reuse of the template
components for example condens a
multiple line resource declaration into
a single line in our template the
resource section it really declares the
AWS resource that you want to include in
the stack such as ec2 instance such as
S3 bucket and some of the resource
fields are The Logical ID the resource
type and the properties let's talk about
them in brief The Logical ID is unique
within the template and The Logical ID
name it actually reference the resource
in other parts of the template in this
case it's my bucket for example I know
if we want to map an elastic Block store
volume or if we want to map an name of
the bucket in another place in the
template now then we would use the
logical ID and again in this case it is
my bucket a logical name has the
physical ID with which we actually
assign the resource for example in this
case my S3 bucket was named as my bucket
to begin with and the resource type in
the template it identifies the type of
the resource is an S3 bucket and the
properties are the additional optional
information that we can specify to our
resource for example if it is an ec2
instance let's say we would like to know
which Ami it used then property section
really defines the Ami that was used or
Ami as the property of the instance so
this section describes the output value
that needs to be imported to other
Stacks or the output value that needs to
be shown in the console for the user to
easily navigate to the resource that are
being created for example for a S3
bucket name we can declare an output and
once the bucket is created we can
actually declare the output and sort of
import the name of the bucket in a
different place in the console so it's
it's easy to view instead of you know
the user getting confused and going to
S3 and searching for the bucket name
this can be made available in the cloud
formation console itself and the output
fails it can include some of these
followings like The Logical ID it's
actually the identifier of the current
output and it's very unique within the
template and it can also include a
description description is really a
string type that describes the output
value and it can also include value and
value is the property that was returned
by the AWS cloud formation describe
Stacks command all right let's talk
about the template resource attribute
now in this section we're going to talk
about attributes that you can add to a
resource to control additional behavior
and relationships so let's talk there
are many resource attributes available
out of which we have I mean if we need
to name them we have a creation policy
and then we have deletion policy it
depends on metadata attribute update
policy attribute let's talk about each
of them separately when we associate the
create policy attribute with the
resource it actually delays the resource
configuration actions before proceeding
with the stack creation I mean the
attribute stack creation is delayed till
the time the cloud formation receives
some number of success signals back I
mean this is a very good use case when
we do auto scaling and this creation
policy can be used only with a limited
number of services like Auto scaling and
ec2 instances some of the use cases
would be if you want to install and
software application on an ec2 instance
you might want the applications to be
running before it proceeds further so in
this case we would use the creation
policy attribute to the instance and
then send the success signal after the
applications are installed and
configured then cloud formation goes to
the next step here in the syntax that
we're looking at the auto scaling
creation policy and the minimum
successful instance percentage it's
actually a number of signals that it
will have to reply back before it can
move forward using deletion policy it
preserves backing up of resources when
the stack is getting deleted and by
default if you don't have a delete
policy the data gets deleted just like
that but if you use an deletion policy
we would be able to preserve the data by
taking a snapshot of it or just letting
the resource and moving on with deleting
the other resources in the stack and we
specify the delete policy attribute for
each resource specifically that we want
to control and there are no deletion
policy mentioned for a particular
resource the cloud formation simply
deletes the resources as that's its
default behavior and if you want to keep
the resource when the stack is deleted
we use we we mention V10 in the delete
policy and that simply retains the
resource from getting deleted so in this
example we're actually retaining an
dynamodb table rest of the resources in
the stack will get deleted and using the
depends on attribute we actually create
an order in which the resource gets
deleted for example if I map one
resource to another resource and say
that this resource depends on the other
resource the other resource gets created
first Then followed by this instance or
this resource so with the difference on
attribute we can specify that the
creation of specific resource is
actually followed by and another when we
add that depends on attributes towards
Source the resources created only after
the creation of the resource specified
by the depends on attribute let's take
this example in this example we're
saying that the resource X depends on
why we've said that X depends on y so in
this case when cloud formation is
executing it's going to deploy y first
because it has some resources that
depends on it so it's going to create y
first and then it's going to create the
resource called X on the same context
let's say in the template we say that an
ec2 is going to depend on S3 and when
the cloud formation is executing it's
going to create an S3 bucket first and
then the ec2 instant that's probably
because the codes needed for the ec2
instance are stored in the S3 bucket and
and what we're looking at is the syntax
of how that depends on template resource
attribute will look like this is how it
actually will look like when we put it
in the cloud formation the instance
depends on the topics the other template
research attribute is metadata
metadatars are the one that really helps
us to associate our Resources with the
the structured data and by including
this attribute in our template or by
including this attribute to a resource
we can specify the data in Json or in
yaml language for example in this
section of the template we're creating a
VPC and the metadata explains our
metadata defines that the VPC is part of
the region Us East one and the update
policy template resource attribute and
cloud formation we can manage and
replace the updates of the instance in
an auto scaling room for example you're
looking at this sample where it says
that the update policy will it replace
the instance in an auto scaling group or
not so depending on what the value is
for the will replace section whether
it's true or false depending on that at
the update policy will replace the
instance or will replace the auto
scaling group itself when it's doing
enrolling deployment now that we've
discussed about templates let's talk
about AWS Stacks as well now we know
that AWS Stacks are the actual resources
that gets generated or that gets created
because we ran a template right so stack
is a collection of AWS resource that we
can manage in a single unit in other
words you know we can create a stack
update a stack or delete a stack and
that would actually create update delete
the collection of resources within the
stack and all the resources in the stack
are really defined by the cloud
formation template and a stack for
instance can include all the resources
required to run a web application such
as a web server running on an Windows
Server 2008 R2 we also have templates
that create a single server and
installation of active directory running
on a Windows server and in fact we have
templates available for elastic
Beanstalk and some sample applications
that runs from an Windows Server 2008 R2
let's talk about stack sets stack sets
actually has taken the attack level
implementation to the next level using
the AWS cloud formation template we can
define a stack set that lets us to
create stack in AWS account across the
globe by using just a single template
and after we create the stack or after
the stack set is defined creating
updating or deleting the stack in the
Target account and the regions can also
be specified by us so the stack said it
really extends the functionality of the
stacks by allowing us to create update
and delete stack across multiple
accounts regions in just a single
operation and using an administrator
account we can Define and manage an AWS
cloud formation template and use the
template as the basis for provisioning
Stacks into you know some selected
Target accounts across a specified
region let's talk about cloud formation
access control with IAM I can specify
the list of users or list of privileged
users who would have access to the cloud
formation template who can create update
and delete Stacks so that's how IM helps
me with having or putting a layer of
control over the cloud formation service
and we can also use service roles
service roles are the one that allows
AWS cloud formation to make a call to a
resource in a stack on the user's behalf
and I can also have stack policies and
these stack policies are applied to the
users who already have access to the
cloud formation service and these
policies are the ones that help the
users who attempt to update the stack
all right let's do a quick lab on
creating and lamp stack on an ec2
instance with a local mySQL database for
storage now now we can do the other way
as well I can pick an ec2 instance and
install the servers one top of the other
and that can be done as well but that's
going to take a lot of time now we're
talking about automating it we're
talking about you know provisioning and
infrastructure using a code and cloud
formation helps us to do that so this is
what we're going to do we're going to
create or we have in cloud formation
template already and we're going to use
that template the provision web instance
and that is going to have look at that
that's going to have MySQL installed in
it that's going to have PHP that's going
to have httpd service installed in it
and running and it's also going to have
an a PHP website running from it so
that's going to receive information from
the website and that's going to store
that information in the database that's
very local to it
this is the template that defines that
environment
all right this is a very simple
provisioning so let's provision this
environment let's create a stack
we're going to give a stack name
and a database password
right and which region is it this is in
California is that
all right
now let me do one thing let me switch to
the Mumbai Legion or let me switch to
North Virginia region
not original from here actually let me
switch to Mumbai region
all right just to be sure it's the same
template that we're provisioning
right that's the same
template that we are provisioning
all right let's give this a name so it
can be great this could be simply long
simply learn lamp stack and what could
be the DB password
and DB root password
and what could be the DB user
I'm going to keep the rest as defaults
and I'm going to launch
all right so there's an issue with the
password
[Music]
should only have Alpha numeric
characters
[Music]
so let's go back and create a new
password
right it also needs to have eight
characters
so what can be your password
look at that the template is actually
creating the resources
and here in the screen we can see the
template that we used to deploy the
environment
if you remember we have we discussed
about instant types in parameters right
the default instance type is T2 small
but these are also allowed
to run
all right parameter section is the one
that was used to receive information
from us like the DB name
the DB password the DB root password DB
user instance type key name and the SSH
locations
all right now this resource section is
is showing us the resource that it
actually created
right looks like it's rolling back why
would that be give me a moment
[Music]
all right this is one live example
anytime it could not provision or any if
there is an interruption that it cannot
proceed it would simply roll back and
delete all the resources that it had
provisioned and that's what it did
now let me fix this
oh as a fix I have switched the regen
because I had some issue with the VPC
that's going to take time for me to
analyze and fix it so here we're going
to understand
about plot formation so I thought I'll
run the cloud formation from another VPC
that I know is working fine that's in
North Virginia
all right let's provision this lamp
server which is running out of Linux
which has Apache installed on it which
has PHP and MySQL already installed in
it so one server gonna act as web and DB
server
all right so I'm going to create a stack
and from here I'm going to pick a sample
stack now if we look at if you look at
it in the designer
it's going to provision one lamp server
and a security attack Security Group
attached to it there you go right so
let's go ahead and create a stack
all right
parameters are used to receive
input from us what could be the DB
password
and the DB user
and
let's select the key name
right I'm going to keep the rest as
defaults and I'm going to create
a stack
all right so us stack
that we run from the template at the
moment it's getting created it's in
progress
from here I can watch the events as to
what is getting created at the moment
like I said in a lot of these would have
already sorted out their dependencies
you know which one needs to get created
first which one needs to get created
second all that is sorted out by cloud
formation itself
and parameters are the values that we
have inputted and resource
tab is a section where we can find what
resources are being provisioned at the
moment so to begin with it created a
security group at the moment it's
creating an instance and output it's
empty as of now we're going to come back
and see it now output is where we can
get outputs of a finished job let's say
here I wanted an URL
of the server that got created so
instead of me uh you know going to a
couple of other places within the
console and find the output of the URL
or the the output of the resource that
was created I can simply get it from
here well this needs to be defined in
the templates First Once We Define it in
the template it's going to be made
available
like here
right so I can open it up
and there you go so it has it already
has
a database locally installed and it's
connected over if I launch an
application on top of it that will get
connected to the database which is very
local and my single
server with web and database in it is
ready for production
now while we're talking about a lamp
server a single lamp server let's talk
about
uh creating an environment like this
which has elastic load balancer a VPC uh
server running in an auto Skilling group
and putting some restrictions that
nobody will be able to access the ECU
instance directly but they should be
able to access the ec2 instance or the
data only through the elastic load
balancer this is a bit complicated than
the environment that we've already
created let's see how this is done all
right in this lab we're going to create
elastic load balance to Auto scaling
Group which is going to create a load
balancer and an auto scaling group and
that auto scaling group receives traffic
only from the load balancer so here's
the template
and here's the architecture that we're
going to provision
let me call it right and the key pair
it's going to use is simply learn key
pair now this is where the problem was
now we were selecting few subnets
so now if I provision it
now this is going to take its short time
to provision the resources
so through parameters we can see the
values that we have inputted
and the events look good no roll back no
no deletes and the resource section
shows the resource that it is creating
so previously created a Target group now
it's creating the application load
balancer itself
all right so it created and
a load balancer and then it create a
security group it creates a launch
configuration it at the moment it's
creating a web server group
and the events look good with all green
and yellow green ones are completed
yellow ones are in progress we don't
have any red delete or rollback errors
so it looks good all right it took a
while and
the resources have been created some of
them show that they are in progress but
the status of the stack is complete
all resources have been created and we
do have an output to access the URL
there you go
and remember there was another feature
of the cloud formation that was it
should restrict access I mean direct
access to ec2 instance let's see if that
has been done
if I try to access using the load
balancer it lets me access but if I try
to access it using
the ec2 instance IP or the DNS name my
connection won't go through because it's
blocked through the security group but
direct access through the load balancer
is allowed and that's what we wanted to
achieve through that template here we're
going to talk about Amazon ECS a service
that's used to manage Docker containers
so without any further Ado let's get
started in this session we would like to
talk about some Basics about AWS and
then we're going to immediately dive
into why Amazon ECS and what is Amazon
ECS in general and then it uses a
service called Docker so we're going to
understand what Docker is and there are
competitive services available for ECS I
mean you could ECS is not the on and
only service to manage Docker containers
but why ECS advantage of ECS we will
talk about that and the architecture of
ECS so how it functions what are the
components present in it and what are
the fun functions that it does I mean
each and every component what are all
the functions that it does all those
things will be discussed in the
architecture of Amazon ECS and how it
works how it all connects together
that's something we will discuss and
what are the companies that are using
ECS what were the challenge and how easy
has helped to fix the challenge that's
something we will discuss and finally we
have a wonderful lab that talks about
how to deploy Docker containers on an
Amazon ECS so let's talk about what is
AWS Amazon web service in short call as
AWS is an web service in the cloud that
provides a variety of services such as
compute power database storage content
delivery and a lot of other resources so
you can scale your business and grow not
focus more on your ID needs and the rest
of the I 80 demands rather you can focus
on your business and let Amazon scale
your it or let Amazon take care of your
it so what is that you can do with AWS
with AWS we can create deploy any
application in the cloud so it's not
just deploying you can also create your
application in the cloud it has all the
tools and services required the tools
and services that you would have
installed in your laptop or you would
have installed in your on-premises
desktop machine for your development
environment you know the same thing can
be installed and used from the cloud so
you can use cloud for creating and not
only that you can use the same Cloud for
deploying and making your application
available for your end user the end user
could be internal internal users the end
user could be the could be in the
internet the end user could be kind of
spread all around the world it doesn't
matter so it can be used to create and
deploy your applications in the the
cloud and like you might have guessed
now it provides service over the
Internet that's how your users worldwide
would be able to use the service that
you create and deploy right so it
provides service over the Internet so
that's for the End customer and how will
you access those Services that's again
through the internet it's like the
extension of your data center in the
internet so it provides all the services
in the internet it provides compute
service through the internet so in other
words you access them through the
internet it provides database service
through the internet over the internet
in other words you can securely access
your database through the internet and
lot more and the best part is this is a
pay as you go or pay only for what you
use there is no long term or you know
beforehand commitment here most of the
services does not have any commitment so
there is no long term and beforehand
commitment you only pay exactly for what
you use there's no overage there's no
overpaying right there's no buying in
advance right you only pay for what you
use let's talk about what ECS is so
before ECS before containers right ECS
is a service that manages Docker
containers right it's not a product or
it's not a feature all by itself it's a
service that's dependent on Docker
container so before Docker containers
all the applications were running on VM
or on an host or on a physical machine
right and that's memory bound that's
latency bound the server might have
issues on and on right so let's say this
is Alice and she's trying to access her
application which is running somewhere
in her on premises and the application
isn't working what could be the reason
some of the reasons could be Memory full
the server is currently down at the
moment we don't have another physical
server to launch the application a lot
of other reasons so a lot of reasons why
the application wouldn't be working in
on-premises some of them are Memory full
issue and server down issue very less a
high availability or in fact single
point of failure and no high
availability if I if I need to tell it
correctly with ECS the services can kind
of breathe free right the services can
run seamlessly now how how is that
possible now those thing we will discuss
in the upcoming sessions so because of
containers and easiest managing
containers the applications can run in a
high available mode they can run in a
high available mode meaning if something
goes wrong right there's another
container that gets spun up and your
application runs in that particular
container very less chances of your
application going down that's what I
mean this is not possible with a
physical Host this is very less possible
with an VM or at least it's going to
take some time for another VM to get
spun up so why ECS or what is ECS Amazon
ECS maintains the availability of the
application and allows every user to
scale containers when necessary so it
not only meets the availability of the
application meaning one container
running your application or one
container hosting your application
should be running all the time so it
means that high availability
availability is making sure your service
is running 24 7. so Container makes sure
that your services run 24 bar 7 not only
that not only that suddenly if there is
an increase in demand how do you meet
that Demand right let's say you have
like thousand users suddenly the next
week there are like 2000 users all right
so how do you meet that demand Container
makes it very easy for you to meet that
demand in case of VM or in case of
physical host you literally have to go
buy another physical host or you know
add more RAM add more memory add more
CPU power to it all right or kind of
Club two three hosts together clustering
you would be doing a lot of other things
to meet that high availability and also
to meet that demand but in case of ECS
it automatically scales the number of
containers it automatically scales the
number of containers needed and it meets
your demand for that particular R so
what is Amazon ECS the full form of ECS
is elastic container service right so
it's basically a container Management
Service which can quickly launch and
exit and manage Docker containers on a
cluster so what's the function of ECS it
helps us to quickly launch and quickly
exit and manage Docker container so it's
kind of a Management Service for the
docker containers you will be running in
Amazon or running in the AWS environment
so in addition to that it helps to
schedule the placement of container
across your cluster so it's like this
you have two physical hosts you know
joined together as a cluster and ECS
helps us to place your containers now
where should your container be placed
should it be placed in host one should
be placed in host too so that logic is
defined in ECS we can Define it you can
also let ECS take control and Define
that logic most cases you will be
defining it so schedule the placement of
containers across your cluster let's say
two containers want to interact heavily
you really don't want to place them in
two different hosts all right you would
want to place them in one single horse
so they can interact with each other so
that logic is defined by us and these
container services you can launch
containers using AWS Management console
and also so you can launch containers
using SDK kids available from Amazon you
can launch through a Java program you
can launch container using an.net
program you can launch container using
an node.js program as in when the
situation demands so there are multiple
ways you can launch containers through
Management console and also
programmatically and ECS also helps to
migrate application to the cloud without
changing the code so anytime you think
of migration the first thing that comes
to your mind is that how will that
environment be based on that I'll have
to alter my code what's what's the IP
what is the storage that's being used
what what are the different parameters
I'll have to include the environment
parameters of the new environment with
containers now that worry is already
taken away because we can create an
pretty exact environment the one that
you had in on-premises the same
environment gets created in the cloud so
no one worries about changing the
application parameter no worries about
changing the code in the application
right you can be like if it ran in my
laptop a container that I was running in
my laptop it's definitely going to run
in the cloud as well because I'm going
to use the same container in the laptop
and also in the cloud in fact you're
going to ship it you're going to move
the container from your laptop to Amazon
ECS and make it run there so it's like
the same the very same image the very
same container that was running in your
laptop will be running in the cloud or
production environment so what is Docker
we know that it ECS helps to quickly
launch exit and manage Docker containers
what is Docker let's let's answer that
question what is Docker now Docker is a
tool that helps to automate the
development of an application as a
lightweight container so that the
application can work efficiently in
different environments this is pretty
much what we discussed right before the
slide I can build an application in my
laptop or in on-premises in a container
environment Docker container environment
and anytime I want to migrate right I
don't have to kind of rewrite the code
and then rerun the code in that new
environment I can simply create an image
a Docker image and move that image to
that production or the new Cloud
environment and simply launch it there
right so no compiling again no
relaunching the application simply pack
all your code in a Docker container
image and ship it to the new environment
and launch the container there that's
all so Docker container is a light
weight package of software that contains
all the dependencies so because you know
when packing you'll be packing all the
dependencies you'll be packing the code
you'll be packing the framework you'll
be be packing the libraries that are
required to run the application so in
the new environment you can be pretty
sure you can be guaranteed that it's
going to run because it's the very same
code it's the very same framework it's
the very same libraries that you have
shipped right there's nothing new in
that new environment it's the very same
thing that's going to run in that
container so you can be rest assured
that they are going to run in that new
environment and these Docker containers
are highly scalable and they are very
efficient suddenly you wanted like 20
more Docker containers to run the
application think of adding 20 more
hosts 20 more VMS right how much time
would it take and compared to that time
the amount of time that Docker
containers would require to kind of
scale to that amount like 20 more
containers it's very less or it's
minimal or negligible so it's a highly
scalable and it's a very efficient
service you can suddenly scale number of
Docker containers to meet any additional
demand very short short boot up time
because it takes it's not going to load
the whole operating system and these
Docker containers you know they use the
Linux kernel and features of the kernel
like c groups and namespaces to kind of
segregate the processor so they can run
independently any environment and it
takes very less time to boot up and the
data us that are stored in the
containers are kind of reusable so you
can have an external data volume and I
can map it to the container and whatever
the space that's occupied by the
container and the data that the
container puts in that volume they are
kind of reusable you can simply remap it
to another application you can kind of
remap it to the next successive
container you can kind of remap it to
the next version of the container next
version of the application you'll be
launching and you don't have to go
through building the data again from the
scratch whatever data the container was
using previously or the previous
container was using that data is
available for the next container as well
so the volumes that the containers users
are very reusable volumes and like I
said it's isolated application so it
kind of isolates by its nature it kind
of by the way it's designed by the way
it is created it isolates one container
from another container meaning anytime
you run applications on different
containers you can be rest assured that
they are very much isolated though they
are running on the same host though they
are running on the same laptop let's say
though they are running on the same
physical machine let's say running 10
containers 10 different applications you
can be sure that they are well
disconnected or well isolated
applications now let's talk about the
advantages of ECS the advantage of ECS
is improved security it's security is
inbuilt in ECS with ECS we have
something called as a container registry
you know that's where all your images
are stored and those images are accessed
only through https not only that those
images are actually encrypted and access
to those images are allowed and denied
through identity and access management
policies IAM and in other words let's
say two container running on the same
instance now one container can have
access to S3 and the others or the rest
of the others are denied access to S3 so
that kind of granular security can be
achieved through containers when we mix
and match the other security products
available in Amazon like IAM encryption
accessing it using https these
containers are very cost efficient like
I've already said these are lightweight
processors right we can schedule
multiple containers on the same node and
this actually allows us to achieve high
density t on an ec2 instance imagine an
ec2 instance that that's very less
utilized that's not possible with a
container because you can actually dance
or crowd an ec2 instance with more
container in it so to best use those
resources in ec2 straightforward you can
just launch one application but with
when we use containers you can launch
like 10 different applications on the
same ec2 server that means 10 different
applications can actually feed on those
resources available and can benefit the
application and ECS not only deploys the
container it also maintains the state of
the containers and it makes sure that
the minimum a set of containers are
always running based on the requirement
that's another cost efficient way of
using it right and anytime an
application fails and that has a direct
impact on the revenue of the company and
is just make sure that you're not losing
any Revenue because your application has
failed and ECS is in pretty extensible
Services it's like this in many
organizations there are majority of
unplanned work because of environment
variation a lot of firefighting happens
when we kind of deploy the code from one
or kind of move the core or redeploy the
code in a new environment a lot of
firefighting happens there right this
Docker containers are pretty extensible
like we discussed already environment is
not a concern for containers because
it's going to kind of shut itself inside
a Docker container and anywhere the
docker container can run the application
will run exactly the way it performed in
the past so environment is not a concern
for the docker containers in addition to
that ECS is easily scalable we have
discussed this already and it improves
it has improved compatibility we have
discussed this already let's talk about
the architecture of ECS like you you
know now the architecture of ECS is the
ECS cluster itself that's group of
servers running the ECS service and it
integrates with Docker right so we have
a Docker registry Docker registry is a
repository where we store all the docker
images or the container images so it's
like three components ECS is of three
components one is the ECS cluster itself
right when I say easy as itself I'm
referring to easiest cluster cluster of
servers that will run the containers and
then the repository where the images
will be stored right the repository
where the images will be stored and the
image itself so container image is the
template of instructions which is used
to create a container right so it's like
what's the OS what is the version of
node that should be running and any
additional software do we need so those
question gets answered here so it's the
template template of instructions which
is used to create the containers and
then the registry is the service where
the docker images are stored and shared
so many people can store there and many
people can access or if there's another
group that wants to access they can
access the image from there or one
person can store the image and rest of
the team can access and the rest of the
team can store imagine this one person
can pick the image from there and kind
of ship it to the customer or ship it to
the production environment all that's
possible in this container registry and
Amazon's version of the container
registry is ECR and there's a third
party Docker itself has a container
registry that's Docker Hub ECS itself
which is the the group of servers that
runs those containers so these two the
container image and the container
registry they kind of handle Docker in
an image format just an image format and
an ECS is where the content against live
and then it becomes an compute resource
and starts to handle requests now starts
to serve the page and starts to do the
batch job you know whatever your plan is
with that container so the cluster of
servers ECS integrates well with the
familiar services like VPC VPC is known
for securing VPC is known for isolating
the whole environment from rest of the
customers or isolating the whole
environment or the whole infrastructure
from the rest of the clients in your
account or from the rest of the
applications in your account on and on
so VPC is a service that provides or
gives you the network isolation ECS
integrates well with VPC and this VPC
enables us to launch AWS resources such
as Amazon ec2 instance in a virtual
private Network that we specified this
is basically what we just discussed now
let's take a closer look at the CS how
does ECS work let's find answer for this
question how does ECS work ECS has got a
couple of components within itself so
these easier servers can run across
availability Zone as you can see there
are two availability zones here they can
actually run across availability zones
and ECS has got two modes fargate mode
and the ec2 mode right here we're seeing
fargate more and then here we're seeing
nothing that means it's an ec2 mode and
then it has got different network
interfaces attached to it because they
need to be running in an isolated
fashion right so anytime you want
Network isolation you need separate IP
and if you want separate IP you need
separate network interface card and
that's what you have elastic network
interface card separate elastic network
interface card for all those tasks and
services and this runs within an VPC
let's talk about the far gate service
tasks are launched using the far gate
service so we will discuss about tasks
what is forget now fargate is a compute
engine in ECS that allows users to
launch containers without having to
monitor the cluster ECS is a service
that manages the containers for you
right otherwise managing containers will
be an full-time job so ECS manages it
for you and if you and you get to manage
ECS that's the basic service but if you
want Amazon to manage ECS and the
containers for you we can go for fargate
so fargate is a compute engine in ECS
that allows users to launch containers
without having to monitor the ECS
cluster and the tasks the tasks that we
discussed the tasks has two components
is the task right here so they have two
components we have easiest container
instance and then the container agent so
like you might have guessed right now
easiest container instance is actually
an ec2 instance right capable of running
containers not all ec2 instances can run
containers so these are like specific
ec2 instances that can run containers
they are ECS container instances and
then we have container agent which is
the agent that actually binds those
clusters together and it does a lot of
other housekeeping work right kind of
connects clusters makes sure that the
version needed is present so it's all
part of that agent or it's all job of
that agent container instances container
instances is part of Amazon ec2 instance
which run Amazon ECS container agent
pretty straightforward definition and
then a container agent is responsible
for communication between ECS and the
instance and it also provides the status
of the running container kind of
monitors the container monitors the
state of the container make sure that
the content is up and running and if
there's anything wrong it kind of
reports it to the appropriate service to
fix the container on and on it's a
container agent when we don't manage
container agent it it runs by itself and
you really don't have to do anything to
make the container agent better it's
already better you really won't be
configuring anything in the agent and
then elastic network interface car is in
Virtual interface Network that can be
connected to an instance in VPC so in
other words elastic network interface is
how the container interacts with another
container and that's how the container
interacts with the ec2 host and that's
how the container interacts with the
internet external world and a cluster a
cluster is a set of ECS container
instances it's not something that's very
difficult to understand it's simply a
group of ec2 instances that runs that
ECS s agent and this cluster it cluster
handles the process of scheduling
monitoring and scaling the request we
know that ECS can scale the containers
can scale how does it scale that's all
Monitor and managed by this ECS cluster
let's talk about the companies that are
using Amazon ECS there are a variety of
companies that use ACS clusters to name
a few okta users easiest cluster and
oaktar is a product that use identity
information to Grant people access to
applications on multiple devices at any
given point of time they make sure that
they have a very strong security
protection so OCTA uses Amazon ECS to
run their OCTA application and serve
their customers and abima abima is an TV
channel and they chose to use
microservices and a Docker containers
they also already had microservices and
Docker containers and when they thought
about a service that they can use in AWS
ECS was the only service that they can
immediately adapt to and because in
abima TV the engineers have already been
using Docker and Docker containers it
was kind of easy for them to adapt
themselves to ECS and start using it
along with the benefits that ECS
provides previously they had to do a lot
of work but now ECS does it for them all
right similarly remind and Ubisoft GoPro
or some of the famous companies that use
Amazon ECS and get benefited from its
scalability get benefited from its cost
gets benefited from its Amazon managed
Services get benefited from the
portability that ECS and the migration
option that ECS provides let's talk
about how to deploy a Docker container
on Amazon Amazon ECS the way to deploy
Docker container on ECS is first we need
to have an AWS account and then set up
and run our first ECS cluster so in our
lab we're going to use the launch wizard
to run an ECS cluster and run containers
in them and then toss definition task
definition tells the size of the
container the number of the container
and when we talk about size it tells how
much of CPU do you need how much of
memory do you need and talking about
numbers you know it requires how many
numbers of container you're going to
launch you know is it 5 is it 10 or is
it just one running all the time now
those kind of information goes in the
task definition file and then we can do
some Advanced configuration on ECS like
load balancers and you know what port
number you want to allow when you don't
want to allow you know who gets access
who shouldn't get access and what's the
IP that you want to allow and deny
requests from from on and on and this is
where we would also mention the name of
the container so the differentiate one
container from the other and the name of
the servers you know is it an a backup
job is it a web application is it an a
data container is it going to take care
of your data data backend and the
desired number of tasks that you want to
be running all the time those details go
in when we try to configure the ECS
service right and then you configure
cluster you put in all the security in
the configure your cluster step or
configure cluster stage and finally we
will have an instance and bunch of
containers running in that instance all
right let's do a demo so here I have
logged in to my Amazon portal and let me
switch to the appropriate region I'm
going to pick not Virginia North
Virginia look for ECS and it tells ECS
is a service that helps to run and
manage Docker containers well and good
click on it I'm a not Virginia I just
want to make sure that I'm in the right
region and go to clusters and here we
can create cluster this is our far gate
and this is our ec2 type launching for
Linux and windows environment but I'm
going to launch through this walkthrough
portal right this gives a lot of
information here so the different steps
involved here is creating a container
definition which is what we're going to
do right now and then a task definition
and then service and finally the cluster
it's a four-step process so in container
definition we Define the image the base
image we are going to use now here I'm
going to launch an httpd or a simple
HTTP web page right so a simple httpd
2.4 image is fair enough for me and it's
not an heavy application equation so 0.5
gigabit of memory is enough and again
it's not a heavy application so 0.25
virtual CPU is enough in our case right
you can edit it based on the requirement
you can always edit it and because I'm
using hdpd the port mapping is already
Port 80 that's how the container is
going to receive the request and there's
no health check as of now when we want
to design critical and complicated
environments we can include health check
right and this is the CPU that we have
chose we can edit it and I'm going to
use some bash commands to create an HTML
page right this page says that you know
Amazon ECS sample app right and then it
says Amazon ECS sample app your
application is running on a container in
Amazon ECS so that's the page the HTML
page that I'm going to create
index.html so I'm going to create and
put it in an appropriate location so
those pages can be served from the
container right if you replace this with
any of your own content then it's going
to be your own content ECS comes with
some basic logs and these are the places
where they get stored that's not the
focus as of now all right so I was just
saying that you can edit it and
customize it to your needs We're not
gonna do any customization now we're
just getting familiar with ECS now and
the task definition name of the task
definition is first one task definition
and then we are running it in a VPC and
then this is an fargate mode meaning the
servers are completely handled by Amazon
and the task memory is 0.5 gigabit and
the task CPU is 0.25 virtual CPU name of
the service is it a batch job is it an
you know a front end is it an back end
or is it a simple copy job what's the
service name of the service goes here
again this you can edit it and here's a
security group as of now I'm allowing
for 80 to the whole world if I want to
rest it to a certain IP I can do that
the default option for load balancing is
no load balancer but I can also choose
to have a load balancer and use port 80
to map that Port 80 to the container for
80 right I can do that the default is no
load balancer all right let's do one
thing let's use load balancer let's use
load balancer and Port 80 that receives
information on Port 80 HTTP what's going
to be the cluster name when the last
step what is the cluster name cluster
name can be simply learn ECS demo next
we're done and we can create so it's
launching a cluster as you can see and
it's picking the task definition file
that we've created and it's using that
to launch and service and then these are
the log groups that we discussed and
it's creating your VPC remember is CS
clubs well with the VPC it's creating a
VPC and it's creating two subnets here
for high availability it's creating that
Security Group Port 80 allowed to the
whole world and then it's putting it
behind and load balancer It generally
would take like five to ten minutes so
which is need to be patient and let it
complete its creation and once this is
complete we can simply access these
servers using the load balancer URL and
when this is running let me actually
take you to the other products or the
other services that are integrated with
ECS it's getting created our service is
getting created as of now ECR repository
this is where all our images are stored
now as of now I'm not pulling my image
from ECR I'm pulling it directly from
the internet Docker Docker Hub but all
custom images all custom images they are
stored in this Repository so you can
create a repository call it app one
create a repository so here's my
repository so any image that I create
locally or any Docker image that I
create locally I can actually push them
push those images using these commands
right here and they get stored here and
I can make my ECS connect with ECR and
pull images from here so they would be
my custom images and as of now because
I'm using a default image it's directly
pulling it from the internet let's go to
ec2 and look for a load balancer because
we wanted to access the application from
behind a load balancer right so here is
a load balancer created for us and
anytime I put the URL so cluster is now
created you know you see there's one
service running all right let's click on
that cluster here is the name of our
application and here is the tasks the
different containers that we are running
and if you click on it we have an IP
right IP of that container and it says
it's running it was created at such and
such time and started at such and such
time and this is the task definition
file that it this container uses meaning
the template the details to all the
version details they all come from here
and it belongs to the cluster called
simply learn ECS demo right and you can
also get some logs container logs from
here so let's go back and there are no
ECS instances here because remember this
is forget you're not managing any ECS
instance right so that's why you're not
seeing any ECS instance here so let's go
back to tasks and go back to the same
page where we found the IP pick that IP
put it in the browser and you have this
sample HTML page running from an
container so let me go back to load
balancer you C2 and then under ec2 I'll
be able to find a load balancer find
that load balancer pick that DNS name
put it in the browser and now it's
accessible to the load balancer URL
right now this URL can be mapped to
other services like DNS this URL can be
emboded in any of your application if
you want to make that application
connect with this container Now using IP
is not all that advisable because these
containers can die and then a new
container gets created and when a new
container gets created it gets a new IP
right so a hot coding IP is not
hardcoding Dynamic IPS are not advisable
so you would be using load balancer and
putting that URL in that application
that you want to make it interact with
this container instance it was a
wonderful experience in Walking you
through this ECS topic and in here we
learn about what AWS is and why we're
using ECS and what is easiest in general
what is Docker in specific and we also
learn about the advantages of ECS the
architecture the different components of
ECS and how ECS works when they're all
connected together and we also looked at
the companies that use ECS and their use
cases and finally a lab how we can
launch ECS far gate through the portal
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 Plus hours of
video content for free visit skillup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more I'm very glad
to walk you through this lesson about
route 53. so in this section we are
going to talk about basics of AWS and
then we're going to immediately dive
into why why we need Amazon Route 53 and
then we're going to expand and talk
about the details of Amazon Route 53 the
benefits it provides over its comp
competitors and the different types of
routing policy it has and some of Amazon
route 53's key features and we're going
to talk about how to access Route 53 I
mean the different ways the different
methods you can access Route 53 and
finally we're going to end with an a
wonderful demo in route 53. so let's
talk about what is AWS Amazon web
services or AWS in short is a cloud
provider that offers a variety of
services such as a variety of ID
services or infrastructure services such
as a compute power database a Content
delivery and other resources that helps
us to scale and grow our business and
AWS is hard AWS is picking up AWS is
being adapted by a lot of customers
that's because AWS is easy to use even
for a beginner and talking about safety
the the AWS this infrastructure is
designed to keep the data safe
irrespective of the size of the data
with small data be it very minimal data
the all the data that you have in
terabytes and in petabytes Amazon can
keep it safe in their environment and
the wonderful thing and the most
important reason why a lot of customers
move into the cloud is that the pay as
you go pricing there is no long-term
commitment and it's very cost effective
what this means is that you're not
paying for a resource that you're not
using in on-premises you do pay for
resources you're not using a lot meaning
you go and buy a server you do the
estimate for the next five years and
only after like three or four years
you'll be hitting the peak capacity but
still you would be buying that capacity
before four years right and then you
will gradually be you know utilizing it
from you know 40 percent date 60
percentage 70 80 and then 100. so what
you have done is that even though you're
not using the full capacity you still
have bought it and are and are paying
for it from day one but in the cloud
it's not like that you only pay for the
resources that you use anytime you want
more you scale up the results and you
you pay for the scaled up resource and
anytime you want less you scale down the
results and you pay less for that scaled
down resource let's talk about why
Amazon route 53. let's take this
scenario where Rachel is trying to open
her web browser and the URL that she hit
isn't working a lot of reasons behind
why the URL isn't working it could be
the server utilization that went High it
could be it could be the memory usage
that went High a lot of reasons and she
starts to think is there an efficient
way to scale resources according to the
user requirements or is there an
efficient way to kind of mask all those
failures and kind of divert traffic to
the appropriate active you know active
resource or active service that's
running our application you always want
to hide the failures right in I.T kind
of mask the failure and direct the
customer to another healthy service
that's running right none of your
customers would want to see a server not
available or you know none of the
customers your customers would want to
see your service not working not
impressive to them and this is Tom Tom
is an I.T guy and he comes up with an
idea and he's answering Rachel yes we
can scale resources efficiently using
Amazon Route 53 in a sense he's saying
that yes we can mask the failure and we
can keep the services up and running
meaning we can provide more High
availability to our customers with the
use of Route 53 and then he goes on and
explains Amazon Route 53 is a DNS
service that gives developers an
efficient way to connect users to to
internet applications without any
downtime now downtime is the key Amazon
Route 53 helps us to avoid any downtime
that customers will experience you still
will have downtime in your server in
your application but your customers will
not be made aware of it and then Rachel
is kind of interested and she's like
yeah that sounds interesting I want to
learn more about it and Tom goes on and
explains the important concepts of
Amazon Rock 53 that's everything that
I'm going to explain it to you as well
alright so what is Amazon Route 53
Amazon raw 53 is a highly scalable DNS
or domain name system web service this
service this Amazon raw 53 it functions
three main things or it has three main
functions so the first thing is if a
website needs a name Route 53 registers
the name for the website domain let's
say you want to buy google.com you want
to buy the domain name let's say you
want to buy that domain name you buy
that through route 53. secondly a Roth
53 is the service that actually connects
your server which is running your
application or which is holding which is
serving your web page so that's the
service that actually Route 53 is the
service that connects the user to your
server when they hit google.com in the
browser or whatever domain name that you
have purchased so you bought a domain
name and the user types in your domain
name.com and then Roth 53 is a service
that helps the user to connect their
browser to the application that's
running in an ec2 instance or any other
server that you are using to serve that
content and not only that Route 53
checks Health off the resource by
sending automated requests over the
internet to a resource so that's how it
identifies if there is any resource that
has failed when I say resource I'm
referring to any infrastructure failure
any application Level failure so I can
kind of keeps checking so it understands
it first before the customer notices it
and then it does the magic kind of
shifts the connection from one server to
the other server we call it routing we
will talk about that as we progress so
the benefits of using rock53 it's highly
scalable meaning suddenly let's say the
number of requests the number of people
trying to access your website through
that domain name that you have bought
let's say it has increased Route 53 is
highly scalable right it can handle even
millions and millions of requests
because it's highly scalable and it's
managed by Amazon uh the same thing it's
reliable it's a highly scalable it can
handle large queries without the users
Without You interacting without the user
who bought it interact with it you don't
have to scale up you know when you're
expecting more requests it automatically
scales and it is very reliable in a
sense that it's very consistent it has
the ability to Route the users to the
appropriate application through the
logic that it has it's very easy to use
when we do the lab you're going to see
that it's very easy easy to use you buy
the domain name and then you simply map
it to the application you simply map it
to the server by putting in the IP or if
you you can simply map it to another
load balancer by putting in the load
balancer URL you can simply map it to
another S3 Buckhead by simply putting
the S3 bucket name or the S3 bucket URL
it's pretty straightforward easy to set
up and it's very cost effective in a way
that we only pay for the service that we
have used so no wastage of money here so
the billing is set up in such a way that
you are paying only for the amount of
requests that you have received right
the amount of traffic the amount of
requests that you have received and
couple of other things the the number of
hosted zones that you have created right
and couple of other things it's very
cost effective in such a way that you
only you pay for the service that you
are using and it's secure in a way that
access to Route 53 is integrated with
identity and access management IAM so
you only have authorized users to gain
access to Route 53. the trainee who just
joined yesterday won't get access and
the contractor or the consultant the
third party consultant you have given
access or who is using your environment
you can block access to that a
particular person because he's not the
admin or he's not a privileged user in
your account so only privileged users
and admin gain access to Route 53
through IAM now let's talk about the
routing policies so when you create a
record in in round 53 record is nothing
but an entry so when you do that you
choose a routing policy right routing
policy is nothing but it determines how
Route 53 responds to your queries how
the DNS queries are being responded all
right that's that's a record or that's a
routing policy so the first one is a
simple routing policy so we use Simple
routing policy for a single resource in
other words simple routing allows to
configure DNS with no special Route 53
routing it's kind of one to one you use
an single resource that performs a given
function to your domain for example if
you want to Simply map an URL to a web
server that's pretty straightforward
simple routing so it routes traffic to a
single resource example web server to a
website and with simple routing multiple
records with the same name cannot be
created but multiple values can be
created in the same record the second
type of routing policy is failover
routing so we would be using failover
routing when we want to configure active
passive failure whatever something
failed right you want to fail over to
the next resource which was previously
the backup resource now the active
resource or which was previously the
backup server now it's an active server
so you would be failing over to that
particular resource or that particular
IP if you want to do that we use
failover routing so failure routing
routes traffic to a resource when the
resource is healthy or to a different
resource when the previous resource is
unhealthy in other words anytime a
resource goes unhealthy I mean it does
all that's needed to shift the traffic
from the primary resource to the
secondary resource in other words from
the unhealthy resource to the healthy
resource and this records can Route
traffic to anything from an Amazon S3
bucket or you can also configure a
complex tree of Records now when we
configure the records it will be more
clear to you so as of now just
understand that Route 53 can route or
this routing policy failover routing
policy can Route traffic to Amazon S3
bucket or to a website that has complex
tree of Records geolocation routing
policy now geolocation routing just like
the name says it takes that routing
decision based on the geographic
location of the user in other words you
know when you want to Route traffic
based on the location of the user so
that's your primary criteria for you
know sending that request to the
appropriate server we will be using geo
location routing so it localizes the
content and presents a part or the
entire website in the language of the
user for example a user from us you
would want to direct them to an English
website and a user from German if you
want to send them to the German website
and a user from France you know you want
to send those requests or you want to
show content specific to account
customer who lives in France a French
website so this is if that's your
condition this is the routing policy we
would be using and the geographic
locations are specified by either
continent or by country or by state in
the United States so only in the United
States you can actually split it to
state level and for the rest of the
countries you can do it on a country
level on a high level you can also do it
on a continent level the next type of
routing policy would be your proximity
routing geoproximity routing policy when
we want to Route traffic based on the
location of our resource and optimally
shift traffic from resources in one
location to resource in another location
we would be using geoproximity routing
so geoproximity routing routes traffic
to the resources based on the geographic
location of the user and the resources
they want to access and it also has an
option to to Route more traffic or less
to a given resource by specifying a
value known as a biased kind of weight
but we also have weighted routing that's
different so we've chosen different name
bias you can send more traffic to a
particular resource by having a bias on
that particular routing condition and a
bias expands or shrinks the size of the
geographic region from which traffic is
routed to a resource and then we have
latency based routing just like the name
says we use latency based routing if we
have resources in multiple AWS regions
and if you want to Route traffic to the
region that provides the best latency at
any given point of time so let's say if
one single website needs to be installed
and hosted on multiple AWS regions then
latency routing policy is what is being
used it improves the performance of the
users by serving their request from the
AWS region that provides the lowest
latency so at any given point if
performance is your criteria and at any
given point of time irrespective of what
happens in Amazon infrastructure
irrespective of what happens in the
internet if you want to route your users
to the best performing website best
performing region then we would be using
latency based routing and for using
latency based routing we should create
latency records for the resources in
multiple AWS regions and then the other
type of a routing policy is multi-value
routing policy where we can make Route
53 to respond to DNS queries with up to
eight healthy records selected at random
so you're not kind of loading one
particular server we can Define eight
records and on a random basis Route 53
will respond to queries from these eight
records so it's not one server that gets
all the requests but eight servers gets
the request in a random fashion so it's
multi-value auditing policy and what we
get by this is that we are Distributing
the traffic to many servers instead of
just one server so multi-value routing
configures uh Route 53 to return
multiple values in response to a single
or multiple DNS queries it also checks
the health of order sources and Returns
the multiple values only for the healthy
resources let's say out of the eight
servers we have Define one server is not
doing healthy it will not respond to the
query with the details of the unhealthy
server right so now it's going to treat
it as only seven servers in the list
because one server is unhealthy and it
has the ability to return multiple
Health checkable IP addresses to improve
availability and load balancing the
other type of routing policy is weighted
routing policy and in here we use to
Route traffic or this is used to Route
traffic to multiple resources in a
proportion that we specify so this is an
weighted routing and weighted routing
routes multiple resources to a single
domain name or a sub domain and control
the traffic that's routed to each
resources so this is very useful when
you are doing load balancing and testing
new versions of the software so when you
have a new version of this software you
really don't want to send 100 of the
traffic to it so you want to get
customers feedback about the new
software that you've launched new
version or new application that you've
launched so you would kind of send only
20 of the traffic to that application
get customer feedback and if all is good
then we would move the rest of the
traffic to that new application so any
software launches application launches
will be using weighted routing now let's
talk about the key benefits are key
features of Route 53 some of the key
features of Route 53 are traffic flow it
routes end users to the endpoint that
should provide the best user experience
that's what we discussed in the routing
policies right it uses a routing policy
a latency based routing policy and Geo
based routing policy and then failover
routing policies so it kind of improves
the user experience and the key feature
the other key feature of Route 53 is we
can buy domain names using a Roth 53
using Route 53 console we can buy it
from here and use it in route 53.
previously it was not the case but now
we can buy it directly from Amazon
through Route 53 and we can assign it to
any resources that we want so anybody
browsing that URL the connection will be
directed to the server in AWS that runs
our website a health checks it monitors
health and performance of the
application so it comes with an health
check attached to it health check are
useful to make sure that the unhealthy
resources are retired right the
unhealthy resources are taken away or
your customers are not kind of hitting
the unhealthy resources and they see an
service down page or something like that
we can have weighted round robin load
balancing that's helpful and spreading
traffic between several services or
servers we are round robin algorithm so
no one server is fully hit or no one
server kind of fully absorbs all the
traffic you know you can shift you can
split and shift the traffic to different
servers based on the weight that you
would be configuring and also weighted
routing also helps with a soft launch
soft launch of your new application or
the new version of your website there
are different ways we can access access
Amazon Route 53 so you can access Amazon
Route 53 through AWS console you can
also access Amazon Route 53 using AWS
sdks and we can access it using we can
configure it using the apis and we can
also do it through the command line
interface that's Linux type Linux flavor
AWS command line interface we can also
do that using Windows command line
Windows Powershell flavored command line
interface as well now let's look at some
of the companies that are using route
53. so some of the famous companies that
use Route 53 are medium medium is an
online publishing platform and it's more
like a social journalism it's kind of
having hybrid collection of
professionals people and Publications or
exclusive blogs or Publishers on medium
it's kind of an blog website and that
you uses a Route 53 for the DNS service
I read it as an social news aggregation
or web content rating and discussion
website that uses route 53s so these are
some websites that that are accessed
throughout the world and they are using
Roth 53 and it's highly scalable
suddenly there is a new news right their
website will be accessed a lot and they
need to keep their service up and
running all the time more availability
otherwise customers will end up in a
broken page and the number of customers
who will be using the website will come
down so it's very critical and these
sites these companies are very critical
you know they're being highly available
the page their site being highly
available and the internet is very
critical and crucial for them and they
rely and use Route 53 to meet that
particular demand and Airbnb is another
company instacart Coursera is another
company stripe is another company that
uses Route 53 to as the DNS provider for
the DNS service they use Route 53 so
their customers get best performance
they use Route 53 so their website is
highly available they use Route 53 to
kind of shift to the traffic between the
resources so their resources are
properly used with all the weighted
routing the resources are properly used
now let's quickly look at a demo I'm in
my AWS console and I'm in rock 53 so let
me click on Route 53. so in this lab
we're actually going to simulate buying
a domain name and then we're going to
create an S3 static website and we're
going to map that website to this DNS
name right so the procedure is the same
for mapping load balancer the procedure
is the same for mapping cloudfront the
procedure is the same for mapping ec2
instances as well we're picking S3 for
Simplicity right but our focus is
actually on route 53 so let's go in here
and I will see if we can we will buy a
domain name here so let's first check
the availability of a domain name called
simply learn hyphen demo hyphen Route 53
let's check its availability it is
available for 12 so let me add it to
cart and then come back here and then
once you continue the last four personal
information once you give the personal
information you finally check out and
then it gets added to your shopping list
once you pay for it Amazon takes like 24
to 40 dollars to make that a DNS name
available so the next stage would be
contact details and then the third stage
would be verify and purchase so once
we've bought the domain name it will
become available in our DNS portal and I
do have a domain name which I bought
some time back and it's now available
for me to use so I can go to hosted Zone
and simply start creating I can go to
hosted Zone and then here it's going to
list all the my names for me right click
on the domain name and then click on the
record set and here I can actually map
plastic load balancer S3 website VPC
endpoint API Gateway and cloudfront
elastic bean stock domain names right
all that gets mapped through this portal
quite simple like four or five step
button clicks and then it'll be done so
I have an domain name bot and then I'm
going to go to S3 and now I'll show you
what I've done in S3 so I've created a
bucket name called as DNS name let me
clear the content in them so I've
created a bucket and then permissions
I've turned off Public Access blocking
and then I've created an a bucket policy
so this bucket is now publicly
accessible and then I went on to
properties and created the static
website hosting right and I've pointed
that this is the file that's my index
file that I'm going to put or name of
the file file that's going to be my
index file that I'm going to put in this
S3 bucket so put the index file.html
saved it and we're going to create a
file now we're going to create an index
file so this is a sample code it says
amazon.53 getting started routing
internet traffic to S3 bucket for your
website and then a couple of other
information so I've saved it as an
index.html file in my desktop so let me
upload that from my desktop into this
bucket so that's index.html and it's in
capital I so let me go to properties and
go to static website hosting and make
sure that I spell it properly right it's
case sensitive and then save it so now
this means that my website should be
running through this URL and it does
it's running to the static website URL
we're halfway through so now let me go
back to Route 53 go back to Route 53 go
back to hosted zones go into the domain
name and then create a record set and
it's going to be an alias record and and
I I see my S3 static website endpoint
there all right so click on it and
create it has now created an record
that's pointing my domain name to the S3
endpoint that I have created and my
static website is running from it so let
me test it right so let me go to the
browser put the domain name in there and
sure enough the domain name when we
browser queried for the domain name
around 53 returned a response saying
this domain name is actually mapped to
the S3 bucket static website hosting
enable S3 bucket and this is the URL for
that static website hosting and then my
browser was able to connect to that S3
bucket and download the details and show
it in my browser all right so it's that
simple and pretty straightforward
today's session is on AWS elastic
Beanstalk so what's in it for you today
we'll be discussing about what is AWS
why we require AWS elastic bean stock
what is AWS elastic bean stock the
advantages disadvant advantages the
components of mean stock along with that
the architecture and the companies that
are primarily using the AWS bean stock
so let's get started and first
understand what is AWS AWS stands for
Amazon web services it's a cloud
provider and that offers a variety of
services such as compute power database
storage content delivery and many other
resources so we know that AWS is the
largest cloud provider in the market and
so many services are available in the
AWS where you can apply the business
Logics and create the solutions using
the cloud platforms now why AWS elastic
mean stock now what happened earlier and
that whenever the developer used to
create the software or the modules
related to the software has to be joined
together to create a big application now
one developer creates a module that has
to be shared with another developer and
if the developers are geographically
separated then it has to be shared over
a medium probably an internet so that is
going to take some time it would be a
difficult process and in return it makes
the application or a software
development a linear process the
building of the software development
linear process so there were challenges
which the developers were facing earlier
and to overcome that we have the mean
stock as a service available in the AWS
so why AWS elastic bean stock is
required AWS elastic being stock has
made the life of the developers quite
easy uh in terms of that they can share
the applications across different
devices at a shorter time duration now
let's understand what is AWS elastic
bean stock AWS elastic bean stock is a
service which is used to deploy and
scale web applications by developers not
only web application any application
that is being developed by the
developers this is a simple
representation of the AWS plastic bean
stock NOW along with that the AWS
elastic bean stock supports the
programming language the runtime
environments that are Java net PHP
node.js python Ruby go and Docker and in
case if you're looking for any other
programming language or a runtime
environment then you can make a request
with AWS to arrange that for you now
what are the advantages associated with
the elastic mean stock first advantages
that it's a highly scalable service now
when we talk about a scalability it
means that whenever we require the
resources in demand we can scale up the
resources or we can scale down the
resources so that is kind of a
flexibility we get in terms of changing
the type of resources whenever we need
it and in that case the elastic
Beanstalk is a highly scalable service
now that is something which is very
difficult to achieve in case of an
on-prem environments because you have to
plan for the infrastructure and in case
if you're short of the resources within
that infrastructure then you have to
procure it again the second Advantage
associated with the Beanstalk is that
it's a fast and simple to begin now when
we say it's fast and simple that means
that you just have to focus focus on the
development of an application building
an application and then you can just
deploy the application directly using
the Beanstalk what the bean stock is
going to do that every networking aspect
is being taken care by the Beanstalk it
deploys your application in the back end
on the servers and then you can directly
access your application using the URL or
through the IP address the third
Advantage is that it offers the quick
deployment that is what we discussed in
the fast and simple to begin as well so
why it offers a quick deployment you
don't have to bother about the
networking Concepts you just have to
focus on the application development and
then you can just upload your
application deploy that and then you are
good to go the other Advantage is that
it supports multi-tenant architecture
when we talk about tenants or
multi-tenance that means we can have a
virtual environments for separate
organizations or the divisions within
the organizations that will be virtually
isolated so likewise you can have a
virtually isolated environments created
on the Beanstalk and the they can be
separated used as a separate entities or
a separate divisions within the
organization and we know that it's a
flexible service since it's a scalable
then it is a flexible also now coming to
the simplifies operations as an
advantage now once the application is
deployed using the Beanstalk then it
becomes very easy to maintain and
support that application using the
Beanstalk Services itself and the last
advantage that we can have from the
Beanstalk is that it's a cost efficient
service the cost efficient as we know
that many of the AWS services are cost
effective the cost optimization can be
better managed using the AWS main stock
as compared to if you are developing or
if you are deploying any kind of an
application or a solution on the on-prem
servers now there are some components
that are associated with the AWS
Beanstalk and it has to be created in
the form of a sequence manner so AWS
elastic Beanstalk consists of few
important components which are required
while developing an application now what
are these components these are four
components one is application the second
is application version the third is
environment and the fourth one is the
environment there and we have to
progress while deploying our
applications or the softwares using the
same sequence now let's understand what
are the different components of the
Beanstalk are the application it refers
to a unique label which is used as a
Deployable code for a web application so
generally you deploy your web
application or you create your
application and that is something which
is basically uh used as a unique label
then the second component is application
versions so it resembles a folder which
stores a collection of components such
as environments versions and environment
configurations so all these components
are being stored using the application
version the third most important
component is the environment in the
environment only the current versions of
the applications runs now remember that
elastic means stock supports multiple
versions as well and using the
environment you can can only run the
current version of the application file
if you wanted to have another version of
an application to be running then you
have to create another environment for
that then comes the environment here and
in the environment here it is basically
it designates the type of application
that the environment runs on now
generally there are two types of
environment here one is the web and the
other one is the worker node and that's
something which we'll be discussing
later as well now let's understand how
does elastic bean stock in AWS works so
first we have to create an application
and this is a task that would be done by
the developers and for that you can
actually select any runtime environment
or a programming language like Java
Docker Ruby gopal or python as well and
once you select that environment you can
develop your application using that
runtime environments now after that once
the application is created then you have
to upload the version of an application
on the AWS and after that once the
version is uploaded and then you have to
launch your environment so just have to
click click on the buttons that's it
nothing more you have to do once the
environment is launched then you can
actually view that environment using a
web URL or using the IP address now what
happens in that case is when you launch
an environment in the back end the
elastic bean stock runs automatically
runs any ec2 instance and using a
metadata the mean stock deploys our
application within that ec2 instance
that is something which you can look
into the ec2 dashboard as well so you
don't have to take care of the security
groups you don't have to take care of
the IP addressing and even you don't
have to login into the instance and
deploy your application it would be done
automatically by the Beanstalk it's just
that you just have to monitor the
environment and the statistics will be
available there itself in the bin stock
dashboard otherwise you can view those
statistics in the cloud watch logs as
well now in case if you wanted to update
any kind of a version then you just
upload a new version and then just apply
that and then monitor your environment
so these are the essential is to create
a local applications for any platform
whether it's a node.js python Etc these
are the things that you have to actually
take care and this is the sequence you
have to follow while creating an
environment so you can say that it's a
four steps creation of a deployment of
your application that's it now after
users upload their versions the
configuration is automatically deployed
with a load balancer yes and with the
load balancer that means you can access
the applications using the load balancer
DNS also and apart from load balancer if
you wanted to put any other feature that
includes the auto scaling for example if
you wanted to create your ec2 instances
where the application will be deployed
within the virtual private cloud or in a
particular subnet within the VPC all
those features that are available and
you can select them using the mean stock
itself you don't have to move out to the
VPC you don't have to actually go to the
ec2 dashboard and select all those
separately everything would be available
within the Beanstalk dashboard so that's
what it says in the presentation that
after creating an application the deploy
service can be specifically accessed
using the URL so once the environment is
created there will be a URL defined now
you can put a URL name also that is
something which you wanted to put for
your application you can Define that you
can check for the availability of that
URL and then you have to use that URL to
access your application or the browser
now once it is done then in the monitor
environment it says the environment is
monitored provided capacity provisioning
load balancing Auto scaling and Hand
Motor features all those features are
available there itself in the mean stock
now let's understand the architecture of
AWS elastic Beanstalk now there are two
types of environments that you have to
select you can select one is the web
server environment and the other one is
the worker environment So based on the
client requirement Beanstalk gives you
two different types of environment that
you have to select generally the web
server environment is the front-end
facing that means the client should be
as accessing this environment directly
using a URL so mostly a web applications
are deployed using that environment the
worker environment is the backend
applications or on the micro apps which
are basically required to support the
running of the web applications now it
depends on the client requirement what
kind of an environment you wanted to
select now in the web server environment
it only handles the HTTP request from
the clients so that's why we use the web
server environment mostly for the web
applications or any application which
works on the HTTP https requests so it's
not only the HTTP you can use the https
as well the worker environment it
process background tasks and minimizes
the consumption of resources so again it
is just like a kind of a micro service
or an application services that are
running in the back end to support the
web server environment now coming to the
understanding of the AWS main stock so
this is how the architecture of the AWS
bean stock is designed and you can refer
to that image also now in the web server
environment let's say if we select a web
server environment and it says that if
the application receives client request
the Amazon Route 53 sends his request to
the elastic load balance now obviously
we discussed here that the web server
environment is primarily an environment
which receives the HTTP requests it's a
kind of a client-facing environment now
if the application receives a client
request Amazon from the Amazon Route 53
this Route 53 user service which is
primarily used for DNS mapping it's a
global Service and it may route you can
route the traffic from the Route 53
matching your domains towards the load
balancer and from the load balancer you
can point that traffic to the web server
environment obviously the web server
environment is nothing it's just the ec2
instances that would be running in the
back end now here in the diagram you can
see that there are two web server
environments and they are created in the
auto scaling group that means there is
some kind of scaling options that are
defined as well and these instances are
created in an availability zone or they
can be created in a different
availability Zone also for the
redundancy as well and these web
application servers are further
connected to your databases which
primarily will be in a different
security groups probably it can be an
RDS database also so so all these
functionalities all these features are
basically available on the elastic mean
stock dashboard itself now what happens
in that case is if the application
receives client requests Amazon Route 53
send these requests to the load balancer
later the load balancer shares those
requests among the ec2 instances how
does that happen it happens using a
predefined algorithm the equal
distribution of a load is distributed to
both the ec2 instances or n number of
ec2 instances running in the
availability zone now in the
availability zones every ec2 instance
would have its own Security Group they
can have a common Security Group also
they can have their own Security Group
as well now after the security group the
load balancer is then connected to the
Amazon ec2 instance which are part of
the auto scaling group so that's
something which we have discussed
already now this Auto scaling group is
would be defined from the Beanstalk
itself and there will be some scaling
options that will be created it could be
a possibility that it might be the
minimum number of instances that would
be running as of now and based on the
threshold defined it may increase the
number of ec2 instance and the load
balancer will keep on Distributing the
load to as many instances that will be
created inside the availability Source
obviously there will be an internal hell
check that the load balancer will be
first doing before Distributing the
real-time traffic to this instances
created by the mean stock now what does
Auto scaling group does it automatically
starts the additional ec2 instance to
accommodate increasing load on your
application that's something which we
know that and also it monitors and
scales instances based on the workload
as well so depends on what kind of a
scaling threshold you have defined in
the auto scaling groups and when the
load of an application decreases the ec2
instance will also be decreased so
whenever we talk about the auto scaling
generally it comes in our mind is that
we scale up the resources that means we
it increases the ec2 instances in the
order scaling you might have the scale
down option also scale down policy also
created in which if the load minimizes
it can terminate the additional ec2
instances as well so that is something
which will be automatically managed all
these features can be achievable using
the elastic bean stock and with this
feature accommodated it gives you the
better cost optimization in terms of
managing your resources now it says that
elastic bean stock has a default
Security Group and the security group
acts as a Firefall for the instances now
here in this diagram it says about the
Security Group auto scaling also you
might create it in a default VPC also
you might create it in your custom EPC
also where you can have the additional
level of security is also created you
can have the NaCl snackers also defined
here before the security groups so that
would give you the additional filtering
option or the firewall option now it
says that with these groups with these
security groups it allows establishing
security groups to the database server
as well so every database would also
have its own Security Group and the
connection can be created between the
web servers environment that is created
by the Beanstalk to the database
security groups as well now let's
discuss about the worker environment now
now understanding the worker environment
what happens is that the client the web
server environment is the client facing
the client sends a request for an access
to the web server and in this diagram
the web server further sends it to the
sqs which is a simple queue service and
the queue service sends it to the worker
environment and then whatever the worker
environment is created for doing some
kind of a processing or some kind of an
application that is running in the back
end that environment initiates and then
send back the results to this sqs and
vice versa so let's understand the
architecture of a AWS elastic Beanstalk
with the worker environment so when a
worker environment here is launched AWS
elastic pin stock install the server on
every ec2 instance so that is in the
case of a web server environment also
and later the server passes the request
to the simple queue service now this
service is an asynchronous service
instead of a simple queue service you
can have other services also it is not
necessary that you need to have the SQL
so this is an example that we are
discussing about and the sqs shares
those message via a post request to the
HTTP path over the broker environment
and there are many case studies also
with respect to this kind of an
environment that is being created that
is being done on many customers and you
can search for these kind of a case
studies available on the internet now
the worker environment executes the task
given by the sqfs with the HTTP response
after the operation is completed now
here what happens is a quick recap the
client request for an access of an
application to a web server using an
HTTP request the web server passes that
request to the Q service the queue
service shares the message with the
worker probably a worker might be the
manual worker and generally it's an
automated worker so it would be shared
via the worker environment only and the
worker sends back the response with the
HTTP response back to the queue that
response can be viewed directly from the
queue service by the client using the
web server so this is one of the example
likewise as I said that there can be
many other examples also where you can
have the worker environments defined now
what are the companies that are using
the elastic bean stock these are few of
the companies that are primarily using
on Zillow jelly button games uh then you
have League of Women Voters eBay these
are some of the few listed companies and
obviously you search on the AWS site and
you'll find many more organizations that
are using the elastic mean stock
primarily for deploying their
applications now the next thing is to go
with the practicals that how actually we
use the elastic Beanstalk so let's look
into the demo using the AWS elastic
Beanstalk now first you have to login
into the AWS console and I'm sure that
you might be having the accounts created
or you can use the IM credentials as
well and then you have to select the
region also now I am in the North
Virginia region likewise you can select
any of the regions that are listed here
now click on the services and you have
to search for the elastic bean stock you
can find the elastic Beanstalk under the
compute section so here itself you'll
find the elastic bean stock as a service
now open this service and there it will
give you an option to create an
environment you have to specifically
select an environment probably a worker
environment or a web service environment
so let's wait for the service to open so
we have the dashboard now available with
us this is how the elastic Beanstalk
looks and this is the symbol
representation of a beanstalk now what
you have to do is we have to click on
get started and that will load and you
have to create a web app so instead of
creating a web app what we'll do we'll
create a new application so just click
on create a new application put an
application name let's say we put
something like x y z you can put any
description to your application let's
say it's a demo app and click on create
now it says you have to select an
environment now the environment the
application name XYZ is created you just
have to select the app environment so
click on create one now and it is going
to ask you that what kind of an
environment here you wanted to select so
as we discussed that there are two types
of environments one is the web server
and the other one is the worker and one
let's look into it what is defined by
the AWS AWS says that it has two types
of environment tiers to support
different types of web applications web
servers are standard applications that
listen for and then process HTTP request
typically Uber port number 80. workers
are specialized applications that have a
background processing task that listens
for message on an Amazon sqs queue
workers application post those messages
to your application by using the HTTP
response so that's what we saw in the
case of the Beanstalk slides also now
the usability of a worker environment
can be anything now we'll do a demo for
creating a web server environment so
just click on select and you we have the
environment name created now we can
Define our own domain it ends with the
region dot elasticbeanstalk.com let's
say I look for a domain which is XYZ
only that's the environment name now
I'll check for the availability whether
that domain name is available with us or
not and it says we don't have that
domain name so probably I'll try to make
it with some other name and let's look
for the availability XYZ ABC and it says
yes it is available now once I deploy my
application I would be able to access
the application using this complete DNS
so you can put a description it's a demo
app that we are creating and then you
have to define a platform as well now
these are the platforms that are
supported by the AWS let's say I wanted
to run a node.js environment so I'll
just click on the node.js platform the
application codes is something which is
basically developed by the developers
and you can upload the App application
right now or you can do that later as
well once the environment is ready now
either you can select to create an
environment if you wanted to go with all
the default settings otherwise if you
wanted to customize it more you can
click on configure more options so let's
click on configure more options and here
you would be able to define various
different features like the type of an
instance for example what kind of an ec2
instance or a server that should be
running so that the Beanstalk can deploy
your applications over it if you wanted
to modify just click on a modify button
and here you can modify your instances
with respect to the storage as well now
apart from that if you wanted to do some
modification in the case of monitoring
in the case of databases in the case of
security or in the case of a capacity
let's look into the capacity so here you
can actually do the modification so in
the capacity you can select the instance
type also by default it is T2 dot micro
but in case if your application requires
a larger type of an instance then you
can actually go for the instance type as
well similarly you can Define your Emi
IDs also because obviously for the
application to run you would require the
operating system also so you can select
that particular Ami ID for your
operating system as well let's cancel
that likewise you have many other
features uh that you can actually Define
here from the dashboard and you don't
have to go to the ec2 dashboard to do
the modifications now let's go and
create an environment let's assume that
we are going with the default
configuration so this is going to create
our environment the environment is being
created and you can get the environment
and the logs defined in the dashboard
itself so you'll see that the Beanstalk
environment is being initiated uh the
environment is being started and in case
if there would be any errors or if it is
deployed correctly you will get all the
logs here itself now the environments
are basically color coded so there are
different color codings that are defined
if you get the environment in a green
color that means everything is good to
go so here you can see that it has
created an elastic IP it has checked the
health of the environment now it has
created the security groups and that
would be an auto security groups created
by the mean stock and the environment
creation has been started you can see
that uh elastic bean stock as Amazon S3
storage bucket for your environment data
as well this is the URL through which
you will be accessing the environment
but right now we cannot do that since
the environment is being created let's
click on the application name and here
you can see that it is in a gray color
that means right now the build is being
done it is being created once it will be
successfully created it should change to
the green color and then we will be able
to access our environment using the URL
now if I move to the ec2 instances and
see in the ec2 dashboard if I see
whether the instance is being created by
the Beanstalk or not so let's see and
let's see what are the differences in
terms of creating an instance manually
and getting it created from the
Beanstalk so click on the ec2 let's go
to the old ec2 experience that's what we
are familiar with and let's see what's
there in the dashboard so here you can
see one running instance let's open that
and the XYZ environment which was
created from the Beanstalk is being
initiated the instance is being
initiated and that is something which is
being done by the mean stock itself we
have not gone to the dashboard and
created it manually now in the security
groups if you see that here the AWS mean
stock security groups are defined it has
the elastic IPS also defined so
everything is being created by the
Beanstalk itself right now let's go back
to the Beanstalk and let's look into the
status of our environment whether the
color coding has been changed from Gray
to green or not and here you can see the
environment is successfully created and
we have that environment colored in
green we'll access the environment and
it says it's a web server environment
its platform is node.js running on
64-bit Amazon Linux Ami and it's a
sample app sample application health
status is okay now the other thing is
that if you do not want to use the web
console the Management console to access
the main stock then the Beanstalk offers
you the elastic Beanstalk CLI as well so
you can install the command line
interface and then you have the command
references CLI command references that
you can actually play with and get your
applications deployed using the
Beanstalk itself so this is one of the
sample CLI commands that you can
actually look into now let's look into
the environment let's click on the
environment and we'll be represented
with the URL it says health is okay
these are the logs that you have to
follow in case if there are any issues
the platform is node.js that is what we
selected now the next thing is you just
have to upload and deploy your
application so just click on upload and
deploy select the version label or the
name select file and wherever your
application is hosted at just select
that upload it and deploy your
application you'll see that the like
your environment is created similarly
your application will be deployed
automatically on the instance and from
this URL you will be able to view the
output it is as simple as just like you
have to follow these four steps now
let's see whether the node.js
environment is running on our instance
before deploying an application so we'll
just click on this URL since the
Beanstalk has already opened up the
security groups or HTTP Port 80 for all
we can actually view that output
directly from the URL so we have the
node.js running that's visible here and
after that you just have to upload and
deploy your application and then from
that URL you can get the output now this
URL you can map it with the root 53
service so using the root 53 DNS
Services the domain names can be pointed
to the elastic Beanstalk URL and from
there it can be pointed to the
applications that are running on the ec2
instance whether you wanted to point it
to the URL directly using the Beanstalk
you can do that otherwise as we saw in
the slides you can use the root 53
pointer to the load balancer and then
point it to the instances directly also
once it is created by the mean stock so
that was the demo guys with respect to
the bean stock and how we can actually
run the environments apart from that the
operational task like system operations
you can manage all these things from the
environment dashboard itself so you have
the configurations you have the logs you
can actually check the health status of
your environment you can do the
monitoring and you can actually get the
alarms and the events here so let's say
if I wanted to if I wanted to see the
logs I can request for the logs here
itself and I'll be represented with the
full log report and I can now download
that log file and I can view logs so
it's in D so we have this bundle locks
in the zip file all right so if you want
to see some kind of logs with respect to
elastic bean stock activity it's in the
form of a notepad and here you can see
what all configurations the Beanstalk
has done on your environment on your
instance similarly you can go for the
health monitoring alarms events and all
those things if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
hi
the AWS Solutions architect course
migrating to the cloud doesn't mean that
resources become completely separated
from the local infrastructure
in fact running applications in the
cloud will be completely transparent to
your end users
AWS offers a number of services to fully
and seamlessly integrate your local
Resources with the cloud
one such service is the Amazon virtual
private cloud
this lesson talks about creating virtual
networks that closely resemble the ones
that operate in your own data centers
but with the added benefit of being able
to take full advantage of AWS
so let's get started
[Music]
in this lesson you'll learn all about
virtual private clouds and understand
their concept
you'll know the difference between
public private and elastic IP addresses
you'll learn about what a public and
private Southerner is
and you'll understand what an internet
gateway is and how it's used
you'll learn what root tables are and
when they are used
you'll understand what a Nat Gateway is
we'll take a look at security groups and
their importance
and we'll take a look at Network ACLS
and how they're used in Amazon VPC
we'll also review the Amazon VPC best
practices
and also the costs associated with
running a VPC in the Amazon Cloud
welcome to the Amazon virtual private
cloud and subnet section
in this section we're going to have an
overview of what Amazon VPC is and how
you use it and we're also going to have
a demonstration of how to create your
own custom virtual private cloud
we're going to look at IP addresses and
the use of elastic IP addresses in AWS
and finally we'll take a look at subnets
and there'll be a demonstration about
how to create your own subnets in an
Amazon VPC
and here are similar terms that are used
in vpcs
the subnets root tables elastic IP
addresses internet gateways Nat gateways
Network ACLS and security groups and in
the next sections we're going to take a
look at each of these and build our own
custom VPC that we'll use throughout
this course
Amazon defines a VPC as a virtual
private Cloud that enables you to launch
AWS resources into a virtual Network
that you've defined this virtual Network
closely resembles a traditional Network
that you'd operate in your own data
center but with the benefits of using
the scalable infrastructure of AWS
a VPC is your own virtual Network in the
Amazon Cloud which is used as the
network layer for your ec2 resources and
this is a diagram of the default VPC now
there's a lot going on here so don't
worry about that what we're going to do
is break down each of the individual
items in this default VPC over the
coming lesson
but what you need to know is that a VPC
is a critical part of the exam and you
need to know all the concepts and how it
differs from your own Networks
throughout this lesson we're going to
create our own VPC from scratch which
you'll need to replicate at the end of
this so you can do well in the exam
each VPC that you create is logically
isolated from other virtual networks in
the AWS Cloud it's fully customizable
you can select the IP address range
create subnet configure root tables set
up Network gateways Define security
settings using security groups and
network access control lists
so each Amazon account comes with a
default VPC that's pre-configured for
you to start using straight away so you
can launch your ec2 instances without
having to think about anything we
mentioned in the opening section A VPC
can span multiple availability zones in
a region
and here's a very basic diagram of a VPC
it isn't this simple in reality
and as we saw in the first section
here's the default Amazon VPC which
looks kind of complicated
but what we need to know at this stage
is that cidr block for the default VPC
is always a 16 subnet mask so in this
example it's
172.31.0.0 16. what that means is this
VPC will provide up to 65
536 private IP addresses
so in the coming sections we'll take a
look at all of these different items
that you can see on this default VPC but
why wouldn't you just use the default
VPC
well the default VPC is great for
launching new instances when you're
testing AWS
but creating a custom VPC allows you to
make things more secure and you can
customize your virtual Network as you
can Define your own IP address range you
can create your own subnets that are
both private and public and you can
tighten down your security settings
by default instances that you launch
into a VPC can't communicate with your
own network
so you can connect your vpcs to your
existing data center using something
called Hardware VPN access so that you
can effectively extend your data center
into the cloud and create a hybrid
environment
now to do this you need a virtual
private Gateway and this is the VPN
concentrator on the Amazon side of the
VPN connection then on your side in your
data center you need a customer Gateway
which is either a physical device or a
software application that sits on your
side of the VPN connection
so when you create a VPN connection a
VPN tunnel comes up when traffic is
generated from your side of the
connection
VPC pairing is an important concept to
understand
appearing connection could be made
between your own bpcs or with a VPC in
another AWS account as long as it's in
the same region
so what that means is if you have
instances in vpca they wouldn't be able
to communicate with instances in vpcb or
C unless you set up appearing connection
hearing is a one-to-one relationship a
VPC can have multiple peering
connections to other vpcs but and this
is important transitive peering is not
supported
in other words
vpca can connect to B and C in this
diagram but C wouldn't be able to
communicate with B unless they were
directly paired
also vpcs with overlapping cidrs cannot
be paired so in this diagram you can see
they all have different IP ranges which
is fine but if they have the same IP of
ranges they wouldn't be able to be
paired
and finally for this section if you
delete the default VPC you have to
contact AWS support to get it back again
so be careful with it and only delete it
if you have good reason to do so and
know what you're doing
this is a demonstration of how to create
a custom VPC
so here we are back at the Amazon web
services Management console and this
time we're going to go down to the
bottom left where the networking section
is I'm going to click on VPC
and the VPC dashboard will load up now
there's a couple of ways you can create
a custom VPC there's something called
the VPC wizard
which will build vpcs on your behalf
from a selection of different
configurations for example a VPC with a
single public subnet or a VPC with
public and private subnets now this is
great because you click a button type in
a few details and it does the work for
you however you're not going to learn
much or pass the exam if this is how you
do it so we'll cancel that and we'll go
to your vpcs and we'll click on create a
VPC
and we're presented with the create a
VPC window so let's give our VPC a name
I'm going to call that simply learn
underscore VPC
and this is the kind of naming
convention I'll be using throughout this
course
next we need to give it the cidr block
or the classes into domain routing block
so we're going to give it a very simple
one
10.0.0.0 and then we need to give it the
subnet mask so you're not allowed to go
larger than 15. so if I try to put 15 in
it says no not going to happen
print reference subnet mask of 15 would
give you around 131 000 IP addresses
and subnet 16 will give you 65
536 which is probably more than enough
for what we're going to do
next you get to choose the tenancy and
there's two options default and
dedicated if you select dedicated then
your ec2 instances will reside on
Hardware that's dedicated to you so your
performance is going to be great but
your cost is going to be significantly
higher so I'm going to stick with
default
and we just click on yes create
it'll take a couple of seconds
and then in our VPC dashboard we can see
our simply learned VPC has been created
now if we go down to the bottom here to
see the information about our new VPC we
can see it has a root table associated
with it
which is our default root table
so there it is and we can see that it's
only allowing local traffic at the
moment
we go back to the VPC again we can see
it's been given a default Network ACL
and we'll click on that and have a look
and you can see this is very similar to
what we looked at in the lesson
so it's allowing all traffic from all
sources inbound and outbound
now if we go to the subnet section
widen the VPC area here
you can see there's no subnets
associated with the VPC we just created
so that means we won't be able to launch
any instances into our VPC
and to prove it I'll just show you we'll
go to the ec2 section
so this is a glimpse into your future
this is what we'll be looking at in the
next lesson and we'll just quickly try
and launch an instance we'll select any
instance it doesn't matter
any size not important so here the
network section if I try and select
simply learn VPC it's saying no subnets
found this is not going to work
so we basically need to create some
subnets in our VPC
and that is what we're going to look at
in the next lesson
now private IP addresses are IP
addresses that are not reachable over
the internet and they're used for
communication between instances in the
same network
when you launch a new instance it's
given a private IP address and an
internal DNS hostname that resolves to
the private IP address of the instance
but if you want to connect to this from
the Internet it's not going to work
so then you'd need a public IP address
which is reachable from the internet you
can use public IP addresses for
communication between your instances and
the internet
each instance that receives a public IP
address is also given an external DNS
hostname
public IP addresses are associated with
your instances from the Amazon Pool of
public IP addresses
when you stop or terminate your instance
the public IP address is released and a
new one is associated when the instance
starts
so if you want your instance to retain
this public IP address
you need to use something called an
elastic IP address
an elastic IP address is a static or
persistent public IP address that's
allocated to your account and can be
Associated to and from your instances as
required an elastic IP address remains
in your account until you choose to
release it there is a charge associated
with an elastic IP address if it's in
your account but not actually allocated
to an instance
this is a demonstration of how to create
an elastic IP address
so we're back at the Amazon web services
Management console we're going to head
back down to the networking VPC section
and we'll get to the VPC dashboard on
the left hand side we'll click on
elastic IPS
now you'll see a list of any elastic IPS
that you have associated in your account
and remember any the elastic IP address
that you're using that isn't allocated
to something you'll be charged for so I
have one available and that is allocated
to an instance currently so we want to
allocate a new address
and it reminds you that there's a charge
if you're not using it I'm saying yes
allocate
and it takes a couple of seconds
and there's our new elastic IP address
now we'll be using this IP address to
associate with the NAT Gateway when we
build that
AWS defines a subnet as a range of IP
addresses in your VPC
you can launch AWS resources into a
subnet that you select you can use a
public subnet for resources that must be
connected to the internet and a private
subnet for resources that won't be
connected to the internet
the netmask for the default Subnet in
your VPC is always 20 which provides up
to 4096 addresses per subnet and a few
of them are reserved for AWS use
a VPC can span multiple availability
zones but the subnet is always mapped to
a single availability Zone this is
important to know so here's our basic
diagram which we're now going to start
adding to so we can see the virtual
private cloud and you can see the
availability zones and now inside each
availability Zone we've rated a subnet
now you won't be able to launch any
instances unless there are subnets in
your VPC
so it's good to spread them across
availability zones for redundancy and
failover purposes
there's two different types of subnet
public and private
you use a public subnet for resources
that must be connected to the internet
for example web servers
a public subnet is made public because
the main root table sends the subnets
traffic that is destined for the
internet to the internet gateway and
we'll touch on internet gateways next
private subnets are for resources that
don't need an internet connection or
that you want to protect from the
internet for example database instances
so in this demonstration we're going to
create some subnets a public and a
private subnet and we're going to put
them in our custom VPC in different
availability zones
so we'll head to networking and VPC
wait for the VPC dashboard to load up
we'll click on subnets
we'll go to create subnet
and I'm going to give the subnet a name
so it's good to give them meaningful
names
so I'm going to call this first one for
the public subnet
10.0.1.0 and I'm going to put this one
in
the US East
one
B availability Zone
and I'm going to call that a simply
learn
car black
so it's quite a long name I understand
but at least it makes it clear for
what's going on in this example so we
need to choose a VPC so we obviously
want to put it in our simply learn VPC
and I said I wanted to put it in Us East
1B I'm using the North Virginia region
by the way
so we click on that then we need to give
it the cidr block
now as I mentioned earlier when I typed
in the name
that's the range I want to use and then
we need to give it the subnet mask and
we're going to go with
24. which should give us 251 addresses
in this range which obviously is going
to be more than enough if I try and put
a different value in that's unacceptable
to Amazon it's going to say
again it's going to give me an error and
tell me not to do that
let's go back to 24. and click on the
cut and paste this by the way just
because I need to type something very
similar for the next one
create
takes a few seconds
okay so there's our new subnet and I
just widen this
you can see so that's
the IP range that's the availability
Zone it's for simple learn and it's
public
so now we want to create
the private
so put the name in I'm going to give the
private the IP address block
of that
I'm going to put this one in Us East 1C
and it's going to be the private
stop now
obviously I want it to be in the same
VPC
credibility zone of Us East 1C
and we're going to give it
10.0.2.0 Dash
24.
and we'll click yes create
and again it takes a few seconds
okay so let me sort by name
so there we go we can see now we've got
our private subnet and our public Subnet
in fact let me just type in simply that
there we are so now you can see them
both there
and you can see they're both in the same
VPC
simply learn VPC
now if we go down to the bottom you can
see the root table associated with these
vpcs
and you can see that they can
communicate with each other internally
but there's no internet access
so that's what we need to do next in the
next lesson you're going to learn about
internet gateways and how we can make
these subnets have internet access
welcome to the networking section
in this section we're going to take a
look at internet gateways route tables
and NAC devices and we'll have a
demonstration on how to create each of
these AWS VPC items
so to allow your VPC the ability to
connect to the internet you need to
attach an internet gateway
and you can only attach one internet
gateway per VPC
so attaching the internet gateway is the
first stage in permitting internet
access to instances in your VPC now
here's our diagram again and now we've
added the internet gateway which is
providing the connection to the internet
to your VPC but before you can configure
internet correctly there's a couple more
steps
for an ec2 instance to be internet
connected you have to adhere to the
following rules
firstly you have to attach an internet
gateway to your VPC which we just
discussed
then you need to ensure that your
instances have public IP addresses or
elastic IP addresses so they're able to
connect to the internet
then you need to ensure that your
subnets root table points to the
internet gateway
and you need to ensure that your network
access control and Security Group rules
allow relevant traffic to flow to and
from your instance so you need to allow
the rules to let in the traffic you want
for example HTTP traffic after the
demonstration for this section we're
going to look at how root tables Access
Control lists and security groups are
used
in this demonstration we're going to
create an internet gateway and attach it
to our custom VPC
so let's go to networking bpc
bring up the VPC dashboard
and on the left hand side we click on
internet gateways
so here's a couple of Internet gateways
I have already
but I need to create a new one so create
internet gateway
I'll give it a name which is going to be
simply learn
internet gateway igw and I'm going to
click create so this is an internet
gateway which will connect a VPC to the
internet because at the moment our
custom VPC has no internet access
so there it is created
you simply learn igw
but this state is detached because it's
not attached to anything so let me try
and attach it to a VPC
and it gives me an option of all the
vpcs that have no
internet gateway attached to them
currently
so I only have one which is simpler than
VPC
yes attach
now you can see our VPC has internet
attached and you can see that down here
so let's click on that and it will take
us to our VPC
but before any instances in our VPC can
access the internet we need to ensure
that our subnet root table points to the
internet gateway
and we don't want to change the main
route table we want to create a custom
root table and that's what you're going
to learn about next
a root table determines where Network
traffic is directed
it does this by defining a set of rules
every subnet has to be associated with a
root table and a subnet can only be
associated with one root table
however multiple subnets can be
associated with the same root table
every VPC has a default route table and
it's good practice to leave this in its
original state and create a new root
table to customize the network traffic
routes associated with your VPC
so here's our example and we've added
two root tables the main root table and
the custom root table
the new root table or the custom root
table will tell the internet gateway to
direct internet traffic to the public
subnet
but the private subnet is still
Associated to the default route table
the main root table which does not allow
internet traffic to it
all traffic inside the private subnet is
just remaining local
in this demonstration we're going to
create a custom root table associated
with our internet gateway and Associate
our public subnet with it
so let's go to networking and VPC
the dashboard will load and we're going
to go to Route tables
now our VPC only has its main route
table at the moment the default one it
was given at the end time it was created
so we want to create a new root table
and we want to give it a name so we're
going to call it simply learn
I'm going to call it root table rtb for
sure
and then we get to pick which VPC we
want to put it in so obviously we want
to use simply learn VPC
so we click create
which will take a couple of seconds and
here you are here's our new root table
so what we need to do now is change its
route so that it points to the internet
gateway so if we go down here to root
at a minute you can see it's just like
our main root table it just has local
access
so we want to click on edit and we want
to add another root
so the destination is
the internet
which is all the zeros and our Target
and we click on this it gives us the
option of our internet gateway which we
want to do so now we have internet
access to this subnet sorry to this root
table
and we click on Save
save for successful so now we can see
that as well as local access we have
internet access
now at the moment if we click on subnet
associations
you do not have any subnet associations
so basically both both our subnets the
public and private subnets are
associated with the main root table
which doesn't have internet access
so we want to change this so we'll click
on edit
and we want our public subnet to be
associated with this root table
let's click on Save
so it's just saving that
so now we can see that our public subnet
is associated with this route table
and this route table is associated with
the internet gateway so now anything we
launch into the public subnet will have
internet access
but what if we wanted our instances in
the private subnet to have internet
access
well there's a way of doing that with a
nap device and that's what we're going
to look at in the next lecture
you can use a Nat device to enable
instances in a private subnet to connect
to the Internet or other AWS services
but prevent the internet from initiating
connections with the instances in the
private subnet
so we talked earlier about public and
private subnets to protect your assets
from be directly connected to the
internet
for example your web server would sit in
the public Subnet in your database in
the private subnet which has no internet
connectivity
however your private subnet database
instance might still need internet
access or the ability to connect to
other AWS resources
if so you can use a network address
translation device or a Nat device to do
this
and that device forwards traffic from
your private subnet to the internet or
other AWS services and then sends the
response back to the instances
when traffic goes to the internet The
Source IP address of your instance is
replaced with the NAT device address and
when the internet traffic comes back
again then that device translates the
address to your instance's private IP
address
so here's our diagram which is getting
ever more complicated and if you look in
the public subnet you can see we've now
added a Nat device and you have to put
Nat devices in the public subnet so that
they get internet connectivity
AWS provides two kinds of nat devices
and that Gateway and in that instance
AWS recommends in that Gateway as it's a
managed service that provides better
availability and bandwidth than that
instances each Nat Gateway is created in
a specific availability Zone and is
implemented with redundancy in that zone
and that instance is launched from a Nat
Ami an Amazon machine image and runs as
an instance in your VPC so it's
something else you have to look after
whereas in that Gateway being a fully
managed service means once it's
installed you can pretty much forget
about it
and that Gateway must be launched into a
public subnet because it needs internet
connectivity it also needs an elastic IP
address which you can select at the time
of launch
once created you need to update the root
table associated with your private
subnet the point internet bound traffic
to the NAT Gateway this way the
instances in your private subnets can
communicate with the internet
so if you remember back to the diagram
when we had the custom root table which
was pointed to the internet gateway
now we're pointing our main root table
to the NAT Gateway so that the private
subnet also gets internet access but in
a more secure manner
welcome to the create and that Gateway
demonstration where we're going to
create a Nat Gateway so that the
instances in our private subnet can get
internet access
so we'll start by going to networking
and VPC
and the first thing we're going to do is
take a look at our subnets and you'll
see why shortly so here are our simply
learn subnets so this is the private
subnet that we want to give internet
access but if you remember from the
section
and that gateways need to be placed in
public subnets so I'm just going to copy
the name of this subnet ID
for the public subnet and you'll see why
in a moment
so then we go to Nat gateways on the
left hand side
and we want to create a new Nat Gateway
so we have to put a subnet in there so
we want to choose our public subnet as
you can see
it truncates a lot of the subnet names
on this option so it's a bit confusing
so we know that we want to put it in our
simply learned VPC
in the public subnet but you can see
it's truncated so it's actually this one
at the bottom but what I'm going to do
is just paste in
the subnet ID which I copied earlier
so there's no confusion
then we need to give it an elastic IP
address now if you remember from the
earlier demonstration we created one so
let's select that but if you hadn't
allocated one you could click on the
create new EIP button
so we'll do that
okay so it's telling me my Nat Gateway
has been created and in order to use you
on that Gateway ensure that you edit
your root table to include a route with
a target of and then on that Gateway ID
so it's given us the option to click on
our edit root tables so we'll go
straight there now here's our here's our
root tables
now
here's the custom root table that we
created earlier and this is the default
the main route over which was created
when we launched our when we created our
VPC so we should probably give this a
name so that we know what it is so let
me just call this simply learn rtb
Main
so now we know that's our main root
table
so if you take a look at the main root
and the subnet associations
you can see that our private subnet is
associated with this table
so what we need to do is put a root in
here that points to the NAT Gateway so
if we click on roots and edit
and we want to add another route
and we want to say that all traffic
can
either go to the simply the internet
gateway which we don't want to do we
want to point it to a nap instance which
is this Nat ID here
and we click save
so now any instances launched in our
private subnet we'll be able to get
internet access via around that Gateway
foreign
security groups and network ACL section
in this section we're going to take a
look at security groups and network ACLS
and we're going to have a demonstration
on how you create both of these items in
the Amazon web services console
a security group acts as a virtual
firewall that controls the traffic for
one or more instances
you add rules to each security group
that allow traffic to or from its
Associated instances
basically a security group controls the
inbound and outbound traffic for one or
more ec2 instances
security groups can be found on both the
ec2 and VPC dashboards in the AWS web
Management console we're going to cover
them here in this section and you'll see
them crop up again in the ec2 lesson
and here is our diagram and you can see
we've now added security groups to it
and you can see that ec2 instances are
sitting inside the security groups and
the security groups will control what
traffic Flows In and Out
so let's take a look at some examples
and we'll start with a security group
for a web server now obviously a web
server needs HTTP and https traffic as a
minimum to be able to access it
so here is an example of the security
group table and you can see we're
allowing HTTP and https the ports that
are associated with those two and the
sources and we're allowing it from the
internet we're basically allowing all
traffic to those ports
and that means any other traffic that
comes in on different ports would be
unable to reach the security group and
the instances inside it
let's take a look at an example for a
database server Security Group
now imagine you have a SQL Server
database
then you would need to open up the SQL
Server Port so that people can access it
which is Port 1433 by default so we've
added that to the table and we've
allowed the source to come from the
internet now because it's a Windows
machine you might want RDP access so you
can log on and do some Administration
so we've also added RDP access to the
security group now you could leave it
open to the internet but that would mean
anyone could try and hack their way into
your box so in this example we've added
a source IP address of
10.00.0.0 so only IP arranges from that
address can RDP to the instance
now there's a few rules associated with
security groups by default security
groups allow all outbound traffic so if
you want to tighten that down you can do
so in a similar way to you can Define
the inbound traffic
Security Group rules are always
permissive you can't create rules that
deny access so you're allowing access
rather than denying it
security groups are stateful so if you
send a request from your instance the
response traffic for that request is
allowed to flow in regardless of the
inbound Security Group rules
and you can modify the rules of a
security group at any time and the rules
are applied immediately
welcome to the create Security Group
demonstration where we're going to
create two security groups one the host
DB servers and one the host web servers
now if you remember from the best
practices section it said it was always
a good idea to tier your applications
into security groups and that's exactly
what we're going to do
so if we go to networking and VPC to
bring up the VPC dashboard
on the left hand side under security we
click on security groups now you can
also get to security groups from the ec2
dashboard as well
so here's a list of my existing security
groups but we want to create a new
security group and we're going to call
it
simply learn
web server
SG Security Group and we'll give the
group name as the same and our
description is going to be simply learn
web servers
security groups
okay and then we need to select our VPC
now it defaults to the default VPC but
obviously we want to put it in our
simply learned VPC so we click yes
create
takes a couple of seconds
and there it is there's our new Security
Group
now if we go down to the rules the
inbound rules
you can see there are none so by default
a new security group has no inbound
rules
but what about outbound rules
if you remember from the lesson
a new Security Group by default allows
all traffic to be outbound
and there you are all traffic
has destination of everywhere so all
traffic is allowed but we want to add
some rules so let's click on inbound
rules click on edit
now this is going to be a web server so
if we click on the drop down
we need to give it http
so you can either choose custom TCP Rule
and type in your own port ranges or you
can just use the ones they have for you
so http
this pre-populates the port range and
then here you can add the source
now if I click on it it's giving me the
option of saying allow
access from different security groups
so you could create a security group and
say I only accept traffic from a
different Security Group which is a nice
way of securing things down you could
also put in here just your IP address so
that only you could do HTTP requests to
the instance but because it's a web
server
we want people to be able to see our
website otherwise it's not going to be
much use so we're going to say all
traffic so all source traffic can access
our instance on Port http 80.
I want to add another rule because we
also want to do https
cheers hiding from me
there we are and again we want to do
the same
and also because this is going to be a
Linux instance we want to be able to
connect to the Linux the instance to do
some work and configuration so we need
to give it SSH access
and again it would be good practice to
tie it down to your specific IP or an IP
range but we're just going to do all for
now and then we click on Save
and there we go there we have our ranges
so now we want to create our security
group for our DB servers so let's click
create Security Group
and then we'll go through it and give it
a similar name
simply learn
TB servers s key
and the description it's going to be
simpler than DB servers Security Group
and our VPC is obviously going to be
simpler than VPC
just click yes create wait a few seconds
and here's our new security group as you
can see it has no inbound Rules by
default and outbound rules allow all
traffic
so this is going to be a SQL Server
database server and so we need to allow
SQL Server traffic into the instance
so we need to give
it Microsoft SQL Port access Now the
default port for Microsoft SQL Server is
now in reality I'd probably change the
port the C for server was running on to
make it more secure
but we'll go with this for now and then
the source so we could choose the IPA
ranges again but what we want to do is
place the DB server in the private
subnet and allow the traffic to come
from the web server
so the web server will accept traffic
and the web server will then go to the
database to get the information it needs
to display on its web on the website or
if people are entering information into
the website we want the information to
be stored in our DB server so basically
we want to say that this the DB servers
can only accept SQL Server traffic from
the web server Security Group
so we can select the simply then web
server Security Group as the source
traffic
but Microsoft SQL Server data
so we'll select that now our SQL Server
is obviously going to be a Windows
instance so from time to time we might
not we might need to log in and
configure it so we want to give RDP
access to now again you would probably
put a specific IP range in there we're
just going to do all traffic for now
then we click save
and there we are so now we have two
security groups
DB servers and web servers
a network ACL is a network access
control list
and it's an optional layer of security
for your VPC that acts as a firewall for
controlling traffic in and out of one or
more of your subnets
you might set up Network ACLS with rules
similar to your security groups in order
to add an additional layer of security
to your VPC
here is our Network diagram and we've
added Network ACLS to the mix now you
can see they sit somewhere between the
root tables and the subnets
this diagram makes it a little bit
clearer and you can see that a network
ACL sits in between a root table and a
subnet
and also you can see an example of the
default Network ACL
which is configured to allow all traffic
to flow in and out of the subnets to
which It's associated
each Network ACL includes a whose rule
number is an Asterix this rule ensures
that if a packet doesn't match any of
the other numbered rules it's denied you
can't modify or remove this rule
so if you take a look at this table you
can see on the inbound some traffic
would come in and it would look for the
first rule which is 100 and that's
saying I'm allowing all traffic from all
sources so that's fine the traffic comes
in if that rule 100 wasn't there it
would go to the Asterix Rule and the
Asterix rule is saying traffic from all
sources is denied
let's take a look at the network ACL
rules
each Subnet in your VPC must be
associated with an ACL if you don't
assign it to a custom ACL it will
automatically be Associated to your
default ACL
a subnet can only be associated with one
ACL however an ACL can be associated
with multiple subnets
an ACL contains a list of numbered rules
which are evaluated in order starting
with the lowest as soon as a rule
matches traffic it's applied regardless
of any higher numbered rules that may
contradict it
AWS recommends incrementing your rules
by a factor of 100 so there's plenty of
room to implement new rules at a later
date
unlike security groups ACLS are
stateless responses to allowed inbound
traffic are subject to the rules for
outbound traffic
welcome to the network ACL demonstration
where we're just going to have an
overview of ocls where they are in the
dashboard
now you don't need to know a huge amount
about them for the exam you just need to
know how they work and where they are so
let's go to networking and VPC
and on when the dashboard loads on the
left hand side under security there's
Network ACLS so let's click on that now
you can see some ACLS that are in my my
AWS account so we want the one that's
associated with our simply learned VPC
so if we extend this VPC
column
that's our Network ACLS simple then VPC
now let's give it a name because it's
not very clear to see otherwise also I'm
kind of an obsessive tagger so let's
call it simply learn ACL and click on
the tick so now it's much easier to see
so we click on inbound rules so this is
exactly what we showed you in the lesson
the rule is 100 so that's the first rule
that's going to get evaluated and it's
saying allow all traffic from all
sources
and the outbound rules are the same
so if you wanted to tighten down the new
rule you could click edit we would give
it a new rule number say which would be
200 so you should always increment them
in 100 so that means if you had 99 more
rules you needed to put in place you'd
have space to put them in in between
these two
and then you could do whatever you
wanted you could say you know we are
allowing HTTP access from
all traffic
and we're allowing or you could say
actually you know what we're going to
deny it so this is the way of
blacklisting traffic into your VPC
now I'm not going to save that because
we don't need it
but this is where Network ACL sit and
this is where you would make any changes
it's also worth having a look at the
subnet associations with your ACL
so we have two subnets in our simply
learn VPC so we would expect to see both
of them associated with this network ACL
because it's the default
and there they are it's both our public
and our private subnets are associated
and you can also see up here on the on
the dashboard it says default so this is
telling us this is our default ACL
if you did want to create a new network
ACL you would click create network ACL
please give it a name it's just a new
ACL and then you would associate it with
your VPC so we would say simply learn
VPC
takes a few seconds
and there we are there we have our new
one now you can see this one says
default no because it obviously isn't
the default ACL for our simply learn VPC
and it has no subnets associated with it
so let's just delete that because we
don't need it but there you are there's
a very brief overview of network pcls
welcome to the Amazon VPC best practices
and costs where we're going to take a
look at the best practices and the costs
associated with the Amazon virtual
private cloud
always use public and private subnets
you should use private subnets to secure
resources that don't need to be
available to the internet such as
database services
to provide secure internet access to the
instances that reside in your private
subnets you should provide a Nat device
when using Nat devices you should use a
Nat Gateway over Nat instances because
there are managed service and require
less Administration effort
you should choose your cidr blocks
carefully
Amazon VPC can contain from 16 to 65
536 IP addresses so you should choose
your cidr block according to how many
instances you think you'll need
you should also create separate Amazon
vpcs for development staging test and
production or create one Amazon VPC with
separate subnets with a subnet each for
production development staging and test
you should understand the Amazon VPC
limits there are various limitations on
the VPC components for example you're
allowed five vpcs per region
200 subnets per VPC
200 route tables per VPC
500 security groups per VPC
50 in and outbound rules per VPC
however some of these rules can be
increased by raising a ticket with AWS
support
you should use security groups and
network ACLS to secure the traffic
coming in and out of your VPC Amazon
advises to use security groups for white
listing traffic and network ACLS for
blacklisting traffic
citizen recommends tiering your security
groups you should create different
security groups for different tiers of
your infrastructure architecture inside
VPC if you have web tears and dbters you
should create different security groups
for each of them creating toy security
groups will increase the infrastructure
security inside the Amazon VPC
so if you launch all your web servers in
the web server security group that means
it'll automatically all have HTTP and
https open conversely the database
Security Group will have SQL Server
ports already open
you should also standardize your
Security Group naming conventions
following a security group naming
convention allows Amazon VPC operation
and management for large-scale
deployments to become much easier
always span your Amazon VPC across
multiple subnets in multiple
availability zones inside a region this
helps in architecting high availability
inside your VPC
if you choose to create a hardware VPN
connection to your VPC using virtual
private Gateway you are charged for each
VPN connection hour that your VPN
connection is provisioned and available
each partial VPN connection hour
consumed is billed as a full hour
you'll also incur standard AWS data
transfer charges for all data
transferred via the VPN connection
if you choose to create a Nat Gateway in
your VPC you are charged for each Nat
Gateway hour that your net Gateway is
provisioned and available data
processing charges apply for each
gigabyte processed through the net
Gateway each partial Nat Gateway hour
consumed is billed as a full hour
this is the practice assignment for
designing a custom VPC where your create
a custom VPC using the concepts learned
in this lesson
using the concepts learned in this
lesson recreate the custom VPC as shown
in the demonstrations
the VPC name should be simply learned
VPC the cidr block should be
10.0.0.016 there should be two subnets
one public with a range of
10.0.1.0 and one private with a range of
10.0.2.0 and they should be placed in
separate availability zones
there should be one internet gateway and
one that Gateway and also one custom
route table for the public subnet
also create two security groups simply
learn web server Security Group and
simply learn DV server Security Group
so let's review the key takeaways from
this lesson
Amazon virtual private cloud or VPC
enables you to launch AWS resources into
a virtual Network that you've defined
this virtual Network closely resembles a
traditional Network that you'd operate
in your own data center but with the
benefits of using scalable
infrastructure of AWS
there are three types of IP address in
AWS
a private IP address this is an IP
address that's not reachable over the
internet and it's used for communication
between instances in the same network
a public IP address is reachable from
the internet which you can use for
communication between your instances and
the internet
and there's an elastic IP address this
is a static public persistent IP address
that persists after an instance restarts
whereas a public IP address is
associated after each restart
Amazon defines a setner as a range of IP
addresses in your VPC you can launch AWS
resources into a subnet that you select
and a subnet is always mapped to a
single availability Zone use a public
subnet for resources that must be
connected to the internet and a private
subnet for resources that won't be
connected to the internet
to allow your VPC the ability to connect
to the internet you need to attach an
internet gateway to it and you can only
attach one internet gateway per VPC
a root table determines where Network
traffic is directed it does this by
defining a set of rules every subnet has
to be associated with a root table and a
sudden that can only have an association
with one root table however multiple
subnets can be Associated to the same
root table
and you can use a Nat device to enable
instances in a private subnet to connect
to the Internet or other AWS services
but and that device will prevent the
internet from initiating connections
with instances inside your private
subnet
a security group acts as a virtual
firewall that controls the traffic for
one or more instances you add rules to
each security group that allow traffic
to or from its Associated instances
a network access control list or network
ACL is an optional layer of security for
your VPC that acts as a firewall for
controlling traffic in and out of one or
more of your subnets
today's session is on AWS stage maker
let's look into what we have in our
today's session
so what's in it for you we would be
covering what is AWS
why do we need AWS sagemaker what is AWS
sagemaker services
what are the benefits of using the AWS
sagemaker
machine learning with AWS sagemaker how
to train a model with AWS stagemaker how
to validate a model with AWS
and the companies that are using AWS
stagemaker along with that we will be
covering up one live demo on the AWS
platform
now let's understand what is AWS so what
is AWS it's an Amazon web services it's
a largest or most widely used public
Cloud platform
offered by Amazon it provides services
over the internet
AWS Services can be used to build
Monitor and deploy any type of
application in the cloud AWS also uses
the subscription pricing model that
means you only pay for whatever the
services you use for
now why do we need AWS stage maker let's
look into it so let's consider an
example of one of the company that is
proquest now before AWS stage maker the
proquest is a Global Information content
and technology company
that provides valuable content such as
ebooks newspapers Etc to the users
before AWS sagemaker the proquest
requirement was to have a better user
experience maximum relevant search
results now after AWS stage maker they
were able to achieve those results so
they achieved more appealing video user
experience they achieved more relevant
search results for the users now what do
we mean by AWS sagemaker why this
service is primarily used so Amazon
sagemaker is a cloud machine learning
platform that helps users in building
training tuning and deploying machine
learning models in a production ready
hosted environment
so it's kind of a machine learning
service which is already hosted on the
AWS platform now what are the benefits
of using AWS sagemaker the key benefits
of using aw sagemaker are it reduces
machine learning data cost so you can do
the cost optimization
while running this particular service on
the AWS all ml components are stored in
a particular place in a dashboard so
they can be managed together
highly scalable so it can be scalable on
you can scale this particular service on
the Fly
it trains the models quite faster
maintains the uptime so you can be
assured that your workloads will be
running all the time it will be
available all the time
High data security so security becomes a
major concern on the cloud platforms and
it ensures that you have the high data
security along with that you can do a
data transfer to different AWS services
like S3 bucket and all with the simple
data transfer techniques
now machine learning with AWS stage
maker let's look into it so machine
learning with AWS sagemaker is a
three-step function
so one is to build second is to test and
tune the model and third is to deploy
the model now with the build it provides
more than 15 widely used ml algorithms
for training purpose now to build a
model you can collect and prepare
training data or you can select from the
Amazon S3 bucket also choose and
optimize the required algorithm so some
of the algorithms that you can select
are k-means linear regressions logistic
regression sagemaker helps developers to
customize ml instances with the Jupiter
notebook interface in the test and tune
you have to set up and manage the
environment for training so you would
need some sample data to train the model
so train and tune a model
with the Amazon sagemaker sagemaker
implements hyper parameter tuning by
adding a suitable combination of
algorithm parameters also it divides the
training data and stores that in the
Amazon S3 S3 is a simple storage service
which is primarily used for storing the
objects and the data hence it is used
for storing and recovering data over the
internet and Below you can see that AWS
stage maker uses Amazon S3 to store data
as it's safe and secure also it divides
the training data and stores in Amazon
S3 where the training algorithm code is
stored in the ECR ECR stands for elastic
container registry which is primarily
used for containers and Dockers ECR
helps users to save Monitor and deploy
Docker and the containers later
sagemaker sets up a cluster for the
input data train set and stores it in
the Amazon S3 itself so this is done by
the sagemaker itself after that you need
to deploy it so suppose you want to
predict limited data at a time you use
Amazon sagemaker hosting services for
that okay but if you want to get
prediction for an entire data set prefer
using Amazon sagemaker batch transform
now the last step that is to deploy the
model
so once tuning is done models can be
deployed to sagemaker endpoints
and in the endpoint real-time prediction
is performed so you would have some data
which you would reserve and
validate your model whether it is
working correctly or not now evaluate
your model and determine whether you
have achieved your business goals now
the other aspect is how we can train a
model with AWS sagemaker
so this is basically a flow diagram
which shows you how to train a model
with the AWS stage maker and here we
have used couple of Services of an AWS
to get that done
so model training in AWS sagemaker is
done on machine learning compute
instances and here we can see there are
two machine learning compute instances
used as helper code and the training
code
along with that we are using two S3
buckets and the ECR for the container
registry
now let's look into what are the ways to
train the model as per the slides
So Below are the following requirements
to train a model so here in the diagram
you can see these are the following
requirements to train a model
the URL of an Amazon S3 bucket where the
training data is stored that is
mentioned
the computer sources on machine learning
compute instances so these are all your
machine learning compute instances
then the URL of an Amazon S3 bucket
where the output will be stored
and the path of AWS elastic container
registry where the code data is safe the
inference code image lies in the elastic
container registry now what are these
calls these are called as the training
jobs
now when a user trains a model in Amazon
sagemaker he she creates a training job
so we need to First create a training
job and then the input data is fetched
from the specified Amazon S3 bucket once
the training job is built Amazon
sagemaker launches the ml compute
instances so these compute instances
will be launched once the training job
is built then it trains the model with
the training code and the data set and
it shows the output and model articrafts
in the AWS S3 bucket so this is done
automatically now here the helper code
performs a task when the training code
fails the interference code which is in
the elastic container registry consists
of multiple linear sequence containers
that process the request for inference
on data the ec2 container registry is a
container registry that helps users to
say Monitor and deploy container images
whereas container images are the ready
applications
once the data is trained the output is
stored in the specified Amazon S3 bucket
so here you can see the output will be
stored here to prevent your algorithm
being deleted save the data in Amazon's
sagemaker critical system
which can process you on your ml compute
instances now how to validate a model
let's look into it so you can evaluate
your model
using offline or using the historical
data so first thing is that you can do
the offline testing to validate a model
you can do an online testing with the
live data so if you have a live data
coming or real-time streams coming you
can validate a model from there itself
you can validate using a holdout set and
also you can validate using the k-fold
validation now use historical data to
send requests to the model
through the jupyter notebook in Amazon
sagemaker for the evaluation online
testing with live data deploys multiple
models into the endpoints of Amazon
sagemaker and directs live traffic to
the model for validation validating
using a holdout set is part of the data
is set aside where which is called hold
outset so the part of the data is left
which is basically called as the holdout
set
this data is not used for the model
training so later when the model is
trained
with the remaining input data and
generalize the data based on what is
learned initially so whatever the data
which is left out will be used for
validating a model because we have not
used the data while training a model the
k-fold validation is the input data is
split into two parts one part is called
K
which is the validation data for testing
the model and the other part is K minus
1. which is used as a training data
now based on the input data the machine
learning model evaluates the final
output now
the companies that are using AWS stage
maker one is the ADP so you must be
knowing about ADB zalando Dow Jones
which is the stock market proquest
and the Intuit now let's look into the
demo that how we can actually run the
AWS stage maker so we'll use the r
algorithm and then package the algorithm
as a container for building training and
deploying a model
we are going to use the jupyter notebook
for that for model building for model
training for model deployment
and the code for the demo is in the
below link so you can see here that from
this link you can get the code for the
demo let's try to
do a demo on the AWS
now I would be using a link which is uh
provided by Amazon to build train and
deploy the machine learning model on the
sagemaker as you can see on my screen
and in this tutorial you would have some
steps where you can put those steps and
the code python codes into your AWS
sagemaker Jupiter lab
so in this tutorial you will learn how
to use Amazon sagemaker to build train
and deploy a machine learning model and
for that we will use the popular XT
boost ml algorithm for this exercise
so first of all what you need to do is
you have to go to the AWS console and
there you have to create a notebook
instance so in this tutorial you will be
creating a notebook instance you will
prepare the data train the model to
learn from the data deploy the model
evaluate your ml models performance and
once all those activities are done then
we'll see how we can actually remove all
the resources in order to prevent the
extra costing
now the first step is we have to enter
to the Amazon sagemaker console so here
you can see I'm already logged in into
the sagemaker console you can click on
the services
search for the sagemaker here
and here you get the Amazon sagemaker
service
now the next step is
that we have to create a notebook
instance so we will select the notebook
instance from the sagemaker service and
then after the notebook instance is
selected we will put a name to our
instance and we'll create a new IM role
for that
so let's wait for the sagemaker studio
to open
so here you can see the studio is open
and you just have to click on the
notebook instances
and here you have to create a notebook
instance so here you can see couple of
notebook instances have already been
created one of them is in service so
this is The Notebook instance that we
are going to use for creating the demo
model
I'll show you how you can create a
notebook instance you just have to click
on create notebook instance button and
put your notebook instance name so you
can put something like demo Dash
sagemaker 987 or we can put it as model
we'll go with notebook instance type as
default which is mlt2.media
and in the permission and encryptions
under the IM role we'll click on create
a new IM role
now why we are creating a new IM rule so
that we can allow the sagemaker to
access any S3 bucket that has been
created on our account
just click on create a role and here you
would see that the new IM role will be
created with the set of permissions then
rest of the things will keep it as
default and then you just have to click
on create a notebook instance
The Notebook instance creation takes
some time so you just have to wait for a
couple of minutes to get that in service
we already have one of the notebook
instance that has been created so we
will be using that to create a demo
now going back to the steps so these are
the steps that we have already performed
now once the notebook instance is
created then we have to prepare the data
so in this step we will be using the
sagemaker notebook instance to
pre-process the data that would require
to train the machine learning model
and for that we would be opening up the
Jupiter notebook and then we have to
select an environment a kernel
environment in the Jupiter notebook that
would be conda underscore python 3. so
let's follow these steps go back to the
sage maker click on the notebook
instances
select the running notebook instance and
here you would select the open Jupiter
lab
now here you would see that the
sagemaker would try to open up the
Jupiter Notepad
and we would be performing all our
inputs into that Jupiter notebook
and executing the results there itself
so just wait for the notebook to open
now here you can see the Jupiter lab
notebook has been open so I would be
selecting one of the notebook that has
been created
so this one so likewise you can create
your own notebook also how you can do
that
first of all let me select the kernel
environment so I would be selecting
Corner underscore Python 3 and just
click on select so how you can create
your own notebook just have to click on
file click on new and here you can
select the notebook just name your
notebook select the environment conda
underscore Python 3 to run this demo
so I have my notebook open so in the
tabs I would be putting up the python
codes and I would be executing those
codes to get the output directly
so the next step is
to prepare the data train the ml model
and deploy it we will need to import
some libraries and Define a few
environment variables in the jupyter
notebook environment so I would be
copying this code
which you can see that would try to
import numpy pandas these are all
required to run the python
syntax so just
copy this code
and paste it into your
notebook
right so once you do that execute your
code
and here you can see that you get the
output which is
that it has imported all the necessary
libraries that have been defined in the
code
now the next step is we would create an
S3 bucket
into the S3 service and for that you
have to copy this python code just that
you have to edit it so you have to
specify this bucket name that you want
to get created
so here I would provide the bucket name
which should be unique
should not overlap
so something like Sage maker
Dash
demo
is the name that I have selected for the
bucket and now you have to execute that
code
it says that the S3 bucket has been
created successfully with the name
sagemaker Dash demo 9876 so this is
something which you can verify so you
can go to the S3 service and there you
can verify whether the bucket has been
created or not now the next task is that
we need to download the data
to the AWS sagemaker instance and load
it into the data frame and for that we
have to follow this URL so from this URL
which is buildtrain deploy machine
learning model would have a data in the
form of bank underscore clean.csv and
this will be deployed onto our sagemaker
instance we'll copy this code
and paste it here
and execute the code
so change that it has successfully
downloaded bank underscoreclean.csv
which is which has the data inside it
and that has to be loaded into the
sagemaker data frame successfully
now we have a data to build and train
our machine learning model
so what we are going to do we are going
to shuffle the data and we are going to
split it one into the training data set
and the other one into test data set
so for the training data set we are
going to use 70 of the customers that
are listed in the CSV file and 30 of the
customers in the CSV file data will be
using it as a test data to train the
model
so we'll copy the following code into a
new code cell and then we are going to
run that code cell
so I'll just copy it
for training the data so that we can
segregate the data model 70 for building
the model and 30 for
testing the data
so click on
run the execution and here you can see
that we got the output successfully
now
we have to train the model from the data
so how we are going to train that model
and for that we will use sagemaker
pre-built xgboost model which is an
algorithm
so you will need to reformat the header
and First Column of the training data
and load the data from the S3 bucket so
what I'll do is I'll copy
this syntax
and paste it
in the node cell
so it has the train data it would train
the model
click on run execution
now it is changing the S3 input class
which will be renamed to training input
because now we are training the model
with the training data
so we just have to wait for some time
till it gets executed completely
now the next thing is that we need to
set up the amazon sagemaker session to
create an instance of the XT boost model
so here we are going to create this
sagemaker session say we are going to
create an instance of the XT boost model
which is an estimator
so just copy that copy that code
and paste it here
executed
and here you can see that it will start
it has basically changed the parameter
image name to the image underscore URI
in the sagemaker python SDK V2
now we'll follow the next step that is
with the data loaded in the XT boost
estimator we'll set up drain the model
using gradient optimization
and we'll copy the following code and
that would actually start the training
of the model
so copy this code
and this would actually
start training the model using our input
data that we have reserved 70 of the
data that we have reserved for training
the model so just copy that
again initiate the execution and it will
start the training job
now we'll deploy the model and for that
I would copy the deploy code put that in
the cell
and execute it
so
it says parameter image will be renamed
to image URI and using already existing
models so XD boost was deployed already
if you have not done that if you're
doing it the first time so it will
initiate another XT boost instead so
where you can find your XT boost and
points created you just have to scroll
down and here under the inference click
on the endpoints and you should find the
XT boost endpoints defined here
so here you can see that today I have
created one XD boost
endpoint and that is now in process of
creating so just refresh it
so it is still created it is going to
take some time to get that in service
now our endpoint is in service state so
now we can use it so going forward with
the next steps we will try to predict
whether the customer in the test data
enroll for the bank product or not for
that we are going to copy this code put
that in the Jupiter cell function
and execute it
so here it gives you the output that it
has actually evaluated and the same
output we got in the screenshot of the
demo as well
now we are going to evaluate the model
performance so what we are going to do
we are going to get the prediction done
so based on the prediction we can
conclude that you predicted a customer
that will involve for a certificate of
deposit accurately for 90 of the
customers in the test data with the
Precision of 65 percent for enrolled and
90 which are which haven't enrolled for
it so for that we are going to copy this
code
and execute it here in the cell
so if it is predicted correctly that
means our model is working absolutely
fine so here you can say the overall
classification rate is 89.5 percent and
there is the accurate
prediction that has been made by the
model and that's what the output we can
see here
in the screenshot of a model so that
means our model is absolutely working
fine it has been built deployed and
trained correctly now the next thing is
that once you are done with that you
terminate your resources and for that
you just have to copy
uh this code and put that in the cell
function so that the additional
resources and the endpoints and the
buckets that have been created by the
Jupiter notepad should be uh terminated
so that you would not be incurred with
the extra costing so just execute it and
here you would see that it is prior to
it would try to terminate all the
additional resources that we have
created from the Jupiter notebook
today's tutorial is on AWS cloudfront
let's look into what we have today in
the cloud front
so what's in it for you we would be
covering up the concept of what is AWS
what was earlier uh before AWS Cloud
front after AWS cloudfront what were the
services that were introduced how it
benefited what do we mean by AWS
cloudfront benefits of the using AWS
cloudfront and how AWS cloudfront
actually is known as a Content delivery
service the name of the companies that
are using AWS cloudfront and we would be
covering up on live demo
now AWS is the Amazon web services it's
a cloud service provider that basically
offers a multiple Services variety of
services such as compute power database
storage networking and other resources
so that you can create your Solutions on
the cloud and help the business grow now
with AWS you only pay for whatever the
services you use so for example if you
are using a service for a couple of
hours then you pay for only that many
hours that you have use that service
before AWS cloudfront so there is an
example that we are going to talk and
that is you must be aware of an
application called Spotify so when you
used to access Spotify and when you
click on it it kept on loading and at
the end you used to get the error and
the error was that the connection failed
and why you received that error because
of a latency issue probably a network
error right so how you can solve these
kind of a latency issues and that is
also going to these kind of an issues
are also going to impact the performance
of an application
so with the introduction of AWS cloud
from this problem of loading the
application got result so after AWS
Cloud front with the help of AWS
cloudfront Spotify gives the facility of
updating new features access to million
songs that you can access instantly
so with the use of AWS cloudfront or the
latency issues were solved and
successfully you can basically access
your application now
what we mean by AWS cloudfront so AWS
cloudfront is a globally distributed
Network that is offered by AWS Amazon
web services which securely delivers
content to the end users across any
geography with a higher transfer speed
and an improve or a low latency now what
are the benefits of AWS cloudfront there
are multiple benefits one is the cost
effective so it helps you to do the cost
optimization when you use the cloud
front it is time saving so it is
implemented easily and also lot of
issues with respect to accessing the
application with respect to latency and
all can be resolved
content privacy so the content is placed
to the end users and also to the
cloudfront servers in a secured manner
in a secured way it is highly
programmable and you can make the
changes amend the changes on the Fly
and you can Target any location any
geography across the globe along with
that it helps you to get the content
delivered quickly now how AWS cloudfront
delivers the content let's look into the
architecture
so this is a flow and the flow is with
respect to how the user is going to get
a content from the cloud front now the
client first access a website by typing
a URL on the browser and in the step one
it acts tries to access the application
then the client requests when the
website is open the client request for
an object to download such as for
example a particular file now at that
time the DNS routes user request to
download that file to AWS cloudfront
the AWS Cloud front connects to the
nearest Edge locations Edge locations
are basically the servers where it
caches
the files documents and the web codes
AWS cloudfront connects to its nearest
Edge location in order to serve the user
the request
at Edge location
AWS cloudfront looks for its requested
cache file once the file is found let's
say if the file is available in the
cache of an edge location AWS cloudfront
then sends the file to the user
otherwise if the file is not found in
the cache memory of an edge location
AWS cloudfront compares the requirement
with the specification and share it with
a respected server that means a web
server or a server where the file is
actually available the server the web
server responds to the edge location by
sending the file back to the cloud front
edge location
and then as soon as the AWS cloudfront
receives the file it shares with the
client also adds the file to the cache
of an edge location for a future
reference this is how the flow of a
cloud front is now
the name of the companies that are using
the AWS cloudfront
so one of them is jio 7 app it is which
is a very popular app so it uses Amazon
cloudfront to deliver 15 petabytes of
audio and video to its subscribers
globally which is a huge data Sky News
it uses the service in order to unify
the content for faster distribution to
scrub subscribers
or the discovery Communications uh also
uses the cloud front it uses the service
for delivering API static asset and also
the dynamic content
and then the TV1 EU streaming Europe is
basically also uses uh the cloudfront
service that helps in improving latency
and performance
that results in fastest delivery of
content
now let's look into the demo how to use
cloudfront to serve private S3 bucket as
a website
now I'm going to
run a cloudfront distribution demo on
the AWS console and we'll basically try
to deliver the content from a private S3
bucket and then map that with the domain
name using the Route 53 service
so what we need for this demo we would
need a domain URL we would need a Route
53 service
we would need
Cloud front we have to create a cloud
front distribution and that will be
linked with our S3 bucket the private S3
bucket right and in the S3 bucket we
would have one HTML file the index.html
file
so let's uh move into AWS console
so right now I have opened up the
cloudfront distribution
and here you can see that couple of
distributions have already been created
so what I'm going to do I'm going to
create a distribution
now there are two types of delivery
method for your content one is the web
distribution and the other one is rtmp
rtmp stands for Real Time audio or video
distribution it's basically used for
distribution of a media content or a
media file which are available in the S3
bucket
here we are going to select a web
distribution because primarily we will
be using files which uses protocols HTTP
or the https
so you have to click on get started and
in the origin domain name you have to
specify the bucket where your code is
available
so I have a bucket already created here
you can see and what you need to do is
you have to create a bucket with a URL
name or the domain name which you would
be mapping with the Route 53 service
so this is a bucket that has already
been created let me show you in a new
tab
so here you have to go to the storage
under the storage you have to select the
S3 bucket
let's open the link in the new tab and
let's look into how we can create the S3
buckets
now here are a couple of buckets already
created I have created one bucket with a
domain name that I'm going to use and
map it with the root 53 service
so that is basically mapped to a region
which is in Ohio
and if you open up this bucket
here you will find an HTML web page the
index.html has been already added
right so similarly you have to create a
bucket with a domain and an index.html
page needs to be uploaded there
now again we'll go to the cloud front we
will try to create a distribution
just have to click on create
distribution
select a web delivery method
select An Origin domain which is
sunshinelearning.in
and origin path you don't have to
specify origin ID is this one so
basically when you define An Origin
domain name automatically the origin ID
appears
you can customize this origin ID as per
your requirement also
so rest of the things primarily we keep
it as a default settings only until and
unless if we require some customized
settings to be done
so let's say if you have to change the
cache Behavior settings you can do that
otherwise we'll keep it as default
now in the distribution setting you can
either select use all Edge locations for
the best performance so what does AWS
basically do here it uses all the edge
locations which are associated with AWS
across the globe
otherwise you can specify based on the
regions also right apart from that if
you want to enable firewalls or the
access control list you can specify here
and then
what you need to do is in the default
root object here you have to specify
your index.html
pitch which is in the S3 bucket
the distribution state has to be enabled
and if you want to use IPv6 as well you
need to enable it
click on create distribution
now you you can see here a distribution
has been created it's in progress and it
is enabled
and it takes around 15 to 20 minutes to
get the distribution completed the
reason is that the web codes the web
pages will be
distributed across all the edge
locations across the globe so hence it
takes time to get that done right now
let's move on to Route 53 service
and let's create the hosted zones
so we'll type Route 53 here scalable DNS
and domain name registration
and what we are going to do here is
we are going to map our URL the domains
pointed to
the name servers that will be provided
by the Route 53 so we have to create a
hosted Zone
let's wait for it
so now the root 53 dashboard is open and
you can see one hosted zone is already
created so just click on the hosted
zones
and in order to point the traffic from
the external domains towards the AWS you
have to first point the domain's traffic
to the
uh hosted Zone in the route 53.
so
I'll click on create hosted Zone but
before that I will first delete the
existing one
and then I'll create another record
Another hosted Zone
right
put your domain name which I put as
sunshinelearning.in
and it is acting as a public hosted Zone
rest of the things will be default click
on create hosted Zone
now it gives you phone name servers and
these fourname servers has to be updated
in the domain so you have to update
these name servers in a platform from
where you have purchased the domain
right so this is half of the work done
then what you need to do is you have to
go and create records
now in the records you can select a
routing policy so right now what we are
targeting we are targeting basically
that the traffic from the domain should
be pointed directly towards the cloud
front distribution hence we are going
with a simple routing right now
click on next
here you have to specify the record set
so we are going to create the records
just click on the file simple record
put here as World Wide Web
and you have to select an endpoint so
endpoint we are selecting for the cloud
front distribution so we have to specify
Alias for the cloud front distribution
now here we are going to put the
cloudfront distribution URL and then we
are going to define the simple report
set
so what we need is we need a cloudfront
distribution URL which you can find it
uh from the cloudfront service itself
and you can find the domain name here
itself
you just have to copy that
and then
paste it here in the distribution
and then just click on Define simple
records again click on create records
and here you can see
the record set has been updated now this
domain is basically pointed towards
these name servers which are further
pointed towards the cloudfront
distribution
right now the only thing which is left
is that
within the domain from wherever you have
purchased the domain you should update
these phonem servers and then you can
see the live traffic coming on this
domain will have an output from the
cloudfront distribution today's topic is
on AWS Auto scaling so this is Akil I
would be taking up a tutorial on the
order scaling let's begin with our
tutorial and let's look into what we
have in today's session
so I would be covering up why we require
AWS Auto scaling what is AWS Auto
scaling
what are the benefits of using the
scaling service
how this Auto scaling works the
different scaling plans we have
what is the difference between the
snapshot and the Ami
what is the load balancer and how many
types of load balancers we have and
along with that I would be covering up a
real life demo on the AWS
let's begin with why we require AWS
order scaling
now before AWS Cloud scaling there was a
question in the mind of Enterprises that
they were spending a lot of money on the
purchase of the infrastructure if they
have to set up some kind of a solution
so they have to purchase an
infrastructure and a one-time cost was
required
so that was a burden for them in terms
of procuring a server Hardware software
and then having a team of experts to
manage all those infrastructure
so they used to think that no longer
they require these resources if there
was a cost efficient solution for their
project that was the project manager
used to think
now after the AWS Cloud scaling that was
introduced automatically the auto
scaling maintains the application
performance based on the user
requirements at the lowest possible
price
so what does the auto scaling does is
that whenever there is a scalability
require it manages it automatically
and hence the cost optimization became
possible
now what is AWS Auto scaling let's look
into deep so AWS Auto scaling is a
service that helps users to monitor
their applications and the servers and
automatically adjust the capacity of
their infrastructure to maintain the
steadiness so they can increase the
capacity they can even decrease the
capacity also for the cost optimization
and also predictable performance at the
lowest possible cost
now what are the benefits of Auto
scaling it gave the better fault
tolerance applications you can get the
servers created and you can have a clone
copy of the servers so that you don't
have to deploy the applications again
and again better cost management because
the scalability is decided by the AWS
automatically based on some threshold
parameters
it was a reliable service and whenever
the scaling is created or initiated you
can get the notifications onto your mail
IDs or to your cell phones
scalability as I mentioned is always
there in the auto scaling it can scale
up it can scale down as well
and it has the flexibility the
flexibility in terms of whenever you
want to schedule it if you want to stop
it if you want to keep the size of the
servers at a fixed number you can always
make the changes on the Fly
and the better availability
now
with the use of the auto scaling we come
around with the terminology called
snapshot and the Ami let's look into the
difference between the snapshots and the
Emi
uh snapshots versus Ami so in a company
there was one of the employee that was
facing an issue with launching the
virtual machines
so he asked his colleague a question is
it possible to launch multiple virtual
machines with a minimum amount of time
because it takes a lot of time in terms
of creating the virtual machines
the other colleague said that yes it is
possible to launch multiple ec2 instance
and that can be done at a lesser time
and with the same configuration
and this can be done either you use a
snapshot or the Ami or the AWS
then the colleague said that what are
the differences between the snapshot and
Airline
let's look into the difference now the
snapshots basically kind of a backup of
a single ABS volume
which is just like a virtual hard drive
that is attached to the ec2 instance
whereas the Ami it is basically used as
a backup of an ec2 instance only
the snapshots opts for this when the
instance contain multiple static EVS
when you opt for the snapshot whenever
the instance contains multiple Statics
EVS volumes
Ami this is widely used to replace the
failed ec2 instance
in the snapshots here you pay only for
the storage of the modified data
whereas with the A9 you pay only for the
storage that you use
the snapshots are non-bootable images on
ABS volume
whereas Ami are bootable images on the
ec2 instance
however creating an Ami image will also
create the EVS snapshots
now how does AWS Auto scaling work let's
look into it
so for the AWS Auto scaling to work you
have to configure single unified scaling
policy for application resource
and this scaling policy with that you
can explore the applications also
and then select the service you want to
scale also for the optimization select
do you want to optimize the cost or do
you want to optimize the performance
and then keep track of scaling by
monitoring or getting the notifications
now what are the different scaling plans
we have so in the auto scaling a scaling
plan basically helps a user to configure
a set of instructions for scaling based
on the particular software requirement
the scaling strategy basically guides
the service of AWS Auto screening on how
to optimize resources in a particular
application so it's basically a kind of
uh the parameters that you set it up so
that how the resource optimization can
be achieved in the auto scaling
with the scaling strategies users can
create their own strategy based on their
required metrics and thresholds and this
can be changed on the fly as well
what are the two types of scaling
policies we have so there are basically
Dynamic scaling and the predictive
scaling
uh now what is dynamic scaling it
basically guides the service of AWS Auto
scaling on how to optimize the resources
and it is helpful in optimizing
resources for availability and
particular price
now with scaling strategies users can
create their plan based on the required
metrics and thresholds so if a metric
can be like let's say a networking
Network out or it can be a CPU
utilization memory utilization likewise
now in the predictive scaling its
objective is to predict future workload
based on daily and weekly Trends and
regular forecast future network traffic
so it is kind of a forecast that happens
based on the previous past experiences
it uses a machine learning technique for
analyzing that Network graphic and this
scaling is like how weather forecast
works right
it provides schedule scaling actions to
ensure the resource capacity is
available for application requirement
now with the auto scaling you would need
the load balancers also because if there
are multiple instances that are created
then you would need a load balancer to
distribute the load through those
instances so let's understand what do we
mean by a load balancer a load balancer
basically acts as a reverse proxy and it
is responsible for Distributing the
network or the application traffic
across multiple servers
with the help of a load balancer you can
achieve a reliability you can achieve a
fault tolerance of an application that
is basically it increases the fault
tolerance and the reliability
so for example when there is a high
Network traffic that is coming to your
application and if that much traffic
comes to your application to the
instances your instances May crash
so how you can avoid that situation so
you need to manage the network traffic
that is coming to your instances and
that can be done with the load balancer
so thanks to the AWS load balancers
which helps in distributing Network
traffic across backend servers in a way
that it increases performance of an
application
here in the image you can see the
traffic coming from a different
resources Landing onto the ec2 instance
and the load balancer is actually
Distributing that traffic to all the
three instances hence managing the
network traffic quite properly
now what are the types of load balancers
we have there are three types of load
balancers on the AWS one is the classic
load balancer second is the application
load balancer and the third one is the
network load balancer
let's look into what we have in the
classical manager
so the classic load balancer is the most
basic form of load balancing and we call
it as a primitive load balancer also and
it is widely used for the ec2 instances
it is based on the IP address and the
TCP port and it routes Network traffic
between end users as well as in between
the backend servers
and it does not support host based
routing and it results in low efficiency
of resources
let's look into what we have in the
application load balancer
this is one of the advanced forms of
load balancing it performs a task on the
application Level in the OSI model
it is used when there are HTTP and https
traffic routing is required
and also it supports the host based and
Pathways routing and performs well with
the micro services or the backend
applications
the network load balancer performs the
task at layer 4 of the connection level
in The OSI model
the prime role of the network load
balancer is to Route the TCP traffic
and it can manage a massive amount of
traffic and is also suitable to manage
the low latencies
let's look into the demo and see how
practically we can
create the auto scale
hi guys let's look into the demo for how
we can create an auto Skilling on the
AWS console
so right now I'm logged into the AWS
console and I am in the Mumbai region
what you need to do is you have to go to
the compute section and under that click
on the easy to service
let's wait for the ec2 servers to come
now just scroll down
and under the load balancing there is an
option called Auto scaling so there
first you have to create a launch
configuration and then after that you
have to create the auto scaling groups
so click on launch configuration
and then you have to click on create
launch configurations
so click on create launch configuration
now this launch configuration is
basically this set of parameters that
you define while launching an auto
scaling so that this uniformity is
maintained with all the instances
so that includes let's say if you select
a Windows Os or a Linux OS that
particular type of an operating system
will be implemented in all the instances
that will be part of an auto scale
so there are certain set of parameters
that we have to specify during the
launch configuration so that we can have
a uniformity in terms of launching the
servers so here I would select an Amazon
Linux Ami
and then I would select the type of a
server which will be t2.micro click on
configure details put the name to the
launch configuration let's say we put it
as a demo
and the rest of the things we'll keep it
default
click on add storage since it's a Linux
Ami we can go with the 8GB storage that
should be fine click on configure
Security Group
let's create a new Security Group which
has the SSH Port open and that is open
for anywhere which is basically source
ipv4 and IPv6 IPS any IP would be able
to access that
click on review just review your launch
configuration if you want to make
changes you can do that otherwise click
on create a launch location
uh you would need the key pair and this
key pair will be a unique key pair which
will be used with all the instances that
are part of the auto scaling group so we
can select an existing key pair if you
have that otherwise you can create a new
key pair so I have an existing key here
I'll go with that acknowledge it and
click on create launch condition
now we have successfully launched the
configuration of an auto scaling the
next thing is to create an auto scaling
group so click on create an auto scaling
group using this launch configuration
put a group name let's say we put
something like test
and the group size to start with it says
one instance so that means at least a
single instance will always be running
and it will be initiated and running 24
cross 7 till the auto scaling is
available you can increase the size of
the minimum base instances Also let's
say you can change it to 2 also so you
would get at least two servers running
all the time
so we'll go with the one instance uh the
network would be the VPC default and uh
in the VPC that particular region we can
select the availability zones so let's
say if I select availability Zone 1A and
then availability is on 1B
so how the instances will be launched so
one instance will be launched in money
the other one in b1b the third one in
the 1A fourth one and the 1B likewise it
will be equally spreaded among the
availability zones
next part is to configure the sailing
policies so click on it if you want to
keep this group at its initial size
let's say if you want to go with only a
single instance or two instances and you
don't want the scaling to progress you
can put it keep this group at its
initial size so this is basically a way
to Halt the scaling
but we'll use the scaling policies to
adjust the capacity of this group so
click on it and we would scale between
let's say minimum one instance that we
have and we'll scale it between one two
four instances
and
what condition on what basis these
instances will be scaled up or scaled
out would be defined in the scale group
size
so the scaling policies you can
Implement based on a scale group size or
using the simple scaling policies using
the steps
so in the scale group size you have a
certain metrics you can use average CPU
utilization you can define a metric
related to average networking average
Network out or the load balancer request
counts per Target and if you create the
simple scaling policies using steps then
you need to create the alarms and there
you can get some more metrics that you
can add up as a parameter for the auto
scaling
let's go over the scaling group size
let's go with the metric type as average
CPU utilization and the target value
here you have to specify what would be
the threshold that when the instance CP
utilization is crossed then a new
instance should be initiated
so you can put a reasonable threshold
for that let's say we put something like
85 percent and whenever the instance CP
utilization is crossed 85 threshold you
will see that there will be a new
instance created
let's go to the next configure
notifications
and here you can add notifications so
let's say if there is a new instance
that is initiated and you want to
basically be notified so you can get
notifications over your email IDs or you
can get it on the cell phones so for
that for adding the notification you
would need the SNS service that is
called as a simple notification service
and you have to create a topic there you
have to subscribe for the topic using
your email ID and then you should get
the notifications
uh click on configure tags the tags are
not mandatory you can basically
put attack let's say if you want to
identify the instance for the purpose it
was created otherwise you can leave it
blank also click on review
and review your scaling policies
notification tags as well as the scaling
group details
click on create auto scaling group and
here you go your scaling has been
launched click on close
and you should get at least a single
instance initiated automatically by the
auto scaling
so let's wait for the details to appear
so here you can see
on launch configuration name demo
Auto scaling group name test
minimum instance we want one the maximum
instances we want four
we have selected two availability zones
AP South one AP South 1B
and uh
the instance one has been initiated and
if you want to verify where exactly this
instance has been initiated just click
on the instances here and here you will
see that our single instance has been
initiated that is in service and that
has been initiated in AP South one way
now once the threshold of this instance
crosses 85 percent that is what we have
defined in the scaling policies
then you should see that another
instance will be initiated
so likewise this is basically I have
created steps to
initiate a scaling policy that needs to
increase the number of servers whenever
the threshold crosses likewise here
itself you can add another policy to
scale down
the resources in case if the CPU
utilization goes to a normal value today
we are going to discuss about Amazon
redshift which is one of the data
warehouse service on the AWS so let's
begin with Amazon redshift and let's see
what we have for today's session so
what's in it for you today we'll see
what is AWS why we require Amazon
redshift what do we mean by Amazon
redshift the advantages of Amazon
redshift the architecture of Amazon
redshift some of the additional Concepts
associated with the redshift and the
companies that are using the Amazon
redshift and finally we'll cover up a
one demo which will show you the
Practical example that how you can
actually use the redshift service now
what is AWS as we know that AWS stands
for Amazon web service it's one of the
largest cloud providers in the market
and it's basically a secure cloud
service platform provided from the
Amazon also on the AWS you can create
and deploy the applications using the
AWS service along with that you can
access the services provided by the AWS
over the public network that is over the
Internet they are accessible plus you
pay only whatever the service you use
for now let's understand why we require
Amazon redshift so earlier before Amazon
redshift what used to happen that the
people used to or the developers used to
fetch the data from the data warehouse
so data warehouse is basically a
terminology which is basically
represents the collection of the data so
a repository where the data is stored is
generally called as a data warehouse now
fetching data from the data warehouse
was a complicated task because might be
a possibility that the developer is
located at a different geography and the
data data warehouses at a different
location and probably there is not that
much network connectivity or some
networking challenges internet
connectivity challenges security
challenges might be and a lot of
Maintenance was required uh to manage
the data warehouses so what are the con
of the traditional data warehouse
Services it was time consuming to
download or get the data from the data
warehouse maintenance cost was high and
there was the possibility of loss of
information in between the downloading
of the data and the data rigidity was an
issue now how these problems could
overcome and this was basically solved
with the introduction of Amazon redshift
over the cloud platform now we say that
Amazon redshift has solved traditional
data warehouse problems that the
developers were facing but how what is
Amazon redshift actually is so what is
Amazon redshift it is one of the
services over the AWS Amazon web
services which is called as a data
warehouse service so Amazon redshift is
a cloud-based service or a data
warehouse service that is primarily used
for collecting and storing the large
chunk of data so it also helps you to
get or extract the data analyze the data
using some of the bi tools so business
intelligence tools you can can use and
get the data from the redshift and
process that and hence it simplifies the
process of handling the large-scale data
sets so this is the symbol for the
Amazon redshift over the AWS now let's
discuss about one of the use case so DNA
is basically a telecommunication company
and they were facing an issue with
managing their website and also the
Amazon S3 data which led down to slow
process of their applications now how
could they overcome this problem let's
see that so they overcome this issue by
using the Amazon redshift and all the
company noticed that there was a 52
increase in the application performance
now did you know that Amazon redshift is
basically cost less to operate than any
other cloud data warehouse service
available on the cloud computing
platforms and also the performance of an
Amazon redshift is the fastest data
warehouse we can say that that is
available as of now so in both cases one
is that it saves the cost as compared to
the traditional data warehouses and also
the performance of this redshift service
or a data warehouse service the fastest
available on the cloud platforms and
more than 15 000 customers primarily
presently they are using the Amazon
redshift service now let's understand
some of the advantages of Amazon
redshift first of all as we saw that it
is one of the fastest available data
warehouse service so it has the high
performance second is it is a low cost
service so you can have a large scale of
data warehouse or a databases combined
in a data warehouse at a very low cost
so whatever you use you pay for that
only scalability now in case if you
wanted to increase the nodes of the
databases in your redshift you can
actually increase that based on your
requirement and that is on the fly so
you don't have to wait for the
procurement of any kind of a hardware or
the infrastructure it is whenever you
require you can scale up or scale down
the resources so the scalability is
again one of the advantage of the Amazon
redshare availability since it's
available across multiple availability
zones so it makes this service as a
highly available service security so
whenever you create whenever you access
redshift you create a clusters in the
redshift and the Clusters are created in
the you can define a specific virtual
private Cloud for your cluster and you
can create your own security groups and
attach it to your cluster so you can
design the security parameters based on
your requirement and you can get your
data warehouse or the data items in a
secured Place flexibility and you can
remove the Clusters you can create under
clusters if you are deleting a cluster
you can take a snapshot of it and you
can move those snapshots to different
regions so that much flexibility is
available on the AWS for the service and
the other Advantage is that it is
basically a very simple way to do a
database migration so if you're planning
that you wanted to migrate your
databases from the traditional data
center over the cloud on the redshift it
is basically a very simple to do a
database migration you can have some of
the inbuilt tools available on the AWS
access you can connect them with your
traditional Data Center and get that
data migrated directly to the redshift
now let's understand the architecture of
the Amazon redshift so architecture of
an Amazon redshift is basically it
combines of a cluster and that we call
it as a data warehouse cluster in this
picture you can see that this is a data
warehouse cluster and this is a
representation of a Amazon redshift so
it has some of the compute nodes which
does the data processing and a leader
node which gives the instructions to
these compute nodes and also the leader
node basically manages the client
applications that require the data from
the redshift so let's understand about
the components of the redshift the
client application of Amazon redshift
basically interact with the leader node
using jdbc or the odbc now what is jdbc
it's a Java database connectivity and
the odbc stands for open database
connectivity the Amazon redshift service
using a jdbc connector can monitor the
connections from the other client
applications so the leader node can
actually have a check on the client
applications using the jdbc connections
whereas the odbc allows a leader node to
have a direct interaction or to have a
live interaction with the Amazon
redshift so odbc allows a user to
interact with live data of Amazon
redshift so it has a direct connectivity
direct access of the applications as
well as the leader node can get the
information from the compute nodes now
what are these compute nodes these are
basically kind of a databases which does
the processing so Amazon redshift has a
set of computing resources which we call
it as a nodes and the nodes when they
are combined together they are called it
as a clusters now a cluster a set of
computing resources which are called as
nodes and this gathers into a group
which we call it as a data warehouse
cluster so you can have a compute node
starting from one to n number of nodes
and that's why we call that the redshift
is a scalable service because we can
scale up the compute nodes whenever we
require now the data warehouse cluster
or the each cluster has one or more
databases in the form of a nodes now
what is the leader node this node
basically manages the interaction
between the client application and the
compute node so it acts as a bridge
compute nodes also it analyzes and
develops designs in order to carry out
any kind of a database operations so
leader node basically sends out the
instructions to the compute nodes
basically perform or execute that
instruction and give that output to the
leader node so that is what we are going
to see in the next slide that the leader
node runs the program and assign the
code to individual compute nodes and the
compute nodes execute the program and
share the result back to the leader node
for the final aggregation and then it is
delivered to the client application for
analytics or whatever the client
application is created for so compute
nodes are basically categorized into
slices and each node slice is allotted
with specific memory space or you can
say a storage space where the data is
processed these node slices Works in
parallel in order to finish their work
and hence when we talk about a redshift
as a fast a faster processing capability
as compared to other data warehouses or
traditional data warehouses this is
because that these node slices work in a
parallel operation that makes it more
faster now the additional concept
associated with Amazon redshift is there
are two additional Concepts associated
with the Redshirt one is called as the
column storage and the other one is
called as the compression let's see what
is the column storage as the name
suggests column storage is basically
kind of a data storage in the form of a
column so that whenever we run a query
it becomes easier to pull out the data
from The Columns so column storage is an
essential factor in optimizing query
performance and resulting in quicker
output so one of the examples are
mentioned here so below example show how
database tables store record into disk
block by row so here you can see that if
we wanted to pull out some kind of an
information based on the city address
age we can basically create a filter and
from there we can put out the details
that we require and that is going to
fetch out the details based on the
column storage so that makes data more
structured more streamlined and it
becomes very easier to run a query and
get that output now the compression is
basically to save the column storage we
can use a compression as an attribute so
compression is a column level operation
which decreases the storage requirement
and hence it improves the query
performance and this is one of the
syntax for the column compression now
the companies that are using Amazon
redshift one is Lya the other one is
Equinox the third one is the Pfizer
which is one of the famous
Pharmaceuticals company McDonald's one
of the burger chains across the globe
and Philips it's an electronic company
so these are one of the biggest
companies that are basically relying on
the they are putting their data on the
redshift data warehouse service now in
another video we'll see the demo for
using the Amazon redshift let's look
into the Amazon redshift demo so these
are the steps that we need to follow for
creating the Amazon redshift cluster and
in this demo what we'll be doing is that
we'll be creating an IM role for the
redshift so that the redshift can call
the services and specifically we'll be
using the S3 service so the role that we
will be creating will be giving the
permission to redshift to have an access
of an S3 in the read-only format so in
the step one what we require we'll check
the prerequisites and what you need to
have is the AWS credentials if you don't
have that you need to create your own
credentials and you can use your credit
and the debit card and then in the Step
2 we'll proceed with the IM role for the
Amazon redshift once the rule is created
we'll launch a sample Amazon redshift
cluster mentioned in the step 3 and then
we'll assign a VPC security groups to
our cluster now you can create it in the
default PC also you can create a default
security groups also otherwise you can
customize the security groups based on
your requirement now to connect to the
sample cluster you need to run the
queries and you can connect to your
cluster and run queries on the AWS
Management console query editor which
you will find it in the redshift only or
if you use the query editor you don't
have to download and set up a SQL client
application separately and in the step 6
what you can do is you can copy the data
from the S3 and upload that in the
redshift because the redshift would have
an access a read-only access for the S3
as that will be created in the IM role
so let's see how we can actually use the
redshift on the AWS so I am already
logged in into my account I am in North
Virginia region I'll search for redshift
service and here I find Amazon redshift
so just click on it
let's wait for the redshift to come now
this is a redshift dashboard and from
here itself you have to run the cluster
so to launch a cluster you just have to
click on this launch cluster and once
the cluster is created and if you wanted
to run queries you can open query editor
or you can basically create queries and
access the data from the redshift so
that's what it was mentioned in the
steps also that you don't require a
separate SQL client application to get
the queries run on the data warehouse
now before creating a cluster we need to
create a role so what we'll do is we'll
click on the services and we'll move to
IM role section so IM rule I can find
here under the security identity and
compliance so just click on the identity
access management and then click on
create roles so let's wait for IM page
to open so here in the IM dashboard you
just have to click on the rules I
already have the role created so what
I'll do is I'll delete this role and
I'll create it separately so just click
on a create role and under the AWS
Services you have to select for the
redshift because now the the redshift
will be calling the other services and
that's why we are creating the role now
which other services that the redshift
will be having an access of S3 why
because we'll be putting up the data on
the S3 and that is something which needs
to be uploaded on the redshift so we'll
just search for the redshift service and
we can find it here so just click on it
and then click on redshift customizable
in the use case now click on next
permissions and here in the permissions
give the access to this role assign the
permissions to this role in the form of
an S3 read-only access so you can search
here for the S3 Also let's wait for the
policies to come in here it is let's
type S3 and here we can find Amazon S3
read-only access so just click on it and
assign the permissions to this role tags
you can leave them blank click on next
review put a name to your role let's put
my redshift role and click on a create
role now you can see that your role has
been created now the next step is that
we move to Redshirt service and we'll
create one cluster so click on the
services click on Amazon redshift you
can find that in the History Section
since we browsed it just now and from
here we are going to create a sample
cluster now to launch a cluster you just
have to click on launch this cluster
whatever the uncompressed data size you
want in the form of a gigabyte terabyte
or petabyte you can select that and
let's say if you select in the form of
GB how much GB memory you want you can
Define it here itself this also gives
you the information about the costing On
Demand is basically pay as you use so
they are going to charge you 0.5 dollars
per hour for using the two node slices
so let's click on launch this cluster
and this will be a dc2 DOT large kind of
an instance that will be given to you it
would be in the form of a solid state
drive ssds which is one of the fastest
way of storing the information and the
nodes two are mentioned by default that
means there will be two node slices and
that will be created in a cluster you
can in increase them also let's say if I
put three note slices so it is going to
give us 3 into 0.16 DB per node storage
now here you have to define the master
username password for your redshift
cluster and you have to follow the
password instructions so I would put a
password to this cluster and if it
accepts that means it does not give you
any kind of a warning otherwise it is
going to tell you about you have to use
the ASCII characters and all and here
you have to assign this cluster the role
that we created recently so in the
available IM rules you just have to
click on my redshift role and then you
have to launch the cluster if you wanted
to change something in with respect to
the default settings let's say if you
wanted to change the VPC from default
VPC to your custom VPC and you wanted to
change the default security groups to
your own Security Group so you can
switch to advanced settings and do that
modification now let's launch the
cluster and here you can see the
redshift cluster is being created now if
you wanted to run queries on this thread
shift cluster so you don't require a
separate SQL client you just have to
follow the simple steps to run a query
data and the query editor you will find
it on the dashboard so let's click on
the cluster and here you would see that
the redshift cluster would be created
with the three nodes in the US East 1B
availability zone so we have created the
redshift cluster in the Ohio region and
now what we'll do is we'll see how we
can create the tables inside the
redshift and we'll see how we can use
the copy command so that we can directly
move the data uploaded on the S3 bucket
to the redshift database tables and then
we'll query the results of a table as
well so how we can do that first of all
after creating the redshift cluster we
have to install SQL workbench slash J
this is not a MySQL which is managed by
Oracle and you can find this on the
Google you can download it from there
and then you have to connect this client
with shift database how you can do click
on file click on connect window and
after connecting a window you have to
paste the URL which is a jdbc driver
this driver link you can find it onto
the AWS console so if you open up a
redshift cluster there you would find
the jdbc driver link let's wait for it
so this is our cluster created let's
open it and here you can find this jdbc
URL and also make sure that in the
security groups of a redshift you have
the port 5439 open for the traffic
incoming traffic you also need to have
the Amazon redshift driver and this is
the link where you can download the
driver and specify the path once you are
done with that you provide the username
and the password that you created while
creating the redshift cluster click on
OK so this connects with the database
and now the database connection is
almost completed now what we will be
doing in the SQL workbench will be first
creating the sales table and then in the
sales table we'll be adding up the
entries copied from the S3 bucket and
then move it to the redshift database
and after that we'll query the results
in the sales table now whatever the
values you are creating in the table the
same values needs to be in the data file
and I have taken up this sample data
file from this link which is
docs.aws.amazon.com redshift sample
database creation and here you can find
a download file ticketdb.zip file this
folder has basically multiple data files
sample data files which you can actually
use it to practice uploading the data on
the redshift cluster so I have extracted
one of the files from this folder and
then I have uploaded that file in the S3
bucket now we'll move into the S3 bucket
let's look for the file that has been
uploaded on the S3 bucket so this is the
bucket sample and sales underscore tab
dot text is the file that I have
uploaded this has the entries data
entries that will be uploaded using a
copy command onto the redshift cluster
now after executing after putting up the
command for creating up the table then
we'll use a copy command and uh copy
command we have to define the table name
the table name is sales and we have to
define the path from where the data
would be copied over to the sales table
in the redshift now path is the S3
bucket and this is the redshift bucket
sample and it has to look for the data
inside the sales underscore tab dot text
file also we have to define the role Arn
that was created previously and once it
is done then the third step is to query
the results inside the sales table to
check whether our data has been uploaded
correctly on the table or not now what
we'll do is we'll execute all these
three syntax it gives us the error
because we have to connect it again to
the database let's wait for it execute
it it's again gives us the error let's
look into the name of the bucket it's
redshift bucket sample so we have two
T's mentioned here right let's connect
with the database again and now execute
it so table sales created and we got the
error the specified bucket does not
exist uh redshift bucket sample let's
view the bucket name redshift bucket
sample let's copy that put it here
connect to the window connect back to
the database right and now execute it so
table sales created uh the data in the
table has been copied from the S3 bucket
to sales underscore tab dot text to the
redshift and then the query of the
results now the results from the table
has been it hi guys I'm Raul from Simply
on and today I'd like to welcome you all
to the greatest debate of the century
today I am joined by two giants of the
cloud computing industry they'll be
going head to head with each other to
decide who amongst them is better it's
going to be one hell of fight now let's
meet our candidates on my left we have
AWS who's voiced by a picture hi guys
and on my right we have Microsoft Azure
who's voiced by Anjali hey there so
today we'll be deciding who's better on
the basis of their origin and the
features they provide their performance
on the present day and comparing them on
the basis of pricing market share and
options free tier and instance
configuration now let's listen to their
opening statements let's start with AWS
launched in 2006 AWS is one of the most
commonly used cloud computing platforms
across the world companies like Adobe
Netflix Airbnb HTC Pinterest and Spotify
have put their faith in AWS for their
proper functioning it also dominates the
cloud computing domain with almost 40
percent of the entire market share so
far nobody's even gotten close to
beating that number AWS also provides a
wide range of services that covers a
great number of domains domains like
compute networking storage migration and
so much more now let's see what Azure
has to say about that Azure was launched
in 2010 and is trusted by almost 80
percent of all Fortune 500 companies the
best of the best companies in the world
choose to work only with Azure Azure
also provides its services to more
regions than any other cloud service
provider in the world Azure covers 42
regions already and 12 more are being
planned to be made Azure also provides
more than 100 Services spanning a
variety of domains now that the opening
statements are done let's have a look at
the current market status of each of our
competitors this is the performance
route here we have the stats for the
market share of AWS Azure and other
cloud service provider us this is for
the early 2018 period Amazon web
services takes up a whopping 40 percent
of the market share closely followed by
sgr at 30 and other cloud services
adding 30 this 40 indicates most
organizations clear interest in using
AWS we are number one because of our
years of experience and Trust we've
created among our users sure you're the
market leader but we are not very far
behind let me remind you more than 80
percent of the Fortune 500 companies
trust Azure with their cloud computing
needs so it's only a match of time
before Azure takes the lead the rest of
the 30 person that is in AWS or Azure
accounts to the other cloud service
providers like Google Cloud platform
Rackspace IBM software and so on now for
our next round the comparison round
first we'll be comparing pricing we'll
be looking at the cost of a very basic
instance which is a virtual machine of
two virtual CPUs and 8 GBS of RAM for
AWS this will cost you approximately
0.0928 US dollars per hour and for the
same instance in Azure it will cost you
approximately 0.096 US dollars per hour
next up let's compare market share and
options as I mentioned before AWS is the
Undisputed market leader when it comes
to the cloud computing domain taking up
40 of the market share by 2020 AWS is
also expected to produce twice its
current Revenue which comes close to 44
billion dollars not to mention AWS is
constantly expanding its already strong
roaster of more than 100 services to
fulfill the shifting business
requirements of organizations all that
is great really good for you but the
research company Gartner has released a
magic quadrant that you have to see you
see the competition is now neck to neck
between Azure and AWS it's only a match
of time before Azure can increase from
its 30 market share and surpass AWS this
becomes more more likely considering how
all companies are migrating from AWS to
Azure to help satisfy their business
needs Azure is not far behind AWS when
this comes to Services as well azure's
service offerings are constantly updated
and improved on to help users satisfy
their cloud computing requirements now
let's compare AWS and azure's free
offerings AWS provides a significant
number of its services for free helping
users get hands-on experience with the
platform products and services the free
tier Services fall under two categories
services that will remain free forever
and the others that are valid only for
one year the always free category offers
more than 20 services for example Amazon
SNS sqs cloudwatch Etc and the valid for
your category offers approximately 20
services for example Amazon S3 ec2
elastic cache Etc both types of services
have limits on the usage for example
storage number of requests compute time
Etc but users are only charged for using
services that fall under the valid for a
year category after a year of their
usage a shop provides a free tier as
well it also provides services that
belong to the categories of free for a
year and always free there are about 25
plus always free services provided by
Azure these include app service
functions container service active
directory and lots more and as of the
valid for a year there are eight
services offered there's Linux or
Windows Virtual machines blob storage
SQL database and few more Azure also
provides the users with credits of 200
US dollars to access all their services
for 30 days now this is a unique feature
that Azure provides which users can use
their credits to utilize any service of
a choice for the entire month now let's
compare instance configuration the
largest instance that AWS offers is that
over whopping 256 GBS of RAM and 16
virtual CPUs the largest that Azure
offers isn't very far behind either 224
GBS of RAM and 16 virtual CPUs and now
for the final round each of our
contestants will be shown facts and they
have to give explanations for these
facts we call it the rapid fire round
first we have features in which AWS is
good and Azure is better AWS does not
cut down on the features it offers its
users however it requires slightly more
Management on the user's part Azure goes
slightly deeper with the services that
fall under certain categories like
platform as a service and infrastructure
as a service next we have hybrid Cloud
where AWS is good and Azure is better OK
although AWS did not emphasize on hybrid
Cloud earlier they are focusing more on
technology now Azure has always
emphasized on hybrid cloud and has
features supporting it since the days of
its inception for developers AWS is
better and azure here is good of course
it's better because AWS supports
integration with third-party
applications well Azure provides access
to data centers that provide a scalable
architecture for pricing both AWS and
Azure are at the same level it's good
for AWS because it provides a
competitive and constantly decreasing
pricing model and in the case of azure
it provides offers that are constantly
experimented upon to provide its users
with the best experience and that's it
our contestants have finished giving
their statements now let's see who won
surprisingly nobody each cloud computing
platform has its own pros and cons
choosing the right one is based entirely
on your organization's requirements
hi guys today we got something very
special in store for you we're going to
talk about the best cloud computing
platform available Amazon web services
uh Rahul I think you said something
wrong here the best cloud computing
platform is obviously Google Cloud
platform no it isn't AWS is more than
100 services that span a variety of
domains all right that Google Cloud
platform has cheaper instances what do
you have to say about that well I guess
there's only one place we can actually
discuss this a boxing ring so guys I'm
apeksha and I will be Google Cloud
platform and I'm Rahul I'll be AWS so
welcome to fight night this is AWS
versus gcp the winner will be chosen on
the basis of their origin and the
features they provide their performance
in the present day and comparing them on
the basis of pricing market share and
options the things they give you for
free and instance configuration now
first let's talk about AWS AWS was
launched in 2004 and is a cloud service
platform that helps businesses grow and
scale by providing them Services then a
number of different domains these
domains include compute database storage
migration networking and so on a very
important aspect about AWS is its years
of experience now AWS has been in the
market a lot longer than any other cloud
service platform which means they know
how businesses work and how they can
contribute to the business growing also
AWS has over 5.1 billion dollars of
Revenue in the last quarter this is a
clear indication of how much faith and
trust people have in AWS they occupy
more than 40 percent of the market which
is a significant chunk of the cloud
computing Market they have at least 100
services that are available at the
moment which means just about every
issue that you have can be solved within
AWS service now that was great but now
can we talk about gcp I hope you know
that gcp was launched very recently in
2011 and it is already helping
businesses significantly with a suite of
intelligent secure and flexible Cloud
Computing Services it lets you build
deploy and scale applications websites
services on the same infrastructure as
Google the intuitive user experience
that gcp provides with dashboards
Wizards is way better in all the aspects
gcp has just stepped in the market and
it is already offering a modest number
of services and the number is rapidly
increasing and the cost for a CPU
instance or Regional storage that JCP
provides is a whole lot cheaper and you
also get a multi-regional cloud storage
now what do you have to say on that I'm
so glad you asked let's look at present
day in fact let's look at the cloud
market share of the fourth quarter of
2017. this will tell you once and for
all that AWS is the leader when it comes
to cloud computing Amazon web services
contributes 47 of the market share
others like Rackspace or Verizon cloud
contribute 36 Microsoft Azure
contributes 10 the Google Cloud platform
contributes four percent and IBM
software contributes three percent 47
percent of the market share is
contributed by AWS you need me to
convince you any more wait wait wait all
that is fine but we only started a few
years back and have already own so much
in such a less span of time having to
heard the latest news our revenue is
already a billion dollars per quarter
wait for a few more years and the world
shall see and AWS makes 5.3 billion
dollars per quarter it's going to take a
good long time before you can even get
close to us yes yes we'll see now let's
compare a few things for starters let's
compare price for AWS a compute instance
of two CPUs and 8 GB ram costs
approximately 68 US Dollars now a
computer instance is a virtual machine
in which you can specify what operating
system Ram or storage you want to have
for cloud storage it costs 2.3 cents per
GB per month with AWS you really want to
do that because gcp wins this hands down
let's take the same compute instance of
two CPUs with 8GB Ram it will cost
approximately 50 dollars per month with
gcp and as per my calculations that's a
25 annual cost reduction when compared
to AWS talking about cloud storage costs
it is only 2 cents per GB per month with
gcp what else do you want me to say
let's talk about market share and
options now AWS is the current market
leader when it comes to cloud computing
now as you remember we contribute at
least 47 of the entire market share AWS
also has at least 100 services available
at the moment which is a clear
indication of how well AWS understands
businesses and helps them grow yeah
that's true but you should also know
that gcp is steadily growing we have
over 60 services that are up and running
as you can see here and a lot more to
come it's only a matter of time when we
will have as many services as you do
many companies have already started
adopting TCP as a cloud service provider
now let's talk about things you get for
free with AWS you get access to almost
all the services for an entire year with
usage limits now these limits include an
hourly or by the minute basis for
example with Amazon ec2 you get 750
hours per month you also have limits on
the number of requests to services for
example with AWS Lambda you have 1
million requests per month now after
these limits are crossed you get charged
standard rates with gcp you get access
to all Cloud platform products like
Firebase the Google Maps API and so on
you also get 300 in credit to spend over
a 12 month period on all the cloud
platform products and interestingly
after the free trial ends you won't be
charged unless you manually upgrade to a
paid account now there is also the
always free version for which you will
need an upgraded billing account here
you get to use a small instance for free
and 5 GB of cloud storage any usage
above this always free usage limits will
be automatically built at standard rates
now let's talk about how you can
configure instances with AWS the largest
instances offered is of 128 CPUs and
four TVs of ram now other than the on
demand method like I mentioned before
you can also use Spartan sensors now
these are for situations where your
application is more fault or rent and
can handle an interruption now you pay
for the spot price which is effective at
a particular are so these spot prices do
fluctuate but are adjusted over a period
of time the largest instance offered
with Google cloud is 160 CPUs and 3.75
TBS Ram like spot instances of AWS
Google Cloud offers short-lived compute
instances suitable for back jobs and for
tolerant workloads they are called as
preemptable instances so these instances
are available at 80 percent off on
on-demand price hence they reduce your
compute engine costs significantly and
unlike AWS these come at a fixed price
Google Cloud platform is a lot more
flexible when it comes to instance
configuration you simply choose your CPU
and RAM combination of course you can
even create your own instance types this
way before we wrap it up let's compare
on some other things as well Telemetry
it's a process of automatically
collecting periodic measurements from
remote devices for example GPS gcp is
obviously better because they have
Superior Telemetry tools which help in
analyzing so services and providing more
opportunities for improvement when it
comes to application support AWS is
obviously better since they have years
of experience under their bed AWS
provides the best support that can be
given to the customers containers are
better with gcp a container is a virtual
process running in user space as
kubernetes was originally developed by
Google TCP has four native support for
the tools other cloud services are just
fine-tuning a way to provide kubernetes
as a service also the containers help
with abstracting applications from their
environment they originally run it the
applications can be deployed easily
regardless of their environment when it
comes to geographies AWS is better since
they have a head start of a few years
AWS in this fan of time has been able to
cover a larger market share and
geographical locations now it's time for
the big decision so who's it going to be
yeah who is it going to be gcp or AWS I
think I'm going to go for choosing the
right cloud computing platform is a
decision that's made on the basis of the
user or the organized requirement on
that note I believe it's time for us to
wrap this video up AWS Azure and gcp are
three of the world's largest cloud
service providers but how are they
different from each other let's find out
hey guys I'm Rahul and I'll be
representing Amazon web services I'm
chinmayi and I'll be representing
Microsoft Azure and I am Shruti and I'll
be representing Google Cloud platform so
welcome to this video on AWS versus
Azure versus gcp talking about market
share Amazon web services leads with
around 32 percent of the worldwide
public cloud share Azure owns up to 16
of the worldwide market share and gcp
owns around nine percent of the world's
market share let's talk about each of
these service providers in detail AWS
provides services that enable users to
create and deploy applications over the
cloud these services are accessible via
the Internet AWS being the oldest of the
lot was launched in the year 2006. Azure
launched in 2010 is a Computing platform
that offers a wide range of services to
build manage and deploy applications on
the network using tools and Frameworks
launched in the year 2008 gcp offers
application development and integration
services for its end users in addition
to Cloud management it also offers
services for Big Data machine learning
and iot now let's talk about
availability zones these are isolated
locations within data center regions
from which public cloud services
originate and operate talking about AWS
they have 69 availability zones within
22 geographical regions this includes
regions in the United States South
America Europe and Asia Pacific they are
also predicted to have 12 more editions
in the future Azure available in 140
countries has over 54 regions worldwide
grouped into six geographies these
geographical locations have more than
100 data centers gcp is available in 200
plus countries across the world as of
today gcp is present in 61 zones and 20
regions with Osaka and Zurich being the
newly added regions now let's talk about
pricing these service says follow the
pay as you go approach you pay only For
The Individual Services you need for as
long as you use them without requiring
long-term contracts or complex licensing
now on screen you can see the pricing
for each of these cloud service
providers with respect to various
instances like general purpose compute
optimized memory optimized and GPU now
let's talk about the compute services
offered first off we have virtual
servers for AWS we have ec2 it is a web
service which eliminates the need to
invest in Hardware so that you can
develop and deploy applications in a
faster manner it provides virtual
machines in which you can run your
applications azure's virtual machines is
one of the several types of computing
resources that Azure offers Azure gives
the user the flexibility to deploy and
manage a virtual environment inside a
virtual Network gcp's VM service enables
users to build deploy and manage virtual
machines to run workloads on the cloud
now let's talk about the pricing of each
of these Services aw cc2 is free to try
it is packaged as part of is Freedia
that lasts for 12 months and provides
750 hours per month of both Linux and
Windows Virtual machines Azure virtual
machine service is a part of the free
tier that offers this service for about
750 hours per month for a year the user
gets access to Windows and Linux virtual
machines gcp's VM service is a part of a
free tier that includes micro instance
per month for up to 12 months now let's
talk about platform as a service or past
services for AWS elastic Beanstalk is an
easy to use service for deploying and
scaling web applications and services
developed with java.net node.js python
and much more it is used for maintaining
capacity provisioning load balancing
Auto scaling and application Health
monitoring the past backbone utilizes
virtualization techniques with the
virtual machine is independent of the
actual Hardware that hosts it hence the
user can write application code without
worrying about the underlying Hardware
Google app engine is a cloud computing
platform as a service which is used by
Developers for hosting and building apps
in Google data centers the app engine
requires the apps to be written in Java
or Python and store data in Google big
table and use the Google query language
for this next let's talk about virtual
private server Services AWS provides
light sale it provides everything you
need to build an application or website
along with the cost effective monthly
plan and minimum number of
configurations in simple words VM image
is a more comprehensive image for
Microsoft Azure virtual machines it
helps the user create many identical
virtual machines in a matter of minutes
unfortunately gcp does not offer any
similar service next up we have
serverless Computing Services AWS has
Lambda it is a serverless compute
service that lets you run your code
without facilitating and managing
servers you only pay for the compute
time you use it is used to execute
backend code and skills automatically
when required Azure functions is a
serverless compute service that lets you
run even triggered code without having
to explicitly provision or manage
structure this allows the users to build
applications using serverless simple
functions with the programming language
of their choice gcp Cloud functions make
it easy for developers to run and scale
code in the cloud and build image driven
serverless applications it is highly
available and fault tolerant now let's
talk about storage services offered by
each of these service providers First
off we have object storage AWS provides
S3 it is an object storage that provides
industry standard scalability data
availability and performance it is
extremely durable and can be used for
storing as well as recovering
information or data from anywhere over
the Internet blob storage is an Azure
feature that lets developers store
unstructured data in Microsoft's Cloud
platform along with storage it also
offers scalability it stores the data in
the form of tiers depending on how often
data is being accessed Google Cloud
Storage is an online storage web service
for storing and accessing data on Google
Cloud platform infrastructure unlike the
Google Drive Google cloud storage is
more suitable for Enterprises it also
shows objects that are organized into
buckets Amazon provides EBS or elastic
Block store it provides high performance
block storage and is used along with ec2
instances for workloads that are
transaction or throughput intensive
Azure managed disk is a virtual hard
disk you can think of it like a physical
disk in an on-premises server but
virtualized these managed disks allow
the users to create up to 10 000 VM
disks in a single subscription
persistent storage is a data storage
device that retains data after power to
the device is shut off Google persistent
disk is durable and high performance
block storage for gcp persistent disk
provides storage which can be attached
to instances running in either Google
compute engine or kubernetes engine next
up we have Disaster Recovery Services
AWS provides a cloud-based recovery
service that ensures that your it
infrastructure and data are recovered
while minimizing the amount of downtime
that could be used site recovery helps
ensure business continuity by keeping
business apps and workloads running
during outages it allows recovery by
orchestrating and automating the
replication process of azure virtual
machines between regions unfortunately
gcp has no disaster recovery service
next let's talk about database Services
first off for AWS we have RDS or
relational database service it is a web
service that's cost effective and
automates administration tasks basically
it simplifies the setup operation and
scaling of a relational database
Microsoft Azure SQL database is a
software as a service platform that
includes built-in intelligence that
learns app patterns and adapts to
maximize performance reliability and
data protection it also eases the
migration of SQL Server databases
without changing the user's applications
Cloud SQL is a fully managed database
service which is easy to set up maintain
and administer relational postgresql
MySQL and SQL Server databases in the
cloud hosted on gcp cloud SQL provides a
database infrastructure for applications
running anywhere next we have nosql
database Services AWS provides dynamodb
which is a managed durable database that
provides security backup and restore and
in-memory caching for applications it is
well known for its low latency and
scalable performance Azure Cosmos DB is
Microsoft's globally distributed
multi-model database service it natively
supports nosql it natively supports
nosql created for low latency and
scalable applications gcp cloud data
store is a nosql database service
offered by Google on the gcp it handles
replication and scales automatically to
your applications load with cloud data
stores interface data can easily be
accessed by any deployment Target now
let's talk about the key Cloud tools for
each of these service providers for AWS
in networking and content delivery we
have AWS Route 53 and AWS cloudfront for
management we have AWS Cloud watch and
AWS cloud formation for development we
have AWS code start and AWS code build
for security we have IAM and Key
Management Service for Microsoft Azure
networking and content delivery we have
content delivery Network and express
route for management tools we have Azure
advisor and network Watcher for
development tools for management we have
Azure advisor and network Watcher for
development we have Visual Studio IDE
and Azure blob studio for security we
have Azure security Center and Azure
active directory for gcp we have the
following tools for networking and
content delivery we have Cloud CDN and
Cloud DNS for management we have
stackdriver and gcp monitoring for
development we have Cloud build and
Cloud SDK and finally for security we
have Google cloud IM and Google and
Cloud security scanner now let's talk
about the companies using these Cloud
providers for AWS we have Netflix
Unilever Kellogg's NASA Nokia and Adobe
Pixar Samsung eBay Fujitsu EMC and BMW
among others use Microsoft so as seen on
your screens the companies that use gcp
are Spotify HSBC Snapchat Twitter PayPal
and 20th Century Fox let's talk about
the advantages of each of these Services
Amazon provides Enterprise friendly
Services you can leverage Amazon's 15
years of experience delivering
large-scale Global infrastructure and it
still continues to hone and innovate its
infrastructure management skills and
capabilities secondly it provides
instant access to resources AWS is
designed to allow application providers
isvs and vendors to quickly and securely
host your applications whether an
existing application or a new SAS based
application Speed and Agility AWS
provides you access to its services
within minutes all you need to select is
what you require and you can proceed you
can access each of these applications
anytime you need them and finally it's
secure and reliable Amazon enables you
to innovate and scale your application
in a secure environment it secures and
hardens your infrastructure more
importantly it provides security at a
cheaper cost than on-premise
environments now talking about some of
the advantages of azure Microsoft Azure
offers better development operations it
also provides strong security profile
Azure has a strong focus on security
following the Standard Security model of
detect assess diagnose stabilize and
close Azure also provides a
cost-effective solution the cloud
environment allows businesses to launch
both customer applications and internal
apps in the cloud which saves an I.T
infrastructure costs hence it's Opex
friendly let's now look at the
advantages of gcp Google bills in minute
level increments so you only pay for the
compute time you use they also provide
discounted prices for long-running
workloads for example you use the VM for
a month and get a discount gcp also
provides live migration of virtual
machines live migration is the process
of moving a running VM from one physical
server to another without disrupting its
availability to the users this is a very
important differentiator for Google
Cloud compared to other Cloud providers
gcp provides automatic scalability this
allows a site's container scale to as
many CPUs as needed Google Cloud Storage
is designed for 99.9 durability it
creates server backup and stores them in
a user configured location let's talk
about the disadvantages of each of these
services for AWS there's a limitation of
the ec2 service AWS provides limitations
on resources that vary from region to
region there may be a limit to the
number of instances that can be created
however you can request for these limits
to be increased secondly they have a
technical support fee AWS charges you
for immediate support and you can opt
for any of these packages developer
which costs 29 per month business which
costs more than 100 an Enterprise that
costs more than fifteen thousand dollars
it has certain network connectivity
issues it also has General issues when
you move to the cloud like downtime
limited control backup protection and so
on however most of these are temporary
issues and can be handled over time
talking about some of the disadvantages
of Microsoft Azure code base is
different when working offline and it
requires modification when working on
the cloud pass across system is not as
efficient as iaas Azure Management
console is frustrating to work with it
is slow to respond and update and
requires far too many clicks to achieve
simple tasks Azure backup is intended
for backing up and restoring data
located on your on-premises servers to
the cloud that's a great feature but
it's not really useful for doing bare
metal restores of servers in a remote
data center let's now look into the
disadvantages of gcp so when it comes to
Cloud providers the support fee is very
minimal but in the case of gcp it is
quite costly it is around 150 dollars
per month for the most basic service
similar to AWS S3 gcp has a complex
pricing schema also it is not very
budget friendly when it comes to
downloading data from Google Cloud
Storage hey guys this is chidanan from
Simply learn and I welcome you to this
short tutorial and demo on kubernetes
kubernetes specific to AWS Cloud
platform so what's a part of this
tutorial and demo what's in store for
you at our offset I would like to cover
the basics of Orchestra tools as most of
you would know kubernetes is one of the
most popular orchestration tools in
recent times specifically for
applications which are Cloud native and
deployed on some or the other types of
containers but what are these
orchestration tools why would one need
to use orchestration tools what are the
facilities of features provided by these
orchestration tools that's the first
thing that I'm going to cover after that
I will pick two orchestration tools
specific to container management Docker
swarm vs kubuntis I am going to compare
them with regard to the features that
they provide the use cases that they
cover what facilities that they provide
and when to use what after that I will
get into little bit details of the
kubernetes architecture what exactly is
required for setting up a kubernetes
cluster what runs in a control plane or
a master node what runs as a part of the
worker node after that I will end the
tutorial by running youth by setting up
a three node kubernetes cluster on AWS
plan form I will use something called as
cops which is one of the admin tools for
setting a production grade kubernetes
cluster so I will use this to set up a
three node cluster on AWS all right now
that we set the context right let me get
started so what are orchestration tools
the application development and the life
cycle management from the time the
application is developed connecting the
source code to your continuous
integration to testing them all along
your development process and eventually
moving it down to production managing
your production servers the dependencies
that your software has the requirement
that it has in terms of the hardware the
features of fault tolerance self-healing
capabilities Auto scaling all this as
complicated over the last few years as a
part of devops one thing that everyone
is interested in is managing all these
application dependency or lifecycle
management using some or the other kind
of a tool so that's where these
orchestration tools have become very
very popular so what kind of features
that they provide is you'll have to just
let them know what are the kinds of tool
sets that is required what are the fault
tolerance mechanisms that it has to be
adopted to what kind of a self-healing
capabilities that application will have
to need and if at all there is any auto
scaling features that is required if at
all you can bake in all these specific
parameters into your tool your
orchestration tool becomes a One-Stop
shop for all your deployment and
configuration management needs that's
where this orchestration tools have
become a very very popular and relevant
specifically these days when people are
more and more interested in adopting
devops practices all right so having
said that about orchestration tools
let's concentrate on two of these
orchestration tools specifically for
container management Docker swarm and
kubuntus many of the applications that
are written for these kind of containers
are called or kind of fall into a
category of cloud native where the
application need not know much about the
underlying infrastructure or the
platform where these applications are
running so these two along with Apache
me Source there are many other container
management systems but I'm going to pick
Docker swarm and kubernetes for
comparing the features that is provided
by these two Frameworks for the sake of
comparison I picked up Docker swarm and
kubuntase just because of the reason
that both of them operate in the space
of container management they do
something very very similar to
Containers that's the similarity that
exists between these two orchestration
tools however there's a big difference
that exists when it comes to the types
of containers that both of them cater to
and also the capacity of workloads they
can be used for Docker swarm is a
cluster management solution that is
provided by Docker container Docker is
one of the very very popular containers
of recent times and in case you have
your applications that is totally
powered by only Docker containers if you
have a need where you want to run a
cluster of servers which are running
only Docker containers Docker swarm
should be your choice for your
orchestration tool kubernetes this on
the other hand can cater to any other
types of containers other than Docker
and including Docker as well so in case
you have your applications which have
got Docker in them which I've got rkt in
them which they have got Alex in them or
any other type of container kubernetes
should be your choice of orchestration
too a Docker swarm can manage up to 40
50 or 60 Max nodes so in case your
application is totally written in Docker
containers and the load or the expected
cluster size is about 50 60 nodes Docker
swarm should be your choice of
orchestration tool on the other hand
kubernetes is something that was open
sourced by Google and the kind of the
scale of operations that kubernetes can
cater to is Google scale so if in case
your applications are more than a
thousand nodes that is where kubernetes
comes into play that's the big
difference that exists between Docker
swarm and kubernetes putting those
differences aside let me compare docus
warm and kubernetes based upon other
features which are similar in nature the
first and important feature that
kubernetes provides is something called
as Auto scaling if at all the load on
your cluster is too high and an
application is experiencing more load so
kubernetes can add new nodes to your
cluster of course you'll have to
configure kubernetes in order to have
those capabilities where it can spin up
new VMS or new nodes if at all you do
that configuration correctly kubernetes
has got the capacity or it has got the
feature where it can bring up a new node
and add it to the cluster on the Fly
based upon the load that exists at that
moment on similar lines if at all the
load is not too high it can identify few
of those nodes which have got less
number of replicas or less number of
application containers running on it it
can move them to some other node and
also scale down by deleting few nodes
from your cluster so that is the of less
of Auto scaling which is provided by
kubernetes and this unfortunately does
not exist in Docker swarm the other
feature of load balancing specifically
application load balancing so Docker
swarm gives you an application Level
Auto load balancing however kubernetes
gives you the flexibility of manually
configuring any other type of load
balancer of your choice for application
load balancing installation as I
mentioned earlier Docker swarm is a
loose cluster of containers which are
running on nodes it is very easy to spin
up a new node and then connect them to a
swarm and this can be done in a very
very loose coupled way where you can
create swarms of your choice notes are
allowed to connect to swarms and quit or
leave the Swarms on the fly so in and
all the installation is pretty easy and
fast kubernetes on the other hand the
configuration of kubernetes is the way
to spin up a big cluster specifying the
size of the node how many Master known
so many config planes that you want how
many nodes that you want it's a pretty
tough thing to bring up a kubernetes
scalability kubernetes strength is very
very strong they are very tightly
coupled and even they have the
capability where on the cluster size
things or the nodes can be increased on
the Fly based upon the requirement on a
Docker swarm the cluster strength is
weak as compared to kubernetes worker
nodes can be added to a swarm worker
notes can be asked to leave us form or
can be taken out of a swarm based upon
the requirement so this is kind of a
Loosely coupled architecture for Docker
swarm while kubernetes the cluster is
very tightly coupled since docus warm
runs only Docker containers containers
find it very easy to share data and a
lot of other things with each other
because they all have the same signature
they are all from the same family so
it's very easy for them to share not
just volumes but a lot of other things
however for kubernetes since it manages
containers of different types if
application as to share some data across
different containers there's a little
bit of a complexity in how you would
want your containers to share data also
when it comes to kubernetes kubernetes
groups containers in something called as
pods while a pod can have either one
container that's a preferred choice or
multiple containers and the idea of pod
is like each pod can run in any other
node it's not guaranteed that you would
want to have two or three parts to be
running on the same node that makes data
sharing a little bit of a different
thing compared to Dockers form GUI so
there's not a good enough UI tool in
Dockers form at least the CE edition of
it which will allow you to get to know
what is running on your containers what
is the size of the containers what is
the volume of the containers and all
that stuff there are some free and open
source tools like portainer which gives
you a good visibility into your running
Docker containers however there's
nothing at a swarm level that is
provided by docker abilities gives you
an out of the box dashboard which is
easy to configure and set up you can
also Club it with some metrics services
and you can also get information about
the size of the cluster that is running
what is the load on the nodes and stuff
like that all this across your cluster
in a very beautiful dashboard
perspective so that way this is little
bit of a good UI for kubernetes file for
Dockers form there isn't anything that
is provided out of the box let me spend
some time in explaining a little bit
about the kubernetes architecture what
comprises of the kubernetes cluster what
resides in a master or a control plane
and what resides in a worker node this
is a very high level depiction of a
kubernetes cluster so this is the master
node which has got something called as a
cluster store a controller a scheduler
component and an API server and these
are the bunch of nodes that are
connected or administered by the master
node the master node can be 1 3 Phi
typically an odd number this is as per a
typical cluster management thing where
you would need the master nodes to be in
odd numbers so that whenever there's any
contention in terms of what needs to be
deployed where or where to give the job
to whom and stuff like that all the
Masters would cast their vote and they
would decide on the outcome so that's
the master node and there are a bunch of
nodes which can be connected and
administered by the master node cubic
CTL or the command from using which
anybody can assign some workloads to the
cluster can also be run either on the
same node or on a separate node so Cube
CTL is the command line tool that we
will be installing and using in order to
fire up our commands to our cluster so
if at all I have to put up a job on our
cluster if I have to give out any
specific commands to my cluster all this
is done using cubic CTL there's a bunch
of rest apis which is used by Q CTL and
Cube CTL will talk to the API server and
fire up the commands specific to my
cluster what runs in the master node
Master node without saying it's the most
important component of any of the
cluster if at all you're running
um cluster with only one master node if
your master node goes down there's no
other way that you know you can or any
user can talk to the different nodes in
the cluster so Master node is the most
vital component responsible for the
complete kubernetes cluster there's
always one node that should be running
as a master node that's a bare minimum
requirement for your cluster so what are
the other components in the master node
the most important one is called etcd so
this is nothing but a data store a value
of key value pair which is stored which
contains all information about your
cluster so all the configuration details
which node is up which worker node is
down all this information is stored in
the cluster store so all the managers
would access this cluster store before
they go ahead and decide any other work
item or anything else that has to be
done specific to your cluster what's in
the controller as the name says
controller is something it's like a
Daemon server that is running in a
continuous loop all the time it is
responsible for controlling the set of
replicas the kind of workloads that is
running based upon the configuration
that the user has set in so if at all if
you are aware of something called as a
replication controllers endpoint
controllers namespace controllers all
these controllers are managed by the
controller component if any user asked
for some three replicas of a particular
pod or a service to be running and if at
all any of the nodes goes down or the
Pod goes down for whatever reason the
controller is the one who wakes up and
assigns this particular job or the Pod
to some other available node by looking
up for the details using in the cluster
store that's the importance of the
control manager or the controller the
scheduler the scheduler assigns the
tasks based upon whoever is asked for
any job to be scheduled based upon a
time frame or based upon some criteria
it also tracks the working load as to
what what exactly is the load who is
running what when in the cluster and
places the workload on whoever is the
available resource at that time all
right APA server this is one other
important component in in our kubernetes
cluster where how would the end user
deploy or give out any sort of a
workload onto your cluster all the
requests come to the API server so this
is an entry point for all your requests
that come into your cluster anybody
wants to deploy something anybody want
to scale up a controller anybody who
wants to bring down few Services anybody
wants to put in a service all this will
have to come in as a part of a rest API
endpoint and API server is the entry
point in case you don't want you know
somebody to access your cluster in case
you want only specific people or
specific users to be running some
specific workloads you can set all those
role-based access control for this API
server so this is the entry point for
anyone who wants to submit any job to
your cluster so that's a quick overview
about the master node what what are the
important components of a master node
now let's go over to what runs in a
worker or a slave node as I mentioned
earlier slave nodes are something where
the job that is submitted to your
cluster is eventually run as a pod as a
service as a container so in kubernetes
world there's something called as a pod
a pod is nothing but a combination of a
container it is a wrapper around your
running containers so slave nodes are
the worker nodes typically run these
parts so that is where the whole
workload typically gets run but there
are a bunch of other components in the
in the node which also manages what runs
in the Pod who has to have access to the
Pod what is the state of the Pod is it
in a running state is it going down for
some reason and all the stuff so let's
quickly go over those components that is
there in the slave node the most
important component in my opinion that
should be on the on the Node should be
the container runtime as I mentioned
earlier kubernetes can run any different
types of containers not just Docker so
in case you want to have a node which
wants to have Docker running on it rkt
running or at LKC running on it or any
other container environment that is
running on it you have to ensure that
the specific container runtime
environment is available on that
specific node so that whenever a job is
submitted description of what needs to
be run as a part of the Pod what should
be the image with it should be powered
and what kind of a container to spin up
so that's what you know when the job is
finally assigned to this particular node
it would definitely need a container
runtime to be up and running so that
that exists only if at all the container
runtime is installed and running on your
kubernetes worker node okay now that we
know what our kubernetes node can run
how would somebody assign a job to our
node that is using something called as a
cube alert as the name says cubelet or
cube alert is a small subset which talks
to the cube API server so any node which
has to run any kind of a pod all these
instructions are passed around by the
qbps server to the tubular and cubelet
is capable of processing whatever job
that is assigned to it and ensuring that
so many parts and so many services are
spun up based upon the requirement the
last component that exists in the worker
node is the cube proxy or kubernetes
proxy this plays a very very important
role acting as a load balancer and a
network proxy so what typically happens
is whenever the pods are running in
nodes the parts can be typically running
in any node there is no um Affinity
towards any node on which these parts
are running because pods or containers
are something called as ephemeral they
can run anywhere so how would somebody
reach out to these applications that is
running in some pod which is running in
one container now and running in
probably another container another node
all together tomorrow so that is where
your kubernetes proxy contains a picture
and this component will ensure that any
container that is spun up or any pod
that is spun up it keeps track of all
these spots and kind of connects the end
points or acts like a DNS server so that
it knows when somebody is trying to
reach out to this particular service
which is the pod on which the service is
typically running so that plays a very
very important role by acting as a load
balancer and a network proxy now that at
a very high level we know what are all
the components that make up of our
kubernetes cluster let's go ahead and
create a small cluster we'll spin up
this cluster on AWS platform finally we
get to the demo section of my two
tutorial now that you guys are aware as
to what is kubernetes what is the use of
kubernetes you also know at a very very
high level what are the components of a
cluster what is a master node or a
control plane what are the components of
a master node and what should be
existing in a worker node probably
you're thinking that it's going to be
pretty hard to kind of set this up so
let me demystify that by running you
with a quick demo of how to set up a
simple free node kubernetes cluster
using a tool called cops and I will be
doing this whole setup on my AWS Cloud
okay so what is cops cops is nothing but
a simple tool is an admin tool that
allows you to bring up production grade
kubernetes environments as I said
setting up a kubernetes cluster on a
bare metal is little challenging so that
is why I would use something called as a
cops and I will use this on my cluster
which I'll spin up on my AWS instance so
I have an AWS account and what I will do
first is I will first spin up an ec2
server I'll power this with one of the
Linux Amis and I will install cops on it
now this will be my starting point from
where I'm going to trigger running up a
big cluster in our case I'll try to keep
it little small I don't want too many
notes in my cluster I'm going to have
one master node and two worker nodes
this whole operation would be done
programmatically by installing this cops
admin tool so as you may know AWS is
little hard for me to programmatically
run other components or rather bring up
servers it's not pretty simple so what I
would do is I will create an IAM role
which will attach to my S2 server so
that my ec2 server gets powered with all
the required role so that it can go
ahead and spin up cluster based upon my
configuration that I'm going to specify
all right so once I have my cluster set
up I will also install cubic CTL which
you probably know by now is nothing but
a command line utility using which I can
kind of connect to my cluster give out
some jobs put some parts and stuff like
that so I will use Cuba CTL I will also
have a pair of SSH keys so that from
this machine I would be able to
successfully get onto the master node
and submit jobs on my behalf so let me
Begin by first logging into my AWS
account all the steps that I will be
following to bring up my AWS cluster
kubernetes cluster will be documented
and I'll be sharing you this document in
a GitHub repository so that in case
anybody wants to try you'll be more than
happy to find all the required
instructions in one place okay now the
first thing that I would need is to
launch an AWS ec2 instance now this is
an instance where I'm going to install
cops and I will use it as a base server
from where I'm going to fight some
commands which will bring up my
kubernetes cluster so let me log into my
AWS account and let me stick to one
particular region and let me bring up
some a one ec2 instance all right so let
me launch my instance let me choose
um it doesn't matter in the ways but in
case you want to try it on your free
tire I would recommend choose free tire
only and choose an Ami of your choice
let me choose this instance I will make
it T2 micro that is good for me
configuration instance details all right
I don't want to change anything here
that looks good maybe I will change this
30 gig that's good for me let me add a
tag to my instance I will name this as
my cops server alright I would need a
bunch of ports to be opened up so what I
will do is I'll create a new security
group called open to the word I would
not recommend that you do this since I
don't want to it will take a long time
for me to specifically uh pick and
choose the ports that has to be open for
running my cluster I don't want to do
that I will open up all the HTTP and
https ports so that it's quicker so I
will say all TCP I would say from
anywhere just to be on the safer side
also open HTTP and https and I will make
this anywhere and anywhere this is good
for me I will say review on launch all
right so I chose a T2 micro instance
just for the sake of easiness I've
opened up all the ports and the instant
details are you've seen what is that
I've chosen all right now important part
is like I would need a keypad I need to
create a new keypad I will call this as
simply learn keys I will download this
key pair and then I will launch the
instance it will take some time for my
ec2 instance to come up in the meanwhile
what I'll do is I will convert I have
this pem file which is the pair of keys
the SSH keys with which I need to log
into my ec2 instance so I'll need to
convert this because I'm trying to
connect from my Windows box I would need
to convert this into a PPK file so I
have putition I am going to load my set
of keys here and convert that key into
application all right open all right I
would say save and save privately yes I
would say simply learn or simply
non-private private key I'll save this
here and that that's all so this is my
public key which is the pem file and
this is my PPK or my private key Now
using the private key I will log into my
ec2 instance okay now my ec2 instance is
up and running it is running in this
Ohio region and this is the IP address
of my public IP address of my machine so
let me connect to it so I use mobile
exterm which is nothing but an SSH
emulator you can use putty or any of
these sessions which allow you to do on
SSH this is my ipe address of my machine
and since I've spun up an Amazon Ami the
user this is the default user I would
need specify the private keys for my
session and this is the private key for
my session say okay I am in my Amazon
ec2 instance so let me look at what are
the other things that I need to do all
right so as I said I just brought up my
ec2 instance but I would need my ec2
instance to run few things on my behalf
so that it can spin up easy to other ec2
instances it can also talk to an S3
bucket where I'm going to store the
instant state of my kubernetes cluster
also some sort of an auto scaling group
because I want to spin up more and more
instances I also want to have a private
hosted Zone using my Route 53 so I would
need my ec2 instance to have all these
sort of permissions for my server so
what I would do is I'll go and create a
permission a role in the ec2 or rather
in the AWS IM role and I will attach
this I am role to my ec2 instance all
right so let me go to my IAM which is
nothing but the iron entity and access
management I'll create a role called as
possibly cops role I will create a role
this role will be used by my ec2 so I'm
going to click on ec2 and say next
permissions they would need a lot of
permissions uh specific permissions to
be very honest and the permissions are
all listed out here S3 ec2 and all this
stuff just to keep it pretty simple what
I will do is I'll create a role with the
administrative access all right so I
don't want any tags I'm going to review
I'll create a role name I will say cops
fold for ec2 all right so I'm going to
create a rule which has got
administrative access rules I'm going to
create a role so this would ensure that
my ec2 instance from which I am going to
run a my cluster would have all the
prerequisite permission so that it can
go and spin up instances talk to S3
buckets and all that stuff all right now
let us have our running instance get
powered by this role so I will connect
this role to my running instance alright
so this is my easy to instant that is
running I will say action attached
attach attach attach replace IM rules so
there is no rule as of now I would want
my cops roll for a series rule that I
created so I want this new rule to be
assigned to my ec2 all right great now
my ec2 instance which is my cop server
has got all the required permissions so
that he can create a cluster on my
behalf great now before this let me do a
sudo gem update iPhone y so that any of
the because this is a newly provisioned
VM I just want to ensure that all my
library system libraries are all updated
so that when I do install cop and Cube
CTL and all those things none of them
will fail because of some dependency or
package issues so I'm just running a
sudo update iPhone y so that all the
libraries are updated okay looks like it
is done so let me go ahead and install
cops cops is a pretty simple
installation it is available in a
particular location I have to just copy
this and ensure that I do a curve and I
install this particular stuff all right
so it is fetching the cops tool it's
installing for me once it is copied down
let me change the mode so that I can
execute it and then also let me move it
to my user local bin so that it is
available for me in my path okay that's
pretty much the corpse installation let
me also do one other thing let me
install something called as cubic CTL so
this is what would be you know a tool
using which I'm going to be firing my
commands to my kubernetes cluster once
it comes up okay this is a pretty
smaller executable so keep sitting here
all right so I have Cuba CTL as well as
cops installed on my ec2 server now okay
now what I'll do next is I'm going to
create an S3 bucket in AWS so that the
equivalent is a cluster state is
persisted in this bucket so let me
create a simple bucket with this name S3
bucket with this name so let me go to S3
and let me create a simple bucket with
this name I will just say create a
bucket okay so this is simply run dot
kubernetes is the bucket that I created
so this bucket will store all
information about my cluster let me now
go and create a DNS entry or a DNS zone
or AWS Route 53 hosted zone for my
cluster so this is required so that you
know I can give a cluster name for my
kubernetes cluster that I am coming up
so I will create a private hosted Zone
and possibility possibly I will call
this as simply learn.in so this will be
my name of my private hosted Zone in
case you already have any other public
hosted zones in your name you can always
put a Route 53 hosted Zone specific for
your domain name since I don't have
anyone I'm just going to create a simple
private hosted zone so let me head down
to Route 53 click on any of these and
you'll get these hosted zones out here
so I'm going to create a hosted Zone
here I'm going to create a hosted Zone
click on create hosted Zone
um this would be simply landlord in I
want to create a public no I don't want
public I want a private hosted Zone and
I'm going to associate my VPC ID for
this hosted Zone since I'm going to try
out all my exercises in the Ohio region
I will associate the VPC of the Ohio
region for this all right so this is the
one that is specific to the Ohio region
so I will say this one I'll say create a
hosted so great now let me come back to
my ec2 box my ec2 is all powered with
whatever it needs in order to go out
with the installation of my cluster only
few things that I need to take care of
is that you know now that I put a name
for my cluster I also have an uh S3
bucket that I've configured for my
cluster I will have to ensure that I
need to put in these two configurations
as a part of my cluster building
activity so I will open my bash RC file
and I'm going to export these two
variables if at all you remember well
these two variables are nothing but the
cluster name which is nothing but the
public or sorry the private hosted Zone
that I created and the S3 bucket where
I'm going to create or rather I'm going
to store my cluster state so let me copy
these two and open up my bash RC file
all right so I will just add these two
and copy these and Export them out as my
variable I'm going to save this here now
let me ensure that this gets picked up
all right I've got these two that have
configured and I've also ensure that
this environment variables are set now
let me create a pair of SSH keys this is
to ensure that I can log into the box
that I'm going to be provisioning as a
part of my cluster SSH hyphen key gen I
don't want to give any parameters let it
go to the home directory with the
default name and without any passphrase
all right so I created a bunch of my key
pair now I'm all set to go ahead and run
my cops now cops will ensure that this
will take some time for the cluster to
come up but this is exactly how I would
Define my cups command I I've copied
here so cops create cluster the state of
the cluster will be stored in this
particular variable which is what I have
exported out the number of node count is
two node count is the worker node count
if at all I don't specif there's a
configuration for specifying the master
or the control pane as well if I don't
specify that the default one is one so
I'm going to create one primary or the
master node and to worker nodes uh size
of my master Note size of the worker
nodes or what are the zones where I want
this to be created and where do I store
the cluster information and okay I've
already added this must account this is
actually not required but this is the
command that I'm going to fire off so
that I bring up my cluster all right
that went off very fast but this
actually did not create a cluster it is
just the definition of a cluster and
that's why this came out very fast now
that everything looks good with whatever
configuration that is specified now let
me go ahead and create the cluster base
in cops update cluster hyphen iPhone 8
yes now this will take some time a good
5-10 minutes for it too because this
will actually start provisioning the
servers and as I mentioned earlier based
upon my configuration I'm going to come
up with one master server and uh two
nodes or these worker nodes all right so
this is the command for me to validate
the cluster and I'm going to try it out
first I'm pretty sure that will fail
because all my servers are not up yet it
is taking some time the validation
everything failed but let me try to look
at my ec2 instances and see how many
servers do I have running as of now if
you see I had only one server that had
started which was my cop server and
automatically the other three instances
one is called notes dot simply not in
and this these two are the nodes and
this is the master node so these three
got automatically provisioned by the
cops command that I ran all right so
this may take a while for it to get
validated and good 5-10 minutes so what
I'll do is I'll pause the video now and
I'll come back once the server the
cluster is up and running it's been a
good uh eight to nine minutes since I
started my cluster so let me validate
now okay seems good so this is a master
node uh minimum One Max one some nodes
which are nothing but the slave nodes or
the worker nodes there are two of them
due to micro uh subnet so my clusters
seem to be up and running and my cluster
name is Milan dot in so what I would
want to do is now let me just log into
the master and see if I can run some
pods so let me get back to my
installation steps here the variation is
done so let me log into my since my
cluster name is simply learn.n this is
the way to log into my box so let me get
into my box so if you see here this is
the host name of the machine that I'm
currently in if you see this this is
nothing but our this cop server this is
now from here I'm trying to get into
this Master box all right so if you see
the IP address has changed I was in a
different box I'm in a different box now
if I see host name you'll find our
different host name so this is 153 which
is nothing but the master note yep
that's 153 this is the particular host
so I'm getting into this machine now so
I started the cluster from my cop server
here it ran and brought up three nodes
so I'm actually getting into my master
node and see if I can run some parts on
it alright so let me try cubic CTL get
cluster info right Cube CTL get nodes
all right so there are three nodes here
Master node and one master node and two
worker nodes so let me see if I have
some pods here give a CDL get pods so
there's no pod as of now so what I'll
try to do is let me just spin up a very
very simple Pawn just to check if my
connections is everything is correct or
not correct I have a simple node.js
application that I've built and I've got
a container for that this is already
pushed to the docker up registered is
called simply run Docker Hub and the
image name that I have here is called my
node app and I will use this image to
power one of my parts that I will run so
this is the way in which I am going to
launch my pod let me show you these
commands qctl run the name for my
deployment that I'm going to run hyphen
iPhone image and this is the image that
is going to be powering my container so
this is simply learn Docker Hub forward
slash my node app hyphen F1 replica is
equal to I want two replicas to be
running and the port that I want to
expose this particular pod is on 8080.
so let me run this as soon as this is
run it creates something called as a
deployment all right now let me just say
I'm not really interested in the
deployment I am interested in checking
effect all the parts are up and running
so I will say Cube CTL get what all
right so that was pretty fast so I have
two parts that are running here these
are two replicas because I asked for two
replicas these parts are running so I
can run Cube CTL describe pod pickup all
right I can pick up any of the name and
see what is the Pod what is the
information does it contain from what is
the image that is pulling what is the
image image Name ID this is actually
running my thought which is actually
spinning up a container great so first
of good so in kubernetes the pods can
are ephemeral so they can be there at
any time cannot be runtime if I need to
expose my pot outside I will have to
create a service for my pod so what I'll
do is I'll create a very very simple
service by exposing this particular
deployment before that you check Cube
CDL get deployment so there's a
deployment that is created the
deployment name is simply in an app so I
will expose my deployment simply learn
app as
um yeah I'll just expose this let me see
all right I'm not specifying what type
and all I don't want to get into the
complications of what are the different
types of exposing this service and all
that stuff so if I don't specify
anything it gives me something closer
cluster ID so this is where my pod is
actually exposed so let me just check if
at all this pod is up and running I'll
just try a simple curl command curl HTTP
colon this is my cluster IP and the port
is 880. if at all I hit this it's
actually hitting my application and
giving me uh whatever I put a simple uh
sys dot out kind of a thing where I'm
just printing
um the container ID of whatever pod is
serving uh being served out of so I'm
actually eating my container and I'm
getting this output from the content so
everything looks good my content is up
and running so let me just go and clean
it up I will say Cube CTL delete
deployment simply long app this should
get rid of all the parts that I created
Cube CTL get pod all right these parts
are interminating things let me just
check Cube CTL get Services there's one
service I don't want this service let me
delete that keep CTL delete service on
this all right this sounds good so let
me come back to my host my cop server
from where I'm running so I managed to
successfully verify this part see if
everything is is up and running so what
I'll do is I'll just go ahead and
complete this demo by going and getting
rid of my cluster so cops delete cluster
hyphen iPhone yes all right so this will
ensure that it will clean up my complete
cluster that I created so I had three or
four running instances if you see that
all the three are shutting down because
you know the cop server which had cops
installed on it has now got a mandate to
go ahead and shut down and clean up the
whole instances and all those things
that are created as a part of my
deployment today I'm going to tell you
how you can become an AWS Solutions
architect so who is an aw Solutions
architect now the main role of an aw
Solutions architect is to help you
deploy your applications on the AWS
platform now this is nothing but a cloud
computing platform so it's not to say
that you can't deploy your applications
on the cloud computing platform yourself
it's just that when it comes to
organizations the applications that you
need to deploy become a whole lot more
complex that's where an AWS Solutions
okay attack can help ever since cloud
computing became a thing companies
around the world have started migrating
their physical infrastructure onto the
cloud that's what an AWS Solutions
architect does they help you migrate
your physical infrastructure onto the
AWS Cloud companies around the world
work on a budget and an aw Solutions
architect will help design a cloud
infrastructure based on the
organization's budget before that can be
done however an aw Solutions architect
has to create a design with an intricate
and detailed blueprint of the cloud
infrastructure that they plan to set up
now aw Solutions Architects also have to
focus mainly on non-functional
requirements like usability reliability
scalability and performance of the cloud
infrastructure they're also responsible
when it comes to minimizing risks that
an organization can face when it comes
to cloud computing platforms now they
could face risks like security leaks
calculation mistakes and application
downtimes and AWS Solutions architect
has to ensure that these don't happen
before we can talk about how you can
become an aw Solutions architect I have
some exciting news for you guys we've
launched our own YouTube Community
you'll get to see a lot of quizzes polls
offers and much more to make your
learning experience a whole lot more fun
you can find all of this on your
subscription feed or you can also click
on the top right corner right now to get
started and let's get back to how can
you become an aw Solutions architect now
to become an aw certified Solutions
architect you need to clear the AWS
certified Solutions architect associate
level examination now here's some
details about it the exam score ranges
from 100 to thousand marks and the
minimum passing score is 720. however
there's a catch the passing marks are
actually set using statistical analysis
so they can be changed based on how
difficult the examination actually is
the exam fee is 150 dollars and you can
also take a practice examination which
costs 20 dollars now regardless of the
examination you take be IT solutions
architect sysops administrator or
developer any associate level
examination costs 150 dollars for the
professional level examination it's
three hundred dollars now if you want to
learn more about the AWS certifications
I suggest you click on the top right
corner and watch our video aw
certifications in 10 minutes to learn
more now the exam duration is of 130
minutes and you have two types of
questions multiple choice and multiple
answer now the multiple choice questions
have four options out which one of them
is right and you have multiple answer
where you have five options out of which
two of them are correct you can take the
examination in English Japanese Korean
and simplify Chinese now let's talk
about how you can schedule an
examination first let's go to Google and
search for AWS certifications
click on the first link
so on this page you can go to the bottom
and find the different certifications
AWS provides click on architect
and select the AWS certified Solutions
architect associate certification
click on register now
and here you need to click on the aw
certification account
you can sign in with your Amazon account
or create a new one
I already have an Amazon account that
I'll be using for signing in here in
case you don't you can click on the
create your Amazon account button here
and create an account for yourself
now after that is done you can schedule
new examination
and you can scroll down to the bottom
here aw certified Solutions architect
associate level certification
click on schedule exam
press continue
and here you need to select your
language
which I'm assuming is English
I'm from India so I don't need to change
anything here but you can change your
country or time zone and other details
based on your requirement and select
your preferred month I want to do it in
October
now select search for Exam Center
select the one that's closest to you
I'm going to select this one
and here you can select the day that you
want to take your test and the time
available I want to do it on 15. select
the time that I want
and press continue
now you can go through all the details
here change them if you want to
otherwise you can press continue
after this is done
close
and here we have the final step which is
the fees
you can enter your details here
and pay now to finish the process now
let's look at an outline of the exam
content now what you're going to see in
the exam are five major domains and here
you have each of the domains with their
respective weightages first you have a
34 designing resilient architectures at
24 you have both defining performant
architectures and specifying secure
applications and architectures a 10
person you have designing cost optimized
architectures and at six percent you
have defining operationally excellent
architectures now let's look at each of
these domains in detail now the first
domain or design resilient architectures
can be divided into four parts firstly
you need to know how you can choose
reliable or resilient storage using
services like AWS S3 AWS Glacier and AWS
EBS then you have how you can design
decoupling mechanisms using AWS Services
now this is possible with the help of
AWS SNS now these aren't the only
services that enable this these are just
some of the services then how you can
design a multi-tier architecture
solution now this is important because
you need to know how you can create a
solution that involves several other
services then you need to know how you
can design highly available and fall
tolerant architectures now for the
second domain defining performance
architectures first you have how to
choose performance storages and
databases services that are used are AWS
RDS AWS threadshift and AWS dynamodb the
second step is how you can apply caching
to improve performance a service that
can be used for this is AWS elastic
cache third how you can design Solutions
with elasticity and scalability you have
AWS Lambda AWS cloudwatch and AWS data
pipeline now for the third domain which
is specifying secure applications and
architectures you need to know how you
can secure applications using services
like AWS inspector AWS cloudtrail and
AWS iaf you need to know how to secure
data using Cloud HSM and AWS Macy and
how you can Define the networking
infrastructure using cloudfront VPC and
elastic load balancer for the fourth
domain you have designing cost optimized
architectures firstly you need to know
how you can design cost optimized
compute Solutions you can use AWS ec2
plastic bean stock Lambda and AWS light
sail then you need to know how you can
design cost optimized Storage Solutions
using AWS S3 Glacier EBS and elastic
file system and the final domain to
define operationally excellent
architectures you need to set up design
features and solutions that enable
operational excellence now some of the
features are that you perform operations
as code you annotate documentation you
make frequent and small reversible
changes and anticipate and Tackle
failures now let's have a look at the
job opportunities when it comes to AWS
Solutions architects now if you have a
look at this graph you can see that AWS
has always provided a lot more job
postings as compared to the other two
giants in the cloud computing domain
which are Microsoft Azure and Google
Cloud platform now if you do a little
bit of research you'll find out that
there's a significant lacking of
experienced Personnel when it comes to
AWS so I would suggest this is the best
time for you to get certified in AWS so
how can simply learn help you with your
AWS certifications now we're on the
sampling on home page
and here we have the AWS Solutions
architect course
on this course which is the AWS
Solutions architect certification
training course we have 36 hours of
instructor-led training 20 hours of
self-paced learning 16 live demos three
simulation exams three Hands-On practice
projects and so much more here our main
emphasis is on making sure that you have
enough hands-on experience with the
services that you crack the examination
at your first attempt
so here we also go through some of the
more important services that you need to
learn like IAM VPC ec2 S3 and so much
more we'll also talk about databases
application Services security practices
disaster recovery and so on we even have
practice examinations to help you
prepare for the real one choose from
over 300 in-demand skills and get access
to 1 000 Plus hours of video content for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more I'm here to walk you through some
of the AWS interview questions which we
find are important and our hope is that
you would use this material in your
interview preparation and be able to
crack that cloud interview and step into
your dream Cloud job by the way I'm and
Cloud technical architect trainer and an
interview panelist for cloud Network and
devops so as you progress in watching
are you gonna see that these questions
are practical scenario based questions
that tests the depth of the knowledge of
a person in a particular AWS product or
in a particular AWS architecture so why
wait let's move on all right so in an
interview you would find yourself with a
question that might ask you define and
explain the three basic types of cloud
services and the AWS products that are
built based on them see here it's a very
straightforward question just explain
three basic types of cloud service and
when we talk about basic type of cloud
service it's compute obviously that's a
very basic service storage obviously
because you need to store your data
somewhere and networking that actually
connects a couple of other services to
your application this basic will not
include monitoring these basic will not
include analytics because they are
considered as optional they are
considered as Advanced Services you
could choose a non-cloud server service
or a product for monitoring of and for
analytics so they're not considered as
basic so when we talk about Basics they
are compute storage and networking and
the second part of the question says
explain some of the AWS products that
are built based on them of course
compute ec2 is a major one that's that's
the major share of the compute resource
and then we have platform as a service
which is elastic bean stock and then
function as a service which is Lambda
Auto scaling and light cell are also
part of compute services so the compute
domain it really helps us to run any
application and the compute service
helps us in managing the scaling and
deployment of an application again
Lambda is a compute service so the
compute service also helps in running
event initiated stateless applications
the next one was storage a lot of
emphasis is on storage these days
because if there is one thing that grows
in a network on a daily basis that
storage every new day we have new data
to store process manage so storage is
again a basic and an important cloud
service and the products that are built
based on the storage services are S3
object storage Glacier for archiving EBS
elastic block storage as a drive
attachment for the ec2 instances and the
EFS file share for the ec2 instances so
the storage domain helps in the
following aspects it holds all the
information that the application uses so
it's the application data and we can
also archive old data using storage
which would be Glacier and any object
files and any requirement for Block
storage can be met through elastic blog
store and S3 which is again an object
storage talking about networks it's just
not important to answer the question
with the name of the services and the
name of the product it'll also be good
if you could go in depth and explain how
they can be used right so that actually
proves you to be a person knowledgeable
enough in that particular service or
product so talking about networking
domain VPC networking can't imagine
networking without VPC in in the cloud
environment especially in AWS Cloud
environment and then we have Route 53
for domain resolution or for DNS and
then we have cloudfront which is an edge
caching service that helps customers get
our customers to read their application
with low latency so networking domain
helps with some of the following use
cases it controls and manages the
connectivity of the AWS services within
our account and we can also pick an IP
address range if you're a network
engineer or if you are somebody who
works in networks or are planning to
work a network you will soon realize the
importance of choosing your own IP
address for easy remembering so having
an option to have your own IP address in
the cloud owned Range of IP address in
the cloud it really helps really really
helps in Cloud networking the other
question that get asked would be the
difference between the availability Zone
and the region actually the question
generally gets asked so to test how well
you can actually differentiate and also
correlate the availability Zone and the
region relationship right so a region is
a separate geographic area like the
us2s1 I mean which represents not
California or the AP South which
represents Mumbai so regions are a
separate geographic area on the contrary
availability Zone resides inside the
region you shouldn't stop there you
should go further and explain about
availability zones and availability
zones are isolated from each other and
some of the services will replicate
themselves within the available T-Zone
so availability Zone does replication
within them but regions they don't
generally do replication between them
the other question you could be asked is
what is order scaling what do we
achieved by Auto scaling so in short
Auto scaling it helps us to
automatically provision and launch new
instances Whenever there is an demand it
not only helps us meeting the increasing
demand it also helps in reducing the
resource usage when there is low demand
so Auto scaling also allows us to
decrease the resources or resource
capacity as per the need of that
particular R now this helps business in
not worrying about putting more effort
in managing or continuously monitoring
the server to see if they have the
needed resource or not because Auto
scaling is gonna handle it for us so
business does not need to worry about it
and auto scaling is one big reason and
why people would want to go and pick a
cloud service especially in AWS service
the ability to increase and Shrink based
on the need of that art that's how
powerful is auto scaling the other
question you could get asked is what's
geo-targeting in Cloud front now we know
that cloudfront is caching and it caches
content globally in the Amazon caching
service Global wide the whole point is
to provide users worldwide access to the
data from a very nearest server possible
that's the whole point in using or going
for cloudfront then what do you mean by
Geo targeting Geo targeting is showing
customer and specific content based on
language we can customize the content
based on what's popular in that place we
can actually customize the content the
URL is the same but we could actually
change the content a little bit not the
whole content otherwise it would be
dynamic but we can change the content a
little bit a specific a file or a
picture or a particular Link in a
website and show customized content to
users who will be in different parts of
the globe so how does it happen
cloudfront will detect the country where
the viewers are located and it will
forward the country code to the origin
server and once the origin server gets
the specialized or a specific country
code it will change the content and it
will send to the caching server and it
get cached there forever and the user
gets to view a Content which is
personalized for them for the country
they are in the other question you could
get asked is the steps involved in using
cloud formation or creating a cloud
formation or a backing up an environment
within cloud formation template we all
know that if there is a template we can
simply run it and it Provisions the
environment but there is a lot more
going into it so the first step in
moving towards infrastructure as a code
is to create the cloud formation
template which as of now supports Json
and yaml file format so first create the
cloud formation template and then save
the code in an S3 bucket S3 bucket
serves as the repository for our code
and then from the cloud formation call
the file in the S3 bucket and create a
stack and now cloud formation uses the
file reads the file understands services
that are being called understands the
order understands how they are connected
with each other cloud formation is
actually an intelligent service it
understands the relation based on the
code it would understand the
relationship between the different
services and it would set an order for
itself and then would provision the
services one after the other let's say a
service has a dependency and the
dependent service the other service
which This Server service let's say it
serves A and B service B is dependent on
service a let's say cloud formation is
an intelligent service it would
provision the resource a first and then
would provision resource B what happens
if we inverse the order if we inverse
the order resource B first gets
provision and because it does not have
dependency chances that the cloud
formation's default behavior is that if
something is not provisioned properly if
something is not healthy it would roll
back chances that the environment
provisioning will roll back so to avoid
that cloud formation first Provisions
all the services that has or that's
dependent on that's depended by another
service so it Provisions those service
first and then Provisions the services
that has dependencies and if you are
being hired for a devops or you know if
the interviewer wanted to test your
skill on systems aside this definitely
would be a question in his list how do
you upgrade or downgrade a system with
near zero downtime now everybody is
moving towards zero downtime or near
zero downtime all of them want their
application to be highly available so
the question would be how do you
actually upgrade or downgrade a system
with near zero downtime now we all know
that I can upgrade an ec2 instance to a
better ec2 instance by changing the
instance type stopping and starting but
stopping and starting is gonna cause a
downtime right so that's you should be
answering or you shouldn't be thinking
in those terms because that's the wrong
answer specifically the interviewer
wants to know how do you upgrade a
system with zero downtime so upgrading
system with zero downtime it includes
launching another system parallelly with
the bigger ec2 instance type over the
bigger capacity and install all that's
needed if you are going to use an Ami of
the old machine well and good you don't
have to go through installing all the
updates and installing all the
application from the Ami once you have
launched it in a bigger instance locally
test the application to see if it is
working don't put it on production yet
working and if the application works we
can actually swap if your server is
behind and behind a Route 53 let's say
all that you could do is go to Route 53
update the information with the new IP
address new IP address of the new server
and that's going to send traffic to the
new server now so the cutover is handled
or if you're using static IP you can
actually remove the static IP from the
old machine and assign it to the new
machine that's one way of doing it or if
you are using elastic Nik card you can
actually remove the new card from the
old machine and attach the new cards to
the new machine so that way we would get
near zero downtime if you're hired for
an architect level you should be
worrying about cost as well along with
the technology and this question would
test how well you manage cost so what
are the tools and techniques we can use
in AWS to identify and correct identify
and know that we are paying the correct
amount for the resources that we are
using or how do you get a visibility of
your AWS resources running one way is to
check the billing there's a place where
you can check the top services that were
utilized it could be free and it could
be paid Service as well top services
that can be utilized it's actually in
the dashboard of the cost Management
console so that table here shows the top
five most used services so looking at it
you can get it all right so I'm using a
lot of storage I'm using a lot of ec2
why is storage high you can go and try
to justify that and you will find if you
are storing things that shouldn't be
storing then click clean it up why is
compute capacity so high why is data
transfer so high so if you start
thinking in those levels you'll be able
to dig in and clean up unnecessary and
be able to save your bill and there are
cost Explorer services available which
will help you to view your usage pattern
or view your spending for the past 13
months or so and it will also forecast
for the next three months now how much
will you be using if your pattern is
like this so that will actually help and
will give you a visibility on how much
you have spent how much you will be
spending if the trend continues budgets
are another excellent a way to control
cost you can actually set up budget all
that this is how much I am willing to
spend for this application for this team
or for this month for this particular
resource so you can actually put a
budget Mark and anytime it exceeds
anytime it's nearing you would get an
alarm saying that well we're about to
reach the allocate added budget amount
stuff like that that way you can go back
and know and you know that how much the
bill is going to be for that month or
you can take steps to control bill
amount for that particular month so AWS
budget is another very good tool that
you could use cost allocation tags helps
in identifying which team or which
resource has spent more in that
particular month instead of looking at
the bill as one list with no
specifications into it and looking at it
as an expenditure list you can actually
break it down and tag the expenditure to
the teams with cost allocation tags the
dev team has spent so much the
production team has spent so much the
training team has spent more than the
dev and the production team why is that
you'll be able to you know think in
those levels only if you have cost
allocation tags now cost allocation tags
are nothing but the tags that you would
put when you create a resource so for
Production Services you would put as a
production you would create a production
tag and you would associate that
resources to it and at a later point
when you actually pull up your bill
that's going to show a detailed a list
of this is the owner this is the group
and this is how much they have used in
the last month and you can move forward
with your investigation and encourage or
stop users using more services with the
cost allocation tax the other famous
question is are there any other tools or
is there any other way of accessing AWS
resource other than the console console
is GUI right so in other words other
than GUI how would you use the AWS
resource and how familiar are you with
those tools and Technologies the other
tools that are available that we can
leverage and access the AWS resource are
of course footy you can configure Puri
to access the AWS resources like log
into an ec2 instance an ec2 instance
does not always have to be logged in
through the console you could use putty
to log into an ec2 instance and like the
jump box like the proxy machine and like
the Gateway machine and from there you
can actually access the rest of the
resources so this is an alternative to
the console and of course we have the
AWS CLI in any of the Linux machines or
Windows machines we can install so
that's 0.23 and 4. we can install AWS
CLI for Linux Windows also for Mac so we
can install them and from there from a
local machine we can access run AWS
commands and access provision monitor
the AWS resources the other ones are we
can access the AWS resource
programmatically using AWS SDK and
Eclipse so these are a bunch of options
we have to use the AWS resource other
than the console if you are interviewed
in a company or buy a company that
focuses more on security and want to use
AWS native services for their security
then you will come across this question
what services can be used to create a
centralized logging solution the basic
Services we could use are cloudwatch
logs store them in S3 and then use
elasticsearch to visualize them and use
Kinesis to move the data from S3 to
elasticsearch right so log management it
actually helps organizations to track
the relationship between operational and
security changes and the events that got
triggered based on those logs instead of
logging into an instance or instead of
logging into the environment and
checking the resources physically I can
come to a fair conclusion by just
looking at the logs every time there's a
change the system would scream and it
gets tracked in the cloud watch and then
Cloud watch pushes it to S3 Kinesis
pushes the data from S3 to elasticsearch
and I can do a Time based filter and I
would get an a fair understanding of
what was going on in the environment for
the past one hour or whatever the time
window that I wanted to look at so it
helps in getting a good understanding of
the infrastructure as a whole all the
logs are getting saved in one place so
all the infrastructure logs are getting
saved in one place so it's easy for me
to look at it in an infrastructure
perspective so we know the services that
can be used and here are some of the
services and how they actually connect
to each other it could be logs that
belongs to One account it could be logs
that belongs to multiple accounts that
doesn't matter you know those three
services are gonna work fairly good and
they're gonna inject or they're gonna
like suck logs from the other accounts
put it in one place and help us to
monitor so as you see you have Cloud
watch here that actually tracks the
metrics you can also use cloud trail if
you want to log API calls as well push
them in an S3 bucket so there are
different types of blog flow logs are
getting captured in an instance
application logs are getting captured
from the same VPC from a different VPC
from the same account from a different
account and all of them are analyzed
using elasticsearch using the kibana
client so step one is to deploy the ECS
cluster step two is to restrict access
to the ECS cluster because it's valid
data you don't want anybody to put their
hands and access their data so restrict
access to the ECS dashboard and we could
use Lambda also to push the data from
cloud watch to The elasticsearch Domain
and then hibana is actually the
graphical tool that helps us to
visualize the logs instead of looking at
log as just statements or a bunch of
characters a bunch of files kibana helps
us to analyze the logs in a graphical or
a chart or a bar diagram format again in
an interview the interview is more
concerned about testing your knowledge
on AWS security products especially on
the logging monitoring even management
or Incident Management then you could
have a question like this what are the
native AWS security logging capabilities
now most of the services have their own
logging in them like have their own
logging like S3 S3 has its own login and
cloudfront has its own logging DS has
its own logging VPC has its own logging
in additional there are account level
logins like a cloudtrail and AWS config
services so there are variety of logging
options available in the AWS like Cloud
soil config cloudfront redshift logging
RDS logging VPC flow logs S3 object
login S3 access logging stuff like that
so we're going to look at two servers in
specific cloudtrail now this cloud trail
the very first product in that picture
we just are the cloudtrail provides an
very high level history of the API calls
for all the account and with that we can
actually perform a very good security
analysis a security analysis of our
account and these logs are actually
delivered to you can configure it they
can be delivered to S3 for long time
archivals and based on a particular
event it can also send an email
notification to us saying hey just got
this error thought I'll let you know
stuff like that the other one is config
service now config service helps us to
understand the configuration changes
that happened in our environment and we
can also set up notifications based on
the configuration changes so it records
the cumulative changes that are made in
a short period of time so if you want to
go through the lifetime of a particular
resource what are the things that happen
what are the things it went through they
can be looked at using aw us config all
right the other question you could get
asked is if you know your role includes
taking care of cloud security as well
then the other question you could get
asked is the native services that Amazon
provides automaticate DDOS which is
denial of service now not all companies
would go with Amazon native services but
there are some companies which want to
stick with Amazon native Services just
to save them from the headache of
managing the other softwares or bringing
in another tool a third-party tool into
managing DDOS they simply want to stick
with Amazon proprietary Amazon native
services and a lot of companies are
using Amazon service to prevent DDOS
denial of service now denial of service
is if you already know what denial of
service is well and good if you do not
know then let's know it now denial of
service is a user trying to or
maliciously making attempt to access a
website or an application the user would
actually create multiple sessions and he
would occupy all the sessions and he
would not let legimate users access the
servers so he's in turn denying the
service for the user a quick picture
review of what denial of services now
look at it these users instead of making
one connection they are making multiple
connections and there are cheap software
programs available that would actually
trigger connections from different
computers in Internet with different Mac
addresses so everything kind of looks
legitimate for the server and it would
accept those connections and it will
keep the sessions open the actual users
won't be able to use them so that's
denying the service for the actual users
denial of service all right and
distributed denial of service is
generating a tax from multiple places
you know from a distributed environment
so that's distributed denial of service
so the tools the native tools that helps
us to provide event the denial of
service attacks in AWS is cloud shield
and web access firewall AWS web now they
are the major ones they are designed to
mitigate a denial of service if your
website is often bothered by denial of
service then we should be using AWS
Shield or AWS Waf and there are a couple
of other tools that all showed us when I
say that also does denial of service is
not their primary job but you could use
them for denial of service route 53's
purpose is to provide DNS cloudfront is
to provide caching elastic load balancer
elb's work is to provide load balancing
VPC is to create and secure a virtual
private environment but they also
support mitigating denial of service but
not to the extent you would get in AWS
shield and AWS web so AWS shield and Waf
are the primary ones but the rest can
also be used to mitigate distributed
denial of service the other tricky
question is this actually will test your
familiarity with the region and the
services available in the region so when
you're trying to provision a service in
a particular region you're not seeing
the service in that region how do we go
about fixing it or how do we go about
using the service in the cloud it's a
tricky question and if you have not gone
through such situation you can totally
blow it away you really need to have a
good understanding on regions the
services available in those regions and
what a particular service is not
available how to go about doing it the
answer is not all services are available
in all regions anytime Amazon announces
a new service they don't immediately
publish them on all regions they start
small and as in when the traffic
increases as and when it becomes more
likeable to the customers they actually
move the service to different regions so
as you see in this picture within
America North Virginia has has more
services compared to Ohio or Compared to
North California So within not America
itself North Virginia is the preferred
one so similarly there are preferred
regions within Europe Middle East and
Africa and prefer regions within Asia
Pacific so anytime we don't see a
service in a particular region chances
that the service is not available in
that region yet we got to check the
documentation and find the nearest
region that offers that service and
start using the service from that region
now you might think well if I'm looking
for a service in Asia let's say in
Mumbai and if it is not available why
not simply switch to North Virginia and
start using it you could but you know
that's going to add more latency to your
application so that's why we need to
check for application which is check for
region which is very near to the place
where you want to serve your customers
and find nearest region instead of
always going back to North Virginia and
deploying an application in North
Virginia again let's is a place there's
a link in aws.com that you can go and
look for services available in different
region and that's exactly what you're
seeing here and if your service is not
available in a particular region switch
to the other region that provides your
service the nearest other region that
provides that service and start using
service from there with the coming up of
cloud a lot of companies have turned
down their monitoring team instead they
want to go with the monitorings that
cloud provides you know nobody wants to
or at least many people don't want to go
through the hassle of at least new
startups and new companies that are
thinking of having a monitoring
environment that they don't want to go
with traditional knock monitoring
instead they would like to leverage AWS
monitorings available because it
monitors a lot of stuff not just the
availability but it monitors a lot of
stuff like failures errors it also
triggers emails stuff like that so how
do you actually set up a monitor to
website I mean how to set up a Monitor
to Monitor the website metrics in real
time in AWS the simple way anytime you
have a question about monitoring
cloudwatch should strike your mind
because cloudwatch is meant for
monitoring it is meant for collecting
metrics is is meant for providing
graphical representation of what's going
on in a particular Network at a
particular point of time so cloudwatch
cloudwatch helps us to monitor
applications and using cloudwatch we can
monitor the state changes not only the
state changes the auto scaling life
cycle events anytime there are more
services added there is a reduction in
the number of servers because of less
usage and very informative messages can
be received through cloudwatch any
cloudwatch can now support scheduled
events if you want to schedule anything
cloudwatch has an event that would
schedule an action all right schedule a
Trigger Time based not incident based
you know anything happening and then you
get an action happening that's incident
based on the other hand you can simply
schedule few things on time based so
that's possible with Cloud watch So This
Cloud watch integrates very well with a
lot of other services like notifications
for notifying the user or for notifying
the administrator about it and it can
integrate well with Lambda so to trigger
an action anytime you're designing an
auto healing environment This Cloud
watch can actually monitor and send an
email if we are integrating it with SNS
simple notification service or this
Cloud watch can monitor and based on
what's Happening it can trigger an event
in Lambda and that would in turn run a
function till the environment comes back
to normal so cloudwatch integrates well
with a lot of other AWS Services all
right so cloudwatch has three statuses
green when everything is going good
hello when the service is degraded and
red when the service is not available
green is good so we don't have to do
anything about it but anytime there's an
Lo the picture that we're looking at
it's actually calling an Lambda function
to debug the application and to fix it
and anytime there's a red alert it
immediately notifies the owner of the
application about well this service is
down and here is the report that I have
here is the metrics that I've collected
about the service stuff like that if the
job role requires you to manage the
servers as well there are certain job
roles which are on the system side there
are certain job roles which is
development plus system side now you're
responsible for the application and the
server as well so if that's the case you
might be tested with some basic
questions like the different types of
virtualization and AWS and what are the
difference between them all right the
three major types of virtualization are
hvm which is Hardware virtual machine
the other one is PV para virtualization
and the third one is PV on hvm para
virtualization on Hardware virtual
module all right the difference between
them are actually describing them is
actually the difference between them hvm
it's actually a fully virtualized
Hardware you know the whole Hardware is
virtualized and all virtual machines act
separate from each other and these VMS
are booted by executing Master boot
record in the root block and when we
talk about para virtualization paragraph
is actually the special boot loader
which boots the PV Amis and when we talk
about PV on hvm it's it's actually the
marriage between hvm and PV and this
para virtualization on hvm in other
words PV on hvm it actually helps
operating system take advantage in
storage and the network input output
available through the host another good
question is name some of the services
that are not region specific now you've
been thought that all services are
within a region and some services are
within an availability zone for example
ec2 is within an availability Zone EBS
is within an availability Zone S3 is
region specific dynamodb is region
specific stuff like that VPC is both
availability and region specific meaning
you know subnets are availability Zone
specific and vpc's region specific stuff
like that so you might have thought you
might have learned in that combination
but that could be some tricky questions
that tests you how well you have
understood the region non-region and
availability non-availability Services I
should say there are services that are
not region specific that would be IAM so
we can't have IAM for every availability
Zone and for every region which means
you know users will have to use one
username and password for one region and
anytime they switch to another region
they will have to use another username
and password that that's more work and
that's not a good design as well
authentication has to be Global so IM is
a global Service and which means it's
not region specific on the other hand
Route 53 is again a regional Pacific so
we can't have a Route 53 for every
region Route 53 is not a region specific
service it's a global Service and it's
one application users access from
everywhere or from every part of the
world so we can't have one URL or one
DNS name for each region if your
application is a global application and
then web application firewall works well
with cloudfront then cloudfront is a
region based service so the web
application firewall it's not region
specific service it's a global Service
and cloudfront is again a global Service
though you can you know cache content on
a continent and country basis it's still
considered a global Service right it's
not bound to any region so when you
activate cloudfront you're activating it
away from region or availability zone so
when you're activating a web application
firewall because it's not a region
specific service you're activating it
away from availability Zone and regions
so a quick recap I am users groups roles
and accounts they are Global Services
they can be used globally around 53
services are offered at Edge locations
and they are Global as well web
application firewall a service that
protects our web application from common
web exploits they are Global Services
well cloudfront cloudfront is global
content delivery Network CDN and they
are offered at Edge locations which are
a global Service in other words
non-region specific service or Beyond
region service all right this is another
good question as well in the project
that you are being interviewed if they
really want to secure their environment
using Nat or if they are already
securing their environment using Nat by
any of these two methods like Nat
Gateway or Nat instances you can expect
this question what are the difference
between a Nat Gateway and Nat instances
now they both saw the same thing right
so they're not two different Services
trying to achieve two different things
they both serve the same thing but still
they do have differences in them all
right on a high level they both achieve
providing nothing for the service behind
it but the difference comes when we talk
about the availability of it not Gateway
is a managed service by Amazon whereas
Nat instance is managed by us now I'm
talking about the third Point
maintenance here not Gateway is managed
by Amazon that instance is managed by us
and availability of nat Gateway is very
high and availability of nat instance is
less compared to the NAT Gateway because
it's managed by us you know it's on an
ec2 instance which could actually fail
and if it fails we'll have to relaunch
it but if it is not Gateway if something
happens to that service Amazon would
take care of reprovisioning it and
talking about bandwidth it can burst up
to 75 gigabits now traffic through the
nag Gateway can burst up to 75 gigabits
but for that instance it actually
depends on the server that we launch and
if we are launching a T2 micro it barely
gets any bandwidth so there's a
difference there and the performance
because it's highly available because of
the bigger pipe 75 gigabits now the
performance of the NAT Gateway is very
high but the performance of the NAT
instance is going to be average again it
depends on the size of the NAT instance
that we pick and billing a billing for
Nat Gateway is the number of gateways
that we provision and the duration for
which we use the NAT Gateway but billing
for not instance is number of instance
and the type of instance that we use of
course number of instance duration and
the type of instance that we use
Security in that Gateway cannot be
assigned meaning it already comes with
full backed security but but in that
instance security is a bit customizable
I can go and change the security because
it's a server managed by me or managed
by us I can always change the security
well allow this allow don't allow this
stuff like that size and load of the NAT
Gateway is uniform but the size and the
load of the NAT instance changes as per
around Gateway is a fixed product but
not instance can be small instance can
be a big instance so the size and the
load through it varies
right the other question you could get
asked is what are the difference between
stopping and terminating an ec2 instance
now you will be able to answer only if
you have worked on environments where
you have your instance stopped and where
you have your instance terminated if you
have only used lab and are attending the
interview chances are that you might you
always lost when answering this question
it might look like both are the same
well stopping and terminating both are
the same but there is a difference in it
so when you stop an instance it actually
performs a normal shutdown on the
instance and it simply moves the
instance to the stop state but when you
actually terminate the instance the
instance is moved to this stop State the
EBS volumes that are attached to it are
deleted and removed and will never be
able to recover them again so that's a
big difference between stopping and
terminating an instance if you're
thinking of using the instance again
along with the data in it you should
only be thinking of stopping the
instance but you should be terminating
the instance only if you want to get rid
of that instance forever
if you are being interviewed for an
architect level position or a junior
architect level position or even an
Cloud consultant level position or even
in an engineering position this is a
very common question that get asked what
are the different types of ec2 instances
based on their cost or based on how we
pay them right they're all compute
capacity for example the different types
are on the balance tenses Port instances
and reserved instances it kind of looks
the same they all provide the compute
capacity they all provide the same type
of Hardwares for us but if you are
looking at Cost saving or optimizing
cost in our environment we're going to
be very careful about which one are we
picking now we might think that well
I'll go with on-demand instance because
I pay on a per hour basis which is cheap
you know I can use them anytime I want
and anytime I don't want I can simply
get rid of it by terminating it you're
right but if the requirement is to use
the service for one year the requirement
is to use the service for three years
then you'll be wasting a lot of money
buying on-demand instances you'll be
wasting a lot of money paying on an
hourly basis instead we should be going
for reserved instance where we can
reserve the capacity for the complete
one year or complete three years and
save huge amount in buying reserved
instances alright so on-demand is cheap
to start with if you are only planning
to use it for a short while but if
you're planning to run it for a long
while then we should be going for
reserved instance that is what is cost
efficient so spot instance is cheaper
than on-demand instance and there are
different use cases for spot instance as
well so let's look at one after the
other the on-demand instance the
on-demand instance is purchased at a
fixed rate per hour this is very short
term and irregular workloads and for
testing for development on demand
instance is a very good use case we
should be using on-demand for production
spot instance spot instance allows users
to purchase ec2 at a reduced price and
anytime we have more instances we can
always go and sell it in spot instances
I'm referring to anytime we have more
reserved instances we can always sell
them in spot instance catalog and the
way we buy Spot instance is we actually
put a budget this is how much I'm
willing to pay all right would you be
able to give service within this cost so
anytime the price comes down and meets
the cost that we have put in will be
assigned an instance and anytime the
price shoots up the instance will be
taken away from us but in case of
on-demand instances we have bought that
instance for that particular R and it
stays with us but with spot instances it
varies based on the price if you meet
the price you get the instance if you
don't meet the price it goes away to
somebody else and the spot instance
availability is actually based on supply
and demand in the market there's no
guarantee that you will get support
instance at all time all right so that's
a caveat there you should be familiar
with that's a caveat there you should be
aware when you are proposing somebody
that we can go for spot instance and
save money it's not always going to be
available if you want your spot instance
to be available to you then we need to
carefully watch the history of the price
of the spot instance now how much was it
last month and how much was it how much
is it this month so how can I code or
how much can I code stuff like that so
you got to look at those history before
you propose somebody that well we're
going to save money using spot instance
on the other hand reserved instance
provide cost savings for the company or
we can opt for reserved instances for
you know one year or three years there
are actually three types of reserved
instances light medium and heavy
reserved instances they are based on the
amount that we would be paying and cost
benefit also depends with reserved
instance the cost benefit also depends
based on are we doing all upfront or no
upfront or partial payment then split
the rest as monthly payments so there
are many purchase options available but
overall if you're looking at using an
application for the next one year and
three years you should not be going for
on-demand instance you should be going
for reserved instance and that's what
gives you the cost benefit
and in an AWS interview sometimes you
might be asked you know how you interact
with the AWS environment are you using
CLI are you using console and depending
on your answer whether console or a CLI
the panelist put a score okay this
person is CLI specific this person is
console specific or this person has used
AWS environment through the SDK stuff
like that so this question tests whether
you are a CLI person or a console person
and the question goes like this how do
you set up SSH agent forwarding so that
you do not have to copy the key every
time you log in if you have used Puri
anytime if you want to log into an ec2
instance you will have to put the IP and
the port number along with that you will
have to map or we will have to map the
key in the Puri and this has to be done
every time that's what we would have
done in our lab environments right but
in production environment using the same
key or mapping the same key again and
again every time it's actually an hassle
it's concerned as a blocker so you might
want to Cache it you might want to
permanently add it in your putty session
so you can immediately log in and start
using it so here in the place where you
would actually map the private key
there's a quick button that actually
fixes or that actually binds your SSH to
your pretty instance so we can enable
SSH agent forwarding and that will
actually bind our key to the SSH and
next time when we try to log in we don't
have to always go through mapping the
key and trying to log in all right this
question what are solar is and ax
operating systems are they available
with AWS that question generally gets
asked to test how familiar are you with
the Amis available how familiar are you
with ec2 how familiar are you with the
ec2 Hardwares available that basically
tests that now the first question or the
first thought that comes to your mind is
well everything is available with AWS
I've seen Windows I've seen in Ubuntu
I've seen Red Hat I've seen Amazon Amis
and if I don't see my operating system
there I can always go to Marketplace and
try them if I don't final Marketplace I
can always go to community and try them
so a lot of Amis available there are a
lot of operating systems available I
will be able to find Solaris and ax but
that's not the case Solaris and ax are
not available with AWS that's because
Solaris uses a different I mean Solaris
does not support the architecture does
not support public Cloud currently the
same goes for ax as well they run on
power CPU and not on Intel and as of now
Amazon does not provide Power machines
this should not be confused with HPC
which is a high performance Computing
should not be confused with that now
these are different Hardwares different
CPU itself that the cloud providers did
do not provide yet another question you
could get asked in organizations that
would want to automate the their
infrastructure using Amazon native
Services would be how do you actually
recover an ec2 instance or Auto recover
an ec2 instance when it fails well we
know that ec2 instances are considered
as immutable meaning irreparable we
don't spend time fixing bugs in an OS
stuff like that you know once and ec2
instance crashes like it goes on a OS
Panic or there are various reasons why
it would fail so we don't have to really
worry about fixing it we can always
relaunch that instance and that would
fix it but what if it happens at two
o'clock in the night what if it happens
that during a weekend when nobody is in
office now looking or monitoring those
instances so you would want to automate
that not only on a weekend or during
midnights but it's general practice good
to automate it so you could face this
question how do you actually automate an
ec2 instance once it fails and the
answer to that question is using Cloud
watch we can recover the instance so as
you see there is an alarm threshold a
set in Cloud watch and once the
threshold is met meaning if there is an
error if there is a failure if the ec2
instance is not responding for a certain
while we can set an alarm and once the
alarm is met let's say the CPU
utilization stayed high for 5 minutes
all right it's not taking any new
connections or the instance is not
pinging for five minutes or in this case
it's two minutes it's not pinging so
it's not going to respond connection so
in those cases you would want to
automatically recover that ec2 instance
by rebooting the instance all right now
look at this the take this action
section under the action so there we
have a bunch of options like recover
this instance meaning reboot the
instance so that's how we would recover
the other two options are beyond the
scope of the question but still you can
go ahead and apply just like I'm gonna
do it so the other option to stop the
instance that's very useful when you
want to stop instances that are having
low utilizations nobody's using the
system as of now you don't want them to
be running and wasting the cloud
expenditure so you can actually set an
alarm that stops the ec2 instance that's
having low utilization so somebody was
working in an instance and they left it
without or they forgot to shut down that
instance and it gets I mean they will
only use it again the next day money so
in between there could be like 12 hours
that the system is running idle nobody's
using it and you're paying for it so you
can identify such instances and actually
stop them when the CPU utilization is
low meaning nobody is using it the other
one is to terminate let's say you want
to give system to somebody temporarily
and you don't want them to hand the
system back to you all right this is
actually an idea in other words this is
actually the scenario so you hand over a
system to somebody and when they're done
they're done we can actually terminate
the system so you could instruct the
other person to terminate the system
when they're done and they could forget
and the instance could be running
forever or you can monitor the system
after the specified time is over and you
can terminate the system or best part
you can automate the system termination
so you assign a system to somebody and
then turn on this cloudwatch action to
terminate the instance when the CPU is
low for like two hours meaning they've
already left or CPU is low for 30
minutes meaning they've already left
stuff like that so that's possible and
if you're getting hired for an system
side architect or even on the sysop site
you could face this question what are
the common and different types of Ami
designs there are a lot of AMR designs
the question is the common ones and the
difference between them so the common
ones are the full back Amis and the
other one is just enough OS Ami j e o s
m i and the other one is hybrid type
Amis so let's look at the difference
between them the full backed Ami just
like the name says it's fully baked it's
ready to use Ami and this is the
simplest Ami to deploy can be a bit
expensive it can be a bit a cumbersome
because you'll have to do a lot of work
beforehand you could use the Amis a lot
of planning a lot of thought process
will go into it and the Ami is ready to
use right you hand over the Ami to
somebody and it's ready to use or if you
want to reuse the Ami it's already ready
for you to use so that's full baked Ami
the other one is just enough operating
system Ami just like the name says it
has I mean as you can also see in the
diagram or in the picture it covers a
part of the OS all bootstraps are
already packed properly and the security
monitoring logging and the other stuff
are configured at the time of deployment
or at the time you would be using it so
not much thought process will go in here
the only focus is on choosing the
operating system and what goes the
operating system specific agents or
bootstraps that goes into the operating
system that's all we worry about the
advantage of this is it's flexible
meaning you can choose to install
additional softwares at the time of
deploying but that's going to require an
additional expertise on the person who
will be using the Ami so that's another
overhead there but the advantage is that
it's kind of flexible I can change the
configurations during the time of
deployment the other one is the hybrid
Ami now the hybrid Ami actually falls in
between the fully baked Ami and just
enough operating system options so these
Amis have some features of the big type
and some features of the just enough OS
type so as you see the security
monitoring logging are packed in that
Ami and the runtime environments or
insta installed during the time of a
deployment so this is where the strict
company policies would go into the Ami
company policies like you got to lock
this you got to monitor this these are
the ports that generally gets open in
all the systems stuff like that so they
strictly go into the Ami and sits in an
AMF format and during deployment you
have the flexibility of choosing the
different runtime and the application
that sits in an ec2 instance another
very famous question you would face in
an interview is how can you recover
login to an ec2 instance to which you
lost the key well we know that if the
key is lost we can't recover it there
are some organizations that integrate
their ec2 instances with an ad that's
different all right so you can go and
reset the password in the ad and you
will be able to log into the new
password but here this specific tricky
question is you are using a key to log
in and how do you recover if you have
lost the key generally companies would
have made a backup of the key so we can
pick from the backup but here the
specific question is we have lost the
key literally no backups on the key at
all so how can we log in and we know
that we can't log into the instance
without the key present with us so the
steps to recover is that make the
instance use another key and use that
key to log in once the key is lost it's
lost forever we won't be able to recover
it you can't raise a ticket with Amazon
not possible they're not going to help
it's beyond the scope so make the
instance use another key it's only the
key that's the problem you still have
valid data in it you got to recover the
data it's just a key that's having the
problem so we can actually focus on the
key part alone and change the key and
that will allow us to log in so how do
we do it step by step procedure so first
verify the ec2 config service is running
in that instance if you want you can
actually beforehand install the ec2
config in that service or you can
actually make the easy to config run
through the console just couple of
button clicks and that will make the
easy to configure one in that easy to
instance and then it detach the root
volume for that instance of course it's
going to require a stop and start to
detach the root volume from the instance
attach the root volume to another
instance as a temporary volume or it
could be a temporary instance that
you've launched only to fix this issue
and then login to that instance and to
that particular volume and modify the
configuration file configuration file
modify it to use the new key and then
move the root volume back to its
original position and restart the
instance and now the instance is going
to have the new key and you also have
the new key with which you can log in so
that's how we go ahead and fix it now
let's move on to some product specific
or S3 product specific questions a
general perception is S3 and EBS can be
used interchangeably and the interviewer
would want to test your knowledge on S3
and EVS well EBS uses S3 that's true but
they can't be interchangeably used so
you might face this question what are
some key differences between AWS S3 and
EBS well the differences are S3 is an
object store meaning you can't install
anything in it you can store drive files
but you can't actually install in it
it's not a file system but ABS is a file
system you can install Services I mean
install applications in it and that's
going to run stuff like that and talking
about performance S3 is much faster and
abs is super faster when accessing from
the instance because from the instance
if you need to access S3 you'll actually
have to go out through the internet and
access the S3 or S3 is an external
service very external service you'll
have to go through or you'll have to go
outside of your VPC to access S3 S3 does
not come under a VPC but EBS comes under
a VPC it's on the same VPC so you would
be able to use it kind of locally
compared to S3 EBS is very local so that
way it's going to be faster and
redundancy talking about redundancy of
S3 and abs S3 is a replicated the data
in S3 is replicated across the data
centers but EBS is replicated within the
data center meaning S3 is replicated
across availability zones EBS is within
an availability zone so that way
redundancy is a bit less in EVS in other
words duranancy is higher in S3 than EPs
and talking about security of S3 is3 can
be made private as well as public
meaning anybody can access S3 from
anywhere in the internet that's possible
with S3 but EBS can only only be
accessed when attached to an ec2
instance right just one instance can
access it whereas S3 is publicly
directly accessible the other question
related to S3 security is how do you
allow access to a user to a certain a
user to a certain bucket which means
this user is not having access to S3 at
all but this user needs to be given
access to a certain bucket how do we do
it the same case applies to servers as
well in few cases there could be an
instance where a person is new to the
team and you actually don't want them to
access the production service now he is
in the production group and by default
he or she is granted access to that
server but you specifically want to deny
access to that production server till
the time he or she is matured enough to
access or understand the process
understand the do's and don'ts before
they can put their hands on the
production server so how do we go about
doing it so first we would categorize
our instances well these are critical
instances these are normal instances and
we were actually put a tag on them
that's how we categorize right so you
put a tag on them put attacks saying
well they are highly critical they are
medium critical and they are not
critical at all still there in
production stuff like that and then you
would pick the users who wants to or who
should be or should not be given access
to a certain server and you would
actually allow the user to access or not
access servers based on a specific tag
in other words you can use actually tags
in in the previous step we put tags on
the critical server right so you would
Define that this user is not going to
use this tag all right this user is not
allowed to use the resources with this
stack so that's how you would make your
step forward so you would allow or deny
based on the tags that you have put so
in this case he or she will not be
allowed to servers which are TAG
critical servers so that's how you allow
deny access to them the same goes for
bucket as well whereas if an
organization is excessively using S3 for
their data storage because of the
benefit that it provides the cost and
the durability you might get asked this
question which is organizations would
replicate the data from one region to
another region for additional data
durability and for having data
redundancy not only for that they would
also do that for Dr purposes for
Disaster Recovery if the whole region is
down you still have the data available
somewhere else and you can pick and use
it some organizations would store data
in different regions for compliance
reasons to provide low latency access to
their users who are local to that region
stuff like that so when companies do
replication how do you make sure that
there is consistency in the replication
how do you make sure that a replication
is not failing and the data gets
transferred for sure and there are logs
for that replication this is something
that the companies would use where they
are excessively using S3 and they're
fully relying on the replication in
running their business and the way we
could do it is we can set up a
replication monitor it's actually set of
tools that we could use together to make
sure that the cloud replication a region
level replication is happening properly
so this is how it happens now on this
side on the left hand side we have the
region one and on the right hand side we
have Region 2 and region 1 is the source
bucket and region two is the destination
bucket all right so object is put in the
source bucket and it has to go directly
to the region to bucket or made a copy
in the region two bucket and the problem
is sometimes it fails and there is no
consistency between them so the way you
would do it is connect these Services
together and create an cross replication
or cross region replication monitor that
actually monitors that actually monitors
your environment so there are cloudwatch
that make sure that the data is moved no
data is failing again there's Cloud
watch on the other end make sure that
the data is moving and then we have the
logs generated through cloudtrail and
that's actually written in dynamodb and
if there is an error if something is
failing you get notified through an SMS
or you get notified through an email
using the SNS service so that's how we
could leverage these tools and set up
and cross region replication monitor
that actually monitors your data
replication some common issues that
company companies face in VPC is that we
all know that I can use Route 53 to
resolve an IP address externally from
the internet but by default the servers
won't connect to the other servers using
our custom DNS name that it does not do
that by default so it's actually a
problem there are some additional things
that as an administrator or as an
architect or as a person who uses it you
will have to do and that's what we're
going to discuss so the question could
be a VPC is not resolving the server
through the DNS you can access it
through the IP but not through the DNS
name and what could be the issue and how
do you go about fixing it and you will
be able to answer this question only if
you have done it already it's a quick
and simple step by default called VPC
does not allow that's the default
feature and we will have to enable the
DNS hostname resolution before now this
is for the custom DNS not for the
default DNS that comes along this is for
the custom DNS so we will have to enable
the DNS hostname resolution so our will
have to enable DNS hostname resolution
so they actually resolve let's say I
want to connect to a server one dot
simplylearn.com by default it's not
allowed but if I enable this option then
I will be able to connect to server one
simplylearn.com if a company has vpcs in
different regions and they have a head
office in a central place and the rest
of them are Branch offices and they are
connecting to the head office for Access
or you know for saving data or for
accessing certain files or certain data
or storing data all right so they would
actually mimic the huben spoke topology
where you have the VPC which is
centrally in an accessible region a
centrally accessible region and then you
would have a local vpcs or Branch
offices in different other regions and
they get connected to the VPC in the
central location and the question is how
do you actually connect the multiple
sites to a VPC and make communication
happen between them by default it does
not do that we know that vpcs they need
to be paired between them in order to
access the resources let's look at this
picture right so I have like a customer
Network or Branch offices in different
parts and they get connected to a VPC
that's fine so what we have achieved is
those different offices the remote
offices they are connecting to the VPC
and they're talking but they can't
connect or they can't talk to each other
that's what we have built but the
requirement is the traffic needs to or
they should be able to talk to each
other but they should not have direct
connection between them which means that
they will have to come and hit the VPC
and then reach the other customer
Network which is in Los Angeles or which
is in New York right that's the
requirement so that's possible with some
architecting in the cloud so that's
using VPN Cloud Hub you look at this
dotted lines which actually allows
customers or which actually allows the
corporate networks to talk to each other
through the VPC Again by default it
doesn't happen cloudhub is an
architecture that we should be using to
make this happen and what's the
advantage of it as a central office or
as the headquarters office which is in
the VPC or headquarters data center
which is in the VPC you have control or
the VPC has control on who talks to who
and what traffic can talk to I mean what
traffic can be routed to the other head
office stuff like that that centralized
control is on the VPC the other question
you could get asked is name and explain
some security products and features
available in VPC well VPC itself is a
security service it provides security
service to the application but how do
you actually secure the VPC itself
that's the question and yes there are
products that can actually secure the
VPC or the VPC delivers those products
to secure the application access to the
vpcs restricted through a network access
control list all right so that's and
security product in VPC and a VPC has
security groups that protects the
instances from unwanted inbound and
outbound traffic and network access
control list protects the subnets from
unwanted inbound and outbound access and
there are flow logs we can capture in VP
scene that captures incoming and
outgoing traffic through a VPC which
will be used for later analysis as in
what's the traffic pattern what's the
behavior of the traffic pattern stuff
like that so there are some security
products and features available in VPC
now how do you monitor VPC VPC is a very
important concept very important Service
as well everything sits in a VPC most of
the service sits in a VPC except for
Lambda and S3 and dynamodb and couple of
other services most of them sit in a VPC
for security reasons so how do you
monitor your VPC how do you gain some
visibility on your VPC well we can gain
visibility on our VPC using VPC flow log
that's the basic Service as you see it
actually captures what's allowed what's
not allowed stuff like that which IPS
allowed which IP is not allowed stuff
like that so we can gather it and we can
use that for analysis and the other one
is cloud watch and Cloud watch logs the
data transfers that happen so this is
you know who gets allowed and who does
not get allowed I mean the flow logs is
who is allowed and who's not allowed
that kind of detail and Cloud watch
gives information about the data
transfer how much data is getting
transferred we can actually pick unusual
data transfers if there is a sudden hike
in the graph there's a sudden hike and
something happens at 12 on a regular
basis and you weren't expecting it
there's something suspicious it could be
valid backups it could be a malicious
activity as well so that's how you know
by looking at cloudwatch logs and
cloudwatch dashboard now let's talk
about multiple choice questions when
going for an interview you might
sometimes find yourself that the company
is conducting an online test based on
the score they can put you to a panelist
and then they would take it forward so
we thought it will also include multiple
choice questions to help you better
handle such situation if you come across
all right when you find yourself in such
situation the key to clear them is to
understand the question properly read
between the lines that's what they say
in know there can be like a big
paragraph with three lines or ten lines
you really got to understand what the
question is about and then try to find
answer for that question so that's a
come rule number one and then the second
rule is try to compare and contrast the
services mentioned or try to compare and
contrast the answers you can easily read
out one or two answers and then you will
be left with only two answers to decide
from you know so that also helps you
with time and that's how that also helps
you with some Precision in your answer
so number one read between the lines
number two compare and contrast the
services and you'll be able to easily
read out the wrong ones so let's try
answering this question suppose you are
a game designer and you want to develop
a game with a single digit millisecond
latency which of the following database
Services would you choose so we know
that the following are database services
are good enough all right and it talks
about about millisecond latency that's
the key point and the third thing is
it's a game it could be a mobile game
it's a game that you are trying to
design and you need the millisecond
latency and it has to be a database all
right so let's talk about the options
available RDS RDS is the database for
sure is it good for game design we'll
come back to that Neptune Neptune is a
graph a database service in Amazon so
that's kind of out of the equation and
snowball is actually a storage all right
it's it's a transport medium I would say
so that's again out of the equation so
the tie is between RDS and dynamodb so
if we need to talk about RDS RDS is an a
platform as a service it provides cost
efficient resizable capacity but it's an
SQL database meaning the tables are kind
of strict you know it's good for Banking
and other type of applications but not
really good for anything that has to do
with the gaming so the only option left
is dynamodb again it's the right answer
dynamodb is actually an fast and
flexible nosql database service and it
provides a single digit millisecond
latency at any scale and it's a database
at the same time it's a key Value Store
model database so the right answer is
dynamodb all right let's look at the
next question if you need to perform
real-time monitoring of AWS services and
get actionable insights which service
would you use all right let's list the
services so it talks about real-time
monitoring a firewall manager what does
it provide now firewall manager is not
really a monitor just like the name says
it's a manager it manages multiple
firewalls and AWS guard duty is and
thread detection service it does
monitoring it does continuously monitor
our environment but it monitors for
threats all right only threats now let's
talk about Cloud watch a cloud watch is
a service that helps to track metrics
it's a service that is used to
monitor the environment and give us a
system-wide visibility and also it helps
us to store logs so at the moment it
kind of looks like that could be the
right answer we don't know that yet but
I mean we have one more option left
that's EBS so what's EBS EBS is a block
storage elastic Block store if we
abbreviate EBS it's elastic Block store
so all three of them are easily out of
the question the first one is to manage
second one is to find threats of course
it does monitoring so there's I mean if
there is one relation between Cloud
watch and guard Duty that's monitoring
so easily we can actually find ourselves
slipped towards picking our duty but
know that God duties only for gaining
security inside but not about getting
AWS service inside so cloudwatch is a
service that helps us to get a system
wide or an AWS wide or an account wide
and it has number of metrics we can
monitor and get a very good Insight of
how a service is performing be it CPU be
it Ram beat Network utilization beat the
connection failures Cloud watch is a
service that helps us perform a
real-time monitoring and get some
actionable insights on the services all
right let's talk about this 33rd
question as a web developer you are
developing an app especially for the
mobile platform all right there is a
mention that this is especially for the
mobile platform so a lot of services
gets filtered out mobile platform right
which of the following lets you add user
sign up sign in and access control to
your web and mobile app quickly and
easily alright so this is all about
signing in to your mobile app so if we
need to read between the lines that's
how we can read sign up or sign in into
a mobile platform all right so we have
like four options here Shield AWS Massey
AWS inspector Amazon Cognito so let's
try to weed out Services which are not
relevant to it so what's AWS Shield AWS
Shield is actually a service that
provides a DDOS mitigation or DDOS
protection denial of service protection
it's a security feature let's talk about
the second option AWS Maxi is again a
security service that uses machine
learning to automatically discover and
classify the data it again talks about
security and this security is all about
encrypting or saving the data does not
come close with signing up an mobile
platform all right let's talk about the
other one AWS inspector now AWS
inspector has something to do with apps
it definitely has something to do with
apps so kind of looks like that as
relevant as of now so it actually helps
with improving the security and
compliance of the apps that we deploy in
the cloud so kind of looks like it could
be because it has to do with apps the
last one Cognito now Cognito is a
service that actually lets the
administrator to have control access
over web and mobile apps and it's a
service that helps us to sign up and
assign in to an mobile and web app so
that very much looks like we found the
answer so cognitive service that helps
web app and mobile app for sign up and
signing in and also gives the
administrator to have control over who
has I mean access control over the web
and the mobile app pretty much we found
it so it's cognitive Cognito is a
service that helps us to set up sign up
sign in and have access control over the
users who would be using our mobile and
web app all right how about this
question uh you are an ml engineer or
learning engineer who is on the lookout
for a solution that will discover
sensitive information that your
Enterprise stores in AWS and then uses
NLP to classify that data and provide
business related insights which among
the following Services would you choose
so we have a bunch of services that's
going to help us achieve or one of it is
going to help us achieve the about
requirement so it's a service that deals
with machine learning you're a machine
learning engineer who's looking for a
service that will help you to discover
information at your Enterprise store so
we're talking about storage discover
information in store and then classify
the data depending on severity the
sensitivity classify the data so which
service is that so firewall manager just
like the name says it's a manager and
the AWS IAM if we abbreviate it it's a
identity and access manage management so
it's identity and access management
nothing to do with identifying sensitive
data and managing it so the first two is
already out of the equation then the AWS
is Massey we already had a quick
definition description for AWS Mass E
that it's actually a security service
that uses machine learning kind of looks
like it could be it it's a security
service that uses machine learning and
it discovers and classifies the
sensitive information not only that it
does not stop there it goes beyond and
protects the sensitive data AWS Mass it
kind of looks like but we still have one
more option to look at which is cloud
HMS Cloud HMS is also a security service
kind of looks like that could be the
answer as well and it enables us to
generate encryption keys and save the
data so kind of 50 of it it's a security
service it encrypts helps us protect the
data but AWS Maxi is right on spot it's
a machine learning service it helps us
to classify the data and also to protect
the data so the answer for this question
would be AWS Massey so hope you kind of
get it how this is going so first we
apply the thumb rule identify the
question that's being asked read between
the lines and then try to find the
service that meets your requirement then
finding the service is by verse reading
out the wrong ones a recollect
everything that you've learned about the
service and see how well that matches
with those hints that you have picked up
and if that doesn't match weed that out
then you'll end up with two just two to
decide from at some point and then it
becomes easy for you to decide click on
the question submit it and then move on
to the other question in your interview
all right so how about this one you are
a system administrator in your company
which is running most of its
infrastructure on AWS you are required
to track your users and keep a look on
how your users are being authenticated
all right so this is where the problem
statement starts right you need to keep
track of how your users are being
authenticated and you wish to create and
manage AWS users and use permissions to
allow and deny their access to the AWS
resources all right you are to give them
permission number one and then I mean if
we put them in the right order first
giving them permissions and then
tracking their usage let's see which of
the service will help us achieve it IEM
is a service that helps us to looking at
the permissions we can actually predict
whether the user or the group will have
servers or not so that helps us to get a
track of who's able to use who's not
able to use certain servers and all that
stuff so it kind of looks like but we
have other three options left let's look
at AWS firewall manager just like the
name says it's actually a firewall
manager it helps us to manage multiple
firewalls simple as that and shield is a
service it's a service that's used to
protect denial of service or distributed
denial of service an API Gateway is a
service that makes it easy for
developers to create publish maintain
and monitor and secure API so I mean
it's completely on the API side very
Less on user and how you authenticate
your user we can get that by looking at
the name itself right if you abbreviate
it or if we if you try to find a
definition for the name API Gateway you
would get it it has to do with API but
if you upgrade AWS IAM its identity and
access management pretty much meets the
requirement but for the problem
statement about it's AWS identity and
access management that's the right
answer all right let's look at this one
if you want to allocate various private
and public IP address in order to make
them communicate with the internet and
other instances you will use this
service which of the following is this
service so it talks about using public
and private IP address so this service
uses IP address and then this service
helps us to allow love and deny
connections to the internet and to the
other instances so you get the question
is it let's pick the service that helps
us achieve it Route 53 Route 53 is
actually a DNS service right so it's not
a service that's used to allow or deny
no it does not do that VPC VPC uses
public and private IP address yes so
kind of looks like a VPC helps us to
allow I mean the security in VPC the
security group the network access
control list in a VPC the routing table
in a VPC that actually helps us to allow
or deny a connection to a particular IP
address or to a particular service
within the VPC or outside of the VPC so
as of now it kind of looks like it could
be but let's look at the other services
what if if we find a service that
closely matches to the above requirement
than the Amazon VPC Gateway API Gateway
we know that it's a managed service that
makes it easy for developers to create
publish maintain and monitor apis and
secure API so that has completely do
with API not with IP Cloud front we know
about cloudfront that it's a Content
delivery Network and it provides global
distribution of servers where our
content can be cached it could be video
or or bulk Media or anything else they
can be cached locally so users can
easily access them and download them
easily alright so that's Cloud front now
at this point after looking at all four
it looks like VPC is the right answer
and in fact VPC is the right answer VPC
has public IP address VPC can help us
with the private IP address VPC can be
used to allow deny connection based on
the security group Access Control list
and routing table it has so that's right
answer is VPC all right how about this
one this platform as a service or
platform as a DB service provides us
with a cost efficient and resizable
capacity while automating time-consuming
administrative tasks so this question is
very clear it's a DB service we gotta
look for and it's a service that can
provide the automating some of the time
consuming tasks it has to be resizable
at the same time so let's talk about
Amazon rational database it's a database
kind of matches the requirement we can
resize it as and when needed
all right looks like it's a fit as of
now it actually automates some of the
time consuming work looks like it's a
fit as of now let's move on to elastic
cache and then try to see if that
matches the definition that we've
figured out about elastic cache it's
actually a caching service it's again an
in-memory data store which helps in
achieving high throughput and low
latency in memory data store so it's not
a full-blown database and it does not
come with any Amazon provisioned
Automation in it for automating any of
the administration task no it does not
come up with anything like that yeah we
can resize the capacity as and when
needed but automation it's not there yet
and moreover it's not a database so
that's out of the equation VPC is not a
resizable one you know once we have
designed VPC it's fixed it can be
resized so that's out of the equation
and uh Amazon Glacier Glacier is a
storage but not a database all right so
that's again of the equation so the tie
is kind of between Amazon rational
database service and Amazon elastic
cache because they both Aid the database
service but elastic cache is not a
full-blown database it actually helps
database but it's not a full-blown
database so it's Amazon relational
database so that's the one which is a
platform as a service it's the one which
can be resized it's the one which can be
used to automate the time consuming
administrative tasks all right let's
talk about this one which of the
following is a means for accessing human
researchers or Consultants to help solve
a problem on a contractual or a
temporary basis all right let's read the
question again which of the following is
a means for accessing human researchers
or consultant to help solve problems on
a contractual or a temporary basis it's
like assigning task or hiring AWS
exports for a temporary job so let's try
to find that kind of service in the four
services that are listed Amazon elastic
map reduce mapreduce is actually an
framework service that makes it easy and
cost effective to analyze large amount
of data but that has nothing to do with
accessing human researchers all right
let's talk about mechanical terms it's a
web service that provides a human
Workforce that's the definition for it
for example automation is good but not
everything can be automated for
something to qualify for automation it
has to be a repeated task one-time task
can't be automated or the time and money
that you would be spending in automation
is not worth it instead you could have
done it manually so that does not
qualify for Automation and anything that
requires intelligence or anything that's
a special case all right automation can
do reperative tasks automation can do
precise work but it has to be repeated
tasks scenario you know it should have
been there already only then that can be
executed but if it's a new scenario and
it requires appropriate addressing then
it requires human thoughts so we could
hire researchers and Consultants who can
help solve a problem using Amazon
Mechanical Turk the other two are
already out of the equation now Dev pay
is actually a payment system through
Amazon and multi-factor authentication
as it says it's an authentication system
so the right answer is Amazon Mechanical
term all right this sounds interesting
let's look at this one this service is
used to make it easy to deploy manage
and scale containerized applications
using kubernetes on AWS which of the
following is this AWS service so it's a
service to deploy manage and scale
containerized applications so it deals
with containers it also should have the
ability to use kubernetes which is a
container orchestration service all
right the first one an Amazon elastic
container service kind of looks like
it's the one the name itself has the
word and the relation we're looking for
elastic
container service so this container
service is an highly scalable high
performance container orchestration
service let's look at the other one AWS
batch it's a service that enables it
professionals to schedule and execute
batch processing I mean the name itself
says that that's meant for batch
processing elastic Beanstalk that's
another service that helps us to deploy
manage and scale but it helps us with
easy two instances not with
containerized instances so that's again
out of the equation would light scale be
a good tie for elastic container service
what's slide sale now light sale is a
service it's called as virtual private
server without a VPC it's called as a
virtual private server it comes with a
predefined in the compute storage
networking capacity it's actually a
server not a container right so at this
point that also becomes out of the
equation so it's Amazon elastic
container service that's the one that
helps us to easily deploy manage scale
container services and it helps us
orchestrate the containers using
kubernetes all right how about this one
all right this service lets us to run
code without provisioning or managing
servers so no servers run code select
the correct service from the below
option all right so no servers but we
should be able to run code Amazon ec2
Auto scaling easy to order scaling ec2
is elastic compute Cloud which is a
server and auto scaling is a service
that helps us to achieve scaling the
server so that's the definition for it
could be that's out of the equation AWS
Lambda now Lambda is a service It's
actually an event driven serverless
Computing platform and Lambda runs code
in response to the event that it
receives and it automatically manages
the compute resource that's required for
that code as long as we have uploaded a
code that's correct and setup events
correctly to map to that code it's going
to run seamlessly so that's about Lambda
it kind of looks like it could be the
answer because Lambda runs code we don't
have to manage servers it manages
service by itself but we can't conclude
as of now we have other two servers to
talk about AWS badge all right batch is
service that enables ID professionals to
run batch job we know that and about the
inspector Amazon inspector it's actually
a service that helps us to increase and
identify any security issues and align
our application with compliance well
that's not the requirement of the
question the requirement and the
question was a run code without
provisioning a server and without any
more space for confusion AWS Lambda is a
service or is the service that runs code
without provisioning and managing
Services right the right one would be
AWS Lambda I'm very excited that you're
watching this video and I'm equally glad
that we were able to provide you a
second part in AWS interview questions
all right let's get started so in an
environment where there's a lot of
automation infrastructure automation
you'll be posted with this question how
can you add an existing instance to a
new auto scaling group now this is when
you are taking an instance away from the
auto scaling group to troubleshoot to
fix a problem you know to look at logs
or if you have suspended the auto
scaling you know you might need to
re-add that instance to the auto scaling
group only then it's going to take part
in it right only then the auto scaling
is going to count it as part of it it's
not a straight procedure you know when
you remove them you know it doesn't get
automatically re-added I've had worked
with some clients when their developers
were managed managing their own
environment they had problems adding the
instance back to the auto scaling group
you know irrespective of what they tried
the instance was not getting added to
the order scaling group and whatever
they fixed that they were provided or
whatever fix that they have provided
were not you know getting encountered in
the auto scaling group so like I said
it's not a straight you know a click
button procedure there are ways we'll
have to do it so how can you add an
existing instance to the auto Skilling
group there are a few steps that we need
to follow so the first one would be to
under the ec2 instance console right
under the instance under actions in
specific you know there's an option
called attach to Auto scaling group
right if you have multiple Auto scaling
groups in your account or in the region
that you're working in then you're going
to be posted with the different Auto
scaling groups that you have in your
account let's say you have five Auto
Skilling groups or five different
application you know you're going to be
posted with five different or scaling
groups and then you would select the
auto scaling the appropriate Auto
scaling group and attach the instance to
that particular order scaling group
while adding to the auto scaling group
if you want to change the instance type
you know that's possible as well
sometimes when you want to add the
instance back to the auto scaling group
there would be requirement that you
change the instance type to a better one
to a better family to the better
instance type you could do that at that
time and after that you are or you have
completely added the instance back to
the auto scaling group so it's actually
an seven step process adding an instance
back to the auto scaling group in an
environment where they're dealing with
migrating the instance or migrating an
application or migrating an instance
migrating and VM into the cloud you know
if the project that you're going to work
with deals with a lot of migrations you
could be posted this question what are
the factors you will consider while
migrating to Amazon web services the
first one is cost is it worth moving the
instance to the cloud given the
additional bills and whistles features
available in the cloud is this
application going to use all of them is
moving into the cloud beneficial to the
application in the first place you know
beneficial to the users who will be
using the application in the first place
so that's a factor to think of so this
actually includes you know cost of the
infrastructure and the ability to match
the demand and Supply transparency is
this application in high demand you know
is it going to be a big loss if the
application becomes unavailable for some
time so there are few things that needs
to be considered before we move the
application to the cloud and then if the
application does the application needs
to be provisioned immediately is there
an urge is there an urge to provision
the application immediately that's
something that needs to be considered if
the application requires to go online if
the application needs to hit the market
immediately then we would need to move
it to the cloud because in on-premises
procuring or buying an infrastructure
buying the bandwidth buying the switch
Port you know buying an instance you
know buying their software so buying the
license related to it it's going to take
time at least like two weeks or so
before you can bring up an server and
launch an application in it right so if
the application cannot wait you know
waiting means you know Workforce
productivity loss is it so we would want
to immediately launch instances and put
application on top of it in those case
if your application is of that type if
there is the urge in making the
application go online as soon as
possible then that's a candidate for
moving to the cloud and if the
application or if the the software or if
the product that you're launching it
requires Hardware it requires an updated
Hardware all the time that's not going
to be possible in on-premises we try to
deal with Legacy see infrastructure all
the time in on-premises but in the cloud
they're constantly upgrading their hard
ways only then they can keep themselves
up going in the market so they
constantly the cloud providers are
constantly updating their hard ways and
if you want to be benefited of your
application wants to be benefited by the
constant upgrading of the Hardwares
making sure the hardware is as latest as
possible the software version the
licensing is as latest as possible then
that's a candidate to be moved to the
cloud and if the application does not
want to go through any risk if the
application is very sensitive to
failures if the application is very much
stacked to the revenue of the company
and you don't want to take a chance in
you know seeing the application fail and
you know seeing the revenue drop then
that's a candidate for moving to the
cloud and business agility you know
moving to the cloud at least half of the
responsibility is now taken care by the
provider in this case it's Amazon at
least half of the responsibility is
taken care by them like if the hardware
fails Amazon makes sure that they're
fixing the hardware immediately and
notifications you know if something
happens you know there are immediate
notifications available that we can set
it up and make ourselves aware that
something has broken and we can
immediately jump in and fix it so you
see there are the responsibility is now
being shared between Amazon and us so if
you want to get that benefit for your
application for your organization for
the product that you're launching then
it needs to be moved to the cloud so you
can get that benefit from the cloud the
other question you could get asked is
what is RTO and RPO in AWS they are
essentially Disaster Recovery terms when
you're planning for Disaster Recovery
you cannot avoid planning disaster
recovery without talking about RTO and
RPO now what's the RTO what's the RPO in
your environment or how do you define
RTO how do you define RPO or some
general questions that get asked RTO is
recovery time objective RTO stands for
the maximum time the company is willing
to wait for the recovery to happen or
for the recovery to finish when an
disaster strikes so RTO is in the future
right how much time is it going to take
to fix and bring everything to normal so
that's RTO on the other hand RPO is
recovery Point objective which is the
maximum amount of data laws your company
is willing to accept as measured in time
RPO always refers to the backups the
number of backups the the frequency of
the backups right because when an outage
happens you can always go back to the
latest backup right and if the latest
backup was before 12 hours you have lost
the in between 12 hours of data data
storage right so RPO is the acceptable
amount if the company wants a less RPO
RPO is 1R then you should be planning on
taking backups everyone up if RPO is 12
hours then you should be planning on
taking backups every 12 hours so that's
how RPO and RTO you know helps Disaster
Recovery the fourth question you could
get asked is if you would like to
transfer huge amount of data which is
the best option among a snowball
snowball Edge and snowmobile again this
is a question that get asked if the
company is dealing with a lot of data
transfer into the cloud or if the
company is dealing with migrating data
into the cloud I'm talking about a huge
amount of data data in petabytes
snowball and all of the snowball series
deals with the petabyte sized data
migrations so there are three options
available as if now AWS snowball is an
data transport solution for moving high
volume of data into and out of a
specified AWS region on the other hand
AWS snowball Edge adds additional
Computing functions snowball is simple
storage and movement of data and
snowball Edge has a compute function
attached to it a snow mobile on the
other hand is an exabyte scale migration
service that allows us to transfer data
up to 100 petabytes that's like 100 000
terabytes so depending on the size of
data that we want to transfer from our
data center to the cloud we can hire we
can rent any of these three services
let's talk about some cloud formation
questions this is a classic question how
is AWS cloud formation different from
AWS elastic bean stock you know from the
surface they both look like the same you
know you don't go through the console
provisioning resources you don't you
know you don't go through CLI and
provision resources both of them
provision resources through click button
right but underneath they are actually
different services they support they aid
different services so knowing that is
going to help you understand this
question a lot better let's talk about
the difference between them and this is
what you will be explaining to the
interviewer or the panelist so the cloud
formation the cloud formation service
helps you describe and provision all the
infrastructure resources in the cloud
environment on the other hand elastic
bean stock provides an simple
environment to which we can deploy and
run application cloud formation gives us
an infrastructure and the elastic bean
stock gives us a small contained
environment in which we can run our
application and cloud formation supports
the infrastructure needs of many
different types of application like the
Enterprise application the Legacy
applications and any new modern
application that you want to have in the
cloud on the other hand the elastic bean
stock It's a combination of for
developer tools they are tools that
helps manage the life cycle of a single
application so cloud formation in short
is managing the infrastructure as a
whole an elastic Beanstalk in short is
managing and running an application in
the cloud and if the company that you're
getting hired is using cloud formation
to manage their infrastructure use it or
if they're using infrastructure or any
of the infrastructure as a code Services
then you would definitely face this
question what are the elements of an AWS
cloud formation template so it has a
four or five basic elements right and
the template is in the form of Json or
in yaml format right so it has
parameters it has outputs it has data it
has resources and then the format or the
format version or the file format
version for the cloud formation template
so parameter is nothing but uh it
actually lets you to specify the type of
easy to instance that you want the type
of RDS that you want all right so ec2 is
an umbrella RDS is an umbrella and
parameters within that ec2 and
parameters within that rdas are the
specific details of the ec2 or the
specific details of the RDS service so
that's what parameter is in a cloud
formation template and then the element
of the cloud formation template is
outputs for example if you want to
Output the name of an S3 bucket that was
created if you want to Output the name
of the ec2 instance if you want to
Output the name of some resources that
have been created instead of looking
into the template instead of you know
navigating through in the console and
finding the name of the resource we can
actually have them outputted in the
result section so we can simply go and
look at all the resources created
through the template in the output
section and that's what output values or
output does in the cloud formation
template and then we have resources
resources are nothing but what defines
what are the cloud components or Cloud
resources that will be created through
this cloud formation template now ec2 is
a resource RDS is a resource and S3
bucket is a resource elastic load
balancer is a resource and the NAT
Gateway is a resource VPC is a resource
so you see all these components are the
resources and there is so section in the
cloud formation defines what are the AWS
Cloud resources that will be created
through this cloud formation template
and then we have version version
actually identifies the capabilities of
the template you know we just need to
make sure that it is of the latest
version type and the latest version is
0909 2010 that's the latest version
number you'll be able to find that on
the top of the cloud formation template
and that version number defines the
capabilities of the cloud formation
template so just need to make sure that
it's the latest all the time still
talking about cloud formation this is
another classic question what happens
when one of the results in a stack
cannot be created successfully well if
the resource in a stack cannot be
created the cloud formation
automatically rolls back and terminates
all the resources that was created using
the cloud formation template so whatever
resources that were created through the
cloud formation template from the
beginning let's say we have created like
10 resources and the 11th resource is
now failing cloud formation will roll
back and delete all the 10 resources
that were created previously and this is
very useful when the cloud formation
cannot you know go forward cloud
formation cannot create additional
resources because we have reached the
elastic IP limits elastic IP limit per
region is 5 right and if you have
already used five IPS and a cloud
formation is trying to buy three more
IPS you know we've hit the soft limit
till we fix that with Amazon cloud
formation will not be able to you know
launch additional you know resources and
additional IPS so it's going to cancel
and roll back everything that's true
with a missing ec2 Ami as well if an Ami
is included in the template and but the
Ami is not actually present then cloud
formation is going to search for the Mi
and because it's not present it's going
to roll back and delete all the
resources that it created so that's what
cloud formation does it simply rolls
back all the resources that it created I
mean if it sees a failure it would
simply roll back all the resources that
it created and this feature actually
simplifies the system administration and
layout Solutions built on top of AWS
cloud formation so at any point we know
that there are no orphan resources in
the in in our environment you know
because something did not work or
because there was an you know cloud
formation executed some there are no
orphan resources in our account at any
point we can be sure that if cloud
formation is launching a resource and if
it's going to fail and it's going to
come back and delete all the resources
it's created so there are no orphan
resources in our account now let's talk
about some questions in elastic Block
store again if the environment deals
with a lot of automation you could be
thrown this question how can you
automate easy to backup using EBS it's
actually a six step process to automate
the ec2 backups we'll need to write a
script to automate the below steps using
AWS API and these are the steps that
should be found in the scripts first get
the list of instances and then and then
the script that we are writing should be
able to connect to AWS using the API and
list the Amazon ABS volumes that are
attached locally to the instance and
then it needs to list the snapshots of
each volume make sure the snapshots are
present and it needs to assign a
retention period for the snapshot
because over time the snapshots are
going to be invalid right once you have
some 10 latest snapshots any snapshot
that you have taken before that then
becomes invalid because you have
captured the latest and 10 snapshot
coverage is enough for you and then the
fifth point is to create a snapshot of
each volume create a new snapshot of
each volume and then delete the old
snapshot anytime a new snapshot gets
created the oldest snapshot on the list
needs to go away so we need to include
options we need to include scripts in
our script lines in our script that make
sure that it's deleting the older
snapshots which are older than the
retention period that we are mentioning
another question that you could see in
the interview be it written interview
beat online interview or beat and
telephonic or face to face interview is
what's the difference between EBA es and
instant store let's talk about EBS first
EBS is kind of permanent storage the
data in it can be restored at a later
point when we save data in EBS the data
lives even after the lifetime of the ec2
instance for example we can stop the
instance and the data is still going to
be present in EBS we can move the EBS
from one instance to another instance
and the data is simply going to be
present there so ABS is kind of
permanent storage when compared to
instance on the other hand instance
store is a temporary storage and that
storage is actually physically attached
to the host of the machine abs is an
external storage and instant store is
locally attached to the instance or
locally attached to the host of The
Machine we cannot detach an instant
store from one instance and attach it to
another but we can do that with EBS so
that's a big difference one is permanent
data and another one is EBS is permanent
instance store is a volatile data and
instant store with instant store we
won't be able to detach the storage and
attach it to another instance and
another feature of instant store is data
in an instant store is lost if the disk
fails or the instance is stopped or
terminated so instant store is only good
for storing cache data if you want to
store permanent data then we should
think of using EBS and not instant store
while talking about storage on the same
lines this is another classic question
how can you take backups of EFS like EBS
and if you can take backup how do you
take that backup the answer is yes we
can take EFS to EFS backup solution EFS
does not support snapshot like EBS EFS
does not support snapshot snapshot is
not an option for EFS elastic file
system right we can only take backup
from one EFS to another EFS and this
backup solution is to recover from
unintended changes or deletions of the
EFS and this can be automated right any
data that we store in EFS can be
automatically replicated to another EFS
and once this EFS goes down or gets
deleted or data gets deleted or you know
the whole EFS is for some reason
interrupted or deleted we can recover
the data from we can use the other EFS
and bring the application to consistency
and to achieve this it's not an One Step
configuration it's a cycle there are
series of steps that's involved before
we can achieve EFS to EFS backup the
first thing is to sign in to the AWS
Management console and under EFS or
click on EFS to EFS restore button from
the services list and from there we can
use the region selector in the console
navigation bar to select the actual
region in which we we want to work on
and from there ensure that we have
selected the right template you know
some of the templates would be you know
EFS to EFS backup granular backups
incremental backups right so there are
some templates the kind of backups that
you want to take do you want to take
granular do you want to take increment
backups stuff like that and then create
a name to that solution the kind of
backup that we have created and finally
review all the configurations that you
have done and click on Save and from
that point onwards the data is going to
be copied and from that point onwards
any additional data that you put is
going to copy it and replicate it now
you have an EFS to EFS backup this is
another classic question in companies
which deals with a data management there
are easy options to create snapshots but
deleting snapshots is not always and you
know click button or a single step
configuration so you you might be facing
a question like how do you Auto delete
old snapshots and the procedure is like
this now as best practice we will take
snapshots of EBS volume to S3 all
snapshots get stored in S3 we know that
now and we can use AWS Ops automator to
automatically handle all snapshots the
Ops automator service it allows us to
create copy delete EBS snapshots so
there are cloud formation templates
available for AWS Ops automator and this
automator template will scan the
environment and it would take snapshots
it would you know copy the snapshot from
one region to another region if you want
I know if you're setting up a Dr
environment and not only that based on
the retention period that we create it's
going to delete the snapshots which are
older than the retention period so life
or managing snapshot is made a lot
easier because of this Ops automator
cloud formation template moving into
questions and elastic load balancer this
again could be an a question in the
interview what are the different types
of load balances in AWS and what's their
use case what's the difference between
them and as of now as we speak there are
three types of load balances which are
available in AWS the first one being
application load balancer just like the
name says the application load balancer
works on the application layer and deals
with the HTTP and https request and it
it also supports path based routing for
example simplylearn.com
some web page simplylearn.com another
website so it's going to direct the path
based on the slash value that you give
in the URLs that's path based routing so
it supports that and not only that it
can support a port based a colon 8080
colon 8081 or colon 8090 you know based
on that also it can take a routing
decision and that's what application
load balancer does on the other hand we
have Network load balancer and the
network load balancer makes routing
decisions at the transport level it's
faster because it has very less thing to
work on it works on Lower OSI layer it
works on a lower layer so it has very
less information to work with than
compared with application layers so
comparatively it's a lot faster and it
handles millions of requests per second
and after the load balancer receives the
connection it selects a Target group for
the default rule using the flow hash
routing algorithm it does simple routing
right it does not do path based or Port
based routing it does simple routing and
because of it it's faster and then we
have classic load balancer which is kind
of expiring as we speak Amazon is
discouraging people using classic load
balancer but there are companies which
are still using classic load balancer
they are the ones over the first one to
step in to Amazon when classic load
balancer was the first load balancer or
the only load balancer available at that
point so it supports HTTP https TCP SSL
protocol and it has a fixed relationship
between load balance report and the
container Port so initially we only have
classic load balancer and then after
some point Amazon said instead of having
one load balancer address all type of
traffic we're gonna have a two load
balances called as the child from the
classic to load balancer and one is
going to specifically address the
application requirement and one is going
to specifically address the network
requirement and let's call it as
application load balancer and network
load balancer so that's how now we have
two different load balances talking
about load balance another classic
question could be what are the different
uses of the various load balancer in AWS
elastic or load balancing there are
three types of load balancer we just
spoke about it application load balancer
is used if we need a flexible
application management and TLS
termination and Network load balancer if
we require Extreme Performance and the
load balancing should happen on based on
static IPS for the application and
classic load balancer is an old load
balancer which is for people who are
still running their environment from EC
to Classic Network now this is an older
version of VPC or this is what was
present before VPC was created easy to
Classic network is what was present
before ec2 was created so they are the
three types and they are the use cases
of it let's talk about some of this
security related questions you would
face in the interview when talking about
security and firewall and AWS we cannot
avoid discussion talking about Waf web
application firewall and you would
definitely see yourself in this
situation where you've been asked how
can you use AWS Waf in monitoring your
AWS applications Waf or web application
firewall protects our web application
from common web exploits and Waf helps
us control which traffic Source your
application should be allowed or a Blog
which traffic from certain Source you
know which source or which traffic from
a certain Source should be allowed or
blocked your application with Waf we can
also create custom rules that blocks
common attack patterns you know if it is
a banking application it has a certain
type of attacks and if it is simple data
management data storage application it
has I mean content management
application it has a separate type of
attack So based on the application type
we can identify a pattern and create
rules that would actually block that
attack based on the rule that we create
and Waf can be used for three cases you
know the first one is allow all requests
and then block all requests and count
all requests for a new policy so it's
also an monitoring and Management
Service which actually counts all the
policies or counts all the requests that
matches a particular policy that that we
create and some of the characteristics
we can mention in AWS web are the origin
IPS and the strings that appear in the
request we can allow block based on
Origin IP allow block based on strings
that appear in the request we can allow
block or count based on the origin
country length of the request yeah we
can block and count the presence of
malicious scripts in an connection you
know we can count the request headers or
we can allow block a certain request
header and we can count the presence of
a malicious SQL code in a connection
that we get and that want to reach our
application still talking about security
what are the different AWS IM categories
we can control using AWS IAM we can do
the following one is create and manage
IM users and once the user database gets
bigger and bigger we can create and
manage them in groups and in IM we can
use it to manage the secure security
credentials kind of setting the
complexity of the password you know
setting additional authentications you
know like MFA and you know rotating the
passwords you know resetting the
password there are a few things we could
do with IM and finally we can create
policies that actually grants access to
AWS services and resources another
question you will see is what are the
policies that you can set for your users
password so some of the policies that we
can set for the user password is the
minimum length or you know the
complexity of the password by at least
having one number or one special
characters in the password so that's one
and then the requirement of a specific
character types including you know
uppercase lowercase number and
non-alphabetic characters so it becomes
very hard for somebody else to guess
what the password would be and and try
to hack them so we can set the length of
the password we can set the com
complexity in the password and then we
can set an automatic expiration of the
password so after a certain time the
user is forced to create a new password
so the password is not still old and
easy to guess in the environment and we
can also set settings like the user
should contact the admin I mean when the
password is about to expire so you know
you can get a hold of how the user is
setting their password is it having good
complexity in it is it meeting company
standards or there are few things that
we can control and set for the users
when the users are setting or recreating
the password another question that could
be posted in an interview so to
understand your understanding of IEM is
what's the difference between an IM role
and an IM user let's talk about IM user
let's touch small and then go big or
let's start simple and then talk about
the complex one the IM user has a
permanent long term essential and it's
used to interact directly with AWS
services and on the other hand IEM role
is an IM entity that defines a set of
permissions for making AWS service
requests so IM user is an permanent
credential and role or temporary AWS IEM
functionalities and with role trusted
entities such as IM users application or
AWS Services assume are the role so when
an IM user is given an a permission you
know it sticks within the IM user but
with roles we can give permissions to
Applications we can give permissions to
users in the same account in a different
account the corporate ID we can give
permissions to ec2 S3 RDS VPC and lot
more role is wide and IM user is is not
so wide you know it's very constrained
only for that IM user let's talk about
manage policies in AWS manage balance is
there are two types you know customer
managed and Amazon managed so managed
policies are IM resources that Express
permissions using the IAM policy
language and we can create policies edit
them manage them manage them separately
from the IAM user group and roles which
they are attached to so they are
something that we can do to managed
policies if it is customer managed and
we can now update policy in one place
and the permissions automatically extend
to all the attached entries so I can
have like three services four Services
point to a particular policy and if I
edit that particular policy it's going
to reflect on those three or four
services so anything that I allow is
going to be allowed for those four
Services anything that I denied is going
to be denied for the four Services
imagine what would be without the IM
managed policy will have to go and
specifically allow deny on those
different instances four or five times
depending on the number number of
instances that we have so like I said
there are two types of managed policies
one is managed by us which is customer
managed policies and then the other is
managed by AWS which is AWS managed
policy this question can you give an
example of an IM policy and a policy
summary this is actually to test how
well-versed are you with the AWS console
the answer to that question is look at
the following policy this policy is used
to Grant access to add update and delete
objects from a specific folder now in
this case name of the folder is example
folder and it's present in a bucket
called example bucket so this is an IAM
policy on the other hand the policy
summary is a list of access level
resource and conditions for each service
defined in a policy so IM policy is all
about one particular resource and the
policy summary is all about multiple
resources with IM policy it was only
talking about S3 bucket and one
particular S3 bucket here it talks about
cloud formation template Cloud watch
logs ec2 elastic bean stock Services
summary summary of resources and the
permissions and policies attached to
them that's what policy summary is all
about another question could be like
this what's the use case of IAM and how
does IM help your business two important
or primary work of IM is to help us
manage IAM users and their access it
provides a secure access to multiple
users to their appropriate AWS resources
so that's one it does and the second
thing it does is manage access for
Federated users Federated users or
non-iam users and through IAM we can
actually allow and provide a secured
access to resources in our AWS account
to our employees without the IM user now
they could be authenticated using the
active directory they could be
authenticated using the Facebook Reddit
chill Google credential Amazon
credential and a couple of other
credentials third party identity
management right so we could actually
trust them and we could give them access
to our account based on the trust
relationship that we have built with the
other identity systems all right so two
things one is manage users and their
access for manage IAM user and their
access in our AWS environment and second
is manage access for Federated users who
are non-im users and more importantly IM
is a free service and with that will
only be charged for the use of the
resources not for the IM username and
password that we create all right let's
now talk about some of the questions in
route 53. one classic question that
could be asked in an interview is what
is the difference between latency based
routing and Geo DNS or Geo based DNS
routing now the geo-based DNS routing
takes routing decisions on the basis of
the geographic location of the request
and on the other hand the latency based
routing utilizes latency measurements
between networks and data centers now
latency based routing is used where you
want to give your customers the lowest
latency as possible so that's when we
would use latency based routing and on
the other hand a geo-based routing is
when we want to direct customers to
different websites based on the country
they are browsing from you know you
could have you know two different or
three different websites for the same
URL you know take Amazon the shopping
website for example when we go to
amazon.com from in the US it directs us
to the US webpage where the products are
different the currency is different
right and the flag and and a couple of
other advertisements that shows up are
different and when we go to amazon.com
from India it gets directed to the
amazon.com Indian site where again the
currency the product and the
advertisements they're all different
right so depending on the country
they're trying to browse if you want to
direct customers to two or three
different websites we would use a
geo-based routing another use case of
geobase routing is if you have a
compliance that you should handle all
the DNS requests sorry if you should
handle all the requests you know from a
country within the country then you
would do jio based routing now you
wouldn't direct the customer to a server
which is in another country all right
you would direct the customer to a
server which is very local to them
that's another use case of geo-based
routing and like I said for latency
based routing the whole goal or aim is
to achieve minimum end user latency if
you are hired for the architect role and
if that requires working a lot on the
DNS then you could be posted with this
question what is the difference between
domain and a hosted Zone a domain is
actually a collection of data describing
a self-contained administrative and
Technical unit on the internet right so
for example you know simplylearn.com is
actually a domain on the other hand
hosted zone is actually an container
that holds information about how you
want to Route traffic on the internet to
a specific domain for example
lms.simplyleon.com is an hosted Zone
whereas simplylearn.com is an domain so
in other words in hosted Zone you would
see the domain name plus and a prefix to
it LMS is a prefix here FTP is is a
prefix mail.simplieron.com as a prefix
so that's how you would see a prefix in
hosted zones another question from
another classic question from Route 53
would be how does Amazon Route 53
provide High availability and low
latency the way Amazon Route 53 provides
High availability and low latency is by
globally distributed DNS service Amazon
is a global Service and they have DNS
Services globally any customer doing a
query from different parts of the world
they get to reach an DNS server which is
very local to them and that's how it
provides low latency now this is not
true with all the DNS providers there
are DNS providers who are very local to
a country who are very local to a
continent so they don't they generally
don't provide low latency service right
it's always high latency it's low
latency for local users but anybody
browsing from a different country or a
different continent it's going to be
high latency for them them but that's
not again true with Amazon Amazon is a
globally distributed DNS provider it has
DNS servers Global wide and like I said
it has optimal locations it has got
global Service or in other words it has
got servers around the globe different
parts in the globe and that's how they
are able to provide High availability
and because it's not running on just one
server but on many servers they provide
High availability and low latency if the
environment that you're going to work on
is going to take a lot of configuration
backups environmental backups then you
can expect questions in AWS config a
classic question would be how does AWS
config work along with AWS cloudtrail
AWS cloudtrail actually records user API
activity on the account and you know any
HTTP https access or any any sort of
access I know that's made to the cloud
environment that's recorded in the cloud
trail in other towards any APA calls the
time is recorded the type of call is
recorded and what was the response given
was it a failure was it successful they
also get recorded in cloudtrail it's
actually a log it actually records the
activity in your Cloud environment on
the other hand config is an a point in
time configuration details of your
resources for example at a given point
what are all the resources that were
present in my environment what are all
the resources or what are the
configuration in those resources at a
given point they get captured in AWS
config right so with that information
you can always answer the question what
did my AWS resource look like at a given
point in time that question gets
answered when we use AWS config on the
other hand with cloudtrail you can
answer the question I mean by looking at
the cloud trail or with the help of
cloudtrail you can easily answer the
question who made an APA call to modify
this resource that's answered by Cloud
soil and with cloudtrail we can detect
if a security group was incorrectly
configured and who did that
configuration let's say there happened
to be a downtime and you want to
identify let's say there happened to be
a downtime and you want to identify who
made that change in the environment you
can simply look at cloudtrail and find
out who made the change and if you want
to look at how the environment looks
like before the change you can always
look at AWS config can AWS configure or
AWS config aggregate data across
different AWS accounts yes it can now
this question is actually to test
whether you have used AWS config or not
I know some of the services are very
local is it some of these services are
availability Zone specific some of them
are Regional specific and some of them
are Global Services in Amazon and those
some of the services are region Services
you still can do some changes you know
add some configuration to it and collect
reach Regional data in it for example S3
is a regional service but still you can
collect logs from all other regions into
an S3 bucket in one particular region
that's possible and cloud trail is and
Cloud watch is an regional service but
still you can with some changes to it
with some adding permissions to it you
can always monitor the cloud watch that
belongs to cloudwatch logs that belongs
to other regions you know they're not
Global by default but you can do some
changes and make it Global similarly AWS
config is a service that's a
region-based service but still you can
make it act globally we can aggregate
data across a different region and
different accounts in an AWS config and
deliver the updates from different
accounts to one S3 bucket and can access
it from there AWS config also works or
integrates seamlessly with SNS topic so
you know anytime there is a change
anytime a new data gets collected you
can always notify yourself for notify a
group of people about the new log or the
new config or new edit that happened in
the environment let's look at some of
the database questions you know database
should be running on reserved instances
right so whether you know that fact or
not the interviewer wants to understand
how well you know that fact by asking
this question how are reserved instances
different from on-demand DB instances
reserved instances and on-demand
instances are exactly the same when it
comes to their function but they only
differ based on how they are built
reserved instances are purchased for one
year or three year reservation and in
return we get a very low per hour
pricing because we're paying upfront
it's generally said that reserved
incidence is 75 percentage cheaper than
on-demand instance and Amazon gives you
that benefit because you know you're
committing for one year and sometimes
your paying in advance for the whole
year on the other hand on-demand
instances are built on an hourly hourly
price talking about Auto scaling how
will you understand the different types
of Auto scaling the interviewer might
ask this question which type of scaling
would you recommend for RDS and why the
two types of scaling as you would know
now vertical and horizontal and in
vertical scaling we can vertically scale
up the master database with a couple of
clicks all right so that's vertical
scaling vertical scaling is keeping the
same node and making it bigger and
bigger if previously it was running on
T2 micro now we would like to run it on
M3 two times large instance previously
it had one virtual CPU one gigabit now
it's gonna have eight virtual CPU and 30
gigabit of ram so that's vertical
scaling on the other hand the horizontal
scaling is adding more nodes to it
previously it was running on one VM now
it's going to run on 2 3 10 VMS right
that's horizontal are scaling so a
database can only be scaled vertically
and there are 18 different types of
instances we can resize our rds2 right
so this is true for RDS MySQL postgres
SQL mariadb Oracle Microsoft SQL servers
there are 18 type of instances we can
vertically scale up to on the other hand
horizontal scaling are good for replicas
so they are read-only replicas we're not
going to touch the master database we're
not going to touch the primary database
but I can do horizontal scaling only
with Amazon Aurora and I can add
additional read replicas I can add up to
15 Read replicas for Amazon Aurora and
up to five a read replicas for RDS MySQL
postgres SQL and mariadb RDS instances
and when we add replica we are
horizontally scaling adding more nodes
right read-only nodes so that's
horizontal scaling so how do you really
decide between vertical and horizontal
scaling if you're looking into increase
the storage and the processing capacity
we'll have to do a vertical scaling if
you are looking at increasing the
performance or of the read heavy
database we need to be looking for
horizontal scaling or we need to be
implementing horizontal scaling in our
environment still talking about database
this is another good question you can
expect in the interview what is a
maintenance window and Amazon RDS will
your DB instance be available during the
maintenance event all right so this is
really to test how well you have
understood the SLA how well you have
understood the Amazon rdas the failover
mechanism of Amazon rdas stuff like that
so RDS maintenance window it lets you
decide when ADB instance modification a
database engine upgrades or software
patching has to occur and you you
actually get to decide should it happen
at 12 in the night or should happen at
afternoon should it happen early in the
morning should it happen in the evening
you actually get to decide an automatic
scheduling by Amazon is done only for
patches that are security and durability
related sometimes Amazon takes down and
does automatic scheduling if you know if
there is a need for a patch update that
deals with security and durability and
by default the maintenance window is is
for 30 minutes and the important point
is the DB instance will be available
during that event because you're going
to have primary and secondary right so
when that upgrade happens Amazon would
shift the connection to the secondary do
the upgrade and then switch back to the
primary another classic question would
be what are the consistency models in
dynamodb in dynamodb there is eventual
consistency read this eventual
consistency model it actually maximizes
your read throughput and the best part
with eventual consistency is all copies
of data reach consistency within a
second and sometimes when you write and
when you're you know trying to read
immediately chances that you you would
still be reading the old data that's
eventual consistency on the other hand
there is another consistency model
called the strong consistency or
strongly consistent read where there is
going to be a delay in writing the data
you know making sure the data is written
in all places but it guarantees one
thing that is once you have done a write
and then you're trying to do a read it's
going to make sure that it's going to
show you the updated data not the old
data now you can be guaranteed of it
that it is going to show the updated
data and not the old data that's
strongly consistent still talking about
database talking about nosql dynamodb or
nosql database which is dynamodb and
Amazon you could be asked this question
what kind of query function
functionality does dynamodb support
dynamodb supports get and put operation
dynamodb supports or dynamodb provides a
flexible querying by letting you query
on non-primary key attributes using
Global secondary index and local
secondary indexes a primary key can be
either a single attribute partition key
or a composite partition sort key in
other words a dynamodb indexes a
composite partition sort key as a
partition key element and a sort key
element and by holding the partition key
you know when doing a search or when
doing a query by holding the partition
key element constant we can search
across the sort key element to retrieve
the other items in that table and at the
composite partition sort key should be a
combination of user ID partition and a
timestamp so that's what the composite
partition sort key is made of let's look
at some of the multiple choice questions
you know sometimes time some companies
would have an written test or an McQ
type online test before they call you
for the first level or before they call
you for the second level so these are
some classical questions that companies
asked or companies ask in their multiple
choice online questions let's look at
this question as a developer using this
pay-per-view service you can send store
and receive messages between software
components which of the following is
being referred here let's look at it
right we have AWS step functions Amazon
mq Amazon simple Q service Amazon simple
notification service let's read the
question again as a developer using this
pay-per-view service so the service that
we are looking for is a pay-per-view
service you can send store and retrieve
messages between two software components
kind of like a queue there so what would
be the right answer it would be Amazon
simple Q service now Amazon simple Q
service is the one that's used to
decouple the environment you know it
breaks the tight coupling and then it
introduces decoupling in that
environment by providing a queue or by
inserting a queue between two software
components let's look at this other
question if you would like to host a
real-time audio and video conferencing
application on AWS right it's an audio
and video conferencing application on
AWS this service provides you with a
secure and easy to use application what
is this service let's look at the
options they are Amazon chime Amazon
workspace Amazon mq Amazon appstream all
right you might tend to look at Amazon
appstream because it's real time and
video conference but it's actually for a
different purpose it's actually Amazon
chime that lets you create chat and
create a chat board and then collaborate
with the security of the AWS services so
it lets you do the audio it's lets you
do the video conference all supported by
AWS security features it's actually
Amazon China let's look at this question
as your company's aw solution architect
you are in charge of Designing thousands
of individual jobs which are similar
which of the following service best
serves your requirement AWS ec2 Auto
scaling AWS snowball AWS fargate AWS
batch let's read the question again as
your company's AWS solution architect
you are in charge of Designing thousands
of individual jobs which are similar it
looks like it's batch service let's look
at the other options as well AWS
snowball is actually an storage
Transport service ec2 auto scaling is
you know in introducing scalability and
elasticity in the environment and AWS
far gate is container services AWS batch
is the one is being referred here that
actually runs thousands of individual
jobs which are similar AWS batch it's
the right answer let's look at the other
one you are a machine learning engineer
and you're looking for a service that
helps you build build and train machine
learning models in AWS which among the
following are we referring to so we have
Amazon sagemaker and AWS deep lens
Amazon comprehend AWS device form let's
read the question again you are a
machine learning engineer and you're
looking for a service that helps you
build and train machine learning models
in AWS which among the following are
referred here the answer is Sage maker
it provides every developer and data
scientist with the ability to build
train and deploy machine learning models
quickly that's what sagemaker does now
for you to be familiar with you know the
products I would recommend you to you
know simply go through the product
description you know there's one page
available on Amazon that explains all
the products a quick neat and simple and
that really helps you to be very
familiar with you know what the product
is all about and what it is capable of
you know is it the DB service is it a
machine learning service or is it a
monitoring service is it a developer
service stuff like that so get that
information get that details before you
attend an interview and that should
really help to answer or face such
questions with a great confidence so the
answer is Amazon sagemaker because
that's the one that provides developers
and a data scientist the ability to
build a train and deploy machine
learning models quickly as possible all
right let's look at this one let's say
that you are working for your company's
ID team and you are designated to adjust
the capacity of the AWS resource based
on the incoming application and network
traffic how do you do it so what's the
service that's actually helps us to
adjust the capacity of the AWS resource
based on the incoming application let's
look at it Amazon VPC Amazon IAM Amazon
inspector Amazon elastic load balancing
Amazon VPC is a networking service
Amazon IEM is an username password
authentication Amazon inspector is a
service that actually does a security
audit in our environment and Amazon
elastic load balancer is a service that
helps in scalability that's in one way
you know indirectly that helps in
increasing the availability of the
application right and monitoring it
monitoring you know how much requests
are coming in through the elastic load
balancer we can actually adjust the
environment that's running behind it so
the answer is going to be Amazon elastic
load balancer all right let's look at
this question this cross-platform video
game development engine that supports PC
Xbox PlayStation IOS and Android
platforms allows developers to build and
host their games on Amazon's servers so
we have Amazon game lift Amazon green
grass Amazon Lumberyard Amazon Sumerian
let's read the question again this
cross-platform video game development
engine that supports PC Xbox PlayStation
IOS and Android platforms allows
developers to build and host their games
on Amazon servers the answer is Amazon a
lumber yard this lumber yard is an free
AAA gaming engine deeply integrated with
the AWS and twitch with full source this
lumber yard provides a growing set of
tools that helps you create an highest
game quality applications and they
connect to a lot of games and vast
compute and storage in the cloud so it's
that service they are referring to let's
look at this question you are the
project manager of your company's Cloud
architect team you are required to
visualize understand and manage your AWS
cost and usage over time which of the
following service will be the best fit
for this we have AWS budgets we have AWS
cost Explorer we have Amazon workmail we
have Amazon connect and the answer is
going to be cost Explorer now cost
Explorer is an option any the Amazon
console that helps you to visualize and
understand and even manage the AWS cost
over time who's spending more who's
spending less and what is the trend what
is the projected cost for the coming
month all these can be visualized in AWS
cost Explorer let's look at this
question you are a chief Cloud architect
at your company and how can you
automatically Monitor and adjust
Computer Resources to ensure maximum
performance and efficiency of all
scalable resources so we have a cloud
formation as a service we have AWS
Aurora as a solution we have AWS Auto
scaling and Amazon API Gateway let's
read the question again you're the chief
Cloud architect at your company how can
you automatically Monitor and adjust
Computer Resources how can you
automatically Monitor and adjust
Computer Resources to ensure maximum
performance and efficiency of all
scalable resources this is an easy
question to answer the answer is auto
scaling all right that's a basic service
and solution architect course is it auto
scaling is the service that helps us to
easily adjust Monitor and ensure the
maximum performance and efficiency of
all scalable resources it does that by
automatically scaling the environment to
handle the inputs let's look at this
question as a database administrator you
will use a service that is used to set
up and manage databases such as MySQL
mayodb and postgres SQL which service
are we referring to Amazon Aurora Amazon
elastic cache AWS RDS AWS database
migration service Amazon Arora is
Amazon's flavor of the RDS service and
elastic cache is is the caching service
provided by Amazon they are not
full-fledged database and database
migration service just like the name
says it helps to migrate the database
from on-premises to the cloud and from
one a database flavor to another
database flavor Amazon RDS is the
service is the console is the service is
the umbrella service that help helps us
to set up manage our databases like
MySQL maridb and postgres SQL it's
Amazon RTS let's look at this last
question a part of your marketing work
requires you to push messages to onto
Google Facebook Windows and Apple
through apis or AWS Management console
you will use the following service so
the options are AWS cloudtrail AWS
config Amazon chime AWS simple
notification service it says a part of
your marketing work requires you to push
messages it's dealing with pushing
messages to Google Facebook Windows and
Apple through apis or AWS Management
console you will use the following
service it's simple notification service
simple notification service is a message
pushing service and sqs is pulling
similarly SMS is pushing right here it
talks about a pushing system that pushes
messages to Google Facebook Windows and
Apple through API and it's going to be a
simple notification system or a simple
notification service so with that we
have come to come to an end of day two
of cloud computing we hope the session
was informative and interesting should
you find any concepts difficult to
understand or have any queries about any
of the topics covered in this session
then please feel free to let us know in
the comment section below our team of
experts will be happy to resolve all
your queries and concerns on a priority
on the day 3 of cloud computing week by
simply learn we will switch cash and set
up to learn another lead cloud computing
framework that is none other than the
Microsoft Azure so don't forget stay
tuned to Simply learn for more updates
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning